Hey,
hey, hey.
Heat. Heat. N.
Heat. Heat.
I hope you
What the [ __ ]
Heat. Heat. N.
Are you
you?
Heat. Heat. N.
Hey, hey, hey.
Down.
Hey,
hey, hey.
hey,
hey.
power.
Down.
We know you
are.
Yeah.
Hey,
hey, hey.
Hey.
Heat.
Hey,
hey, hey.
Heat. Heat.
Hey,
Oh [ __ ]
Hey
Hey, hey,
hey.
Hey hey hey.
Heat. Heat.
Welcome back, Riftbounders, to the
Vancouver regional qualifier. Moments
from now, these chairs will be filled
with the remaining competitors of a
rigorous tournament. Eight rounds have
been concluded from day one. Five more
remain with a cut to top eight. Could
this be our first ever returning champ?
Bringing Dewali, Sam Sherman,
Prismaticism, or even Allen's EQ for a
second win. But plenty of competitors
are still hungry for that crown. Now, 34
of our 40 legends still remain in this
rigorous championship. Rivalries are
forming, stars are rising, but everyone
does not want their dreams to turn to
dust. Don't go anywhere, folks, because
the exciting conclusion to this
tournament is about to begin.
That's right, everybody. Good morning
and welcome back to the regional
qualifier here in Vancouver. I'm Barrett
Bryant, joined by with the wonderful
Silverfuse. Excellent casting by the
way. You must have seen some incredible
gameplay because I know I was watching
the entire time.
>> Oh yeah, there were so many good plays
by a lot of these players. Just over and
over again, we saw some interesting
decks come out as well. So, it was a lot
of fun casting all these games.
>> Well, not just the decks, but let's talk
about the players. We're going to dive
right into it to everyone. You don't
want to be waiting. Our players don't
want to be waiting, but we have some
standings of course that we went over at
the end of yesterday, but I really want
to focus on these 8 and 0 decks. We got
eight players here all the way from
Dewali down to Pog Chungus playing a
wide variety of these legends that
locked in going undefeated yesterday.
>> Yes. Uh that's the great thing about
seeing all these legends here and I want
to highlight how we have Dewali here on
that staple Diana deck and also one of
our champions of the past as well.
>> Yeah, Alan ZQ with a different version
of course and we know don't don't spoil
the sauce too much right now. But
speaking of sauce, we've got a couple of
these the secret sauce. Dizzy here at 70
and1 and Ryan Fairies that we want to
focus as well. But on our next slide, we
still want to pay attention to a lot of
these 7 in1 players as well. A lot of
these players we were able to kind of
look at and legends continue to be
diversified, which don't worry everyone,
we're going to get into those a little
bit more. I look at people like Azir,
Pike being piloted by Rat here and
Roosecow. These are decks that I think a
lot of people were maybe talking about
but not necessarily seeing right here
that are only one loss going into today.
>> Yeah, Pike was something that we really
had our eye on as a couple players were
considering bringing Pike such as
Prisbat. Decided to stay with that Annie
though.
>> Yeah, absolutely. And of course, you
still have some other familiar names
that we want to talk about. You see Rock
Low that we got to have on stream. Gonka
playing Annie because there's not just
Prismat at this tournament playing this
legend. There are quite a few others and
I'm excited to talk about them. No
veggies we have here. Again, another
representation for the secret sauce, but
challenger TCG is still someone in a
team that we don't want to forget about
here. So, these seven and one players
are 100% still in this running cuz as we
saw already, there's only eight
undefeateds. We have five more Swiss
rounds to go. There is even a
potentiality that an undefeated player
like these could continue to lose in
these rounds even before we get to the
next last few ones.
>> And I want to point out there, we even
have a Lux at 7 and one from Raid Bowser
here. So, that's awesome to see. Gail
wins is on Lilia at 71. We cast him
earlier and seeing him be successful on
this Lilia and for the team secret sauce
as well.
>> Absolutely. But we're over here talking
about standings as we continue to let
them fly through. I'm ready to talk
about a couple of these deck lists as
well because we want to highlight a few
of these before we dive into the action
today. So, we're going to pay attention
to maybe some of these legends that we
necessarily didn't think or have 100% on
our radar with also looking at some of
the discrepancies that different players
are bringing with the same legend. So,
first off, we want to dive into that
Azir deck that we kind of got to see at
the top of this. This is for our rat 69
Lys list. And, you know, I love Azir. I
think a lot of us here on the caster
desk are a lot of fans of Azir. This
deck isn't necessarily anything special
or crazy out there. Lots of threes, but
the deck is so consistent. And we saw
how aggressive it can be into Aurora
matchups.
>> Exactly. The big thing was the soul
sword being added from Unleash allowing
for that bit more consistency overall
into this deck. Something that a lot of
these players have gravitated towards.
>> Yeah, absolutely. And I think a lot of
extra tools for extra draw power being
added. Things like meditation and even
defensive tools like Back Off that also
still replace themselves as long as you
play them from hand. It's just a strong
deck. We already know how powerful death
grip can be and when you're just killing
off tokens, you know, the these sand
soldiers and moving it over to another
one, it feels like this temporary power
you're just delivering to another unit.
>> Yeah. And something else is on guard is
kind of a tech that we haven't seen from
a lot of players. And the reason being
is that usually you have a lot of sand
soldiers. So you don't have one unit
going in at a time a lot of the time,
but this on guard has added for really
great early game trades, especially with
things like mid-range Ye.
>> One last call out for this deck list,
the 3x here of the guards. I think this
card is obviously very strong and a lot
of people like it, but being able to
have a sort of accelerated version, a
ready sand soldier at your disposal. And
the fact that it has hidden as well
means you can play this for a lot
cheaper. But we're going to keep things
moving along. We've got more stuff. And
I had the pleasure to interview one of
our undefeated Kai'Sa decks from Senzari
yesterday. So, we want to take a look at
that deck list as well because 8 and0
Kaiso was not on I think anyone's radar
because a lot of people have been sort
of discounting this deck for quite a
while, I think, in this format. Yeah, we
got to see a lot from him as we got to
see him take down Aurora even earlier
and it was excellently navigated and
piloted by him. And something
interesting about this deck list is it
has a lot of pieces from Origins
overall. And really since hey no one's
playing Kai'Sa I think she's better than
this and I'm going to show people
exactly why
>> and he's showing all of us I think
especially me you know abs absolutely
pleasure to talk to him yesterday. Even
the smite being mainboarded here
respecting the Leblancs in the room.
Turn to dust of course still being
mainboarded as well. Making sure that we
can respect these Aurora decks and other
instrumental gears that you go to. But
the main boarded two time warp. It's
just so interesting seeing the evolution
of this legend because we've seen all
the way back, you know, how many of
Kathn Reigns do I play? Well, right now
it's none. But time warp, you know, that
took its spot for a little while. Maybe
a mixture of both. And now we're seeing
the solid solidification right now. At
least in this format, time warp seems to
be the one to stick with.
>> Oh, yeah. Time warp is so good in this
format, too, because you do get to keep
it secret a lot of the time. And also it
allows you to sneak into those Aurora
games where you're able to time warp and
then get those extra points. Uh
something else that I would like to
highlight is the void seeker. Something
that we saw a lot in set one. Then we
saw it not really be around in set two,
but it has come back mostly to deal with
Vex apathetic. So seeing Void Seeker
once again into the Kaiso list is really
interesting.
>> I love Void Seeker. It draws a card, you
know, it feels really good. Just got to
avoid those defies for sure. This one
feels real bad if you end up having to
get that card taken care of. We want to
continue to move along though. We have
another interesting deck. Sticking with
the fury domain, we've got Roose Cow on
this pike list. And I'll be honest with
you, I'm not a huge expert on this deck.
But what I am an expert on is that Fury
and Chaos historically has always been
good. And this might be the legend to
talk about aside from maybe something
like Annie. Yes, exactly. Also, I just
love how Pike has gone about hidden
cards and also featuring our new card.
Baron Nasher is a main wing condition of
the deck. This is a card that people
thought of originally was going to be an
Aurora, but instead Pah said, "You know
what? This is a really good card for me
to win the game with instead." I think
we have to highlight Fizz as well. I
think Fizz has been such an instrumental
card, not just for this deck, because of
the ability to have it back to your hand
and get another use of a Fizz. It's I
mean, it just tells me why there's two
copies in it. but being able to reuse a
lot of these spells that we can have and
bring them back from the from the trash
pile as well as being able to have a
very strong champion unit to play. Right
here we have our Pike that is incredibly
early to play. We saw the success from
the champion unit from Pike uh when
going second especially just dropping it
on the first turn.
>> Yes, having that utility has been huge
in this deck. And I also like just
having a lot of hand disruption as well
with the Mindsplitter being a key card
in this deck too. And we see a lot of
Auroras and things that we want to take
out of the hand nice and early and mind
spplitter is a great way to do that.
>> We've seen in the Aurora decks of
course, but let's talk about some deck
comparisons. We have quite a few legends
obviously that are represented in
multiple ways, but players are starting
to take their own takes now.
Prismaticism here that we want to
highlight coming into this day two. This
is still his bread and butter. We've
been playing Annie now for quite a
while. Plenty of bests that we have
already taken home. And this list to me
is very familiar to what we've seen. I
love the Kha'Zix that's been added into
this deck. We saw the success from
ambush units literally winning him a
regional qualifier in Atlanta because
you can't counter spell a unit, but
Kha'Zix, a lot of people are attacking
with singular units right now to get on
the battlefield and Kha'Zix just really
takes advantage of that.
>> Yes, he's excellent. And overall, this
deck has been highly refined by
Prismaticism. So, it's even found its
spot in other decks that are similar to
it. But a big thing with it, of course,
is the star cross. We have to highlight
that card. We talked about how key this
card is in multiple decks already and it
gives Annie extra utility because you
can throw back your own Annie and you
can continue to recycle the spells.
We've seen it do very well with Fizz in
the past, but Annie just has her own
access to her champion unit right away.
>> Um, we're and now we're going to look at
another Annie list. This one is going to
be piloted instead this weekend and the
rest of the day today by Bolan Zang, who
is another known name in the community.
I also want to make a shout out. This
list is pretty comparable to Gonkra's
list who we saw take down and go seven
and0 in that seventh round of Swiss
yesterday. This one having a way
different focus. Ambush units, things
like Grim Apothecary, but the hidden
cards in this deck are incredible. Yes,
I absolutely love this Evelyn tech. It's
something that personally wasn't on my
radar at all. And being able to play
Evelyn to essentially charm a unit into
you when you have all these ambush and
assault units is very helpful and giving
yourself a little bit extra proactivity
on the board as well.
>> Chaos Domain Pike. I think this card is
a little under reppresented in my opin
in my opinion just because I think it's
just so powerful as a unit. It's so much
might to be bring onto a battlefield out
of nowhere and like you said the Evelyn
trick is so incredibly powerful. So, the
the biggest thing to me as we kind of
take a moment is this deck is focusing a
lot more about playing units during
showdowns, right? As you can already
see, you know, from the beans that we
get to play, extra draw cards, but it's
a lot easier to do that with not just
hidden cards, also with the ambush units
that we're playing. And we still get to
take advantage of highlevel spells such
as flash to keep our units alive.
>> Yes, I absolutely love just seeing these
different takes on the Annie deck. Uh
because it they're both being
successful, too. That's the biggest
thing is these are successful Annie
decks with very different game plans and
different ideas of how to pilot these
decks.
>> Moving on to our last little deck
highlight that we want to do. This is
another comparison. That's right. We've
got CTG Allen ZQ here. Also a regional
qualifier champion winner here and this
is a shifted version of the deck that
we've kind of seen. This is Allen's
version, but we have another one that we
want to talk about soon after this. And
I mean the fact is that he's been not
just refining this deck, but refining
these domains for quite a while now. and
has really defined himself as a mind
chaos player. And it makes sense. The
tools inside of this deck are just so
powerful.
>> And Allen has his unique play style,
too, that he's really used this deck to
refine to his play style. He does really
like some of those grindy, slower
control games, high value overall.
Something I want to highlight is the
acceptable losses in the main deck.
Something that we were expecting players
to see is a lot of potential Aurora or
gear. And Allan saying, you know, I
don't even want this just in my
sideboard. I want it on the main board
so I always have access to it.
>> Still playing powerful cards of course.
Hi, I think is the talk of the town for
the Mayan domain right now. Um, so I'm
excited to see even with this comparison
and the comparison deck that we want to
take a look at is another regional
qualifier champion who is also moving at
8 to0 coming in today. That's right,
it's Dewali who is piloting a sideways
version of this deck is the best way to
describe it. And we have to talk about
the big big difference that a lot of
people are interesting. Frigid Jewel.
Yes, this is a card that once again has
been a hot take. Is this card good or
not? And why is it good? So, seeing
Dewali saying yes, Frigid Duel is good.
I get to give extra might usually way is
a very common one to be able to get over
uh some of these stronger cards such as
like an elder dragon for instance, being
able to take that out. And also too, we
have Consult the Pass, which isn't
really something we've seen very often
in these Diana decks.
>> No. And it's a card that I think just
really helps refuel all those tool extra
tools. And it's another hidden card that
you can put down to maybe like scare
your opponent away on like what could it
be cuz we typically are going to imagine
it's going to be a tide turner. But when
you have another option that's like
actually you played around this tide
turner, you didn't let me use any more
resources. I get a little freebie and
I'll flip this up and I'll drop two more
cards. So absolutely great to see how
the difference between these two decks
throughout the day is going to go.
>> Yes. And especially too Dewali and Allen
CQ, they're testing partners and they
came up with two very different versions
of how to play this deck and what they
wanted in the deck.
>> Yeah. Now, that was a look in the
specialization of these decks from these
players that are going to have to play
out five more rounds of Swiss and
hopefully make their way to top eight
later today. But we want to talk about
the tournament as a whole. So, we're
going to take a look at some of the top
cards across the weekend of in general.
So, we're going to start with units or
gear. We got gear going first. So we
have right I mean it's not really a big
surprise Aurora being here in the middle
but still not the number one card of the
day recursion and recalling your units
back. Zonia's Hourglass and Guardians
Angel. So a lot of that we're probably
seeing from our Aurelia decks. I'm a
little bit surprised to see the
Hourglass be a little bit higher. Of
course Yi can use it as well. So it's
probably really coming down to the Yi
and Airelia and a few other of those
green decks as well. So the guardian
angel of course all over Aurelia. You
have to protect yourself from those
elder dragons for instance. And then
just keeping yourself alive from cold a
week as we've seen multiple times in
these casts as well in these games.
>> And I my spawn one cuz we were already
just talking about the mind domain
sprite fountain has been huge.
Absolutely huge. Well, I I remember
having an interview lit literally
yesterday and someone was explaining to
me how the amount of might total payoff
you get for that card for how much the
energy and the power cost are is is
something that's just not really
replicated somewhere else in the game
without needing additional pieces. This
is a singular card that you can put into
your deck and it generates two sprite
tokens across its, you know, lifetime.
>> And we've seen Lilia utilize it
extremely well is a big thing because
the amount of might that you get from it
very quickly.
>> Absolutely. Moving on to our mostused
units. I think Vex Apathetic makes a ton
of sense, but I have to call out my MVP
for the entirety of the weekend. It's
Seymour the Scuttle Crab hand
information is so big right now.
>> See the how much more this card has been
being played. A lot of people really
underlooked it saying it's zero might.
What really can it do? But after this,
we saw it do very well in Sydney and a
lot of Ireelia players, a lot of Yi
players were all saying yes, we have to
play this in our deck. And the hand
information has been absolutely critical
as you're able to play around things
that you wouldn't have been able to play
around before because you know the hand,
you know exactly what to do.
>> Th this percentage next to Elder Dragon
is so telling to me as well. It's not
that I obviously everyone knows that
Aurora is here and Aurora is doing well,
but 14% to me is just so drastically
different when I look at Vex Apathetic
at 33 and dare I say the Origins Allstar
in that Thousand Tailed Watcher
operators are represented in this top
three because Thousand Tale Watcher is
just finding a home in all of these mind
legends across the board. LeBlanc is
playing this card. You know, we see
people Diana are maybe even playing a
version of it. Ezreal still likes to
play it there. There's just so much of
it across the board.
>> Oh yeah, Victor as well. all we saw
earlier. So, a lot of options there. And
I do like to see that Elder Dragon isn't
as highly represented as we expected. We
saw Kai'Sa at the same amount.
>> And then our last most used list is
going to be for spells. Honestly, Gust
on top of the list here is kind of
surprising because we just kind of
talked about how, you know, a stacked
deck next to it is a telling story as
well because we've talked about
yesterday and a lot across the weekend
how some decks are starting to cut
copies of stacked deck, but maybe it's
because they're being replaced from the
disruption of Gust. Exactly. Something
that we saw is Allen went from zero Gust
all the way up to three Gust in his
Diana deck, saying, "You know what? I
actually do love the tempo that I get
from Gust. It is an extreme amount
really and it keeps Lelanc off the
board. It's another favorite deck. So,
being able to have an exact answer to
Leblanc is really nice as well.
>> All right, I think the players are
starting to get ready for some real
action. The tournament is really heating
up. I can I can feel the tension in the
room behind me, honestly. So, we're
going to talk about conversion rates and
that's the last thing that we're really
going to set our players up before we
send it over to our casters. So, for the
top decks in the room, we want to really
pay attention to a lot of these legends.
So the ones that we saw represented
highly on day one of course the Ireelia,
Diana's, Master Yiz, Bladesmen, Leblanc,
Kazir, Kha'Zix, Annie, and Civer. And
then next to them, you can see based off
of that total number how many of them
are here in day two. And honestly, I
think it's pretty much speaks for
itself. I think the only one I'm very
surprised with is a 41% from Kha'Zix.
Yes, the Kha'Zix one is the first one
that comes to my mind as well,
especially when there's multiple ways to
play Kha'Zix right now. Not only is
there Aurora, but we have seen mid-range
tempo Kha'Zix do very well, too.
>> Yeah, the Annie makes sense. We were
just highlighting two different versions
that are basically making a run for it.
But I also have to call attention to
we're talking about Aurora quite a bit,
but Civer's all the way down there at
17.
>> I mean, a big thing that we've seen
multiple players just miss their
Auroras, and Civer doesn't really have
the recovery tools to come back if she
does miss Aurora, and that sometimes you
just draw the wrong part of your deck.
Same thing with Misfortune
>> and we at top right corner right here.
League of Draven might be back because
we have had some successful Draven lists
moving into today and I'm excited to see
again where this fury and chaos domain
kind of combination comes back from. We
talked about Annie, we've already talked
about Pike now that Draven is still to
come and we know how strong this
champion or this legend can be because
of all the draw abilities. I will say
the kind of underperformance from uh
even I think Vex has kind of
disappointed me this weekend that I've
seen at least not even being represented
in that 8 and0 bracket. But man, look at
that Lux there. You talked about it at
71. 9.7% is not very high of course, but
Set still making a name for himself at
25.
>> Yeah, set is really interesting because
we've seen players really have a hard
time doing well on it outside. But we'll
take a look at also Poppy. I'm really
excited about Poppy and Jin. Jyn having
two make it to the next A after not
being very successful in Sydney. So
players are continuing to refine this
deck.
>> Absolutely. And with that we are going
to show off the last few of these
legends. Of course now we have you know
we must say farewell to some of these
legends towards the end here because
those bests have already been locked in
where they will be awarded later today.
But there will not be any Rumbles,
Master Yi, um Master Bladesman, Jinxes
and Jaxes either here today. And you
know I think there was a couple too but
we're going to go ahead and quickly move
along. Of course, we already had eight
rounds of Swiss yesterday, but we want
to pay attention to what we're going to
be doing today. That's right. We have
five more rounds of Swiss as it is
championship Sunday here and then we
will cut to a single elimination top
eight. And I genuinely think, Silver,
that it could be anyone's game.
>> It definitely can.
>> All right, so we're going to go ahead
and quickly keep continue to moving.
We're going to have the schedule, but
now we're going to keep on moving along
for the prizing that these players are
going to be going for. Remember that Vex
top 128 is something that players are
actually fighting for here. You can't
just show up to these five rounds here
and lose them cuz you won't go home with
that extra prizing that's been added as
well.
>> And of course that top 64 that regional
championship invite something else that
a lot of players are gunning for as
well.
>> Yeah, I mean I know a lot of people that
are specifically here just to go and get
that. Of course they want to go for the
win total, but it's also one of those
things that you have to show up and the
extra prize wall tickets. Of course
there's plated legends that people want
to take home. But our last little stop
here for today before we get to some
actual action. I must applaud you all.
You guys had some excellent choices and
I think the fact that we have two
different Diana decks that we're paying
attention to for the rest of today is
really speaks volumes for the three of
y'all. But Urs Day is going to make take
a run for y'all's money because Leblanc
is still represented.
>> Oh, of course. I mean, all these decks
are ones that we expected to go through
and I am really happy to see Diana being
undefeated. So, I can't wait to see more
of her. But that's a lot of yapping from
us. We did a lot of information and
stats for you all. I hope you can enjoy
them at home for the rest of today. Just
keep those in mind because now it's time
to look at the players. And for those
players, we're going to send it to the
casters to kick us off for round nine.
All right, thank you guys for covering
all that. A lot of data. We had a huge
Saturday and we just halfway through the
event. I am here with Ursa Day. How you
feeling this morning? Uh, I'm having a
great morning so far. A little bit sad
to only see one undefeated Leblanc
versus two undefeated Diana's, but what
about you?
>> Uh, you know, I'm actually a little bit
happy about that if you ask me in
comparison. But, uh, you know, it should
be a lot of fun. And, and the thing
about today, too, is that, you know,
even if you're 8, you are not guaranteed
into anything yet. You still have to
play five more rounds. And we've got a
lot of action coming up.
>> Yeah, I think we're going to have some
fantastic games here today. Obviously
coming to day two, we have players who
were able to go minimum six and two
yesterday and I mean they're fighting
tooth and nail
>> definitely. And we've got our round nine
setup and we've got two potential
matches. Let's see what we've got. And
we've got some voting in the chat. So if
you guys want match A, which is going to
be Kai'Sa versus Diana, press A in the
chat. And otherwise for match B, Diana
versus Annie, press B in the chat and
we'll see what ends up winning that.
>> I think both of these matches could be I
mean absolute master classes. Obviously,
Dewali is a regional uh qualifier
champion from Houston. Obviously, a
different deck this time uh because he
is playing Diana. And then obviously,
Prismaticism who's done fantastically as
well in this game so far playing Annie
in match B. So, make sure that you guys
do vote in chat, A in chat for that CIR
versus Dewali and B in chat for Wise Guy
versus Prismaticism. I see two potential
Diana wins here. So, I'm not really
upset on either of them, right? And
we're going to see, you know, uh, some
of the more origins for it, either the
Kai'Sa and Annie, but looks like we're
going to see, I think, match B, Wise Guy
versus Prismaticism, is going to be
Diana versus Annie.
>> Definitely not sad to see this one.
Really excited to see how this plays
out. Uh, this is going to be really
exciting.
>> Yeah. So, uh, I think we looked at some
of these deck lists previously, uh, with
Barrett and Silverfuse, but we're going
to look at the decks real quick. So, we
got Wise Guy here with Diana, and we've
seen a couple builds. I think the big
biggest uh choice is if we're playing
frigid jewel or not. That's been a kind
of decision point, but I do see a little
bit more uh other gear, right? We see
the boots of swiftness and last rights
in this build, which I don't normally
see in it.
>> Yeah, I think these are going to be
really interesting to see how they do
play out. I do think we may have seen a
last rights yesterday in this list, but
you did.
>> Definitely not a boost of swiftness,
though.
>> Yeah, not a boot of swiftness at all.
And we're really excited to see how
ganking can affect this game play
interest obvious also that Kha'Zix which
we did see in Sydney but I mean we
haven't seen as much at this tournament
with that unit
>> definitely. So uh here's wise guys list
and we're going to see uh I think
Prismaticism's list in a second here. Uh
obviously Prismaticism's been known for
playing Annie, known for being uh you
know an owner of some of those bests who
want to continue that streak I'm sure
and there has been I think a couple
updates as we've seen previously.
>> Yeah, definitely for sure. And I mean he
has I think three already best of this
Annie. Actually insane. But there's so
many really cool cards I think in this
deck. I'm really excited to see how he
uses those ambush cards especially.
>> Yeah. and specifically Annie, when you
get those two extra runes on defense,
but now you have more things to do in
those windows. Uh, you know, just
exponential more plays you can do. So, I
think we're ready. I think they're
ready, too. So, let's go see our round
nine match again. It's going to be uh
the uh Diana versus Annie.
>> I cannot wait to see what uh we have in
store here. It does look like it's going
to be that abandoned hall for Wise Guy
and seat of power for Annie. Abandoned
Hall, I think, is going to work really
well obviously with Diana. She loves to
cast spells and abandon hall loves them
as well.
>> Yeah. And then we've got seed of power
for pmaticism. So, uh being able to get
that potential extra drop is nice. I
think sometimes Annie is a deck that we
have a lot of runes but not necessarily
uh you know active cards to play with
them all the time. So, that will help
quite a bit.
>> Yeah, I definitely definitely agree with
that. It's going to be really exciting
to see how these do interact. I think
both these players kind of have that
like extra energy that you're not really
going to expect from their legend
ability. Diana obviously does get an
energy during showdowns if you exhaust
her that you can use for spells as well
as Annie during your opponent's turn
does get those two runes back as well.
>> Yeah. And and also you know if we
weren't already like the you know one of
the best if not the best Annie player.
Prismaticism has the Do you see little
necklace he was wearing?
>> I did not. Is it
>> when he moves his arm? You're going to
see he is he is like Yeah. I I play
Annie. I I know how this deck works. Uh
definitely my my favorite card. Yeah.
See right there. Yeah. Very fun. Very,
very fun. So, resolving our mulligans.
We're getting started here. And looks
like Wise Guy is starting us off. Two
runes, double chaos.
>> That's going to feel really nice. And it
does look like it's going to be that
plungering porro here going down from
Wise Guy. I mean, really nice to start
generating some different resources when
it conquers is able to generate a gold.
>> Yeah, we're playing up the grim
apothecary and passing. And you know,
this is also, you know, kind of an
interesting matchup, right? Uh we do
have Diana where we get, you know, one
uh extra of this energy, but we can, you
know, the timing is a little bit more
specific. You know, Andy gets two extra
runes, which is usually two extra
energy, but you can only use it on your
opponent's turn, so you're a little bit
less flexible with the timing. So, uh
you know, that's that's just interesting
in general, I think.
>> Yeah, I think both of them I mean, they
definitely work in different ways, so
it'll be cool to see how it affects the
tour uh of the game.
>> Yeah. And uh looks like we play out our
Diana Champion first. We're leaving the
Porro in the base. They're not feeling
like plundering today, but we've got
five runes for Prismaticism, and we'll
see how they use them.
>> Yeah, I'm really excited to see what
they do here. Maybe prismaticism will
move to one of these battlefields. Would
love to see obviously those points start
to stack up.
>> Yeah, and especially with like seed of
power, right? Uh you're so inclined to
be able to take both battlefields at the
same time. This could be like I'm going
to take a turn off from getting points,
but make it easier for me to get the
double points and the draw next turn.
>> That makes a lot of sense. And honestly,
staying sometimes on those even points
can be really important as we move into
units. You may move up to one enemy unit
to that location. Enemy units at that
location get minus two might this turn.
>> All right. And I think just making sure
on
>> uh yeah, a a card or yeah, how Moonfall
works. Yeah. So, choose a battlefield
where you have units, you may move them
to one enemy unit to that battlefield,
then give an enemy unit there minus two
might that turn. So, obviously a
signature spell uh you know, we do, you
know, Annie's Annie is kind of
interesting where we don't necessarily
use our signature cards. Obviously, like
the the champion unit for Annie has been
very good. We've seen it also wander
into other decks, right? We did see it
in uh 420 YOLO Swags. Yeah. build of the
civer yesterday and did some work. But
uh yeah, just going to play out the
Kai'Sa for four and get two rooms back.
>> Yeah, I thought that was so interesting
seeing Annie in uh that civer list
yesterday. Obviously, he did help a lot
and I really think that obviously Annie
is pretty good at it here as well. But
on Prismaticism side, he actually gets
to choose when he wants that Annie
because that chosen champion spot so
unique to this game is really nice to to
kind of save her there for the perfect
moment. Yeah, it's it's such a good ace
in the hole for for a deck like this.
And again, what my favorite thing about
Annie is you're just you have so many
decisions and you're so flexible. And
you know, even the games you lose,
you're like, "All right, I think there
was another play line that we can do."
And uh that's really rewarding as a
player.
>> Yeah, I think decks that you get to have
all these decision points can really
help you then, you know, that's where
that skill expression really comes in.
>> Yeah. So, uh again, we're at Wise Guys,
uh you know, it's it's funny. We're zero
points across the board, you know,
against some, you know, kind of these
more aggressive faster. We're just going
to play out the Hawaii uh and keeping it
in the back, trying to keep it safe. Uh
recognizing that, you know what, uh you
know, every turn that I just don't do
anything. That's runes they didn't use,
right? Uh you have to be careful about
all this ambush mechanics, right? That's
something I think that Annie can take
advantage of with all these new fury
cards, too. Uh and yeah, is very strong.
>> Yeah, I think that's a great point. I
think it's so interesting to see though,
as you said, like both of these more
kind of aggressive decks work into our
turn threes now and still not a single
point on board. Kind of interesting to
see like how they're having to play
around some of these new mechanics.
>> Yeah, and you know, uh we've seen it
with Aurelia. There are some units in
the game such as Hawaii, uh that we want
to protect because the longer they're on
the board, the more value they get. Uh,
and you know, in in these both these
decks, right, we have a lot of uh, you
know, quicker uh, spells and stuff we
can play, but we need to make sure that
we get our uh, card draw associated with
it. So, all right. Uh, moving up to the
abandoned hall here,
>> asking for a point and a card draw. And
there it is. First point of the game.
And, uh, with the conquer from Kaiso, we
do get that extra draw. And we're trying
to go for another draw here. And yeah,
that's 20 for Prismat. And, uh, getting
that additional draw, too. Yeah, that is
I mean nice going to get up to two here.
I have I mean I think this is one of the
reasons that Kai'Sa the uh unit has you
know survive so long in the meta is just
that draw ability once you've conquered.
Really really nice.
>> Yeah. All right. Looks like we are
see considering playing another card.
Okay. Starcross here. We're going to use
it on the way and looks like potentially
the inferno there. Yep. Get it back to
hand. Yeah, I think it's interesting how
so many of these different players are
really prioritizing keeping Hua off the
board. We saw it in so many different
matches yesterday and even today was
very particular about how he played that
inferno and then later in the game still
pushing that back into wise guy's hand.
>> Yeah. And and the inferno is really
interesting because we can uh play it
for two, right? We get the two runes out
open uh and we do have the Noxis Hopeful
there again. uh all these cards that we
get to play for two. Whenever you see
these, you're like, "Well, I get two
extra runes every turn, so this this is
perfect for me." And uh we're gonna see
if Wise Guy is feeling uh confident
enough to maybe challenge these
battlefields now.
>> Yeah, I have to think Wise Guy has a lot
to kind of like account for coming. This
those two runes could very potentially
be that Inferno again coming down with
ambush or multiple different spells that
Annie has in their toolbox.
All right, we've got seven runes here.
Uh I believe we have for Wise Guy since
we did have to recycle one for the
Hawaii last turn. Uh we are going to
play out the boots of swiftness here. Uh
uh you know this is a more unusual ad
from my uh the buildout and we're going
to go into the Kai'Sa. We're currently 5
to three and uh considering the ability
from the
>> uh from the Kai'Sa here or not from the
Diana resolve once. I thought I didn't
pay until it was resolving.
Yeah. And and there is a a new I know
ruling for this Diana where it goes on
the stack and then you don't pay it
until it resolves. Uh so I know that
this is kind of a newer ruling for this
today. Um so just confirming on that
one.
>> Yeah. Yeah. You have to commit to the
you have to tell if you want to go on
the chain.
>> So I have to pay one and then it's on
>> You say I want to go on the chain.
>> Okay.
>> So before he resolves I pay you. I have
to pay one for. Okay. Okay.
>> I've heard this rolled literally both
different ways, I think, at multiple
points, but no worries.
>> So, yeah, I will pay for those.
>> Y
>> and uh think of Okay, so we're here to
interact with it. We're just going to
flash back both of our units at both
battlefields here.
>> And we're going to hard bargain uh which
you know you when they have zero runes
up, you know, it's the bargain is very
>> very difficult to uh to not take there.
So, we are going to use the uh Diana
effect. We're going to see a stack deck
off the top there. So, we add that to
hand and it's five to four.
>> And yeah, there goes the
>> Kai'Sa.
>> Getting to deny that uh flash feels so
painful for prismaticism. I mean, being
able to flash both those units safely
back to base with just two runes would
have kept I mean, so much might on our
side as well as then just opening us up
to having more options next turn. So I
mean that hard bargain really hurts
here.
>> Yeah. And and Kaiso is also just like a
unit where uh you know you are able to
uh you know continually get draw the
more and more it conquers. So we are
just going to play out a Raven Bloom
student and we're going to pass it
there. So uh you know no runes up for
Wise Guy and we've already used our
Diana legend ability. So uh you know
Prisbat's really kind of in a spot where
they can do whatever they want now.
>> Yeah, that part is so nice. I mean, a
lot of times we're talking about how
much information we get from someone's
hand from cards like Scuttle Crab, but
the information of like knowing that
your opponent can't do anything this
turn because of their lack of
unexhausted runes is really nice as
well.
>> Mhm. So, we got whole eight runes here
and looks like I'm guessing uh a cleave
here. So, just making sure. Uh so, that
will be seven to five. There goes our
Diana and uh we will be able to keep our
boots of swiftness though.
four points now. And we're going to move
the apothecary back.
Going to pay 34
>> and recycle one to play out our Annie.
And we're going to use it to get our
star cross back.
>> Now, there's like a, you know, a mild,
you know, infinite loop, right, with
Annie and Starcross. You just keep using
it to play each other, right? uh you
know, you still got to pay the the runes
for it, but uh you know, it's if you
already have like the tempo lead, that's
a really good interaction.
>> Yeah. And honestly, when Annie is kind
of, you know, just like getting those
rune backs every single time they pass,
it doesn't completely pay for the star
cross, but it it gets pretty close.
>> Yeah.
>> All right, we've got again, I think a
full uh not full, but we've got eight
runes here. Uh I think we know that, you
know, Wise Guy still has a Hawaii in
hand. uh that we would would have loved
to have on the the base here, but uh not
quite yet. We do have the boots of
swiftness, but again with six runes
ready on the other side, there's so many
things you have to play around.
>> Yeah, that is so true. And we just know
there's so many options that
prismaticism could have. Obviously,
again, we have those ambush cards in
this any list. Obviously, those spells
and you know, starcross is in hand as
well. It does look like we're going to
attach that boots of swiftness to the
Raven Bloom student and up into
abandoned hall.
>> Yeah. And so we are going to go
>> uh yeah five into uh this three here and
we are going to play out a stacked deck.
Uh so this will also get essentially an
additional plus two might uh off of the
abandoned hall and the student. So
looking at top three.
Yeah, it feels like Abandoned Hall is
just like so nice with Raven Bloom
Student. Both with a very similar
ability that when you play a spell, uh,
you do get that extra might.
>> All right, so deciding what we get
there. So start off as a five to four
and then sorry, four to four and then
with the plus two, it's currently a six
to four.
>> So we are just above it here. I wonder
if prismaticism will have any options to
try to even this out cuz obviously we do
have, you know, fury uh fury runes.
>> We know that there are damage spells,
you know, in the fury domain. And I have
to wonder like does Prism have
something? He's got five runes up.
>> Yeah. And like we also have a lot of
ability to again like ambush has been
again a new uh mechanic that's been like
fully realized with unleashed here. Uh
Annie being able to just have all these
additional runes available means that we
can play uh you know with these reacts a
lot nicer here. Uh and then also Wise
Guy I think is doing a really good job.
It's it's really tough when uh you know
you are just barely beating uh you know
a battlefield by might and it's you have
to kind of double invest into it but
wise guy ends up taking the second point
here uh will offer a chance for the
plundering porro to uh to not only start
plundering but get you a card draw off
the seed of power here. So that will be
nice if it resolves. But Prismat looking
at their hand, seeing if there's
anything they want to do about this this
porro here.
>> Let's see what they decide to do. But
obviously Wise Guy needs to start taking
these points, bringing it back.
Prismaticism was feeling pretty
confident I feel like at the beginning
or at the end of his own turn being able
to control both those battlefields
already at four. Mhm.
>> So
>> yeah, and something like specifically
for both these decks, uh because we also
have this uh idea that we have extra
runes and energy to work with, it's very
easy for us just to use everything all
at once and then kind of run out of gas.
But uh both of them are kind of have to,
you know, respect each other. They have
to make sure like, you know, I could,
you know, dump a bunch of my resources
here, but then I'm out of resources. So
they're trying to find the best way to
effectively use everything. And again,
making sure you you're applying the
right amount of pressure. Like it's just
a two might porro, right? But that's
going to offer a gold and a card draw.
Can I afford to let them do that?
>> Yeah. And I think the point of like this
is kind of like a resource game, right?
Like who obviously we both have a lot of
runes, a lot of energy, a lot of power
to be able to spend and spells to spend
them with orb ambush cards to spend them
with, but you need the number of cards
to do it. And kind of seed of power is
going to be giving out all this card
draw, especially when you already have
control of the other battlefield as
well. And so I have to wonder like at
some point do you think I'm going to
spend stuff to starve them of resources
if they're out if they might get low on
cards and
>> do I want to prioritize it or not?
>> Yeah. So we end up reacting with the
Rengar to base. Uh another thing to kind
of really balance is that you know with
everything having really open timing uh
for Annie specifically uh you can leave
a lot open to make your opponent worried
but then you need to make sure that
you're still investing those runes or
you kind of lose them right.
>> Mhm. So, just saying, you know what, I
don't really have anything to contest
here. I'm just going to uh play my
Rengar to, you know, at least use some
of the runes I got uh for the previous
turn and uh let them continue their
turn.
All right, so it's three points for Wise
Guy and four for Prismaticism. We still
have not only the seven runes open, but
we also do have one floating here. Uh
and we'll see what the choices. We were
able to get the draw and the gold off of
that conquer, which is nice. And yeah,
now we just got to decide how we use the
rest of our runes here.
>> Yeah, I mean, and as you said, you kind
of do want to spin them to some extent,
as in that you don't want uh when it
comes back to your turn to not have been
able to use them to the best of your
ability. Does look like it's going to be
that fizz allowing us to then play one
of these spells from our trash pile and
it's going to be stack deck.
>> Yep. And looking out the top three
there, I think I saw a Hawaii and
another stack deck. Uh I think they got
the the one card he didn't see. So we'll
see what that ends up being. But uh we
got that there with the Fizz. You know,
obviously having a draw one off a card
like this is fine. Uh still five runes
open. We could be trying to play out the
Hawaii again.
>> Does also just offer us really no
interaction on the other side. But you
know, having a Raven student on a
abandoned hall does it is terrifying,
right? like it can just get so uh so
much might off of a couple spells.
>> Yeah, for sure. I would definitely be
concerned as prismaticism like how I'm
going to deal with that Raven Bloom
student. Obviously, Plundering Porro, I
mean, it's too might. It's it could be
generating gold in the long term. Uh but
it's not going to scale in the same way
that this Raven Bloom on Abandoned Hall
very well can.
>> Oh, but it's got a buddy now. Uh we've
got the Raven Bloom student there. So,
we got four might uh at both
battlefields right now, but any spell we
play uh Wise Sky will be able to get a
lot of additional might with especially
three of these runes open.
>> Yeah, that is for sure. So many options
with those three runes.
>> All right, back to Prismaticism. We've
got eight runes right now. Four points
to three. Uh again, the other thing is
that, you know, if we want to try to
conquer some of these battlefields, uh
we definitely want to try to get the
abandoned hall first and seat of power
second. Uh just offers us a card draw,
but uh you know, we'll see.
>> I'll swing in five to four.
>> It's going to be the Rengar here and I
think it's going to be 524 right now
with the assault two.
>> Yeah, I mean five to four obviously
right now Rengar is winning, but any
spell can boost that Raven Bloom just
right above that Rengar. Yeah, there's
cards as we've seen stack deck that
could also be like a supify uh which
would be great. It' offer a three might
deficit, right? Two uh might to your
raven boom suit and one minus to the
Rengar.
>> Yeah, that would
look like we are going to be doing
something here. It is going to be that
supify just like you mentioned.
>> Yeah. So, uh yeah, using it on
likely the the Rengar, but it could be
anything really. Uh, this is going to
offer a lot of additional uh, might, but
this does have to resolve to do so. So,
we'll see if prismaticism lets it
resolve.
>> I'm going to respond
gust.
>> Respond with gust on the other student
before you're able to get the additional
uh, you know, spell there. So, that does
mean that it will be too tiny and you'd
have to essentially play I think two
more spells right now. reaction to be
able to get rid of it. But Gus ends up
working here. We do get the additional
boost here from the student. We get the
draw and the minus one. Additionally, we
do get the plus one on the Rengar from
the abandoned hall yourself. We're
playing out the long sword for another
plus two might here. And uh we'll have
to decide we'll have to make sure what
the total might totals are on that
battlefield. Yeah, I think that was such
like good forethought by by prismaticism
reacting with that gust to start
decreasing what is on the other
battlefield, especially when wise guy,
he has to think like, do I really want
to commit to save it versus I'm already
in a fight and maybe he doesn't want to
just yet, but that long sword is kind of
going to seal the deal up at the
abandoned hall.
>> Yeah, and I think we used the supify
must have been on uh maybe the Annie.
Uh, I'm not exactly sure where it
landed, but uh it does not look like it
was on the Rengar. So,
or it must it must have been on the
Rengar and then you got the the it was a
plus on the abandoned hall. That's what
it was. Yeah. So, there were there
weren't any dice because it got a plus
one and a minus one.
All right. So, we're back to wise guy
again. Prismaticism able to get to six
points. Uh, and this is really key cuz a
double conquer next turn could get you
there. Uh, we only have the one Annie in
the back. We also have seven runes left
open uh when we pass. So that is a lot
of interaction that Annie can do. Uh
wise guy currently just has a single
fizz with the boots of swiftness. So uh
it's going to be difficult to to really
move uh aggressively I find.
>> Yeah, I mean wise guy obviously only
does have to take one of these
battlefields to stop prismaticism from
winning for the hold, but then
prismaticism has so many points points
runes open to kind of just take it back
next turn. So, I think Panic is in a
really nice spot. I mean, six is the
magic number, I feel like, when it comes
to Annie.
>> Yeah. And right Yeah. It's five to three
right now. So, even if we had like
another long sword, uh, you know, we'd
just be tying.
>> And yeah, again, with seven runes open,
there's so much you can do with it.
>> Yeah, that is for sure.
I have to wonder. Do I I
>> do you want to stop the attack here and
win off that hold?
>> I mean, you know, there is what is this?
>> Eight runes up on Wise Guy's side. It
looks like we are just going to let that
grim apothecary die.
>> Yeah. So, got to four points here for
Wise Guy. But, uh, you know, at this
point too, it could just be a simple
hold on the Bandon Hall. and then just
being able to conquer the seat of power
for the eighth point. So, you know,
fantasticism is just offering a lot of
pressure to try to take the win next
turn.
>> Yes.
>> Let's see.
>> I think yeah, there's four cars in hand
as well. We are just going to play out
the Vex uh as we noticed the the most
played unit I think this weekend.
>> Yeah, I think that's what we saw earlier
which is I mean it seems like a very
strong card and it seems like every
single player is agreeing with that.
Vexman at a battlefield makes it where
your opponent's cards when they are
played are stunned. Uh so this is going
to be it's difficult then to play a card
and get it in somewhere to attack. So
it's kind of only the Annie that we have
a risk with right now.
>> Yeah. So we go to our seventh point here
for prismaticism and yeah we're just
like okay well we could hold this. Uh
they've made it very difficult to you
know conquer this seat of power. We not
only have inherently nine might on it
right now, uh, but we also do have a
hidden card. Vex also kind of prevents
like any new cards hitting the board,
uh, you know, either from accelerate or
from ambush. However, they will be
stunned and not be able to move for the
turn. So, uh, you know, I think a really
tough spot to try to get that eighth
point here.
>> Yeah, definitely. Definitely.
>> And obviously you could also try to hold
for that eighth point up where that
Rengar is.
>> There's so many questions, right? What
is that hidden card? What are those two
runes that are up? We also still do have
that Diana legend that is not tapped
yet. So we, you know, that is an extra
energy in a showdown as well.
>> Yeah. Now I think we do have a star
cross I think still in hand. Yeah. And
we do. So we are going to use it. Uh and
we're going to target the Vex and likely
the Rengar. I really like this play too
because it does mean the long sword
falls off and then we can re equip it to
the Annie. And yeah, there goes the Vex
here. There goes the Rengar
>> equip to Annie.
>> Yeah. And then spending the one on
Annie. And so now we're going currently
five to three. And then we are going to
react by playing that Rengar right back
out. This is some real good sequencing.
And uh yeah, since we are the attacker,
I believe it's currently 10 to five on
this seat of power. that is going to be
difficult to deal with. It does look
like Tide Turner was our hidden card,
bringing that Raven Bloom Student up
into the seat of power. We mentioned
earlier just how quickly Raven Bloom
Student can grow if needed. 7 to 10
right now. And uh we'll have to see what
Wise Guy has with the two runes and the
Diana energy.
>> Yeah, and we are going to use our own
copy of Star Cross here on the Tide
Turner. And uh looks like it's going to
bring the Annie back.
>> And this is going to offer another uh
point for the Raven Bloom. So
>> Oh, we've got another Rengar, though.
This is going to be a full 10. And
that's going to be the game.
Prismaticism takes the first game.
>> What a fantastic job by Prismaticism. I
definitely was not expecting the double
Rengar and being able to start cross
that Rengar to hand freeing up the long
sword was such a smart move. Yeah, and
you know, it goes back to like uh you
know, I would say the Annie was played
pretty early uh into this game. Uh
getting the star cross a little bit
earlier than you know, generally you
play Annie, you get the spell you need
immediately, right? But having the
foresight to say, I think this star
cross is going to be important later in
the game. I'm going to get it when I
have kind of some runes and stuff
floating. Uh and it obviously made a
huge difference here. So, we're going to
go into the second game. Wise guy is
going to be using the arena's greatest.
And we've got the Zon Warren for
prismaticism. That is I'm excited to see
on Warren. It's definitely a staple in
any list and has been I feel like since
that set one when you
>> uh conquer. Yeah,
>> Zan Warren you discard and you draw a
card and then arena's greatest also a
really strong battlefield though since
it's set one does allow both players to
start with one point. Yeah, I mean with
Annie specifically, right, we have all
these extra runes and energy to play
with, but that means that we need more
cards to play. So, uh having a lot of
draw heavy uh battlefields makes sense.
Uh we're going to start off Raven Blue
Student in the back for wise guy and
then sending it back to Prismaticis.
>> Raven Blue Student is a really strong
start for those two runes. We'll have to
see if Annie does have a turn one unit.
It does look like so with that traveling
merchant.
>> Yeah, we haven't seen it. uh it must be
traveling elsewhere during game one, but
it's uh returned home and uh we're going
to see if it's able to get us some, you
know, extra draw. I mean, it on Z on
Warren that's, you know, two new cards
that you can play with.
>> Yeah, I I think those two together I
feel like traveling merchant and Z
warren just really helps you find the
exact cards that you want in hand. And
even if you do end up with zero cards in
hand at some point, you do get that draw
still.
>> Definitely. Uh and we are looking about
moving Yeah. this Raven Blue soon to the
Zon Warren. So we'll be at two points
for wise guy here. Uh both players did
start with one point due to the arena's
greatest as well. Uh and we've got four
runes left to play with on Diana's side.
And looks like we are going to play out
uh sorry get the discard of the tie
turner for the draw off the zon. And
we'll see if we've got something for
four. Uh we could play something like
fax. I could see that being very
powerful here.
>> Yep. And it's just that.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah, I'm interested to see how
this game plays out. Obviously, both
these decks can play rather
aggressively. But in game one, we saw
them really stay back and wait for these
for before taking any of the
battlefields. But Arena's Greatest
really kind of shrinks that time that
they have. So, they're going to have to
I mean, be a lot more aggressive here.
>> Yeah. And I I I think we saw it already.
I'm pretty sure Prismaticism's third
battlefield is also Arena's greatest,
right? So, uh obviously it does uh
benefit the player going first, I think,
a lot. Um, I do think in this game,
particularly in this format, you know,
going second is not uh, you know, there
have been some good ways to go second. I
thought I think a lot of these champions
like Diana where you can just play it
for three from the champion zone has
helped it, too. Uh, but we've got, uh,
you know, I think this Vex in particular
has been a bit of a bane for a lot of
these Fury decks. Uh, when they want to
be playing out, you know, and reacting
with these units, you really can't uh,
you know, get as much value when that
Vex is on the battlefield.
>> Yeah, that is for sure. discard a
4Runner draw card.
>> They're just going to go in and do I
think the move trigger. But I am excited
to see like why obviously does have no
runes up, but he still does have the
Diana energy.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. And that's also kind of the tricky
part too is recognizing that we do have
the inferna. We're just playing out for
two. Uh and you know, also just another
ambush unit, especially like an ambush
unit, you can pay for two, which is
great for Annie's uh legend ability too.
Uh and helps you out there. and the Nox
is hopeful. Both were stunned and
couldn't move, but you know that does
fall off and we're back to wise guy.
>> Yeah, I have to wonder, did we like
obviously Inferna can can't really use
that ambush in the same way because of
the stun right now. Uh
>> but in our first game, we saw the
Inferno played kind of specifically to
do the star cross. Yeah.
>> Right. And I wonder if that how we'll
see that work out this time.
>> Yeah. I I we haven't seen it, but I can
definitely see some times where like,
okay, I react with Inferna and then I
react with Starcross. And then, you
know, being able to, you know, for
essentially five be able to return one
of their cards back to their hand is
pretty nice
>> for sure.
>> Right. We're going to move the student
back to the base here. And then for
three, uh, looks like we are going to
play out our Diana champion here.
>> And pass it back with three open. Yeah,
I feel like we're just like slowly
building our board here on Wise Guy's
side. Keeping that Vex up there just to
make sure that these stuns stick.
>> Seven runes for prismaticism here. We
still also have our Annie champion unit
in it. And uh again with the Vex on the
battlefield here, it will offer some
stuns and uh movement protection for
anything being played. Uh so we do have
to play around that. But, you know, we
could just move into these on warrants
and see if they do have a way to uh, you
know, defend this facts.
>> All right. Big think here.
>> Oh, go for it.
>> Prison has to want to take this Vex out.
>> Uh, just because it feels like a lot of
his deck is set up around those ambush
units. we don't have as many damage
spells in this Annie list. Uh, so
this Vex putting a little bit of a, you
know,
>> stay on those is a little bit difficult.
>> And the falling star, what a brutal card
here is going to be a little expensive.
Uh, you know, rune wise, we do have to
recycle two, but uh, you know, spending
one card to get rid of two of your
opponent's cards does feel very good.
So, we'll see if there's any interaction
here. Again, we'd have to like double
react to save the Raven Bloom suit
essentially. uh to get two more spells
to get to four might. But yeah, this is
looking pretty tough. And yeah,
unfortunately, yeah, there they go. And
Falling Star takes another two.
>> Let's see.
>> All right, for two, we are going to play
a Noxus Hopeful into the arena's
greatest here. And we are going to go
maybe seven.
You also do have three open for a
potential star cross as well. I could
see you, you know, moving back uh the
traveling merchant and then, you know,
we could play it again later. Uh but
yeah, having uh all these flexible plays
have been so good.
>> Yeah, I'm really enjoying to see how
Prismaticism kind of works out this
puzzle. He's taken out wise guys entire
backline now, but it looks like we are
going to be attempting to take the Vex
off the board, too. I think this would
just be such a swing in prism
prismaticism's uh direction if we can
completely clear wise guy off the board.
>> Yeah. So it currently it's a 724 due to
the assault two from the inferna
>> and we've got three open and we are
going to play the eclipse here and then
that is going to be on the uh Noxus
hopeful. So Eclipse gets that minus four
and it can put it down to zero. So,
currently it's four to three uh for our
Vex here.
>> Yeah, that's I mean that's going to be
difficult. We can't really just bring in
any of those ambush units just like we
mentioned earlier because of that stun.
So, this is a difficult spot forism
>> and we only have two cards in hand too,
right? Uh you know, compared to last
game, uh it's been a lot more of a
grind. Uh obviously, the seed of power
in Kai'Sa offered us a little bit more
card draw. Uh and I think they're, you
know, making sure that this is
resolving. So we do also get the predict
uh so we can look at the top card and we
can recycle if we want to but currently
four to three. We are going to play the
cleave here on it looks like the inferno
resolves.
>> So uh that will offer plus three here.
It's going to be six to four. Uh and
we've got the existential dread stun. Uh
one of these units probably going to be
the inferna.
>> Mhm. I'm so excited to see existential
dread. I did see it on wise guys list
when we were looking at the board. We
don't see that card too much. I feel
like so was really exciting to see how
it was going to play out and it looks
like this may be the moment for it.
>> Yeah, and the the numbers are quite
tricky here. So, uh you know, it doesn't
matter how big you make your inferna
anymore. It just won't be able to you
know, get over the Vex if it's stunned.
Also, with the uh minus 4 on the Noxis
hopeful, you know, it's not really doing
anything either. So, I think
>> yeah, all this resolves. So,
>> kill the initi
hopeful. Uh the inferno, you know, does
currently have, I believe it was six
might. Uh so it doesn't get uh killed,
but it does have to just move back
because it was stunned. And then
looks like we're thinking about Yeah, I
I think the idea is that we're going to
Yeah. play out the long sword
and thinking about maybe equipping it
when we do.
>> Oh, two.
>> And then that means that when we move
with the merchant, uh we have a discard
one, draw one. And since our hand is
empty, it just turns into a draw one.
hold the floor.
>> Yeah, that's going to be nice to try to
build our hand back up, but that's got
to be a huge ouch for prismaticism. Uh
he did, you know, clear out the entire
backline. Wise guy did not react in any
way to it, even though he did have runes
up and he was so smart in saving those
runes, saving his cards to be able to
protect Vex. And again, these stuns are
doing so much prismaticism
because I mean, his kind of just built
around attacking.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So, uh, making, you know,
their numbers not matter as much as
good. Existential dread can also have
some fun interactions with, uh, the Vex
where, you know, since it stuns
something, you can actually, you know,
target something that's stunned and it
gets returned to hand, too. So, uh,
makes a lot of sense. We're going to
start the turn though with a stack deck.
Looking at the top three,
I was I one of the cards was Gus. I'm
interested to see what we do decide to
pull here. sack deck is so nice to kind
of I mean get through the deck, try to
curate your hand to have exactly what
you need to beat your opponent.
>> Yeah, I mean we looked at the statistics
at the beginning of the day, right? One
of the most used spells uh in the game
right now. Only second to I think Gust,
which we're able to play both here, uh
very good for consistency and obviously
we're playing stuff like Raven Blue
Suit, Abandon Hall, uh you know, paying
one to give a plus one might and look
and draw a card just you know,
irreplaceable.
>> Yeah, that is for sure. I mean, it looks
like just looking at the resources
between these different two players,
Wise Guy seems to have a lot more cards
than Prismaticism does and a lot more
runes.
>> Yeah, and again, Vex can just be quite a
bully here uh when it comes to
preventing any, you know, dramatic
plays. It really slows down uh
Prismaticism. Uh yeah, I will say that
Prismat's kind of in a interesting spot
though cuz it's going to be kind of easy
for Merchant to get these free draw ones
off the top of the deck uh by using
their cards. Mhm.
>> But we'll see. Uh looks like for three.
Oh, we are going to play with the
Moonfall.
>> All right.
>> I love this signature spell, Moonfall.
It's kind of almost like a dual charm
plus a
double stify.
>> Yeah, it it just does so much. Uh and
also it's, you know, gives everything
the minus two. And then also the fact
that uh you know uh you it doesn't have
the you know down to a minimum of one
might so you can give stuff negative. Uh
all of that ends up I think being very
very important. So we do get rid of the
Noxus hopeful there uh off the arena's
greatest.
>> Probably was a little bit tempting to
maybe do it on the inferna right would
have been a little bit tougher. It would
have been a four to three if we did
that. Oh and we're going to use the fizz
here though. Are we going to use it on
moonfall once again? And we're going to
use it on the merchant. So merchants's
going to have to you have to discard
this card
>> and then get another draw. And yeah,
nothing there. So uh I think this is
great because it really just, you know,
turns off their potential draw engine
here.
>> And then we're just going to move the
Vex back saying, you know what, we've
done our job. I don't want to lose this
Vex is doing a lot. Inferno is really
good at being aggressive. And now, you
know, this is the low resource game
we're at now.
>> Yeah. So, I mean, now why this guy is at
those lure resources just like
prismaticism. I have to wonder if Pris
Prismat even though we're only at six
runes might want to try to build out
that base as much as possible since he
knows that if when the Vex comes up to a
battlefield, he won't be able to play
those ambush units.
>> Yeah. Uh and so since we're in a
showdown, we're going to use our Diana
Legend ability to play another copy of
stack deck to get another draw one.
Inferno is going to get us to four
points. We're going to discard a card
off the wars to get a draw one. Uh big
difference though is that prismaticism
still has their champion unit Annie,
right? That's kind of like an extra card
in hand sometimes, right? Especially
since it does essentially draw a card
too. So uh we're thinking about uh these
six runes and what we want to do with
them. Uh you know, obviously Annie's
like in contention for one of her cards.
And I think by using the four it could
be, but it's going to be a Kai'Sa on the
Z warren and pass.
I kind of like this idea of kind of just
trying to hold the Z warren. It does
seem like we're kind of committing to
doing just that as well since we are
also playing Kai'Sa up to the
battlefield instead of to the base.
>> Yeah. And uh you know there are some
trickiness right now because Vex is not
at a battlefield. Its abilities don't
activate. So uh new cards being played
could be uh you know have not be stunned
essentially. Um, and we'll see how they
want to try to pick apart this Z wars.
>> Stupify your Kai'Sa.
>> Going to try to stupify the Kai'Sa here.
So, get a draw one and a minus one here.
So, uh, currently on that battlefield,
it's at six might.
>> And I like this. So, we're just going to
go right into here. It's going to be
three to six, but this can offer a trade
on either one of these units. Uh, and I
think this is really set up really well
for this.
>> Yeah, this does seem to be really nice.
I do have to think like the one card in
hand right now. Vex isn't at the
battlefield. Are we going to want to
play something? Maybe an ambush unit,
but we have four runes up and that's a
lot of options.
>> Yeah, we could see a Rengar, but still
just the fact that Fizz is going to be
trading with one of these no matter what
is really strong. Uh, obviously we do
want to try to get rid of the Kaiso. Oh,
the flash to get rid of both.
don't dislike this. But if we have a
hard bargain though,
>> uh you know, paying four could be
everything. But yeah, we are going to
get rid of the uh just the Kai'Sa here.
>> I'll stupify your Inferno.
>> We're going to stupify the Inferno. All
right, get the minus there. So, the Fizz
does survive.
>> Very nice here.
>> There was definitely a risk that
Prismaticism took only flashing back the
Kai'Sa. Uh I think he was kind of hoping
to trade probably, but also trying to
free up that long sword. Sadly, it did
end up only dying the Fizz surviving,
but long sword is free.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So, uh that can offer you
sometimes, you're right, like you you
just have a uh you know, gear just stuck
to one of my units. So, being able to
get the uh you know, unattached is nice,
but
>> likely would have liked the trade with
>> 100%.
>> All right. So, thinking about this, um,
I could see a possibility, uh, if we
have Star Cross with Fizz here, that
could be huge. Uh, puts the Kaisa back
into hand, but then if we do have, uh,
the ability to, you know, play the Vex
out on a battlefield, we just know that
they can't move anything, which is nice.
>> Discard this draw card.
>> Yeah. All right. Finally, uh, using the
Zorn. So, discarding the Porro, get the
draw one.
Yeah. I I really think yeah, if we have
a star cross for this Fizz, that could
really wrap it up. We're tapping three.
>> Yeah, clearing out Prismaticism board
would be such a huge moment. Uh just
because especially ones that have Vex in
Battlefield, you can't really just get
into any of these as you wish because of
those stuns.
>> Yeah, and we're going to use it for a
stack deck. So, unfortunately, not the
star cross here, but uh we will get
another draw which is going to be pretty
nice. We're going to have also six power
here, which is enough to uh tie with a
long sword Kai'Sa, which is good as
well.
>> And then, yeah, thinking on how we feel
about these two runes open, we've used
our Moonfalls. We only have two open.
We've used I think two stupifies. So,
uh, you know, not as many defensive, uh,
you know, spells as we're thinking.
We're just going to leave it open. Say,
you know, we can grind out a lot of
value here. Uh, and even just with the
Kai'Sa being at six, we do get the
double trade with this Fizz, and that's
good enough for me.
>> Yeah, I think that really just shows how
much we care about keeping this Vex
alive, even though it's not currently
stunning units, because six is such an
important number. It does seem like
we're kind of hoping to hold into that
six with that double fizz, but
>> if we moved up to six, there was some
world that we could have won next turn
where now that's not possible.
>> Yeah. So, stack deck looking at the top
three. Uh, you know, one of the probably
better draws at least from the
consistency, right? Like you get the
best of your top three, not just the
best off your top one.
>> Mhm.
>> You do have to pay a rune for it, but
there it goes. We're going to pay four
and recycle one. So likely going to be
our Annie champion unit here. And we're
going to go back and pick up maybe a
falling star and we're going to use it
immediately for a fizz and one of the uh
the students there. And then we do get
the kind of free conquer draw off of
this. So we are going to draw first and
then we're going to get a discard draw
off the zod.
>> Yeah. And it's going to be really nice
with getting more of those cards.
Obviously, prismaticism was kind of
lacking in cards earlier, but between
this Kai'Sa, between the ZH Warrens,
we're going to be getting a lot of
refreshing cards in hand.
>> Yeah, and you know, Falling Star has
shown once again, one card that can get
rid of two has been very strong. Uh, you
know, it's kind of like a draw one in
those scenarios. We are going to go four
to four on the Kai'Sa and we're going to
spend three
and the Moonfall and we're going to try
to move the Annie in here. Uh this is
going to be quite the potential trade
here. So currently it is three to four
with the minus two on both of these.
>> That's going to be painful.
>> Uh
have to
>> Yeah, I I mean we could have maybe
equipped the long sword last turn. Uh we
have the potential of Rengar here and
we're just going to put it in the base.
>> Making sure that we're using our runes
while we can. uh you know because other
otherwise we just lose the two. We also
play around kind of the stun ability
too. So uh you know we're not going to
be stunned next turn with it. But we're
at six points for wise guy. Five open.
>> Yeah. Like just saving off having a
completely wiped board is going to be so
important for prismaticism. I do love
seeing that Rengar come down even if it
can't help out with that Vex just yet.
>> Yeah. And you know we've got five open.
We haven't really seen Hawaii all
weekend, right? Uh, I think we've seen
it often just kind of moved. We are
going to use the tide turner here to
move the Vex back. Keeping three open
and it's going to be back to
prismaticism.
>> Yeah, we love keeping that Vex very
safe. Uh, we want to keep it vulnered to
be vulnerable at one of these
battlefields. And we're just going to go
on and kill that tide turner with Rengar
taking it another point. Both players
are six to six now it looks like. And
yeah, I would love to see like a Houe
actually do, you know, its ability
because we've seen it a couple times,
but it dies before it does anything. It
doesn't.
>> Yeah, people just really respect what it
can do. Uh, we're going to discard the
Apothecary off the Zworn. So, two cards
in hand for prismaticism. We got long
sword still equipped here and we're
going to spend
something. We're thinking about it.
They're going to spend four and recycle
uh one
>> going to play out a Kha'Zix. Okay, so
making it difficult for these, you know,
single attacks here
>> and we're going to think from there. Now
with the point totals, it could be a
chance where we move next to the arena's
greatest next turn and it could just
kind of hold if there's nothing that can
move from that battlefield. So
>> yeah, that could definitely be a
problem. I have to hope that if that
obviously prismanism would be thinking
about that playing the Kha'Zix into the
Don Warren and it makes me have to
wonder is there something like a flash
that can move these two units back to
base ready and then take out the Vex on
the other side or something like that.
>> Uh
>> yeah, I think I think that's a really
really good point and yeah, currently
six points to six here. Vex could go to
the arena's greatest and hold at seven
potentially getting this. We've got 11
and a half minutes left in this round.
So, if we do go to game three, we're
going to have to be a quick one. I mean,
again, these are both kind of more
aggressive leaning decks, I would say.
And we've been really grinding it out.
>> Yeah, that is for sure. And these
players are making it so hard for each
other to be able to find the perfect way
of doing it. They're keeping all their
information to their chest. Uh, and I
mean, they're obviously such great
players at their decks. Yeah. So,
currently Vex is not at the Arena's
greatest right now. It's in the base. I
know they're they're pretty close
together, but uh yeah, we are going to
move into Arena's greatest
>> going to seven points,
>> 70 or six
>> and thinking about I mean, it looks like
we've got five uh and three split
across. We've got a another copy of Fizz
here.
>> Deck.
>> This could be pretty good for a stacked
deck.
Yeah, really nice to get that stack deck
right here. Obviously, this turn coming
up is going to be so important for Wise
Guy and Prismaticism, honestly. So,
having those perfect cards in hand is
kind of what we're going to want. It
does look like we are going to keep
reinforcing that arena's greatest
though. Uh, and spending a lot of those
in a lot of those runes. It looks like
we are going to leave ourselves with one
rune open and that Diana and luckily
forism at least does have that flash we
talked about.
>> Yeah, flash has been super good here and
I think we're going in one at a time.
This is going to be a total of seven
might to 11. So we do get rid of the two
units and this is such good timing
because now this Kha'Zix gets to attack
by itself into something. We get the
long sword and that's enough. And
prismaticism with the flash able to take
that 20 in quite a close. Wow, what a
close match and what a fantastic job by
Prismaticism really being smart sending
that Rangard in by itself with that long
sword able to clear some of the units
out and then obviously the Kha'Zix
ability but also then reattaching that
long sword to Kha'Zix as well just to
make him such a mighty beast.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I think uh you also wise guy
uh played a lot to their outs. I think
they made it really tough for
prismaticism. Really put them on low
resources. Luckily, a combination was on
Warren and the traveling merchant really
let them get a little, you know, extra
card draw. And yeah, that flash at the
end made a huge difference.
>> Yeah, you can tell they really just like
planned out their knew exactly what they
needed to do to potentially win the
game. Wise guy, he was so close for
sure.
>> Yeah, great game there. And uh we we'll
see prismaticism uh I think currently
8-1 I think for for the day. I think
they started the day at 7-1. currently
8-1 and Wise Guy currently 72, but still
being able to win out these next four
rounds can put you into a lot of these
different uh prize brackets.
>> Yeah, there's so many things that these
players are competing for. Obviously,
those best of that top eight. Uh they're
definitely very strong and have
practiced a lot at their decks. So, I'm
sure both are things that they're
shooting for.
>> Yeah. So, again, we did have Wise Guy
versus Prismaticism. Prismaticism able
to take it 20. But again, quite a match.
And again, I think Wise Guy really
showed that they knew what, you know,
Prismaticism was trying to do. Was able
to make it very tough for it.
Prismaticism able to still find a way,
but you know, there's just it was just
so tight, right?
>> Yeah, for sure. You could see it wasn't
like he immediately checked out after he
was able to get that battlefield. He
knew there was a chance that uh Annie
could still do something like that
flash, and so he tried to reinforce that
battlefield to the best of his ability.
>> Yeah. And I I think that's just showed
just a lot of power there. Uh you know,
and we were playing to a lot of outs.
I'm not sure if the uh the flash move is
the top deck or is the one they were
holding, right? Uh but without it, we
definitely couldn't have moved things to
that battlefield.
>> Yeah, exactly. And I mean, like you're
saying, it was only a few cards left in
Prismaticism's hand. They did such a
good job at really almost running
Prismat out of those resources.
>> Yeah. And I think one one more thing,
too, uh you know, Hui never really made
a bit of a you know, presence. It showed
up a little bit in game one just to get
Starcross back to hand. Uh, you know,
once that hits the board and stays on
board, it becomes a totally different
game, I think, as well.
>> Yeah, I would love to see Hui really do
some action on the board in some of
these upcoming games.
>> Yeah. So, you know, obviously we also
looked at, you know, there's a couple
different uh ideas for how Diana could
be built in this format, right? Uh, you
know, if it has the frigid jewel or not.
So, without that that those might totals
become a little bit more difficult. And
you know, when Annie and Diana have such
similar might totals, right, the extra
two might can make a big difference.
>> Yeah, I think that's a really great
point. I'm interested to see how these
different builds really do continue
throughout the tournament. Is one going
to come out on top?
>> Yeah. Yeah. So, I don't think we're
going to be able to go to table B, but
we did have uh our other matchup uh uh
playing at the same time with uh but you
know, it was Dewali who was also playing
Diana. We saw that build was the Frigid
Jewel build for it, too. So, uh, we'll
have to see if they're currently one of
those players are currently 9, which is
really exciting.
>> Yeah, that is so exciting. I would love
honestly to have that repeat obviously
with Dwalli, but also I'm kind of a
Kai'Sa believer. I really liked her in
set one. I was more Z set two, but uh I
would love to see Kai'Sa do well again.
>> Yeah, and we already saw in that match
up with Annie, right? Obviously, Falling
Star is a little bit more expensive, but
being able to spend one card to get rid
of two of your opponent's cards always
great value in this game.
>> Yeah, 100%. And I think Annie and Kai'Sa
are both decks that or a few of the
decks can really harness that falling
star because of how they can use the
power, right? Kai'Sa with the legend
ability to give a power and Annie
bringing back those two runes every
turn.
>> Definitely. And we do have an interview
with Prismaticism. So, let's see them
over there.
>> Thanks so much. I'm Bear Bryant and I'm
joined by the wonderful Prismaticism.
Uh it's always good to have you here on
the desk. So, first of all, I want to
say congratulations on your match win. I
know you we were talking a little bit
beforehand. You know, you said no, not
entirely warmed up yet, but you still
started the day with a win and pretty
divisive or decisive, I should say. Not
really.
>> How are you feeling?
>> It should have it should have been
better. Like both both games I
misplayed. Game one, I should have
gusted his plundering porro when I had
the chance. And then I also uh when he
went in with his Fizz on the very last
turn, I need to just develop my units to
play around the Vex. I was not I don't
know. Just forgetting about cards is is
really bad. And then game two, I forgot
about existential dread. I was only
thinking about Gust. So with the long
sword cleave in my hand, I could have
beaten that combat and the game would
have been over instantly. Like both
those games should have been way more
>> conf and and you you were kind of
telling me obviously this is a deck that
you have a lot of proficiency from
testing against quite a bit. And so you
know those are all these things that you
already know and like want to be
>> I played against Allen. I know what's
going on. Like I know there's hard
bargain there. I know Moonfall is going
to punish me if I stack battlefields or
if I'm too reliant on flash it can also
pull me back in clear me. Like that's
why I mean I made a good play at least
game two or game game game one where I
just kept was it whichever game it was.
Oh my god. I'm out of it. It's like
where I played Kai'Sa in base instead of
accelerating her.
>> Yeah.
>> I I believe that was game one where I
could have accelerated Kisa out. I had
the flash. That's like the traditional
anything you do when you go second.
>> Yeah.
>> But it's too risky.
>> Yeah. And it makes it makes a lot of
sense to me. But you're all you're here
I mean you guys are having to make the
hard decisions in this game because you
have to constantly know what you're
playing around knowing what the opponent
might have or might not have. And then
sometimes in this game if you play
around the wrong thing you can put
yourself in a slightly disad
disadvantageous position and then it
that same train of thought has to happen
on a future turn or three turns later of
course but I kind of then want to ask
you in a similar situation the the
Kha'Zix in your deck. I I'm really
focusing a lot on the Kha'Zix and and
you've already know how successful you
are with ambush units. You've literally
won a regional champion or a regional
qualifier because of these ambush units
that you know are so powerful and
strong. Has it been successful to you?
because when I talked to Allan, it's
obviously not in his Diana list anymore.
>> Yeah, not anymore. Yeah, he's changed
his version to a bit more spell focused
list. Um, but it's been all right. He it
is very expensive for runes even on the
opponent's turn and there's those Vexs
that disrupts it. There's a lot of decks
that are going to put multiple units on
battlefields. So, he's been
inconsistent, but when he works, he is
very very strong in a lot of situations.
Perfect. And we've had a little bit of
talk on the deck. So my last question
for you is you are obviously not the
only Annie deck right now in contention,
not just for the best of, but making a
run for top cuts of course, but I got to
ask you,
>> can you tell me the strengths maybe
necessarily of your deck versus like
some other Annie lists that are existing
right now in the field of just like
they're playing the game a little bit
differently, but still using the
strengths of both Fury and Chaos? And
why do you think your deck is maybe
tailored better for the field right now
versus a version like I I think my deck
can flex depending on the draws between
being aggressive and being more controly
or more mid-rangey and holding. Uh like
my draw in game two was very aggressive.
I dump my entire hand by turn three
almost. And uh then I go go very
quickly, but depending on the hand, my
opponent doesn't get that read until
it's too late a lot of the time whether
they they need to play slowly or play
quickly as well or if they're vulnerable
to me attacking them or I'm going to
just develop a forerunner. And it it
splits them between that decision where
either they have to put themselves on
battle fields to stop the 4Runner or if
they put themselves on battlefields, I
just cleave over them and clear their
units for free. Uh the other versions,
like you were telling me, it's a very
hidden focused version of Annie. Uh
which is interesting, but I think that
leans you completely into the aggressive
side.
>> Yeah.
>> And then that that can get you into
trouble, especially going second. You
you really need a different plan when
you go second because that's not going
to cut it a lot of the time.
>> You're right. But sometimes I've heard
that going first is a little overrated.
But here we have some great insight here
from Prismaticism. Congratulations on
your first round win for the day. Of
course, you have four more rounds to go
and I'm excited to hopefully see your
name still at the top of that
leaderboard for the rest of the day.
Congratulations. Thank you. We'll send
it back.
>> All right. Well, thank you for that
interview and always great to hear the
insights of Pismasism. Again, I love
that necklace. Trying to get another
one, I'm sure, today to match with it.
But yeah, great interview.
>> Yeah, great interview. I loved seeing
how confident he was and even just
knowing his own constructive criticism
for himself. That's how these players
keep continuing getting better and
better and better.
>> Yeah, I think his biggest critic is
himself.
Like, ah, there's there's definitely
something that you can do to be better.
But that kind of mentality definitely
shows with, you know, the results and
being able to consistently be in these
situations.
>> Yeah. And I love the insight on those
different types of Annie lists as well.
>> Yeah. And with Annie specifically,
right, you just have all of these kind
of smaller cost options, the sequencing
that you do, what you're playing into,
what you play around. Uh there's always
a lot of decision-m so I think that's
something, you know, when you are really
confident in that, that shows in your
gameplay and your standings as well.
>> Yeah, it definitely seems to be the case
for prismaticism. I mean, he was very
confident interview, very seems
confident with Annie. I even talked to
him before the tournament began and he
was just like, I think my list is the
best list that Annie can have.
>> Good. Well, I mean, that's good to know,
right? And so, uh, you know, that's
that's the the critique. Like, if the if
the deck is perfect, then I have to be
perfect with it as well, right?
>> Yeah. I mean, if the deck's there, you
got to match it.
>> Definitely. So, uh, I don't think we're
going to be able to jump into the other
game, unfortunately. But, we did have,
you know, another Diana. It was going to
be Kai'Sa versus Dwali. We'll try to see
what the results were on that. I'm sure
we're going to see what four uh decks
are left undefeated after this round
since we started with eight. Uh, good
variety. But again, we've got five whole
rounds of Swiss, so four more left
today. Yeah, and then we still have the
top cut as well. So, so many fantastic
games of Riftbound to be played.
>> Yeah. So, I know uh Prismaticism still
in the running for it. Definitely trying
their best. Uh you know, and even
without that, we saw all the prizing. Uh
we don't only have our top eight
prizing. We've got top 32, top 64, the
new top 128 with the Vex playmat. Very
exciting,
>> honestly. And everyone seems to love
Vex. So, why not also play on a Vex
playmat? Well, I'm I'm sure there were
times in that previous game prismaticism
maybe didn't like Vex as much, right? It
definitely was a little obnoxious to,
you know, prevent some of the movement
in playing that was trying to happen,
but uh yeah, obviously clearly a really
good uh unit in this game right now.
>> Yeah, these stuns are really coming so
in like so handy. I remember obviously
like set two you had like Thonk and a
couple of those, but now it's just you
could see how important it was,
especially during that turn where was
able to stun the Inferno. Yeah, it's
just so flexible uh and ends up being
very nice. Obviously, uh I don't think
we've really seen that many Vex uh
legends this weekend, right? Uh
obviously having that in your champion
zone is really nice because you it's
just always a flexible play.
>> Yeah, being we were talking about it at
the beginning with even the any chosen
champion that chosen champion slot can
have so many different options.
Obviously, maybe it's your turn one,
your turn two unit that you always can
access or something like Annie that can
bring out the spell. So, kind of
interesting to think that like Vex seems
really strong. Why wouldn't having it in
your chosen spot also be super strong?
>> Yeah. And the like these decisions in
general for a lot of the decks, right?
Uh with, you know, domains not being as
unique as, you know, every set we get
another uh combination of domains again.
Uh so, you know, there's been the
decision decision of either the
Misfortune or the Civer, right? Which
one of those are better? Uh the
champion, I think, makes a big
difference because both them have their
own usage for it. Uh and but also
saying, I have an idea for a deck and
now I have to find a home for it. you
know, one of my favorite deck building
constraints for this game.
>> Yeah, I think that's such a like
interesting part of it for sure. Like
between the domains, can it synergize
with your legend? Do you really care if
it synergizes with it?
>> Yeah. Yeah. So, uh we are going to go to
a break. We've got four more rounds of
Swiss. So, looking forward to that and
we'll see you guys in round number 10.
Yum.
I'm here with Challenger TCG. And so
many of these guys have made it into day
two with some fantastic decks. So, would
you guys like to introduce yourselves
and tell us what deck you're playing?
Yeah, I'm Daniel Zidenberg and I'm
playing Leblanc.
>> I'm John Rossom and I'm playing Pike.
>> Coco Lopez on Aurelia.
>> I'm Zane. I'm Zane. I'm playing Kha'Zix.
>> Uh Colin Kaiser on set.
>> Alex Bllandon on Azir.
>> Trevor Koul and I was playing Diana.
Uh, villionaire on Volibar, of course.
>> Minwin on Aurelia.
>> So, which of you guys do you think is
going to make top eight today?
>> Oh, ideally all of us, but all nine of
us in top eight.
>> All nine.
>> But, uh, Alex for sure and, uh, and Zayn
back there. That would be crazy.
>> Yeah.
>> Let's go.
We just saw prismaticism close out an
absolutely fantastic game. And I mean,
listen for Annie, there's a lot to go
through with Diana. So, let's actually
go to the clips here and take a look at
what we saw. So, right off the top here,
what we're going to see is Starcross
being utilized to get rid of Hui. Hui is
one of those major units that is being
utilized to generate a lot of value for
Diana. And so, Starcross being used to
good effectiveness here to get it off
the board and just not allow Hui to
generate value. And of course, because
you're Annie, you don't want to
necessarily just leave runes on you. So,
why not get a Noxus hopeful out on the
field to play, get that four white body,
and of course, at the end of the turn,
you're going to ready those runes and be
ready to defend. If we go to the next
clip here, Starcross is going to make a
new appearance because one of the
absolute arch nemesis of Fury is going
to be Vex Apathetic. What you're going
to see here is Vex Apathetic on the
bottom battlefield here. Um, and
Vexapathetic is one of those units that
obviously is going to be a death nail
for a lot of the fury units. You can't
ambush in because it just simply shuts
that down. So, we need to find a way to
deal with it. Well, what you're going to
do, you're going to play Starcross.
You're going to get rid of that Vex
apathetic. But the key thing here is
you're actually going to target the
Rengar. Targeting the Rengar is going to
release the long sword, allow you to
attach the long sword onto Annie and
bring Annie in. And now that Vex is
gone, you get to ambush again. Rengar is
going to come back in. I absolutely
loved this play. Now, of course, you
have answers if you're Diana. We have a
hidden card there. That hidden card
might be able to kind of flip the script
a little bit. And it is a tie turner.
So, naturally, you're going to want to
bring in the Raven Bloom Student, which
is going to have that like ramping might
as you cast additional spells. Well,
what spell do I think that Diana is
going to play? I mean, spoiler alert, I
I do know what spell it is. I bet you
you know exactly what spell it's going
to be. It's going to be Starcross. And
again, Starcross is going to be used to
target the Annie that has the long
sword. It's going to release the long
sword. And what's going to happen here
is okay, now the might is favoring
favoring Diana. What are we going to do?
Well, Vex is gone. Prismaticism wants to
win this game. So, what do you think
we're going to see? Another Rengar
pounce in to close out game one. You
absolutely love to see it.
>> I'm here with team TSS. And so many of
you guys made it into day two. Would you
like to introduce yourselves and what
deck you're playing?
>> Yeah, sure. Uh, I'm Nightingale and I'm
playing a Vex.
>> I'm Vigs and I'm playing Kha'Zix.
>> Uh, I'm Dizzy. I'm a villain and I'm
playing Civer.
>> I'm No Veggies. I'm a hero and I'm
playing Poppy.
>> I'm Houses Are Big and I'm playing
Master Yi.
I'm Gail Wins and I'm on Lilia.
>> So, how many of you guys or which of you
guys will do you think will be in top
eight today? I'm really confident in all
my guys here. I didn't make top eight,
but everyone behind me, everyone behind
me is an absolute star, master of their
deck. I have not been more confident in
anything in my life that these guys, you
know, one, two, three, all six of them
technically could make top eight. I
think that's very likely to be honest
with you. All of you, like I think it's
our team. They're they're amazing and
they're they're great players. Yeah,
>> it's been an absolutely remarkable start
to the action here. Day two in
Vancouver. What have you seen thus far
that has really caught your attention?
>> Well, of course, we have a lot of meta
diversity with the number of decks that
we were we weren't expecting to get into
that 80, the 900. Like for instance, we
did see the Kai'Sa start off really
strong and then we seen Rexi do well as
well. So, just seeing those decks that
were under the radar doing extremely
well. Yeah, the meta seems really solid
here in Vancouver. And why don't we take
a second to take a look at the standings
thus far here.
Dewali 9 and0 on Diana. Absolutely a
remarkable result for someone who has
been an absolute mainstay in the
competitive scene.
>> Absolutely. Of course, it wouldn't be a
tournament without Ireelia. Also
performing very well at that 9 and0
mark. We have Allan ZQ here at 9 and0 as
well with that Diana deck too. Want to
shout out a couple things here.
Prismaticism, you saw them on the stage
earlier here, 8 and one. And uh, you
know, I think that they're looking to
take home another championship victory.
Swag YOLO 420. Yeah. On Civer. That was
an absolutely remarkable game that we
saw yesterday.
>> Absolutely.
>> Let's go to the vote. You guys are going
to get the opportunity here to be able
to decide the next match. Uh, but before
we dive into the vote here, well, we're
going to dive into the vote right now.
We got match A, which is going to be
Allan ZQ on Diana versus Sketchy Man on
Ireelia. Match B, we have Diana piloted
by Golden Monkey. And then, hold on a
second. Is that a Lux raid Bowser on Lux
in the chat, you get to spam whether you
want A or B to choose the results of the
vote.
>> So, no matter what, we will see Diana,
which we are expecting to do extremely
well in this tournament. And then it
comes down to do you want to see Allan
pilot it or do you want to see the
Ireelia or do you want to see Lux which
we have not seen and weren't really
expecting to do as well as it is. So
whichever one we'll see what chat
decides.
>> I'm actually excited for all of these
matches and if anything I hope that we
see a little bit of both. That's
something that we've had the pleasure of
doing here as uh I think that the
competition has been fast, it's been
furious and it's given us an opportunity
to take a look at multiple games here.
So make sure you guys get your votes in.
Now, Lux, is this one of the top
performing Lux Lux performances we've
seen at a regional?
>> We have seen multiple Luxes make it to
day two and do pretty decently. So, it's
really going to be dependent on how this
Lux player does on day two.
>> Well, guess what? The people have
spoken. It's going to be match B. We're
going to be seeing Diana versus Lux.
Guys, get ready. It's time to see some
Lux Riftbound gameplay here as we get
ready to go to the games. Here are the
decks here. We have Golden Monkey here.
This is going to be the Diana deck. Now,
we've seen a lot of Diana this weekend.
It is well, it was my pick to win of the
tournament. What stands out to you in
this particular uh list by Golden
Monkey?
>> A big thing is the last rights. A lot of
players have opted to not play this in
their in their Diana decks anymore. So,
last rights just having a little bit
extra recursion, being able to recycle
cards from your deck list has been
really big. So, also, of course, we
wouldn't be able to talk about Diana
without talking about Frigid Jewel
because so many players have decided,
yes, I love this. I love being able to
get over Elder Dragons. I love being
able to sometimes instead of draw with
my way instead of discarding a unit. So,
Fri Jewel has been an interesting card
because we've had decks of Diana perform
very well with it, as well as decks that
just say, "No, I don't want it." And
they're also performing well. Either
way, we've seen Diana perform.
>> One of the key cards for Diana has been
Hoe. It generates a tremendous amount of
value once it's on the field of play. Uh
you get so much optionality as to how
you wish to use this card. And you know
what? It's actually one of the main
targets. We actually saw it in the
prismaticism game. It's targeted by
Starcross very often because opponents
just want to get it off the field of
play. They do not want it to generate
the value for their opponents.
>> Yeah, SU's biggest weakness of course is
removal and getting bounced. So, he is
such a strong card that you have to
react to him because if he does generate
that value, he will absolutely run away
with games.
>> All right, so let's take a quick look at
the Lux list as well from Raid Bowser.
Now, I know that, you know, people don't
spend that much time looking at Lux
playlist, but here we are. We got a lot
happening here. And if I listen, this
looks like a control list if I've ever
seen one.
>> Absolutely. It does have a lot of value.
We have a three of the ruination in this
deck list. being able to clear the board
and reset the entire game where so many
decks that once they get ruinated, they
can't really come back from it.
>> And of course, that is a heavy power
cost to pay, but you have so much gold
generation here. Even something like
wages of pain, we've talked about so
often that not only is this card
incredibly versatile, it can be hidden,
but that three damage on a unit as a
battlefield can be remarkable. We have
rocket barrage as well, which can be
used to clean out the units at base, but
of course kill the gear.
>> Yes. And something I want to touch base
on with the wages of pain is because it
is at a battlefield. Uh something that
we've seen over and over again is flash
from our Diana decks do very well into
responding to these wages of pain. So
this out of battlefield can be a
detriment at times. On top of that, we
do have the salvage or gear removal in
the main deck as both players had gear
in the main or gear removal in the main
deck. So something that isn't going to
come to play as much in this game
though. I love the idea of this list,
how you have a number of very fast
attacking plays. You have the sprite
fountain, the sprite burst, get on the
uh get on the board early there, but you
have so much control, even three of call
the week. Let's go to the action here at
the tables. We get started in our next
round.
>> Like, will this match be shown later?
>> Battlefields, we have Aspirin's Climb
and Raven Blue Conservatory. Yes,
because Lux is such a deep control list
and it does go for that long game.
Starting off with the Aspirin's climb
does favor it tremendously because
extending the game just a little bit
longer helps Lux out.
>> As a control deck, you definitely want
to just have that longer game. You want
to allow your opponent to just kind of
run out of steam. And I mean, the entire
deck is designed to just absolutely
punish every single unit that would dare
stay on the field of play.
>> So, yeah, I'm really excited about uh
this lock play here. So, something
really interesting about Diana is it's a
deck that can be very proactive, but
also very reactive at the same time. So,
you have to decide, are you the reactive
player or the proactive player in this?
And of course, against Slux being a
heavy controlist, the Diana deck is
going to have to be a bit more
aggressive than it tends to be.
>> Yeah. And having Diana come out on the
uh on the draw there is absolutely
perfect. It's a one of the absolute
superpowers of being a three cost with
no power cost as well. With four runes
here, we're going to see three come down
and it's going to be a card sharp.
>> And taking a look at that card here, the
player is offered if they would like to
create a gold. The Lux player gets to
create a gold no matter what. And if the
player declines it, then they don't get
to take an extra gold. But if the player
accepts, then they both create a gold.
>> And I just want to mention something
here. I absolutely love the fact that,
you know, you have uh Golden Monkey pick
up that card, reread the text, and you
even have Raid Bowser kind of explaining
how that card functions. And what's
really interesting about that, you do
see Golden Monkey take the gold, which
uh I mean we we've talked about in the
past is an interesting decision. And
it's it's interesting because like when
you play something like a Lux and people
aren't well practiced against Lux, they
might not really uh
>> anticipate some of the ways that you can
perhaps punish them later.
>> Yeah. For example, we did see that
triple ruin Nation. So being able to not
have to ramp over and over again can be
really big for this deck. Obviously
Diana has to have a plan here. Whether
they maybe have Moonfalls in hand, they
likely have something in their hand that
costs power that they feel very that
this gold will be very effective for
them.
>> Yeah, they definitely can use the gold
as well. The concern might be that you
do have Lux that can definitely as well.
Hui does come down. This is a card we
talked about prior. Hui is an absolute
engine for Diana. So, we'll have to see
if Raid Bowser is going to want to get
rid of that rather quickly. It seems to
have been a massive target throughout
the course of this tournament thus far.
Yeah, way on curve is always a bit scary
and as noted, we didn't have to spend a
power there because we had the gold.
Obviously did have the plan said, "Oh, I
have way in hand." And this is the way
that I win the game. So, that was a
great decision there.
>> I do see a fallen comet in hand. Uh way
does have to be out of battlefield to
punish it. But, we do see the wages of
pain come out. We talked about that
card. You are going to generate a gold
and we've uh said so many times that
three damage is just it just hits so
many vital units and card sharp is going
to come in for a comp.
>> Yep. So, this is really big because we
weren't able to use a flash to respond
to it. So, the wages of pain actually
being effective here, removing Diana,
she wasn't able to use her trigger
ability earlier because we weren't able
to spend the mana. And the coal the
week, this is absolutely brutal here.
>> Yeah, we we talked about how like Haye
needs to be removed rather quickly. It's
definitely a target for removal and the
coal of the week absolutely demolishes
it there. And again, we talked about it
before Lux the whole plan here is to
just keep the board stay clear and work
towards your win condition. So,
something interesting here is we didn't
spend the gold. And most viewers at home
would say, obviously, this is a misplay.
Why aren't they spending the gold? But
take a look at the runes here. We only
have a single mine rune. So, this is a
big read that there is something that
costs multiple mine runes in the hand
because we're saving the gold for that
reason.
>> Love that shout out there.
>> Golden monkey considering their next
play.
>> And losing Diana is actually a massive.
We got Fizz. Fizz is coming down. It's
going to go into the pile here. It's
going to pull out a stack deck.
>> Take a look there.
>> Frost. I saw a stupify there.
>> Yeah, really. Starcross is interesting
in this matchup because it doesn't
really hit a lot of things. Of course,
there is Lux. Uh, but overall, there's
so much removal spells that the star
cross I I don't think that was what was
taken here. And it makes a lot of sense
why that would be put into our
>> Titan Turner
>> back into our deck.
>> Tie Turner coming out of the field of
play. Turn has been passed. I will
channel two. Draw one.
>> Yep.
>> Lot of cards on hand. Looks like we did
have another tie turner and a flash in
hand available to us.
>> I see a Sprite Fountain as well. One of
my absolute favorite cards from
Unleashed.
>> I'm really curious as to when they
decide to kind of put the pressure on
and start scoring the points.
>> Is it gold?
>> It looks like it might be right now.
That's a gold. And is it Sprite? It is
Sprite Fountain coming on in. We're
going to get a readyied sprite token for
this turn and next.
>> And there is the first point for Bowser.
>> Turn has been passed.
>> And oh, there's a response. Gust. We're
gusting away the sprite.
>> So, something interesting about Raid
Bowser is Primaria played Victor before
this. The same colors, kind of the same
control idea. And I would love to know
why they decided to go for the Lux
instead. Whether it be for a best of
legend or if uh we just said, you know
what, maybe Lux can make a deep run like
we are right now.
>> I'm gonna suggest that Ray Bowser is
like, you know what, y'all sleeping on
Lux, watch this run. Cuz for me, I love
when people come in with off meta stuff
and absolutely showcase the capabilities
of the deck.
>> And this is going to be a two-point play
here from Golden Monkey. Tie Turner
going in. And we also have the fist,
>> but there is going to be a response
here. And it is going to be the falling
comet here.
>> But is there an answer?
>> Yeah, not the most efficient removal
here, but as Lux, you have so many
options for a removal. And we did get
that cold and weak on the way already.
So just saying, I don't want you to
score any points. And really, Lux
doesn't have a ton of units overall. So
you do have to slow down your opponent
over and over again. And as we said
earlier, Diana needs to be the very
proactive deck here. So taking care of
that removal early is important. I'm
going to flash.
>> There's the flash
>> to return both of these back to base.
>> So, both being returned back. Does Diane
have a response? Don't think it's going
to resolve.
>> Still draws.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> Now, because they went back to the base,
they're no longer valid targets. Full
comment is expired.
>> So, even though they're not valid
targets anymore, we still do get the
draw from Lux because it does
essentially go off, but just onto no
target.
>> And there is Vex cheerless.
So, we've seen a lot of Vex. We've seen
uh Vex Apathetic, and now we have the
Vex cheer list. Now, this was one that
was kind of being slept on early on, and
then uh I believe it was Allen that
really brought it into popularity during
the Spirit Forge meta.
>> I like the setup here from Golden Monkey
with the Vex cheerless and holding
everything back here at the base. Is
looking to make potentially a strong
hold here with the Vex.
>> Yep.
>> Okay, big play coming here. Gold token
utilized.
>> Card is ash. So, I'll get the real card.
So, um
>> Oh, there's Ash.
>> And then you can reload this.
>> Yeah,
>> Ash been a key card throughout this uh
throughout this day, throughout the
weekend because she allows you to reveal
the hand and banish a card. Uh been a
strong tech choice overall into the
game, especially when we have such high
value cards here.
>> I should Yeah,
>> so we'll have to take it. So, I guess
they're thinking whether or not they
want to respond, but I don't think they
really can here. Yeah. So, they're going
to reveal the hand. We do have a gust,
the frigid jewel, ride the wind, and
star cross.
>> So unnerving watching your opponent
write down your hand.
>> Absolutely is. But it is a great habit
to get into if you don't already. You
will notice players throughout the
entire weekend will be taking notes as
they are allowed.
>> You guys can't see it on screen, but
Silver takes notes constantly throughout
the course of the game as you see cards.
>> Exactly. Having knowledge in card games
is it is the real power. Knowledge is
what wins you games at the end of the
day. I love the ride the wind take
because as we said needs to be
aggressive, needs to be getting these
early points and ride them and win is a
great way just to take one of the
battlefield after the other one and we
notice that this is the best way for
more points to be scored and that's why
that was the discard there. I think
that's a great decision from Raid Bowser
here.
>> We're starting to get into the mid game
>> Now, in your opinion, Golden Monkey only
has two points on board here. Would you
have hoped to have scored more points as
a Diana player here? Oh, and that's
another Gust, so no point being scored
there. And of course, the sprite will
just dissipate as it cannot go back to
hand.
>> But yeah, it's only a two-1 game right
now. And as the game gets longer, you
start to playing into Lux's power.
>> Yes, taking a look at the Vex cheer list
there, it is really important and it's
very strong against Lux because it makes
you pay a power and an extra energy when
she is in a showdown.
>> Just a reminder, you're at two points.
>> Yeah. Okay.
>> I'm at you at one. It's high.
>> Sounds good. So once it's on a
battlefield, it's going to be a major uh
>> a major target for removal for our Lux
player. Now we do know we have lots of
options here.
>> Runation being one of them.
>> Many options for ruination.
>> Three in fact.
>> All into the battlefield here.
>> That's focus.
>> Yeah, Skull Monkey is going to have to
play this game. You It's hard because
you want to play it quickly, but at the
same time, you cannot play into Rune
Nation and Lux. Run nation being granted
in the deck is very common, but a lot of
players don't play against Lux all that
often. So, it might not be as apparent
as some of these players would think.
>> We've talked about in the past, bring a
non-meta deck to a regional and just
might be advantage you as your opponents
just aren't as well practiced against
your lines.
>> I'll tap five.
>> Okay, tap five here. Responds to the the
>> Vex attempt.
>> And there it is.
Drag under. It's really just an
aggressive removal.
>> You don't really ever play it from
anywhere else other than your hand, but
it's literally just kill a unit of
Battlefield for five in a one power.
>> Is there a response?
>> Yeah, that's fine.
>> All right, I will draw one from my
legend.
>> And because she was not in active combat
there, we were able to play that card.
>> I'll bring Tide China. Yeah,
>> you're good. Tide turner comes in for
the point and that point's going to go
through.
>> I like that play from Raid Bowser. You
definitely don't want that that Vex
sitting on a battlefield. It is so
detrimental to your overall game plan.
>> Vex is just such a interesting I mean we
got these different variations and it's
kind of funny cuz like a Vex apathetic
may not necessarily do pretty much
anything against uh the Lux deck.
Actually that's not true. We do have a
lot of the sprites being generated as
point uh generators. So uh for the most
part any Vex is just problematic for
Lux. So, a big thing from Golden Monkey
on this Diana is we know that the hand
is very low on units and of course Lux
doesn't play that many units either. So,
we might have a slower game go overall
that starts to favor Raid Bowser as we
keep going.
>> As of right now, it is a 4 to one tally.
Raid Bowser has to start threatening
either clearing this board
>> or putting up some points.
>> Top five for Sprite Burst.
>> Sprite Burst. So, that's going to bring
in two ready sprites.
>> That results. Yeah,
>> as well as the fact that if Golden
Monkey is able to hold here, we'll get
that ride the wind back. And that could
be a big piece if we were to find
another way and then play the wind and
potentially start digging through our
deck a little bit more because we are so
low on units to be able to score.
>> Yeah, absolutely. You don't want to let
them hold because that ride the wind is
going to allow them to uh to combo some
points together.
>> I'll tap two. I'll attempt a blood
money.
>> Okay, we got blood money coming down
here.
>> Kill a unit.
>> Yeah. So under two might, you kill a
unit,
>> you get a gear token exhausted.
>> If I were to guess by the number of
cards that we've been seeing read by
Golden Monkey, probably has not played a
deluxe very much.
>> No, definitely not. But I mean, that's
that's part of the fun here, right?
>> I mean, you do all this testing, all
this preparation as you're expecting to
see your Ielas, your civers, and stuff
like that, and then you see Lux come to
the scene. It's expected that a lot of
players haven't played against Lux yet.
>> Absolutely. And we have the hard bargain
being uh grabbed there on the defense
trigger.
>> Raven Bloom Conservatory. An absolutely
excellent battlefield for the likes of
Diana. See what Golden Monkey does.
>> Yes, anything that is playing a high
number of spells is really good for the
conservatory overall. And also
remembering that trigger right away uh
shows that this player has played Diana
quite a bit.
carefully thinking out their turn here.
Both players and Okay. Okay. We got
Moonfall.
>> Uh, choosing this battlefield
and I will not move anything.
>> Choosing not to move anything.
>> Uh,
let me see.
>> Makes sense to me.
>> The the text does say you may move
something.
>> Uh,
>> electing not to here.
>> I will pass. That's good.
>> Focus passed.
So, these die.
>> Yep.
>> Okay. Sprites will die.
>> And I banish this, right? Okay.
>> Yeah, that's
>> Raid Bowser is identifying that the Ride
the Wind is banished and will come back
if held.
>> You have three cards, right?
>> Yes. Three cards in there.
>> Um, I'll send Ash.
>> All right. Ash coming in.
>> There's the trigger on Raven Bloom
Conservatory once again.
>> Eclipse.
>> That's going to say if you want to
spell, why don't you use the Eclipse?
Oh. Oh. Oh, you're passing focus ash.
>> I may eclipse your ash.
>> And something to note that on eclipse it
is not to a minimum of one. It is just a
flatout minus four might.
>> So she Yeah. Yeah. That resolves. So she
>> that resolves as well.
>> I will recycle this.
>> And you also do get the prediction.
>> Really trying to get this hold here.
really wanting to find this right one
back in hand as it is banished.
>> All right, that is going to be a portal
rescue.
>> I will
>> banish a friendly unit,
>> then play it to base, ignoring its cost.
>> That is a card we don't see very often
here.
>> Yes, it is just a oneup in the deck. So
something that just comes up in
situations just like this.
>> That was a remarkable turn of events
there.
>> Turn has been passed.
>> I'll hold up to hard bargain. Yeah. Was
was devastating in that scenario as
well.
>> Ride the wind back, right?
>> Yeah. Ride the wind brought back to hand
by Golden Monkey.
>> We have Tenrins available to us this
turn. A lot of things that Diana can do,
especially if we are able to find
another unit here. Looks like we're
looking at potentially
>> turning two here.
>> I'll play Plundering.
>> Hey, Plundering Plural.
>> So, we did find a unit. When we're
seeing a low value unit like this coming
right away, we know that we didn't find
those ways or those other strong units
that we need. And that is such a sigh of
relief for Raid Bowser here on this Lux.
Of course, we'll have all the removal in
the world to deal with a lot of this,
but you know that your opponent's hand
is very low value overall.
>> Yeah, and they've been getting a lot of
value from the Raven Bloom Conservatory,
literally pulling spells that they're
using near immediately as we saw with
the Eclipse. But eventually against a
control deck, especially one that is
starting to really build up its runes
here,
>> two yellows and the gold,
>> you have to start scoring the points and
like just starting to take advantage of
uh of the game state before you start to
fall too far behind
>> and it is going to be the ruination. All
units are going to be destroyed.
>> I love this here of that there are
almost no units in the opponent's hand.
Either that or we could have a really
big game play from Golden Monkey saying,
"I want to try to get one of these ruin
nations out by baiting it out by playing
a couple more units here, threatening to
score two more battlefields and put
myself up to seven points." That's
another thing that could be done here.
And if that is the case, I would be so
impressed.
>> Stack deck. Okay, so that's a Gust.
That's a Huay. I imagine be Okay, that
was fast.
>> That was double whey.
>> Was that double? Okay, cuz I was going
to say you don't want you want to grab
that away and I mean there's a really
fast decision here and I bet you that's
what we're going to be see come down
here.
>> And I wouldn't be surprised too if we
see it paired up with ride the wind as
well because we know our hand has been a
little bit on the weaker side.
>> I'll wave cycle.
>> I'll ride the wind to move him here.
>> Yeah, that's good.
>> You can see the future move.
Well, when you have a few options,
sometimes you just know exactly what you
want to do. We did have the draw. We
will discard the frigid jewel to ready
two more runes, which is really
interesting to see. We talked about
jewel over and over again. Uh whether
the value is there or not because you
have stupify way and a couple options to
actually get that draw. Uh sometimes it
is just better to discard it to get more
options from your runes.
>> Now, Hui is sitting at base here. If it
was in the battlefield, I believe we had
seen another fallen common in hand from
Raid Bowser. very prudent to pull it
back to base.
>> Raven Bloom student I mean play
>> and it looks like we're doing a little
uh Raven Bloom student edition here.
>> Yep.
>> So something that Raid Bowser has to
think about is whether this Friger Drill
was discarded because we have something
in hand that we really going to play for
four runes or less. Uh specifically that
three and four rune threshold. So
Moonfall becomes available for instance
if we had units at the battlefield that
is. But uh there's other cards in the
hand that become available with the
number of runes open here. Or is it the
fact that we didn't think we could
actually get value from the proje which
I think in this matchup is more likely
because adding the extra might isn't
really doing anything against these
units overall. So I think that that is
pretty easy read and make as more that
it's not really useful in this matchup
so much,
>> but it's still something to be thinking
about here. That progress day is a draw
four. That's actually a draw five for
Lux. So that hand has rapidly been
regenerated for Raid Bowser. This is a
good let's get ready to close out this
game hand. I mean I just said close out
the game at one point. But you do see
the singularity here that is absolutely
going to be targeting away.
>> Good choice here. You got to get it off
the field of play.
>> Found exactly what they wanted to find.
However, does Cold Monkey have an answer
here? It does have that star cross. We
did talk about how getting those runes
ready could make a big difference here
in saving way will make all the
difference in the world here. A great
play with that star cross.
>> Then you have just one card.
>> Yep. Just one.
>> Uh I'll pass.
>> You do get the draw from the Lux.
>> Perhaps you draw into another
singularity to punish the Huay later.
>> Really would love to find more Ride the
Winds here because we need to find a way
to score. We know Lux has so many
removal options. We're starting to get
deeper into the game and with that it
starts to favor Lux if it is able to
stabilize here. We are going all the way
up to nine points. So really Diana's
going to have to find some options soon.
>> I agree.
>> Just wanted to jump.
>> Yep.
>> There's so many cards in hand here.
>> Yellow.
>> Y
>> lots of cards. There's lots of
decisions.
>> I will play call the week.
>> Okay. Call the week.
>> And unfortunately no response. Even if
there weren't be a starcross, there
needs to be a valid target on the other
side as well. So, we can't save the way
there.
>> This Lux control deh deck is all about
keeping the battlefield clear
>> and we're starting to see it come into
full force here.
>> I'll banish the card in your hand.
>> Yep.
>> Ash comes back and Flash is being
banished.
>> And that was the only card in hand, so
it was a quick response there.
>> I will.
>> This is a very difficult situation for
Golden Monkey here. You're sitting at
six points. Raid valves are at one, but
you're in top deck mode.
>> Absolutely. We'll have to see what it
is.
>> I'll play stack deck.
>> Okay.
>> Okay. That's at least an option here.
But I saw ride the win. I saw a stupify
and
>> whatever they picked was what I did not
see.
>> You can go ahead.
>> I will.
>> So, something to note here is that we
did see two ways in the stack deck
earlier. So, we know that there's one
left really as an option and with ride
the wind maybe we are able to do a
little bit something, but it is a tough
spot here overall. just because we're
seeing what Lux control does. It does
outv value at the end of the day.
There's a very few decks that can outv
value this. Leblanc is one of them for
instance, but overall it's just a tough
spot to be in against these control list
>> and that is another banished card. Ash
comes down and now what you're going to
be able to do is you're going to be able
to get into these battlefields and even
the Raven Bloom Conservatory is going to
allow Raid Bowser to start pulling
additional value from his deck cuz
there's so many spells. And although
these cards are banished and they can
come back, the only way to get them back
is by a hold, which isn't really going
to be possible here. So, more or less,
these cards are essentially discarded,
although they aren't technically so.
>> I'll top four
>> golden monkeys.
>> No hand, no cards in hand, or is there
one card in hand we just don't see off
screen? Because the ride the wind was
probably what they had top deck on the
prior turn, but
>> then they had done this the stack deck.
Okay, there's the card.
You have nothing open, right?
>> Yeah, I'm tapped out.
>> And we tapped out.
>> Yep. All tapped out. So, we'll have to
see if there is a way to potentially get
back into this game. We do have a whole
army there for Lux.
>> Looking at the trash. I'm wondering if
they're considering a Fizz play here.
>> Fizz into stack deck. Potentially
finding a way would be a possibility
>> for Golden Monkey. This is looking
increasingly difficult.
>> I'll pass two
>> and it's going to be a straight up pass
>> and then
>> hold to five will hold to five points
>> and Lux doing what it does best here.
Just saying outv value you. And the
tough thing is way is actually really
known for the card draw. But when it's
removed instantly, it's really hard to
filter through your deck, which this
deck is so used to doing. So it's not a
very common spot for Diana to find
itself in. So, Golden Monkey still
playing this game out, seeing if there's
a way to potentially sneak in the win.
>> I like the idea of stacking the Raven
Bloom Conservatory.
>> Uh, let me see. I'm going to tap Lux to
>> Lux is being tapped here.
>> Tap one, two, so six.
>> She adds two energy to her pool for
spells.
>> Let's draw five.
>> Yep.
>> So, once again, a full hand becoming
even more full here. saying, "I want to
have every answer possible for anything
you decide to throw at me."
>> I'll pass.
>> Yeah. And passing uh here with a a
number of runes available. Looks like
five or six or perhaps even more as they
fan them out.
>> We do also have that garbage grabber
there that can potentially draw even
more cards in the future.
>> Yeah, that's a stupify for a draw here.
>> Again, just there's no gas in the tank
here.
still making a, you know, thought about
this. Uh, some one reason that people
may play out a game like this where it
doesn't feel all that great. If you're
not used to playing against a deck such
as Lux, you're able to see more pieces
of the deck come out and it can help you
for your sideboard for the next game and
also your game plan for next. So, some
players might ask like, "This game it
doesn't look very great for me. What can
I do?" And this is one things that you
can do is say, I am going to continue to
see what my opponent is playing and how
I can respond for it to the next game.
>> Last rights is going to be a pretty
solid
>> spell here. The problem is though,
unfortunately, you're going to be
recycling those, but you'll be able to
go to the trash using Fizz.
>> Have to target a spell
>> again that will be recycled.
was checking those banish cards. Just
trying to see counting the number of
cards left in the deck. We will see the
stock deck stack deck.
>> The stack deck. Can we find a way
potentially because that would be the
way to win this game. I wish I thought
of that first.
Golden Monkey considering their stack
deck here. I thought I might have seen
the mine spplitter, but that's not going
to do pretty much anything here. Your
opponent is holding I don't know their
entire deck. So,
it's probably not the card. It's a big
body, but it's just not what you're
looking for right now. It's just but
like at the same time, it's like this
seems like a very, very difficult
position to be in.
>> Card has been selected. And you are
right. Quay would be the one you'd want
to try to get and just start generating
value, but something tells me in
literally the
>> the cluster of cards in Ray Bowser's
hand, there's going to be some removal
there.
Yeah, looks like we might be trying to
potentially set up a conquer onto this
aspirin's climb in the future.
>> So, first off, we are recycling from the
last rights,
>> trying to get more units into our deck.
>> And even if you pull away, we had seen
singularities in the main deck. I
believe it was a three
>> and singularity, it's not going to be
safe from a singularity. And there's a
very good chance we've seen one, but
>> there's a good chance at this point that
they've drawn another. So,
>> there's also Thousand Tail Watchers in
the deck. There's Imperial Decree.
There's Bellow's Breath. There's so many
options for the units overall. And with
this stack of cards in hand, we expect
to see just about an answer to
everything, including a salvage coming
down, hitting that last rights, a card
that we have talked about over and over
again as being a main board and from
going from tech to main board because
the amount of gear in the game right
now. and call the week clears the board
once again. And now because this is an
aspirin climb game, you're at the very
critical sevenpoint marker here.
>> If you're able to hold these next two
going into the next turn, it'll be the
end of game one.
>> I'll tap two and I'll play.
>> And once again, very important this
information for Golden Monkey is finding
out what exactly this deck is playing.
So once again, taking time probably
taking some mental notes here too to
figure out how to get into this next
game and saying I'm not going to see any
more information here because of the
holding to conquer next game or next
turn. So we're going on to that next
game.
>> Game two.
What's your strategy for Diane here?
You've obviously seen a little bit of
what Lux's game plan is here. raid.
Bowser did an absolutely remarkable job
of controlling the board state and
unfortunately even something like
Moonfall because the board isn't
necessarily wide and it's such a control
ccentric strategy.
How do you catch up when you start to
fall behind on the board because that's
essentially what happened to Golden
Monkey, you're expelling so many
resources to try to stay in the game and
Raid Bowser is able just to punish.
>> So if I were Golden Monkey, I would
really be looking to add more units from
my sideboard into my main deck. Um the
big thing is we needed units over and
over again to try to actually put
pressure on the board. There's so many
removal tools for our Lux on so we have
to find ways to say okay we will be fine
even if all of our units get removed
over and over again. So I'd really be
looking to find more units to put into
the deck.
>> In the main deck we did see two of
Starcross. Uh if there is a third in the
sideboard you might consider it as well
could be used as a save. Yeah, and
something else for Golden Monkey, the
Frigid Jewel, we saw the best thing that
it did was be discarded here. It's not
really a might versus might kind of
match up. We're not doing a lot of unit
onunit combat. So, frigid jewel might be
something that you look at sighting out
here. Is holding on to what we got a
glimpse of. It looked like an unchecked
power in hand. Not something that's
particularly great in this matchup
because Lux is pretty low on units
overall. The only way it would be good
if it really was a haha got you moment
like we saw in the first game where we
did see a stack on the battlefields.
>> And what's interesting as well is like
even with the game plan of Raid Bowser
like the gusts were impactful but they
just didn't have the staying power
because like they were able to, you
know, obviously repopulate the board
rather quickly and then just maintain
that board presence. It's just a very
difficult position to be in and like
even something like a mindspplitter like
you just saw your opponent draw
literally. I'm gonna like not joke here
like half their deck. So, it's a very
difficult position for Diana to be in.
And I mean that game was extremely well
pilot piloted by Ray Bowser. It was
their aspirin's climb game. It's kind of
what you expect here. So, we'll have to
see what their second battlefield of
choice is and if Golden Monkey can turn
on the jets and be aggressive to shut
out the game before it gets too long.
>> Yeah.
>> Exactly. Here. Also, I got to ask you a
question. Are you someone who shuffles
their entire sideboard into their deck
and then just removes cards or do you
select one by one?
>> So, first of all, I'm the one that likes
to shuffle my champion unit into the
deck every single time, then apologize
to my opponent. But no, I uh I like to
keep them separate and then I uh yeah, I
always have a plan. I like to have like
a chart of like what I sideboard against
what matchups because in the moment I
feel like uh being prepared and having
the uh the exact sideboards per legend
is very helpful. Um, it's one of those
things that I try to do preparing to go
into the summoner skirmishes.
Helps take some of the guesswork out,
but then again, like sometimes you're
against uh unique decks and uh sometimes
people have different flavors and the
deck building, the the actual the
personality of each individual player
and how they incorporate the spicy
choices of their deck designs can throw
a curveball into the way you sideboard.
So, what Golden Monkey did prior there,
which extended the game, stayed in the
game as long as it could to, as you
said, see as many cards as possible, was
definitely a good choice. And we do see
that Targon's peak coming in for Golden
Monkey. Going to be likely going first,
which means that you're likely the first
person to conquer. However, this can be
very good for Lux as well as they both
are high spell decks.
>> Forbidden Waste is interesting as well.
It's going to reduce the might of the
units there at the battlefield, which is
fantastic for Lux cuz if your your whole
game plan is to remove, you have a five
might unit there like a Hawaii, all of a
sudden wages of pain is enough to wipe
it out.
>> Exactly. It looks like we do have that
Raven Bloom student in the hand for
Diana. So, we'll be able to get on the
board nice and early, start trying to
push for those points because this game
will need to be quicker than the last
one. Oh, we have the Plundering Porro.
Also a great option.
>> Good old Pirate Porro coming on down.
>> Draw one.
So also being able to generate gold if
we aren't removed that is but being able
to set up for potentially a way turn.
The Lux not finding anything but will
likely maybe a wages of pain in hand is
a potential here.
>> Golden monkey knows they have to start
scoring these points early there. Plenty
of pearl comes in is going to generate
the gold token.
>> So that was a quick yes that's fine. So
an easy read here for Golden Monkey is
that there is no wages of pain in hand.
I will play Vex in base.
>> All right, Vex. It does come down. That
looks like Vex. Apathetic.
>> So, something here is we aren't playing
Vex at a battlefield, which means her
ability isn't actually active. And there
is Sprite Fountain in the deck of Raid
Bowser. So, Sprite Fountain, if it were
to be in the hand, could do a lot of
work here. But the Sprite burst is being
played instead. And this is a huge
punish here. Yeah, it is because those
sprites are going to come in ready and
they're going to be able to actually go
onto these battle if it's a hard bargain
here. That hard bargain being completely
tapped out is going to be enough to
completely counteract that spell
>> which almost feels like a bait a trap
that was just set up here by Golden
Monkey. A very great play overall. I I
mean it has to it hadn't been
intentional at this point. Um
>> if they know about this right burst, but
either way just said actually you know
>> I have a hard bargain here. Maybe I can
get a high cost spell out of the hand
here for Raid Bowser. And exactly that.
So this is going to set this Lux quite a
bit behind. Although it's not game
determining most likely.
>> You do have so much removal. We do see
the down under in hand. It'll be able to
be cast this next turn here unless
something changes. Vex is sitting at the
for uh the forbidden waste there. And of
course it's going to have that negative
two.
>> Play Diana here.
>> So I'm a bit concerned here about the
number of units on board. Uh, we are not
into ruin nation range quite yet, but we
will be quite shortly. So, I know we
want to score these as much as possible
in early on, but this is a lot of units
in a deck that wasn't running a ton of
units. So, maybe our hand is just very
unit heavy right now.
>> For Golden Monkey, your hand is
definitely a resource. We literally saw
that game one. And so, I think you're
right. Having a little bit in your hand
there even from the champion zone,
right? Being able to have that access to
a unit is super valuable because you
might quickly run out of steam, which is
exactly what happened on the last game.
Now, they are looking to perhaps remove
that Vex. Vex is going to shut down a
lot of the strategies from raid vows
here. And we know they have options and
you're right, we're not in Run Nation
territory, but you can definitely punish
that Vex.
So a big thing is because you have to
play around ruin nation though you also
have to play around a much cheaper card
the week. So having these other units to
go ahead and try to protect this Vex as
much as possible keep her on the board.
We know our opponent opponent is running
things such sprite burst. So the Vex
being protected by cold against cold
weak with these smaller units is really
useful. So
>> we have the plumbing portal come on down
for raid Bowser. Golden monkey is on
turn.
Vex does remain at the battlefield here
for the time being. And I bet you
they'll probably want to stay there.
Likely see the Targon's peak points be
scored. Diana,
>> so I like this because we can use the
Diana trigger as well as the Plunder
Porro getting a conquer as well. A lot
of players would think about just
sending one in, but you're getting a lot
more value into this. And against a deck
that does have heavy control, has
multiple ways to remove these units, you
potentially get value from both here.
>> It looks like they're reacting here.
>> Diana,
>> and they're going to hit Diana.
>> Kill Diana.
>> That's going to be a drag under
>> using that react that that window there
to uh to respond.
>> Um I'll draw my card. Yeah,
>> we will still get the conquer from the
plundering Toro and we will create a
gold with that as well which can be very
useful in this deck.
>> And Vex remains
>> and there's minds
with my
>> can spend one of those gold. The other
one is still exhausted
>> but still very efficient overall.
>> Okay,
>> if you need to see it.
>> Yeah, this is the one that kills all
units, right?
I'll just
>> I think I'm going to take I need to
write down the rest of these, but
>> listening in on the conversation.
>> So, we do have the plundering porros of
our own. We have the week. We have
progress day.
Actually have to think about taking out
either this rune nation or this progress
day. Even the progress day because we
saw how much value it got. And if the
game is going long, the other option you
say is I'm going to put so much pressure
on you. You can never play this progress
day. So, I'd actually be less likely to
do that. This ruination is probably the
scariest card in the deck.
>> Yeah, we talked about before the
ruination, which just completely blows
up all the cards. You've got four units
on the field of play.
>> I don't know if you want those four
units to just disappear.
>> I put one.
>> Exactly. You can't win the games if you
don't have units at the end of the day.
And Raid Bowser having that history on
Victor knows that very well that usually
on Victor, you can always have access to
a unit. Lux not so much.
>> Well, the monkey does choose to get rid
of ruination. I would tend to agree.
>> Raven Bloom student.
>> Yes, I love that decision there for
sure. And this mindslitter coming in
very handy here to a good
>> I like the decision to put in the Raven
Bloom student as the forbidding waste
will no longer apply its negative power.
It does provide some utility there.
brings uh the Vex out of the range of
something like a wages of pain.
>> Exactly.
>> So from from hand here. Oh, we almost
had a glimpse of it. Oh, there. Oh,
wages of pain is in hand now. We have
hand read that there wasn't one earlier,
but uh as you said,
>> oh, there it is right there. is Raven
Bloom student and that is then going to
drop the Vex down to three or by two
provided this goes through but there
might be a response.
>> So we'll have to see here if there is a
flash available because it is at a
battlefield only. Looks like we won't be
having that. And we do create that gold
from the wages of pain as well.
>> Vex now debuffed by two.
>> He has three up.
>> Yes. still has three up for this. Diana
has access to things such as Moonfall
for instance if this plunderering porro
does move in. However, there we have the
debuff now.
>> Yeah,
>> I should clarify that when the the unit
has to be defending to receive the two
>> debuff stupify. Yeah.
>> Yeah, that was
>> Well, the stupify coming in very handy
here. Vex now winning the might showdown
just by a little bit. Just by one. Good
use of Stupify there.
>> Gets the draw as well. That was
something that we saw in last game. An
issue the hand size this time. Not as
much of an issue. Feeling pretty good
for Diana here. Got rid of that ruin
nation. Looking like a very different
game than our first one.
>> Okay,
>> Bowser planning a response here. And
it's going to be Lux coming into the
play into the battlefield
>> or into the base.
>> Lux is one of those cards that you have
to kind of get it out early if you want
to play Lux. However, we are at seven
points already here. So, Diana has to be
feeling good for Golden Monkey has a ton
of runes available to him. Videot
potential stealing the game later, even
if there were to be a rune nation next
turn, which we're not expecting as we
just saw that Lux getting played here.
Really looking at potentially getting a
unit to contest the battlefield or more
so adding that extra spell energy from
the Lux in the future. must have a big
play planned in the future to be able to
take out these battlefields and
potentially slow down Golden Monkey.
>> And unfortunately, you're starting to
get to the point where Golden Monkey is
threatening to end the game within the
next turn. So, you have to be able to
make a play here.
>> You have to have a response.
>> Yeah. So, I'm interested to see if we do
decide to retreat these units. I like
this a lot personally because you don't
care if there is a sprite burst or
something that takes points from these
battlefields or not. It's not an issue
for you. What you really need to focus
on is double conquer next turn and if
you conquer once too, you can get that
extra draw, potentially find that last
bit. I like keeping all the runes open
here. You're able to protect things. Uh
Starross is a potential here if the
removal goes down. Also, taking units
off the battlefield keeps things like
wages of pain out of reach as well. We
did just see a coal top deck there. So,
we do have two coals available. However,
we would have to lose our own lux for
it.
>> Very difficult position here. Raid
Bowser desperately wants to clear this
board and reset
>> and I can't help to notice the salvage
is a bit dead in hand here. Um, for me
personally, I would have probably cited
out the frrigid jewels for golden monkey
and I would have looked to potentially
take the salvage out. We are just
getting a draw from it. You don't have
to target a gear. You may target a gear.
So, we do still get the draw from the
salvage.
>> It's too late to progress day.
>> You have to have the answer now. And it
looks like that uh mindsplitter that had
gotten rid of the ruination is really
showing itself here.
>> Exactly. With that ruination, there
would be a chance to reset the board.
Here comes that first coal or Lux will
be dying and we'll see likely the second
coal as well. just trying to remove that
board.
>> I'll play the second call.
>> Yep.
>> So,
>> a big note here is a double conquer does
have to happen to end the game. So, by
potentially removing one of these units,
we need to either find a fight the wind
or a way to accelerate our units.
>> Well, if you have, you haven't. So, I'll
tap two. Hey, Raid Bowser still going
through the uh third turn here and it's
going to be a Plundering Porro and a
Honest Broker.
>> I'll move my splitter here eight. Get
the draw
>> and then I'll ride in there and ride the
wind over.
>> There it is.
>> Golden monkey with game two going into
game three. Very well played.
>> And I like that Golden Monkey clearly
made some adjustments going into game
two. Not just with obviously their
sideboard and stuff like that, but just
the overall strategy they wanted to
utilize.
>> That extra game against Lux, I think
really made a difference.
>> Exactly. And did end up adding more
units because uh Golden Monkey doesn't
actually run Vex apathetic in the main
deck. So we did see that Vex apathetic
be another unit to for Bowser to have to
deal with. And so by seeing that, we
know that the strategy of adding more
units into the deck was part of the
strategy here from the side. And I want
to mention at least 40 minutesplitter.
We had kind of joked earlier about
mindsplitter being a little uneffective
in the first game and it was actually
the key card of this game because what
it did is got rid of the ruination which
prevented that board wipe from
occurring. And so uh I just want to
shout that out because it was one of
those things that seemed so I don't want
to say useless but that first game it's
like well he's got 40 cards in his hand
like what's the point? And then in the
second game he targeted the exact card
he had to hit to keep his board alive.
I'm also wondering if we took the last
rights out of the sideboard for Golden
Monkey here because really we're not if
we are that far behind we're probably
not going to be conquering and getting
things back. So I wonder if that was a
consideration here and knowing that
there was salvage available for the Lux
as well. It really does become mind
games in this third game potentially.
>> Oh yeah, it's going to be interesting.
We didn't see much pressure from Raid
Bowser in that prior game
and uh with that Vex apathetic now being
shown. I wonder if he's going to want to
be a little more aggressive with his
sprites, the sprite fountain. We'll have
to see. And again, but he has so many
answers to Vex. You have the
singularities call the weeks like you
have ways to get rid of him. We have the
battlefield selections here. We have
abandoned hall and sigil of the storm
for raid bowser.
Sigil of the Storm is an interesting
one. A lot of control decks really love
doing it because the reason is is that
you have to recycle a rune whenever you
conquer it and game decks that want to
be very aggressive in the early game,
want to be very proactive, are forced to
lose resources to gain points. So, this
does it's a really strong battlefield
for Lux overall.
>> We've been seeing a lot of abandoned
hall in the meta primarily with Aurelia,
but of course Diana loves it, too. And
might I suggest even the Raven Bloom
student can catch people by surprise on
something like abandoned hall.
>> Yeah, and I would say abandoned hall is
one of Diana's strongest battlefields
here. So it does help them out quite a
bit. Sigil of the Storm also doing a lot
of work as well.
>> I got to be honest with you, for Diana,
all three of these battlefields I think
are remarkable. It really plays into the
game plan. It feels like you have a very
consistent uh kind of uh power spike on
each of these battlefields at different
points.
Yeah, we'll see what will happen here
because a lot these players absolutely
need to get this win to continue their
hopes at a potential top eight here.
>> We're in the mulligan stage here. We'll
have to see who chose to go first.
>> I'll start.
>> Yep.
>> Channel two.
>> Game three begins now. Raid Bowser
electing to go first. pass
>> and three purple runes there with chaos.
>> Not going to matter too much. Here we
have Diana. That is one of the greatest
things about Diana overall is having
that very consistent turn one going
second play.
>> Lux
>> Lux nice and early here. We have both
champions coming out of the champion
zone and establishing their presence on
the board.
>> I really like this because we'll be able
to see a lot of spells come out from
Lux. Yeah.
>> However though, it does say likely no
wages a pain in hand. So, this Diana
does get to just take abandoned hall and
also gets the trigger here without
having to worry about it being
contested.
>> I'll take it. I'll get Eclipse.
>> Okay, grabbing the Eclipse.
>> Uh, conquer.
>> I go one.
>> Had to decide there was it worth taking
the gamble onto the next one or not.
Eclipse isn't exactly what you want to
see in this matchup. Of course, drawing
a card is never that bad, but besides,
you know, drawing the card is better
than taking the gamble and and seeing
what my next top card is.
>> Was potentially looking at getting a
stack deck there since we saw the one
changes mind says I need to develop
more, which I like this play quite a
bit. Uh, however, we are topped out. So
if Lux is able to activate here and then
add two energy to our pool for spells,
we could be finding some strong removal
here. For instance, if we do see a
singularity, this game would be I mean
it would be really tough from here on
out. But it looks like luckily enough,
no singularity in the hand.
>> You have a sprite burst there, though.
>> Yes.
>> And that Vex cheerless does
>> does make everything a little more
expensive once it's in combat for the
>> Lux player Raid Bowser. in total.
>> Yep.
>> All right, we have five runes activated
here for the sprite burst. Yes,
>> good.
>> I will get two ready.
>> And I like getting this down nice and
early, too, because we know that Vex
Apathetic is part of the deck now as we
saw it in the previous game. Uh getting
the sprite burst out as we saw it get
hard bargained earlier with it being
tapped out. We don't even have to worry
about that now.
Raid Bowser thinking about how they want
to uh take make their next move here.
>> Golden monkey is tapped out.
>> I'll just enter both.
>> Two sprites into Diana.
>> That's fine.
>> Had to do a lot of math there too
because sigil the storm although always
bad for your opponent, it could be bad
for you as well. So they are looking at
their future turns as well. A lot of
players get stuck on thinking what is
good for me right now and a lot of
players would say just getting the point
right now. However, that's not the case
here.
>> I like that use of call the week. Vex
cheerless is now in the trash.
>> Yeah, s of the storm is uh if you're
playing control, right, you want to get
to your your major pieces as early as
possible, but at the same time, it's
like you want to punish these aggressive
decks because you're going to be
removing those cards very often. If they
have to keep re-entering and
reconquering the Sigil of the Storm, it
can be punishing. I want to point out
here that Lux is only on mind runes
right now. So is going to have to find
those yellow runes to be able to
potentially place some of the cards in
hand. Uh cold the week, you know,
recycling one of those yellows. So we'll
have to see. There's no run or there is
ruin nation in hand. So if we want to
play that in the future, which could be
game changing here, especially if we
don't find another mind spplitter, we
need to see those yellow runes coming up
here pretty soon.
>> Fizz on the stack deck.
I see Hui
just off camera there. I'm assuming
perhaps it was Hui that was taken.
>> There's an eclipse and ride the wind
hand that we had seen earlier. Uh still
allowing us to get a lot of value here.
It needs to find a way to make this way
to stick. Uh making way stick here just
gets that's it's our engine. We need it
and it will help us out a lot. However,
against Luxa is always a tall order. I
will channel to two. I'd
>> be curious to see what Raid B's plan is
here.
>> If you have something like a progress
day, which I'm not sure we saw. Okay, we
do. Okay, there's a singularities.
>> How many cards in it?
>> Six.
>> The singularity is something that we
would be looking at doing potentially
because we do know hard bargain is in
the deck. Since we are topped out,
there's not always a great time to play
singularity because hard bargain
existing. And if you are hard bargained
and aren't able to actually pay for it,
it could be a blowout turn. So, the
singularity has to be a consideration
here for sure.
>> Hey, they're bringing Lux in.
>> Actually, I'm going to
>> Golden Monkey considering perhaps
>> they're going to stack.
>> Okay, they're going to use stack deck on
the trigger.
>> Yep, a showdown has begun. So, Diana can
be used with the one energy.
>> We saw Vex and I think that might have
been a Porro was kind of fast there.
>> Conquer the two.
>> Maybe found something good.
>> Uh, I'll play singularity.
>> And there's a singularity. I love the
singularity play as mentioned before
because it can't be countered and we
know that that there's only so many
units in Diana's deck. So I think this
is a really big play for Raid Bowser.
>> Raid Bowser is basically saying,
"Listen, I know that eventually you're
going to run out of people to put on the
field of play and so we're going to keep
punishing if possible.
Lux is going to hold on this next turn
unless something gets accelerated out."
And by playing the singularity too, we
don't we start to get closer to solving
the ruin nation problem that we don't
have to play ruin nation anymore. So the
yellow rune is less of a problem now.
>> Play way.
>> Yeah, there's way
>> and we'll likely see ride the wind
paired up with way. There it is.
>> Way to move him here. I just want to
note here that although Lux's time is
likely done with us, uh, it got so much
value these last couple turns. Was able
to get it out nice and early. Spend a
lot of energy for this Lux as well.
>> Unfortunately, it looks like this Lux
may be in danger here.
>> Yes, I don't believe we have a retreat
that we could play on Lux. Uh, it's not
really a frequent card played in Lux
because you say, "Oh, I got the value
from her. I got a point with her and
that's about all I need.
>> Hoy back to base. Won't be safe from
another singularity from that p that
position, but I don't think we see
another in hand yet.
>> Yeah, staying away from that drag under
is the biggest thing here. We've seen
that card come out multiple times. Now
>> I'll play for
>> second unit and it's the plundering for
>> Lux is going to find need to find a bit
more removal here. Silver only at two to
two. plenty of game to be played.
>> And the uh the power cost of the
singularity being felt here on this next
turn.
>> Absolutely a necessary one, but
definitely being felt.
Nice seven runes available. Not many
units in the hand. We have a lecturing
Yortle. It looks like that was
sideboarded in just to give another unit
and some draw.
You definitely want to deal with these
two units at base here because Golden
Monkey is really going to start
chippoing at the score and you're going
to run out of time.
>> The aspirin's climb game was just
absolutely uh phenomenally well done by
Raid Bowser.
>> And it looks like we have Ash Focused
coming out. Reveal the hand.
>> So we got the stupify the flash
and the last is still in the main or
still in the main board.
surprised to see that to be honest with
you. But
>> maybe saying because the game can last
long, maybe this is the what exactly
what I need or more importantly it can
actually put way out of range of
singularity.
>> It's actually an excellent point. It's
>> okay if I look at a great one.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> You do only have one unit in hand.
Stupify represents a draw.
So, I think Raid Bowser's taking a look
and say, "You know what? I can start to
exhaust the resources here.
Raid Bowser needs to make a plan for
what these next three turns look like
cuz if they can punish the board now and
if that Vex is all that's really left in
hand outside of the stupify that can
draw,
he might be able to take control of the
game again.
>> I will get rid of
>> I really like taking a look at the trash
here as well. Just using every bit of
information to make the decision and
flashing it. We know there's wages of
pain in hand. So that could be a bit of
a handy for Golden Monkey here, saying
if the flash is taken back, we have
things that want to deal damage at
battlefields, so we'll have to be very
mindful when wanting to hold a
battlefield.
>> That flash was an absolutely excellent
call there.
>> Plundering Porro perhaps being
considered, but you're going to go with
the wave first. Let's see what gets
discarded.
And we are on that abandoned hall. So we
have plenty of options to pro protect
this way if we do have damage based
spells coming out. We do know that from
the discard likely does have things that
target things at battlefields. So going
to the abandoned hall and on top of that
avoiding discarding a recycling a room
from the sigil also makes plenty of
sense.
>> Stupify on the ash get additional draw
there.
>> Yeah. And it was Eclipse that was
discarded from Hoy.
>> Makes sense. That was one that when seen
earlier was like ah I guess I'll take it
from Diana but not really wanting to
take it. So makes sense as a discard
here. Love tide turner being able to
protect way just a little bit more
giving the move trigger as well.
>> Discard last.
>> Last rights being discarded here.
>> That is going to allow him to ready two
runes.
Very good turn from Golden Monkey here.
>> And we're really seeing the value that
Diana can also do herself. Uh that's
something that we love about Diana is
that she can also
>> like we actually got to see wavy be
played and not removed instantly. That's
actually a huge piece here for Diana.
>> Yeah,
>> Blood Money does come down.
>> Yep.
>> And uh so far does
>> survive. We'll have to see. It might be
a major target for this next turn. Vex
apathetic out obviously does negatively
impact the spritebased strategies for
raid Bowser
>> and we do see Moonfall potentially
represented here as we are wanting to
protect that abandoned hole. It makes
the Ash going in not that great. On top
of that if Ash were to want to score a
point here has to say all right we're
recycling something and then on top of
that way can easily take her out. This
makes the choice for Raid Bowser
extremely hard.
Ray Bowser carefully considering their
play here.
>> Still has that wages of pain in hand.
>> Could be looking to do that.
>> Okay, they have focus. So fash ash does
come in.
>> Ash focus.
>> Focus.
>> Oh yeah, there it is. Yep.
>> And they just trade. Okay,
>> they trade to Vex apathetic top three.
>> I think that's a fine trade to make
overall. and wages of pain on the tie
turner.
>> Three runes up for golden monkey though.
>> So we saw that moonfall was being
represented but it isn't actually in
hand. So it is an attempted bluff that
did not work out.
>> Titer does get flashed here.
>> I still think that Raid Bowser has to
try to clear these units
>> one way or the other. It has to happen
because we is just going to get so much
value.
>> So yeah, no singularity in hand here.
>> And with the tie turner, the ways been
moving in and out of the battlefields as
it is.
>> Five.
>> Five being tapped here.
>> Um
five. I'll play a second ash.
>> Okay.
>> Second Ash.
>> Yeah.
>> Using the gold.
>> Reveal the hand.
>> So we have a rain balloon student.
>> Get rid of a rates. And of course the
ride the wind is gotten rid of there.
That's going to prevent Wii from
generating a little extra value, which
is exactly what Raid Bowser had
determined.
>> And we have to note that if we are able
to hold as Golden Monkey, we will get
these cards back. And they are huge
pieces that we would love to see once
again.
>> It's a great way to rejuvenate your hand
by getting that hold.
But Raid Bowser has a plethora of
answers.
>> Maybe not at this given moment, but has
the potential.
>> Trigger is okay.
>> Yes. is tapped out. So, uh, Wayey will
be able to get some value here
potentially through maybe we discard a
spell here. Looking for the draw. We'll
have to see what we end up doing.
>> Star cross.
>> Yep. Star cross for the draw.
>> It's an interesting discard because it
has the potential to save way in the
future like we saw in the previous
match.
>> So, I wonder if we have a second one in
hand potentially, but we don't because
we saw Ash focused already. So, no, we
don't have a second one.
I'll play Mindsplitter.
>> Mindsplitter. This was the MVP of the
the last game here, game two.
>> So, these are ruinations.
>> Two ruinations. Card sharp.
>> That looks like a uh Is that an honest
broker? And I can't quite make out. That
might be a pull under
drag under. Yes.
>> Oh, we have the safety inspector there.
That's one that a lot of people have
kind of looked to sideboard in at times.
>> So, safety inspector is you may pay 3 XP
additional cost to play him. And if you
do with that additional cost, you get to
kill a unit and then you don't have to
kill your own if you pay that additional
cost. We're not an XP based deck, but
it's a tech card that a lot of people
have been putting in these yellow decks
overall. You can
>> now that was not in the main deck. That
must have been sideboarded in.
>> Yes.
>> Move here. Conquer.
>> Five.
>> Oh, we cycle the spoon. Conquering them.
>> And of course that mine spplitter
hitting one of these rune nations.
>> And I will pass it to you.
>> But this time there's a second one.
>> Yep, there is a second one.
>> Channel two.
>> Yep.
Now,
>> this is a very important turn for Raid
Bowser cuz you want to prevent the hold
here.
>> Tie Turner and Hay holding either
holding would be devastating as the ride
the wind and it's a flash as well would
come back into hand.
>> We're going to just see the rune nation
here has plenty of access to the runes.
uh I don't know if it has a two drop
available to them or not, but I want to
see what raid Bowser decides is looking
at the uh disc at the trash here. And I
think this is really important because
you want to figure out how many units
does my opponent have left. Am I getting
the value I need out of this ruin nation
to be able to win the game or not?
>> Now, do you think about perhaps trying
to use the Ash, score the point on the
tide turner, and then use Ruin Nation?
>> Oh, yeah. definitely would have to look
into that for sure because any extra
point that you can chip away here makes
a big difference. However, the one
downside is with the sigil of the storm,
you have to get rid of one of your
runes.
>> That's right.
>> Not necessarily what you want to do when
you're playing control.
>> And I'll pay a gold.
>> Looks like we're not uh playing under
>> the ruination yet. It's going to be drag
under. Quite does pay the price there.
>> And that's a big piece of the board to
get off. Nash does come in to score the
point there.
>> So no hold there. So ride the wind and
flash remains banished.
>> A big thing of why not to play the rune
nation too here is you don't run that
many units yourself. So killing off your
own Ash, one of your bigger bodies that
you have available makes a lot of sense
here too. And we do have the safety
inspector coming down here to kill this
mind spplitter.
>> I got to say, look at that art.
>> I absolutely love it. And on top of
that, of course, the 3 XP cost was not
there, but he can just kill himself
instead and so he is in the trash. And
Ash gets to remain on the board. What a
great play here from Raid Bowser.
>> Golden Monkey now on turn.
>> We see it looks like a last rights in
hand, the Frigid Jewel in hand as well.
We're seeing what we saw kind of in game
one too where maybe we aren't going to
have the gas available here, but with
stack deck that helps us out quite a
bit.
>> This third game is turning out to be an
absolute
>> just example of what makes Riftbound
incredible.
>> It's so intense.
>> And we do have the Raven Bloom student
come out
>> alongside of the last rides. Are we
seeing a ride the wind here potentially?
>> That would help a lot because we get the
conquer and then add some units,
>> but likely won't be seeing that. Let's
see. We get last rights from our trash
because to equip last rights, we have to
take two from our trash, recycle them.
So, the frigid jewel also coming back as
well. These can be really important,
especially if we are to get another way
online. Maybe we do see the cards again
if we're expecting to have a long grind
here. But that's why you see players do
take that. On top of that, because Fizz
can play uh spells from the trash, you
don't want to uh put your spells back
into your deck either. So that's why we
saw gear there instead.
>> So I'm seeing
>> Ride the Wind does come in. Raven Blue
Student will get a plus one.
>> Yeah.
>> And it's enough to take out the
>> axe from Conquering there up to six.
So now the uh the board has now been
cleared with the exception of the Raven
Bloom student
>> and once again we won't want that Raven
Bloom student to hold
>> as those banish cards will return to
hand and this monkey a lot of options
here it is readied and they could
consider moving it back.
>> I guess he passed the turn first and now
is deciding whether or not he wants to
make the decision.
>> No, I just awakened.
>> Yeah, he he passed. Let's take a look at
what these players are saying here.
>> Oh, thank you.
>> It looks like the judge may be uh
>> getting further clarification. It looks
like what happened was that Golden
Monkey did uh
>> demonstrate that they were uh
>> passing their turn. Raid Bowser then
activated the runes and then Golden
Monkey said, you know, I want to pull
this Raven Bloom student back.
>> And I think that the initial reaction
from Raid B like, yeah, yeah, it's no
problem. But then they're just doing
their due diligence, checking with the
judgment, make sure everything's good.
>> Well, because we are in such a high
stakes match, too, it's understandable
for this to go in really either
direction. Uh I've done this several
times myself because you're just so
quick to be like, "Oh, yes, I score."
And oh, I'm also ready. Oh, yep. It
happens quite a bit. Yes,
>> it's an honesty.
>> I didn't.
>> However, something that's important
here, we talked about holding being
potentially important here. So, there's
a chance that this works out even if it
is left. So this could actually be good
for Ray Bowser instead.
>> It's true because now you're not going
to hold. But at the same time, uh I want
to just mention here, we've seen it so
many times the absolute sportsmanship
read like, "Yeah, that's okay. You do
what you want to do. Don't worry about
that."
>> And it is going to be singularity coming
down.
>> Didn't matter anyway.
>> Didn't matter anyway. You were going to
Ra and you were going to the trash
regardless.
>> Um now the question becomes though that
that singularity has proven to be so
valuable. Now we got a quick glimpse at
Ray Bowser's hand. I don't know if we
saw a second. We do have the portal come
down here
>> and another portal. We have two portals.
So that's going to establish the board
here and it's going to allow him to
conquer two on the next turn. Let's see
if Golden Monkey has any units available
in hand. The uh is that only two or
three in hand? It's hard to say. Golden
uh Golden Monkey keeping their cards
close to chest may only be two.
>> Yes. Uh not too many options here
available. Is there a unit is the big
question. And if there is, which unit is
it? This is the exact Oh, we can almost
see it's the exact same situation of
that last game. So, it's a hard pass
here. So, I don't think we saw a unit.
And now these little porros are going to
go in. They're going to plunder. They're
going to generate the gold tokens, which
is actually significant for Lux because
that's going to defend a lot of those
power costs that a lot of the more
expensive spells do pay.
>> Yeah, none of these cards are
>> exactly here with this. Oh, still taking
a look at it.
Yeah. No,
>> I will conquer here.
>> Yep.
>> All right. Going for that conquer on the
abandoned hall. We'll get that gold
generator.
>> Sorry. I need two points, right? Or it's
two points. I'll conquer here,
>> right? Yeah.
>> So, five.
>> Yep.
>> So, five points here.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. We tie.
>> Okay.
>> Oh, I think Yeah, cuz they're on turns
here. Yeah. So, they're going to be
tying the game here. So, it ends up in a
tie. Raid Bowser unlocks taking the
first game. Golden Monkey with a rem a
remarkable game two and then ultimately
it's going to be a tie. Neither could
win by two.
>> That's one of those games that honestly
like I find incredibly fun and
entertaining. First of all, getting to
see a control Lux. I hope that the
people at home did enjoy that. It was a
great demonstration of what that deck is
capable of. Is it something that you'd
be interested in playing?
>> Well, Lux is actually my favorite
champion in League of Legends. So, it's
someone that I've been wanting to play
for quite a bit now. and I was concerned
about its spot in the meta, but after
seeing that, I can see why it does
better than we expected.
>> It was one of those games where it's
like you're seeing how both players are
trying to feel out each other's
strategy. And it's interesting cuz like
each game had its own flavor. The first
game was very much a learning experience
because you're taking the opponent's
cards, you're reading the Lux cards for
what might be the first time for some
players. I'm not going to say the first
time, but you don't see these cards very
often. And then as a result, you have to
start making up a game plan. And you're
seeing your opponent as a Lux control
the board, go far ahead. They have 40
cards in their hand. You're thinking to
yourself, well, how did this happen? How
can I respond? And then we saw that in
game two.
>> Exactly. And of course, the sideboards
came into play multiple times there.
That safety inspector was a massive play
that we hadn't really seen that card
shine yet.
>> For Diana, one thing I want to kind of
pitch your way here, it's very clear
that Hoy has been an absolutely
remarkable card for Diana. Why do you
think that it is such an important
target to remove off the board for uh
for anybody who's trying to compete
against the Diana deck?
>> Well, not only does it filter through
your deck by drawing cards, it gets
value from its discards as well. So,
being able to say, you know what, I get
to look through my deck a bit more. And
we saw how even discarding gear and
writing runes to be able to have access
to showing more on the table overall
saying like, oh, I could be Moonfall. I
could be Starcross. It made a huge
difference in that game. Fizz is another
card that we've been seeing quite a bit
in Diana shells. Obviously, we're seeing
a lot of stack decks being brought back.
Stack deck being utilized to kind of
take a look through and often pulling
the ways for you. How valuable is
stacked deck in these decks.
>> Oh, for a lot of players have looked at
cutting stack decks, especially like in
Aurelia, but in Diana, it's been a key
part to finding units because you play
so many spells. We saw what it looks
like when you lose out on too many
units. You can't actually win the game
anymore. So stack deck is a way to
filter through your deck a little bit
further to find specifically units and
specifically way of something like
Ireelia you always have access to
Ireelia where you don't always have
access to way. So as someone who has
chased a best of for an underrepresented
champion what would you kind of what
advice would you give people out there
that are thinking about maybe going to a
future regional with an underrepresented
champion like Lux like we just saw? How
would you approach the deck building
side? like what would you do to catch
people by surprise?
>> Well, first off, I would say find a deck
that you love and that you're ready to
play a lot of and test and have fun with
it because that makes it all the much
easier when you go into it with the
mindset of like, I'm going to go play
this deck because I enjoy it and that
makes it all that much fun. Or if you
enjoy just winning a lot of games, maybe
you play something more meta like Diana.
Either one. Uh the big thing is enjoying
the deck and being ready to spend a lot
of time with it.
>> I think we do see that as well. like
prismaticism for instance is playing
Annie. Obviously Annie has a very large
meta representation. However, very very
well practiced, right? Very well
practiced. Knows the ins and notes,
knows the matchups very well. And I
think one of the key advantages like if
you're on Rumble, right, and I'm on my
my Teemo, right? That is going to be a
situation I'm like, well, you know what?
I actually don't know this matchup as
well. Like when I'm playing against
Dianos, when I'm playing against
Dravens, when that was part of the meta,
like I was very well verssed, I was very
well prepared. My notes were long. But
then I see a Rumble or I see a Lux,
right? And I've even seen Lux decks that
are running like Vanguard Armories, that
type of approach. And so I think that
when you're very creative with your deck
building, the person could absolutely
take the meta by surprise. And I mean,
we saw that with this Lux. Let's take it
to the desk.
All right, we are back and thank you
guys. So, uh, I know we don't look at
Lux games very often, but I think it
just shows a lot of like the feast and
family we get from this. At the end of
game one, look at how many cards are in
Raid Bowser's hand. Like, we've got a
whole stack of cards there. And really
just this kind of idea that we're able
to not only draw cards off of our legend
ability here, but being able to use our
cards to trade one for one, let's makes
us get to this endame scenario where we
have cards like the Ash, which we saw,
being able to use that to get cards out
of their hand and just make it so they
don't really have any plays. like it's
six points to the one here. It's really
behind for Lux, but since we were able
to stabilize, you're able to just
incrementally get those points time and
time again and kind of force that game
two. So, that's kind of how the deck
works, but we did see, you know, going
into this round, Raid Bowser was 711.
And with the, you know, infinite time, I
do think Lux has a lot of chances to win
games, but that's not just necessarily
what happens in these tournament
settings. So, we can go into the last
game, uh, that we had here, and, you
know, it was pretty tense. a lot of back
and forth, a lot of value. Uh, you know,
especially in game two, we did see the
mine spplitters come up and try to get
that value, but we have to use the
singularity, right? We were able to use
it to get the removal here. Uh, and we
do have the raid bowser. We can keep
going forward. Uh, the point totals
right now were six to the three here and
we are in time. So, we kind of did
stabilize for Raid Bowser here and we
were able to put out two of these
plundering porros as seen. Uh, which
will be able to offer a chance to get to
five points here. But even with all
that, no resources really for Golden
Monkey because we were able to get to
the six point total. We just weren't
able to close it out in time. So, uh,
with that, right, no really interaction
from Golden Monkey here. We can probably
skip forward. We see Raid Bowser say,
"Hey, I'm going to move these forward.
We're going to get to five points,
right?" Uh, and given a couple extra
turns, that could have changed the
winner for this one. But, uh, you know,
time is a resource in these tournament
settings, and you do have to make sure
to use the best of them. So, that's kind
of how the game ended. You see uh both
these players at a 712 record. Still in
contention for some good prizing and
looking forward to seeing, you know, if
that's able to be the best of lucks.
That was awesome, Eggman. Thank you so
much. And guys, that was an absolutely
remarkable round 10. We got more coming
in round 11, so stay tuned.
I'm out here on the floor here at the
regional qualifier here at Vancouver.
And of course, the players around me are
all playing in their own events. I
believe a sealed events going on right
at this current moment. But I just want
to talk about all the different formats
that you can play for Riftbound. One of
my favorites being 2v2. Now, it's one of
these formats that we're starting to
bring up a little bit more at all these
events and playing more of these sort of
scheduled sanctioned things because 2v2
changes the way the game is played
completely. You have to play to 12
points instead. And anytime a car refers
to friendly units, you're allowed to
target your friendly teammate ones as
well. Completely changes the dynamic and
the way that deck building exists as
well. So many things just like 2v2 and
sealed. Plenty of events here at
Vancouver. So, make sure you check them
out.
All right, Nick. We have two new friends
here. Your names?
>> Brandon.
>> James.
>> And how long have you guys been playing
Riftbound?
>> Never.
>> Whoa, whoa, whoa. Hold on. Is that
allowed?
>> Uh, you must be into League at some.
>> Oh, yeah. League. Absolutely.
>> Lots of League.
>> So, what got you into Riftbound?
>> Uh, well, I have a couple friends who I
actually got into League in the first
place, and they're big card game
players. So, I got them to League.
League got them into riftbound and now
they're trying to get me into riftbound
so we have another thing to share
between us.
>> Yeah, I mean I'm a Poppy man and there's
a Poppy card here and I just really
wanted that to be honest.
>> All right, I'm here for that. Okay,
that's awesome. All right, question
number one. First to three points is
going to win a pack from our judge here,
Nick. Question number one, what is the
name of Riftbound's first ever set?
>> Origins.
>> That's one point.
>> There's no buzzer. You got to just yell
it out.
>> I have no clue.
>> I was just
>> Sorry. I was assuming we knew that we
get to just yell out answers here. You
don't have to put up your hand. There's
no buzzers. No invisible buzzers here.
Okay. All right.
>> Okay. Whatever. You get that point.
>> All right. You guys, now this is a bit
of a lore question a little bit here.
>> What is the first champion to have two
different legend cards in Riftbound?
>> Draven.
>> Lux.
>> Now, Draven did have two champion units,
but specifically the legends. He has a
sword. Wuju Master, the blade master.
>> Ye. Master Y.
>> Master Yi is correct.
>> Why did you say Wu?
>> Hold on. Wu Master is one of the uh the
legends. One of the ver versions.
>> You guys are so close. Who gets the
point, Nick?
>> I got to say this guy right here.
>> All right. That guy right there gets the
point.
>> It's 1-1. Question number two. This is a
little more riffbound oriented though.
What is the name of the primary resource
we use to put spells and units on the
field of play?
>> What is runes?
>> Runes. What?
>> What is runes? Yeah,
>> what is runes is correct.
>> I forgot where Jeopardy actually runes.
>> Question number I can't remember. What
is the highest rarity card currently
available in Riftbound?
>> Mythic.
>> He's big. He's from the pit.
>> Baron.
>> Wait, wait. You just got to finish his
name. You said
>> Baron Nasher is correct. Nick, what's
the score thus far?
>> We got two to one right here.
>> It's two to one. I I was going to say,
>> see, I wasn't even sure. It's a little
bit of a chaotic episode here. I lost
track and you lost track, too. All
right, this one's for all the marbles.
Whoever gets this one right is going to
get an unleashed pack here.
What is the name of the League of
Legends show on Netflix?
>> What is Arcane?
>> You lose, you win. Let's go. That's a
pack.
>> There you go. Let's crack it open.
>> All right, guys. Let's see what you got.
>> Let's see. Can you open it? My hands are
sweaty. My hands.
>> Your hands are that sweaty.
>> I was trying too hard.
>> Okay, Jake.
>> It's yours.
>> Read them out for the people at home.
>> Downstream. Seeatics. Prepare. Neopight.
Double trouble. Damasian diplomat. Lunar
boon. Oh my god.
>> Loyal pearl.
Targonian visionary. Enthusiastic
promoter. Black flame alter. Disposal
order. Shiny disposal order.
>> Oh, Master Y.
>> Show the camera.
>> Master Yuju master.
>> Answer the question.
>> Yeah. Never forget.
>> Hold it up one more time. He said,
>> "No way.
>> Lucky man."
>> Yeah. And an irresistible faith oak.
>> Awesome. Guys, thank you so much for
playing. That was a ton of fun. I hope
you guys enjoyed it.
>> Thank you so much.
>> This weekend,
>> hopefully
>> we're going to now learn how to play.
There we go. We're trying to lay right
here.
>> Good luck then.
>> Thanks so much.
>> Take care, guys. Thank you.
>> All right, we are back for round 11 of
the Riftbound Regional Qualifier here in
Vancouver and we've got, I think, two
players left undefeated going to this
round. Is that correct?
>> I believe so. Which is so exciting.
We're really getting to that cream of
the crop.
>> Yeah. We're going to look at some
standings real quick. We see Dewali and
Allen ZQ both on Diana. Wow. We I think
the whole broadcasting team said Diana,
right? Was I wrong?
>> I think that's an error. I think that's
an error. I think Yeah, it has to be an
error.
>> Has to be an error. Well, we'll see if
we can correct that. But we do also see
some civers. Uh we see Swag Yellow 420.
Yeah. From yesterday. Uh still with a
respectful record of 91. We see some
Annies. We see some Kais. We see Poppy.
We've got uh the secret sauce, no veggie
uh with 91 on Poppy. Really impressive
there.
>> Yeah, really impressive. Just so many
names that we can recognize here from
those two regional qualifier winners,
Wall-E and Allen EQ. So many best of
winners as well like Swag Guild 420.
Yeah. Uh No Veggies and I believe Rocklo
as well. I mean there's another of those
secret sauce members houses are big up
at 11 playing a master. I've heard it's
a very interesting list that he's got
his own secret sauce of Master Ye, some
might say. Obviously, Sam D. Sherman
that we know very well from that Las
Vegas win as well. And CTCG Alexander
the the greatest, not the the
>> Yeah. Yeah. And we've we've got that
there. So exciting to see. I'm happy to
see Rengar 91. That's really exciting as
well. Uh and we do have uh we saw Zetto
yesterday. We've got Flex Dueland. So we
do have some Leblancs for you there.
Pretty good.
>> Two sideby side. two side by side with
the the 82 record. So, still in
contention there. Uh we saw Prismaticism
earlier still on an 8-2 record there.
So, uh pretty good. And we do I think
know our first match for uh this round.
We are going to see a battle of the two
teams. We've got the secret sauce houses
are big with their build of the Master
Yi. Yeah, I've heard so many I've been
talking to them a lot this weekend and
supposedly this is a really special list
of Ye a little bit different from both
that mid-range or Aurora list. I mean,
I'm seeing one of my favorite spells if
I'm being honest from set one, which is
primal strength.
>> Oh, yeah. So, uh being able to use that.
I mean, we're already so uh kind of good
at leaving these runes open. We've seen
Rengar be something to to use this. So,
you're like, "Oh, you know, they have
five runes open. They're going to use
Ranggar. That's a plus six. Primal
stank's plus seven, right? So, that
difference can make a huge uh, you know,
battle difference.
>> Yeah, 100%. Plus seven is hard to
account for, especially when you are
trying to figure out if you can take
someone's battlefield or not. And I
mean, leaving four runes up, even if you
don't have that one of primal strength,
you still have that threat of it.
>> Yeah, for sure. So, uh, looking forward
to that. We've seen the Battlefield
Starring be very good, seed of power,
the Emperor's Das, which is also a
really unique ad. Uh but being able to
uh use these battlefields to her
advantage uh you know this mastery is
you know pretty special I think.
>> Yeah I really do like it. It's going to
be interesting to see how it how well it
does. I mean a couple different units in
here I think are going to be really
important to help in this matchup.
>> Yeah. Well talking about sand soldier
tokens. We're going to see on the other
side what challenger TCG has uh with
their Azir deck also trying to qualify
for that top eight. So looking forward
to seeing what the build is from Alex.
>> Yeah, I think it's so interesting that
we're going to get to watch TSS versus
CTCG. We've been following them so
closely this weekend and obviously I
mean Azir is definitely one of my
favorite uh was my favorite set to
legend. Um but I mean what a cool list
here as well.
>> Yeah and uh you know there has been like
the sacred shears. I know that's been a
temporary ad for some decks but we do
see the single copy there. Uh so very
interesting. We've have a lot of uh you
know new ads. I think salvage in the
main's been pretty standard. We've got
back off the new VI also uh from
Unleashed has been very helpful
generally where you know a deck that
doesn't run a lot of units but this VI
just ends up being too good to pass up.
>> Yeah, 100%. I think CTCG has been
talking a lot about this VI even in
their Leblanc list they've been playing.
They said this VI is just so strong. So
really cool to see it included in their
Azir list as well.
>> Yeah and we do see again another seat of
power for both these. cuz we've got the
Trafarian War Camp and the uh Hall of
Legends. So, uh you know, a pretty
standard build of Azer. A couple tricks
up their sleeve and uh really curious to
see who's going to take it.
>> This is going to be a really fun match
to watch for sure.
>> Definitely. So, I think we're ready to
go. If so, we're going to switch on over
there. It's going to be again a battle
of the two teams. We've got the Secret
Sauce versus Challenger TCG. We're going
to see who comes out on top.
>> I am excited. And it looks like seed of
power and hall of legends are going to
be our starting battlefields here.
>> Yeah. And uh you know seed of power the
battlefield that we have for both sides.
Again, houses are big on the left with
Master Yi and we've got Alexander the
Greatest with the Azir here. And another
thing to kind of mention, these are both
uh you know have a lot of mechanics uh
for battle. Making our numbers a little
bit bigger. Try to make our might as
large as possible. And uh we're going to
get on into it.
>> Yeah, I think both of these battlefields
we're really going to have to look at.
Obviously, Hall of Legends is going to
be really interesting, especially for
the Azir. It's kind of actually neutral
for Ye. When you conquer here, you can
pay one to ready your legend, but Ye
does not get tapped and it doesn't
ready, but Azir can. Yeah. Yeah. So,
having some of these battlefields that
only you get benefits for, uh trying to
find those situations are really nice.
And I think uh you know only being the
one for the hall of legend for this
match up is really strong.
>> Yeah, it seems like a nice game one
legend for battlefield for sure.
>> All right, we've got our gear and yeah,
being able to have these additional uh
turn one gears to then use with our Azir
ability is strong. If you guys don't
know how the legend works is that you
can pay one to play out a sand soldier
token, but you have to have played a
gear this turn. So, uh, having more
options for turn one, being able to
have, you know, an early three might
unit ends up being, uh, pretty snowbally
and I think Azir ends up being, you
know, very aggressive because of it.
>> Yeah, I think it's so nice to be able to
make all these sand soldiers and
especially with the ability of that
weapon master like you mentioned,
there's some really fun gameplay that
you see, especially with some of those
hidden cards like guard, which you still
get the weapon master onto it and it can
really kind of make it a tossup of how
much might these sand soldiers might
have.
>> Yeah. And we've got a first mate on
houses are big. Not necessarily the best
start, but at least we got a uh unit on
the board here. We've got uh four runes
open for Alex. And there is a fun play
with Hollow Legends if we do have
another one cost equipment here. So, we
can play an equipment for one play the
token. And it looks like we might be
able to see it. We do see the sacred
sword.
And uh we're going to put there on the
token. And we can conquer the hall of
legends. When we do, we can pay one rune
to ready our legend and then we can pay
one again to play another sand soldier
token.
>> I mean, that's gonna be so nice really
just to build out this base, especially
in some of these uh decks that are built
to generate tokens instead of having
units in the list. Yeah,
>> it can kind of get bottlenecked, right?
But in this case, we're actually going
to get two every single time that we can
trigger that Hall of Legends.
>> So, uh you know, we already kind of have
the unit advantage here. We already have
three of these uh sand soldier tokens.
Uh and yeah, it's going to be a huge uh
kind of tempo for Alex off the gate.
>> Yeah, it'll be a good start. It does
look like we are going to be buffing
that first mate with pit rookie. So, it
is a little bit bigger than normal for
might going to go up into Hall of
Legends taking it, but again, not really
going to get to use that battlefield for
themselves.
>> Yeah. And and that's kind of like the
additional thing with all this uh this
gear too and equipment uh where we're
able to, you know, still gain the cost,
right? The fact that goes back to your
base, you can, you know, equip it later
uh for some additional uh might boost is
great. And we're just going to pass it
back. It's four might for the first
mate, but since it will be defending
alone, that's six might, uh which is a
little bit tricky to overcome.
>> Yeah, for sure. And I'm excited to see
like how these soul swords uh scale up.
They do get extra might if you can get
uh to level three.
>> Mhm.
All right. Thinking on our six rune turn
here.
>> Mhm. I do see some extra gear uh
equipment in hand. Obviously that
brutalizer, some extra might hand as
well. Um, I think fertilizer is an
interesting
>> looking for a discipline, bro.
>> Equipment definitely in basically every
Azir list, but the might that it gives
to your unit changes based on the turn
that you've attached it.
>> Yeah. And I'm kind of taking a quick
peek uh on the hand for Alexander.
Obviously, you're kind of uh you want to
play one gear return, right? That's the
big thing. So, you can make sure to just
keep your tempo going.
>> Equip here and then
>> six. Yep.
>> Yep. And so, we're going to go to six
here. And then we are going to play out
the sand soldier token here. So with the
brutalizer, we do get uh plus one might.
And then if it's the turn that we equip
it, we do get that extra plus three uh
plus two to make it a a three total. So
uh you know, we do have this potential
six to six here. But with three uh runes
open, there could be some scary
business. We're going to also equip
another soul sword. So uh we've got
three gears here. And it's going to go
seven to six.
>> This is much bigger, right?
>> That is one big sand soldier. It's plus
five.
>> Yeah. So,
>> oh, it's seven total. Seven. Yeah. Seven
total.
>> Yeah. But it's the dice are
>> Oh, no. The plus two cuz this this is
the indicator for the actual mic.
>> Yeah. So, that's the plus two.
>> I understand now. I understand. I
misunderstood. Sorry. I apologize.
>> No, you're good. You're good.
>> All right. So, it looks like it is
currently a six first might uh with the
uh sand soldier token. Seven might. We
have the onguard here. Um,
>> yeah, on guard is going to be nice
making that first mate just a little bit
bigger. I mean, a lot of these com decks
do have that might in hand and hopefully
>> Alexander the greatest will have it as
well.
>> Yeah, but uh you know, we're able to uh
to answer the unguard with the
discipline there, get the card draw. Uh
so we do get the Hall Legend
>> with only one open. Not really worth uh
using our the ability there, but
>> a token
>> we can
Uh, did I
>> Yeah, I think he used the Yeah, I think
he made the token already. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah, he already made one. Okay. You
could have paid one. Yeah. To do it, but
yeah. So, not not quite there. So, we do
have the other token here that can get
the seat of power to get a potential
draw.
>> Um,
>> but yeah, if we're if we're paying one,
we can ready our legend, but we don't
have the extra one to play out the uh
the token again, right?
>> Yeah, that makes a lot of sense. And I
think it's it'll be really important to
try to get this seed of power that draw
is so important in Azir. I feel like
when I've played the deck, a lot of
times the problem that I have is that a
lot of times I run out of cards.
>> Mhm. So, we got one open. I think I see
that there is the potential of like
maybe a charm. Uh if we charm the pit
rookie, it really means that we kind of
are safe on the next turn. It does mean
we're going down to three runes,
starting at five runes next turn, but
being able to keep our pieces safe. Uh
could be important. So, you know,
Alexander definitely thinking here on uh
there and yeah, passing pit rookie
survives another day and there's going
to be seven runes for houses are big.
>> Yeah, we definitely are kind of leading
this rune uh resources as well since we
had to spend so much on Alexander the
greatest side last turn. We kind of hand
attached some of those equipment,
meaning we had to pay for it. Yeah. Uh,
and so the brutalizer only gets the
boost of might on the turn that you play
it. So currently the sand soldier at the
Hall of Legends is only at five might.
So could be interacted with the pit
rookies at two. So you could collide
with the sand soldier in the seat of
power. But we'll see what houses are big
is going to do.
>> See, and it looks like we may be playing
that chosen champion the of Master Yi.
>> Yeah. So uh would cost four here for it.
uh you know, one of the new cards from
Unleashed, uh which super helpful to
have a you know, just kind of a a tempo
champion kind of what I've been calling,
right? If you've got nothing better to
do, you can just play it out. Uh but
just passing from there and not going to
interact with Alexander. So Alexander
the greatest here, five points due to
the double hold and uh we'll see the
decision here.
>> But both of these uh you know,
battlefields really uh incline you to
conquer them, right? So when you're
holding them like this, there's not
really any uh bonus effects, right?
>> Yeah, that's like definitely one thing
that is a little bit of a problem I feel
like with these like conquer
battlefields because do you then retreat
back to your base or do you try to hold
it for another turn because obviously as
you said
>> you kind of want the effects.
>> Yeah. But then there is the decision too
on Master Y where you know once it's at
a battlefield it's more difficult to
interact with them too. So, like, you
know, you could get another like token
uh activation. You can get another draw
from seat of power if you want to. Uh
but then yeah, you you have to be
worried. So, it looks like we're going
to put the sand soldier token into the
uh you know, seat of power here.
>> Yeah. So, it kind of seems I mean it
definitely seems like we may be trying
to hold the seat of power at minimum. uh
trying to kind of like reinforce that
top battlefield. But we do still need to
find another equipment. It's going to be
right there with that BF sword if we
want to generate another sand soldier.
And it looks like we will.
>> Yeah. So, we're going to play another
one into the base there. And we're going
to use the weapon master to equip the BF
sword.
>> So, four total there and then the extra
one. So, we've got one open
and uh looks like we are going to hide a
card at the seat of power.
>> Ooh,
yeah. I feel like when you're going into
a zir, a lot of times these hidden cards
can be so dangerous. Their one rune is
up obviously, so we do have to account
for that as well. But if it's one of
those hidden cards that could generate a
sand soldier, you could pull one of the
equipments off of another one, including
like that brutalizer, that BF sword, and
suddenly there's so much more might on
that battlefield.
>> Yeah. Yeah. It's, you know, could also
be hidden blade, right? Uh, you know,
fantastic card for order two. So, you
have to be really careful on, you know,
what you're trying to play around.
>> 100%.
>> So, I'm looking at six over here.
>> Five. Five.
>> Five.
>> Would you like an indicator or
>> No, you're good. Yeah. And uh yeah, as
mentioned, uh the northern battlefield
with seed of power does have four might
across two tokens. And then uh the
bottom one, the Hall of Legends, has
five with a sand soldier with a a mini
armory attached to it.
>> That is for sure. It looks like a little
mini armory right now.
>> All right, we've got a full what looks
like I think eight runes for houses are
big here.
Maybe even nine runes actually. Yeah, it
looks like nine runes here. Uh we've got
some ways to interact. Uh but looks like
we're just going to go
I know. It's tough. The these these
numbers are so close, right? Four is
enough to trade outright without any
interaction, but you you like to win not
to trade. Uh four is bigger than five,
so they can't immediately interact with
that. That one could be an unguard as
well to make the sand soldier at the
seat of power a big seven. But looks
like we are trying to aim
and attack into one of them.
Yeah, and Houses are big has so many
options here as well with that all those
runes we tal Oh, I mean punch first is
another one of the spells they have that
just allows them to buff up their unit
so large.
>> Yeah, and you know, normally we kind of
see it more as like an action. Uh, but
we're going to put it on the master. So,
currently it has nine might
>> big plus five here. And we're going to
go into the uh hall of legend here. And
yeah,
>> Alex thinking about it
>> explodes.
>> Yep. And there goes the uh all the loot,
you know, you know, after you uh kill a
unit, right? Just explodes with
everything. So, uh goes back to the base
with those. We do have a second point
there for houses are big. And uh you
know, if they're able to conquer the
northern battlefield too, they will be
able to get a pretty strong draw one.
So, we've got Ashan here. uh has weapon
master, but you can pay the additional
two body runes and recycle them. Uh when
you do um you know move an enemy gear to
your base, you control it until I leave
the board. If it's equipment, you can
attach it to me.
>> Yeah, it feels like Aan is going to be
really really nice against Azir. You can
try to take one of these equipments that
kind of is doing a lot potentially for
Alexander the Great. Obviously though,
Axan in some other matchups could pull
things like Aurora, which would be
really interesting.
>> Yeah. And so we do get to equip it. Uh,
and you know, I think they were
mentioning it too. It doesn't target.
Uh, you just get to move the gear on
resolution. So, uh, you know, nothing to
really interact with. Uh, and we'll see.
We might be able to hold the seat of
power, though.
>> Go there.
>> Let's go with a
>> Looks like we're potentially looking at
uh,
>> another Auction. Wow.
>> Yep. And we get not only the BF sword
but the brutalizer and uh you know those
are your big kind of might striven uh
equipment here. So we do hold 26 which
uh you know for trying to go for game
next turn uh that's kind of the number
we want. Uh offers a double conquer to
eight. Uh but we are a little bit kind
of weaker in this spot.
>> Yeah 100%. I just have to think about
how much potential might got removed
from Alexander the greatest aside. I'm
just thinking like potential new uh sand
soldiers. If we see a rise come down,
you have ones that could pull some of
those equipments. But now they don't
have access to it until we can remove
these auctionons.
>> Yeah. Now, a couple things to note. One,
uh these are definitely cards I think
people would expect in games two or
three, but game one double auction, uh
you know, is a little bit unexpected, I
would say. Uh the other thing is that it
was expensive. We had to recycle four
body runes to be able to do this play
here. Uh, and the kind of funny thing if
like the BF sword, uh, we we don't have
a way to re-equip it though. If the Oxon
does leave, we do get the the swords
back and such, but, uh, you know, this
is kind of a a weird spot for Alexander
the Greatest, I feel.
>> Yeah, 100%.
>> All right. And we will see this VI here.
We talked about it, one of the newer ads
to the deck. Uh, and so we are going to
be able to stun the Master G and get a
seven to their six. So, we will be going
to seven points right now, but getting
rid of that Y, I think, is a priority
for us.
>> Yeah. And it's so nice to get that
battlefield back, putting us up to
seven. This is additional like threat
that we're putting onto houses are big
now because next turn he's going to have
to take at least Well, he's going to
have to take both of them otherwise
we're able to win the game.
>> Looks like we are going to recycle one
and put the soul sword onto the VI.
question. Um, if I get my weapon back,
does it count as playing a weapon? I
assume not, but I want to make sure.
>> Changes control, right?
>> Okay.
>> Yeah. Just confirming also. Yeah. Aan,
you know, being able to, you know,
borrow your opponent's cards offers some
uh interesting ruling interactions and
just making sure on
>> the playing like likely there's a way to
maybe remove it and then, you know, you
want to be able to use your your legend
ability against. Yeah, I thought that
was really interesting of an
>> This is a five, right?
>> Very smart for sure when it comes to his
ear.
>> Right. We are going to use the charm
here.
>> I see. And so
>> we're going to go other side.
>> Yeah. So wanting to make sure Yeah.
Going to get rid of the sand soldier
token, but we do get our brutalizer
backy
>> which is quite nice. Again, wanting to
be like, hey, I didn't play I didn't
actually play a gear this turn, right? I
can't just use my my legend ability. And
yeah, unfortunately cannot do. So
>> yeah, if we were if it would count as
that, otherwise we would do it. But
we'll have to still play one this turn
if we want to summon another sand
soldier.
>> Yeah. And and here we go. Alexander the
greatest here saying, "Well, I think I
can hold here. We've got uh you know,
two hidden cards. We've got some pretty
stacked boards. Uh also, you know,
there's no fear of punch first here
since they have no body run. So that is
a good indication. You've got one rune
left open for Alexander.
>> So maybe they got you in the mines.
>> Yeah. If one of these holds were going
to game.
>> Yeah. Okay. Sure. Sure.
>> Yeah. Also not really having to worry
about primal strength either. That one
also costs a body rune. So I mean I feel
like just like looking here obviously
five runes you can still do a lot with
that but we have a lot more information
since it's only of one domain.
>> Yeah. And I kind of got a little bit of
a sneak peek on houses or big hand. Uh,
no copies of specifically. Uh, I think
we've got challenge in hand, which
unfortunately does nothing here. Um,
>> another spell that's going to cost a
body rune that we don't have.
>> Mhm.
>> All right. And looks like Oxan thinking
about here. Oxon with the BF sword is
currently at seven might. We've got two
hidden cards.
>> Is that in the rules?
>> Yes. When you end the game, you get to
see all hidden cards. I mean, judge.
>> Yeah.
>> All right. I think he's he's thinking
about conceding and just confirming that
you get to
>> You show them.
>> Yeah. Okay. Okay.
>> You play Magic.
>> All right. Yeah. Yeah. I concede. Just
making sure that the cards that are
hidden are are valid cards for it. So,
it looks like House been conceding
saying I want to go to game number two.
And Alexander the Greatest takes the
first one.
>> Yeah, that was a great game one by CTCG.
Alexander the Greatest. These are two
fantastic teams currently that are kind
of like doing so well uh in Riftbound
right now. So really cool to see these
two players interacting
playing such a great game.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And you know they're
discussing it. This is a game where a
lot of players with a lot of backgrounds
are coming saying you know this game is
really competitive. Uh I want to play
it. I'm having such a great time with
it. Uh and yeah just like this
combination against so many players.
>> Yeah 100%. It's so cool to see
especially like sometimes you have
friends from different backgrounds as
well that like get to rem meet at the
riftbound event. Uh it does we're going
to be going into game two though here
we're just finding out our battlefields.
>> Yeah. So it looks like houses are big
has already locked in the star spring.
We've seen this earlier with masteries.
Uh sometimes movement's a little bit
trickier for masteries in specific. So,
being able to put a unit at a uh at the
battlefield you already own, being able
to push back something that was holding
next turn and being able to be
aggressive with it on the other
battlefield's been really strong.
>> Yeah, I was thinking earlier obviously
it seems to synergize well with Leblanc,
but it also seems to do so well with
that Master Yi legend ability because
you only want one guy at the battlefield
if you want to get that plus two
>> for sure. And Alexander's going to have
to think on their second battlefield.
Uh, looks like the choices are either
the seed of power, which you know, both
are playing are the Trafarian War Camp.
Generally speaking, Trafarian War Camp's
the one I like to go first with just
because I know generally it's the the
one I feel more confident with. But if
you are kind of afraid of Mastery, I
could see maybe this is something that
if you know you're going first, it's
when you uh you want to use it.
>> Yeah, for sure. And I feel like
obviously mastery still will be able to
use it. Uh it is units here. So that
includes attackers will be getting that
plus one. But again that those sand
soldiers, we really kind of like to
swarm the sand soldiers in spots
sometimes. Uh so we can get more of
those plus ones whereas Master Y most of
the time is kind of just one unit going
into a battlefield.
>> Yeah. And additionally too, you know,
being able to hold for win for for
Master, it's so difficult to uh to get
that. Sometimes you're you're usually
trying to win by just going, you know,
you're at six and then you do a uh
double conquer to eight. Uh those kind
of situations, but we're going to use
the Trafarian War camp here going
second. Uh generally speaking, I think
you're going to have more units on the
board than mastery generally. So, uh I
do think that it's something that you
can get the, you know, better benefits
from.
>> Yeah, 100%. I definitely think so as
well. Well, I'm interested to know or
try to figure out here what maybe the
what houses are big is doing to
>> kind of beat Azir, right? Obviously,
they had a little bit of difficulty in
game one. Uh they but now they've had
access to their sideboard. They've got
an idea even more about how Alexander
the Greatest plays his deck and
hopefully we can come back from it.
>> Yeah. And also, you've spent a good
amount of time with the Secret Sauce and
Challenger TCG. You've interviewed uh
both their teams. What's kind of the
vibe between the two? How would you
explain it?
>> I think they're I mean both of them are
very excited today. They're I They're
always laughing which is a lot of fun.
Um but I think they have a good like
healthy competitivity right now. They're
definitely um
>> excited to show who's the best.
>> Yeah. And uh you can correct me on this
one. I think Challenger TCG has already
secured some bests, right? We did see
our volleyball uh volley beer player be
able to get there. Uh, and but looking
at Secret Sauce, I think going into day
two, their records were a little bit
better, but not necessarily securing
this year, right?
>> Yeah, I think uh their records may have
been better. A couple of them were
definitely coming into day two leading
for a number of legends or just in
second place for a number of the
legends, but I'm not sure how they're
doing later in the day uh at this point.
So, I mean, both teams also competing
for those bests and they are neck and
neck for us.
>> Definitely. And I think we saw the
secret sauce their team Poppy is doing
very good with no veggies. So uh you
know definitely you know houses are big.
I think they're tied with 91. So they're
both kind of seeing who's going to be
the best of uh of even just the the
secret sauce team.
>> Yeah 100%. I was talking to the Poppy
actually before this game uh and No
Veggies was like somehow I won again
with Poppy. I would love to see Poppy
and Top.
>> I would I would love to see it in Topy.
The game was really fun. Uh it seemed
like a pretty dynamic uh build too and
uh you know we'll see if that ends up
getting there. But we're going into game
two here once again. We've got houses
are big on the back foot with Starring
and we've got CTG's Alexander the
Greatest with the Terfarian War Camp
trying to get one more game ending this
round with a 10 and1 record if they do.
>> Yeah, and that would be such a great
spot going into that next round. They do
just complete those mulligans. I love
the mulligan in Riftbound. Very unique.
you do put those up to two cards to the
bottom of your deck and then draw the
next two. So, even if you draw into
something that you don't really like, it
would have been a card that you would
draw into either way, just getting
further and further into that deck.
>> Yeah. And it's uh I I find it's it's
interesting uh how many cards you see
just from it, too. Uh you have a lot of
ways for openings, and obviously with
more and more cards, we're going to get
more and more consistent. But I've been
I've been really happy with the the
starter games here,
>> 100%. We do luckily get those like
starting units for both players here. uh
that uh that equipment for Alexander the
greatest to be able to make a sand
soldier and that lonely porro. I love
lonely porro. I wish he wasn't so
lonely.
>> Yeah. Well, unfortunately almost every
card in Master Use deck I think is
lonely, right? Uh we're just so uh you
know pressed to only play one card in an
area. Uh it looks like we're going to
try to play our champion here
>> and uh either into base or into star
spring to push back the Loro if we want
to.
>> But uh yeah, we're going to pass it back
to Alexander the greatest. Yeah, it did
look like we were kind of thinking there
for a moment if we did want to play it
into Starring, but Lonely Porro's death
kneel is kind of why we like that Porro
just so much. Does help us draw some
more cards. Drawing cards means
consistency and consistency means a
happy card player.
>> Yeah, and uh right now we're at four
might with this lonely porro uh due to
the uh mastery when when we're in a
combat, right? Not in generically, but
uh that is tough when there is only a
three might sand soldier on the other
side.
>> Yeah, that is difficult. But where there
is that open Trafarian war camp at that
southern battlefield, we'll have to see
if Alexander the Greatest does try to
just, you know, take the easy path or if
he wants to try to take out that lonely
boro.
>> Yeah, looks like we're thing about
paying two here. Uh could be like a
brutalizer or yeah, I guess brutalizer.
Uh and we are actually going to equip it
to the sand soldier here and we're going
to go a big five to the four. Mhm. I
think that's such I mean smart and
interesting play to see him choose to do
the brutalizer first pay to equip it
because it does mean we're creating the
sand soldier and there's the option as
well, right? Uh to potentially move one
of those equipments back onto that new
sand soldier though it does appear we
don't decide to do that.
>> Yeah. And uh we do end up using uh you
know the legend ability. We don't
necessarily have to equip it when we do.
Uh we just have to make sure that there
was one that was played. So, Brutalizer
uh was played and we get to play it out.
And uh yeah, Brutalizer is kind of weird
for this deck because we kind of want it
to fall off so we can equip it again.
It's very hard to kind of juggle uh the
extra might that you get from it.
>> Yeah, I definitely definitely agree. I
mean, but it does feel nice on the ones
that do get accelerate. It's
>> nice,
>> but it's going to be that disarming
Drake coming down just another piece of
that gear hate that we're seeing in this
current meta. fast.
>> Yeah. And uh yeah, we've been seeing a
lot of this. You look at this unit and
you're like, man, it's a little like I
have to recycle one and it only has the
uh two might there, but getting rid of
that brutalizer is huge. It offers, you
know, an additional two uh you know, or
what, one to three might so much
throughout the game that just getting
rid of it uh is just super strong.
>> Yeah, I forgot about that.
I mean, not to have to worry about that
brutalizer because I don't know,
definitely some of these different
equipments that can like change in the
amount of might that something has can
be a little tricky in figuring out how
the math for if you're going to win or
not win.
>> Yeah. So, we do end up taking the star
spring and then I think houses are big
is thinking about using a challenge
here. It would be able to get rid of the
sand soldier and then like the only card
on the other side for Alexander the
greatest would just be that one soul
sword. So, uh, instead we're going to
use the charm here. Uh, Alexander's
like, "Yeah, I understand what's going
on. I know how this works here." Uh, and
then passing back from there. But this
is a huge start for houses are big.
>> Yeah, I definitely think taking out
these early sand soldiers, making sure
that Alexander the Greatest has nothing
really to be able to fight with here is
going to be houses. House is the our big
best way to be able to win against this
more aggressive deck.
>> Yeah. And we've got six currently. Uh we
do kind of need to play out a couple
more equipment here. I think anyways.
>> Yeah. Uh paying the one for the sand
color if you have to.
>> What's up?
>> You said it's already
>> No, no, no, no. No, no, no. You're good.
No. I don't need to do anything. Yeah.
>> Yeah. So, thinking about if we want to
equip it with the sword or uh the
shield, always a choice, I think, for a
lot of situations here. But going to put
it on the soul sword. We're going to
play out the Azir champion for the first
time this match and pass it back to
House.
>> I absolutely love the chosen champion
for Azir that Azir Sovereign I think it
is. Uh he has a really interesting
ability where when he moves into a
battlefield, he can move any of
>> a certain point of any of those sand
soldiers up with him.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And uh and just really any
token. So unfortunately right now we've
only got an army of one, but that can
definitely change in the next couple of
turns. Uh, houses are big is at three
points and four XP. So, an additional
two. We do get level six for our Y
champion unit there. It does get ganking
and deflect, which would be pretty nice.
Uh, and thinking about pushing up likely
the rake to the Trafarian War camp.
>> All right. Uh, looks like we are going
to play out the first mate
>> potentially.
Interesting.
>> Yeah, we're going to play it out there.
Uh, it's going to move this back
>> and we're going to move it up to the
Trafarian War camp.
>> Sugar hunt.
>> Yeah, almost giving it little pseudo
ganking right there. Uh, just being able
to push it back with star spring.
>> Mhm. But also still have a unit on
there. Oh, and the challenge. Now we're
at five. This is some really good math.
So, Trafaran War camp is whenever you
are at a battlefield, you get that plus
one might. And so getting that five to
four means that you do get rid of their
Azir without losing your mastery. That's
fantastic.
>> Yeah, that is going to be so nice. And
it's so important to get out that Azir
as quickly as possible when it comes to
going up against uh a deck like this
because you kind of don't want the sand
soldiers moving as easily as they would
if Azer was alive.
>> Yeah. And you can kind of tell here too,
kind of joking around like, man, you
used my battlefield to make that happen.
Like that is that is some tough
business. So, uh, houses are big does
have 6 XP. We are level six, so we do
have that deflect and ganking now, too.
Uh, we are getting the plus two might
whenever we are defending alone. So,
it's effectively a five and six might on
these battlefields. And all we have is a
single sand soldier and a sword and a
shield.
>> Just doing some math.
>> There's a time in there. Wish we had a
clock.
>> Swords and shields are great to fight
with, but we will need more sand
soldiers to do so.
>> Yeah.
Oh, and yeah, I guess additionally on
the Trafaran War camp, we do get that
one extra might as mentioned too. So,
uh, you know, it's it's uniform to
everything that goes there, but you
know, potentially having seven might on
that E by itself is uh pretty tough,
>> I suspect.
>> Yeah, for sure. We are moving up this
smaller sand soldier right now into that
Trafarian war camp. I believe it is
currently forite with fair war camp, but
I do assume there Oh, we come in with
that ambush by. Yeah. Uh we saw that do
some damage last turn as well. Uh so
currently we are at seven might for Yi.
Uh the sand soldier is at four might and
the VI is at six. So currently it is
going to be a I believe 10 to seven
here.
>> That is going to be a lot of might to
deal with. But
>> we have at least one rune up. I'm
thinking mainly of ong guard with that
uh number of runes. But I'm sure there
are other options as well.
>> Yeah. Uh I think it have to be a punch
first if we are trying to get any
difference. I see one kind of sneaking
in the hand there. It would make us a 12
to 10. Now the mastery is still stunned.
It wouldn't be able to you know kill any
of these units but it would survive and
stay uh on the Trafarian War camp which
means that uh you know houses are big
does get to keep it. Yeah, I will
mention that the the punch first is
going to take obviously so much so many
runes with the power and there's still
runes up on Alexander's side. So, I kind
of think it's a smart decision here.
Lighouses are big. Chooses to do just
goes on and gives up that master E.
>> Yeah, but I understand like why it was
the decision there. Uh but yeah, that
stunning from the VI made it uh you know
a little bit tougher to get the value
>> 100%.
>> Can I use my dice on the side like not
on stream? Okay.
All right, we've got three runes left up
for Alexander the Greatest. We have two
points here and we're on our Trafarian
War camp. We're actually going to play
out the shears here.
>> Y
>> shears was my favorite equipment when
playing Azir again. I always found a lot
of trouble with, you know, keeping a
good hand size and she and shears is so
nice of that. It gives your sand soldier
or whoever it's attached to death nil of
draw one which doesn't seem like a lot
but over time especially if you get it
your turn one feels so strong.
>> Yeah. And I I think what Riftbound does
very good is it it has this choice like
you can draw a lot but you have to
recycle runes. So like being able to
find the line in the middle where you're
drawing enough cards but also you have
enough runes to play them has always
been a thing. So when I've played shears
in the past I think the card draw is
great but like that extra recycle can
sneak up on you. So, uh, it's not like
the free value all the time, but if
you're able to keep looping it, that's
so much card draw,
>> 100%.
>> So, we end up passing by equipping the
door and shield there. So, that does
give tank to our sand soldier. So, keeps
our VI a little bit safer. And we've got
houses are big at seven runes right now.
Trying to see what we're going to do
with them.
>> Three. All right. And thinking on here,
so uh again without the uh with the
Trafarian War camp buff, the uh VI is at
six might and then the sand soldiers at
five. So there's 11 might on the
Trafarian War camp right now. Uh and
then we do just have the first mate at
the Starring currently at three, but
five when defending by itself.
>> Mhm.
>> That plus two just feels like it makes
the unit so much larger. I mean, it
obviously does, but it's crazy how it
scales.
>> Yeah. And we are going to use the
auction. And we are going to get rid of
the shears here. We're additionally
going to use the effect of star spring
to move the first mate back.
>> The nice thing here is we're just
incrementally kind of like growing the
unit on star spring. We had three was 9
in a showdown might on it and now we're
kind of protecting with five would be
sevenown.
>> Yeah. So currently it's 7 to 111, but
then we get an additional five. So it's
13 to 11.
>> I'm just making sure that
>> and uh I think it's it's bigger number.
I think only one unit is going to
survive this this battle.
>> Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. And then you're Yep.
Yep.
>> So uh you choose one to live, which I
assume is
>> Yeah, the rake will Yes, that will die.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Okay. So, the rake the rake
survives
>> uh that huge battle got the punch first,
but again, we had to recycle I think
what four uh body runes. We're down to
three runes for houses are big. So, a
little bit of a scary situation. Uh
currently the rake is at uh five might
would be seven when defending alone. Uh
currently the rake is at three, but will
be a five might defending alone. Um, so
yeah, these are some some good numbers
that uh that Alexander the Great has to
try to navigate around.
>> Yeah, we don't seem to have a lot of
units to do it with right now. We are,
it looks like, at six runes. Uh, so I
mean
>> I'm interested
to see what Alex can do here.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. And looks like we are going to
play out a soul sword. uh considering
maybe using our legend ability now that
we can. Two open could mean uh double on
guard are uh a copy of the discipline.
Uh luckily nobody run so punch first is
not really in contention here. Uh but
again that rake being a five on defense
is a little scary.
>> Yeah and this time we are going to be
attaching that uh Dorian shield it
appears which is I mean really nice and
does
>> go in here. We'll trade.
>> Yeah. So offers a
>> Yeah, we're
>> Yes. Yes.
>> Yeah. There's so many additional
numbers, right? There's the war camp,
there's the ye uh there's a the you know
the gear there. So, but yeah, it ended
up being a five to five. Uh and so
there's the trade there.
>> But the thing is if there's another unit
in hand
>> uh for the can move back and then go to
the war camp and get a uh you know the
two points that we need next turn. So
we're going to defy
And yeah, Alexander's just like, well, I
hope I hope they don't have a unit to
play.
>> Yeah, fingers crossed here for Alexander
is a great we are holding up to seven
like you mentioned.
>> Definitely a bit of a risk down to looks
like
I believe on has big side activities.
All right, good. Good. Yep. Yep.
>> All right, so we're going to four. Yeah,
just confirming on point total. So
holding to seven here. Uh, Starring can
help this Axon move all the way over to
the Trafarian War camp.
>> Uh, we're going to start with a sabotage
though.
>> Yeah. Uh, goodbye Arise.
>> Top
>> probably. Go ahead, man.
>> And oh, but no unit. Okay. And this is
it. Like we do have these situations
where
>> No, I wish uh you know, you have to
force your opponent to have it and you
you kind of need to see it, right?
>> 100%. Taking out that arise, I think, is
so important with it. We are at six
runes on Alexander the greatest side
which means we could have potentially
played it had three more of those sand
soldiers and potentially.
>> All right, they're asking the question
that uh I I wish I knew the answer to.
So Ashan did have the sacred shears. It
does have this death nail to draw one
when I die. But also when Ashan dies you
give the shears back. So uh we're going
to have a judge confirmation on I don't
really know who gets the draw off the
top of my head. Yeah, I actually was
thinking about this, but I have no clue
if he is the draw or not.
>> Uh, but it's a really interesting
interaction.
>> Um,
>> all right. So, it looks like we are
thinking about just making sure where
it's going. Um,
>> I guess it has to go there. I'm dead.
So,
>> couldn't blade there on the auction.
Yeah, saying yeah, there's the defy.
>> I think that kills me.
>> Yeah. And I think uh with the defy, I
think we're going to force
>> defense
>> another game perhap.
It does look like we may be forcing that
game three here. Two runes as all houses
are big has left though. But it looks
like we are going to game three. They're
scooping up here and just cleaning up
the board to get into it.
>> Exciting.
>> Yeah. And you know what? This is this is
obviously uh a really close game. It's
quickly becoming one of my favorite
games of this tournament, right? The
fact that we're getting to game three.
We've got 20 minutes left. Both these
players know what their deck are doing,
right? It's back and forth. We got the
battle of these two teams, right? trying
to get some dominance in this stacked
event. Uh can't wait to see who wins
game three.
>> Yeah, this is going to be so exciting to
see who comes out on top here. I mean,
they have been fighting all weekend
trying to, you know, get top eight, but
now we're actually just facing it off
>> right here.
>> Yeah. So, going to this game, I think we
know the battlefields that are left.
We've got seed of power, I believe, for
also for houses are big. I think we've
got the Emperor's Das left. Uh, which,
you know, weirdly enough, there could be
a chance that Alex Alexander has a way
to get more advantage because those are
sand soldier tokens. And we do have that
extra weapon master given from our Azir
legend.
>> Yeah, that is going to be so
interesting. And I love that Azir still
gives weapon master to basically any
sand soldier. So, I mean, what is that
gonna mean for houses are big when
honestly think he obviously it's his
battlefield. He wants it to work in his
favor, but it might work in Alexander
the Greatest.
>> Yeah. So, uh we're getting shuffled up
for that. Again, I think Alexander the
Greatest will likely take first, which
in a match like this one, I think that
does give a little bit of an edge, but
uh don't count houses as big out yet.
>> Yeah, that is for sure.
And uh you know, we're looking at you
know, potentially some sideboard cards
that we've already seen come in, right?
I think Disarming Rake definitely helped
you uh control the tempo uh for that
game. I think that's something that e
easily both players could be playing as
well.
>> And yeah, that's a just a great ad.
>> Yeah, I thought the sabotage also was
fantastic of addition really pulling
that arise out of Alexander the greatest
hand when honestly he was going into the
turn that he probably wanted it for.
And we do have again these last
battlefield. Seed of power for Alexander
the Greatest here. Uh you're able to get
a potential draw one if you conquer it
second essentially. And then Emperor's
Das here. Uh being able to create some
more sand soldier tokens. It's going to
be a little bit tough to get I think the
full value from that from Alexander to
have a unit to bounce back to your hand,
right? Cuz you're sometimes you're just
making a sand soldier token to play
another token kind of thing. But but uh
there's that
>> 100%. Yeah, it's going to be difficult
with the sand soldiers. With sand
soldiers, when your unit gets bounced,
well, it's a token gets bounced. Uh
>> it's kind of just killing it.
>> Yeah. Yeah. You're just kind of, you
know, replacing it here. But, uh I could
see some uh weird situations where like
maybe you want to unequip the weapon to
then be give it to something else to
conquer the other battlefield. Uh there
could be some situations where you
bounce your VI back to then use it again
next turn. Uh since, you know, with that
reaction uh and ambush, that is really
nice. But we start with Alexander the
Greatest uh just saying, "Hey, I have a
turn to play." Oh, and we haven't seen
this gear yet. Uh honestly, one of my
favorites for the deck.
>> Yeah, this is another really nice gear.
When I move, you get to play a one might
recruit token, which is going to be so
nice to really build out the board.
However, houses are big says, "No, Siri,
my disarming rake will send that
straight to your trash."
>> Yeah, Houses are big are like, "Yeah, I
agree. It's a really cool equipment. Uh
I need to get that
soldier in there.
>> We'll see if there's uh you know some
more equipment to be playing here.
Honestly, look at the hand from
Alexander though. It's not too terrible.
There are some good situations. Uh you
know, the fact that we have another gear
I think if we want to is great. Uh but
yeah, this disarming rake uh has foiled
our plans just a little bit.
>> Yeah, but at least we do have another
equipment though. playing that
brutalizer and getting another sand
soldier out. Uh
>> come here for one.
>> I'll be at one point.
>> Yep. Going into the seed of power, too.
>> Go ahead.
>> Uh not equipping the brutalizer and
recognizing that it's going to be
stronger the turn uh that I equip it.
So, I'd rather do that instead.
>> And we're going to go to the Emperor's
Das here. And this is going to offer a
chance to put this disarming rake back
into hand. And guess what? I think this
brutalizer is not meant for this world.
Yeah, this is going to be a bit of a
problem getting to bounce this disarming
rake. If we play it again, that
brutalizer
may very well go to trash as well. It
will. And I feel like cast are big are
saying, look, this house isn't big
enough for all your opponent.
>> Yeah. And that could have been a, you
know, a slight, you know, decision
change for Alexander saying, you know
what, I gave them a free removal for
that one. But we're going to hold the
two with the seat of power.
>> Talked about it. You can turn your
soldier to another soldier.
>> I love hearing them laugh with each
other. They're having a lot of fun with
this game.
>> Yeah, they've got some really good
banter and love to hear the back and
forth. Uh but yeah, being able to have
this access to reusing our you know on
plays are really strong when you know
the rake you know we are losing a rune
right every time we play it. But uh you
know taking care of these two gears have
been really strong.
>> Yeah, for sure. I'm interested to see if
houses are big will want to uh give up
that Emperor's Das for a turn to be able
to reuse it again because it seems just
so strong.
>> Yeah, and I mean we've got some
decision-m uh looks like we have the
potential for another gear, but I think
it is the shears so it's a little bit
expensive to do so. Uh we have
potentially uh looks like another VI as
well and we are just going to use the VI
there. Uh if we could return the Vita to
hand as we kind of mentioned two
>> three for me up.
>> Yeah, that would be really nice to be
able to protect it again, not letting it
stay vulnerable at that uh battlefield.
But also if we free up the battlefield
too much, you're potentially sending
that disarming rake back nipper's dice
back to House of Big's hand back to the
base where it could kill another
equipment.
>> Yeah. And and probably thinking, all
right, uh there could be access to a
charm here. uh would be, you know, you
trading, you know, token for a rake
here, but it's obviously caused a lot of
issues and
>> thinking about it real hard here for for
Alexander.
>> Charging.
>> One, two, three, four, five.
>> All right. And we've got Yeah. One point
to three. Five cards in hand for houses
are big. And we are going to use the
charm on the disarming rake. Yeah. And
just say we know what's happening. Two
for two. Vi is now defending alone. But
unfortunately doesn't get any bonuses
for that.
>> Yeah. Too bad for Azir not doing that.
But at least we did get rid of the
disarming rake. It was being a bit of a
problem obviously for Alexander the
greatest. And now we are back with
houses are big. We only have body runes
this time unlike some of our earlier
games. But Rengar will be able to beat
out that VI. Yeah, we haven't seen
Rengar at all this game. Uh, and I'm I'm
sure Alex was thinking about this like,
man, if they have Rengar, they have
Rengar cuz uh otherwise I have a chance
for some good momentum. It's hard for
them to move to Battlefields. I can get
seed of power with this other token, but
this is a real tough spot. Only a token,
no gear around. Uh, houses are big has
gotten some real good momentum just from
their kind of atypical battlefield and
that disarming rate for you.
>> Yeah, 100%. They are kind of just like
pushing forward trying to get to that
that eight points.
>> Obviously, Alexander the Great is going
to want to try to figure out how to deal
with that Reng Guard. There are no runes
up on houses, our big side. Meaning, if
we want to get rid of it, this is
probably a good time to do it.
>> Yeah. So, uh you know, if we have we
we'd have to put so much to get rid of
this Rengar, right? It' have to be like
a BF sword. like a BF brutalizer I think
would take it cuz it's going to be at a
seven might uh sorry eight might while
while defending cuz it's six plus two so
that that is such a high total there
>> yeah that's gigantic
>> as you please
>> luckily a lot of these uh calm decks
again have mine in hand maybe we could
make it looks like we are going to be
playing those shears though even though
it does cost one power it can can get
plus one might, but we'll have to see if
we decide to deal with the ring guard
just yet.
>> Yeah. And now there's a decision. Yeah,
sure we can play a token out, but then
where do we put the shears onto our
other token uh that we're probably
moving up to the to the battlefield?
It's going to likely get the death nail
earlier, but it's another rune we have
to recycle. Um, you know, a lot of
decisions
and looks like we are just going to pay
one for another token and we're going to
put the equip the shears with the weapon
master afforded from the legend. We're
going to move the sand soldier token to
the seat of power here.
>> Going to four points to two and thinking
about this three. Yeah, passing it back.
>> We are going to let that Rengard get a
point from holding then.
Y
>> we I mean we are got to start get set up
so that we can deceit that Rengar at
some point.
>> Yeah. And it's uh it's quite the
terrifying presence here. Uh we do have
some ways to move it around. Something
like a first mate could be huge here. Uh
but yeah, I think there could have been,
you know, oh, a sabotage. Let's see what
you have and let's get rid of it. We've
got back off. Uh we do have the guards
and we do have uh the
name just escaped me in my head. Right.
It's the uh the death grip. Thank you
very much. Yes. So uh which is not doing
too much here. Uh
>> could be like death grip into the sand
soldier. Get the death meal draw too.
But yeah, I think the back off
specifically is the uh is the scary one.
>> Yeah, for sure. Your stuns have been so
strong,
so it'll be good to get rid of that back
off. Sabotage though, so strong into
Azir in this deck where it does now, I
guess, run a unit being that VI, but for
the most part, it's all spells.
>> Yeah, it's you almost always get value
from it. So, um, you know, we'll see.
Yeah, looks looks like it's going to be
the back off here.
>> But what am I what am I? got five runes
left to play with. Uh, you know, if if
there is a first mate, that can offer
some good removal. And I I see I see one
at the far right of the hand here.
>> Yeah, that would definitely be nice. We
do still have to account for those three
runes, though. But we know exactly what
is in Alexander's hand. So hopefully
causes are big has a plan.
>> Yeah. and
thinking here. Yeah, it should be.
>> Yeah. Oh, just another Rengar. All
right. Yeah. So, okay. This offers an
interesting trade here. Uh we could uh
get rid of our other stand soldier be
five to five and offer us a draw two.
>> Mhm. And getting rid of I mean that back
off is really important here because
obviously we could have used it at least
to save off another turn stunning it if
Alexander the Great had been able to
keep it.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Agreed. So, uh, able to get
the the, uh, seed of power there. That
does offer another draw. One
>> four four points to four. Uh, there
could be some ways to get rid of one of
these, but again, these are eight might
uh, Rengars here. Those are really
difficult.
>> Yeah, that Y plus two is going to be
really hard for Alexander the greatest
to overcome. We could potentially find
some of those spells in the future like
hidden blade that might be able to deal
with it. uh or
you know hopefully something that allows
us to kind of avoid that eight might but
we'll have to see.
>> Yeah, it looks like uh I think Alexander
the Graves drew an arise which can be a
game changer in a lot of situations but
when you only have one gear thanks to
that disarming rake it doesn't get much
value on that first.
>> Yeah, if we had three right now I feel
like we would be in a lot better spot
for that arise but this does not feel
good. It looks like we are just going to
send that sand soldier with shears
directly into a Rengar just to let it
die and draw us another card.
>> Yeah, and I think I got my numbers wrong
for that. If we use the death grip, it
would have been five to six cuz for
whatever reason it's a five might uh six
might Rengar with five power. So, or
five cost. So,
>> uh yeah, it would not have been enough
if we did the death grip. But we are
going to play out the Azir and we're
going to replay out a soldier with the
shears there. So going to six points
here for houses are big and definitely
kind of forcing this point.
>> Yeah, it definitely feels like houses
are big. It kind of has a pretty good
foothold here. Really kind of just
steamrolling straight to those eight
points. It definitely doesn't feel good
as a zir to be summoning sand soldiers.
I mean your one sand soldier per turn
with guards versus actually getting an
equipment set up.
>> Mhm.
>> No. Oh, the disarming rake. Once again,
>> this disarming rake has done so much
this game. Obviously, I think there was
a different one, but like disarming rake
kind of the MVP of this game.
>> Yeah, and we're just going through the
motions. Uh, you know, Alexander still
playing it out, but yeah, six points to
four. We'll see what we can do with a
single token here,
>> but not looking great.
>> No green.
Yeah, and this this is tough. You know,
I've played a good amount of Azir. Uh
you one of the kind of footholds for
this meta is that you know, fury is less
around. So you can do like thermmo beam
is kind of a game changer. So it's not
present, but this this disarming rake is
doing its best to pretend that is a
thermo beam, right? I think we've gotten
rid of three gears and it just keeps
getting value.
>> Yeah, we have all gears. He got He got
me. He got me. Good.
>> Yeah, broke got free information. I wish
I could play Scuttle Craft for free,
man.
>> All right. Baking the uh Dorian Shield
here. So, it will offer us uh you know,
another token. Sure.
>> It's good value.
>> Yeah, at least we do get the one
>> charm. Uh put the Rengars hanging out
together.
>> Yeah, that does save us another turn if
we do that, which is going to be nice.
It's a good use especially of the of
charm. I mean, a lot of times I feel
like we think of charm being used to
loosen him up to kill it, but in this
case, we're using it kind of defensively
to give us an extra potential extra
turn.
>> Yeah. So, we've got uh you know, five
points to six here. We're going to use
our uh effect of our legend. Yeah. We've
got
>> six runes open.
>> Oh, I pay one more. Sorry.
>> That's You're good. You're good. You're
good. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Oh, sorry. Five runes open. Yeah. Just
making sure on the
>> Azir.
>> But yeah, this is going to be really
tough and this could be the houses are
big taken this match. Seven points just
need to conquer that seat of power.
>> Yeah, I mean we are to seven. All as you
said, all we have to do is take that
seat of power. We do have that disarming
rake and obviously six runes are up. Uh,
we have that discipline and those four
runes to the side seem really scary to
me. It kind of feels like it's saying I
have more to play. I dare you to have
it.
>> Yeah. And looks like we're going to try
to press a
>> four to two here with this disarming
rake. We again have the plus two with
the discipline.
We're going to move our Rengar back
>> and then we will play the first mate
here. So that will be able to active
this Rengar and I think we're going to
go in. This is going to be a big 10 to
two.
>> We're going to give the three uh the
three might sand soldier, but not going
to be enough. And Houses are big secures
the win and it's going to be 101 after
this round.
>> What a fantastic job by Houses are big.
Fantastic game.
>> Yeah. and and really just kind of showed
off some of the kind of more unique
picks I think for for this deck.
Obviously, the Ashon in the main helped
out a lot. We did also have the
disarming rake and the Emperor's Das to
have a way to replay that uh disarming
rake just be able to eat up all that
gear and equipment ended up being very
strong.
>> Yeah, I was so surprised by how much
they really got with that disarming
rake. I thought Emperor's, you know, Das
may get a couple uses, but it just
seemed to repeat over and over and over
how strong it was.
>> Yeah. Uh 100% on that one. We did also
see like the strength of Rengar, right?
Being able to have uh that ambush,
especially where there are already uh
you know, enemy units ends up being
strong. Kind of gives you accelerate in
a lot of situations, too. So, that is
great. And uh yeah, what a what a tight
game.
>> Yeah, what a tight game. And also just
coming back from that game one loss. I
feel like a lot of times when stuff like
that happens, you can kind of get in
your head and maybe have more difficulty
coming back, but he kind of just he
swung it right. He got that game two and
then game three was his.
>> Yeah. And you know, I think there was a
decision on game three uh you know, did
we where do we conquer the Emperor's Das
or the Seed of Power? I think that did
make a big difference because getting
that free Emperor's Das to not even have
to contest being able to play this
disarming rake again uh ended up I think
getting a lot of momentum.
>> Oh yeah, for sure. and Alex just could
not come back from it. He couldn't get
those equipment set up, which is going
to be a huge problem for Zir.
>> Yeah, and we will actually have game
three of our other table. We're going to
look at the deck list real quick and
let's see what our matchup is.
>> All right, we've got Wisely with the
Victor here. Uh we haven't been seeing
as much Victor. We have been seeing, you
know, a lot of blue yellow. We've seen
Leblanc, right? We saw Lux earlier. Uh
and now we've got Victor.
>> Yeah. And Victor's another one of those
decks can that can really just generate
those tokens. Obviously, that is
Victor's entire calling for his legend
ability. Very similar to Azir in some
ways like that. But in this case, it
does look like Victor is deciding to
play a lot of units.
>> Yeah. Yeah. We've again seen like the
kind of spell heavy ones. We do see a
lot of new cards, too. We do see that Vi
once again. I think one of the best
order cards from Unleash being able to
get that ambush, being able to get that
stun. very hard to contest. We also do
see the sprite fountain. We haven't made
enough tokens already. So, let's make
some new sprite tokens as well. Uh, you
know, being able to get two of these
across two turns have been really strong
in a lot of decks.
>> Yeah, I love sprite token. Being able
also like those ready sprites sometimes
you can be a little bit slow generating
these recruits at your base, but not for
Sprite Fountain.
>> Yeah. And so, we're going to look at the
other deck. We're going to see Azir and
uh you know it's going to be a battle of
the token decks as well. We did see
Alexander the Great on the previous one
and looking at this there are some kind
of minor changes between the two builds.
>> Yeah, I really love seeing this shadows
call here in the in this Azir's list.
You get to choose a friendly unit that
doesn't have temporary. Obviously our
sand soldiers do not. You give it
temporary but you get to draw too which
is again huge problem for Azir.
>> Yeah, that card draw ends up being
really important. We do see a lot of the
kind of familiar faces with gear
equipment. We do see the VI. Uh we
didn't see last game, but Arise also can
be a kind of snowball card. Uh the
signature spell for the deck. So you get
to play a two might sand soldier unit
token for each equipment you control and
you you get to ready two of them. So if
you have four equipment now, that's four
new units. Two of them uh are also
active. So that is really important.
>> Yeah, that card can be so strong. Either
you said to get the momentum going
sometimes to close out the game. And I
mean the battlefields just slightly
different here. Only difference is that
arena's greatest.
>> Yeah. And uh looks like we're going to
go into our third game for that one of
Battle of the Tokens. Let's see who's
able to take it home.
>> I am so excited to see how these two do.
Which of the token decks will come out
on top?
>> All right. And we are getting set up. So
we saw for game one, we had Rockfall
Path and the Hollow Legends. Game two,
we did have the forbidding waste and the
uh arena's greatest. So, I think on game
three, it's what? Arena's greatest
likely. Uh I think I think we're jumping
into game three, but maybe maybe we are
jumping into game two. Game two. All
right, there it is.
>> Good luck.
>> You too.
>> All right.
>> And no spoilers. I I we actually do not
know if there's game three or not, so
don't
>> Oh, no.
>> Uh yeah, I mean, I'm really excited to
see how this plays out. But we saw Azir
is just so aggressive in our last match.
So that arena's greatest is really going
to help shrink the game size and try to
get this game finished as quickly as
possible.
>> Yeah. And uh we do see that Wisely was
able to take game number one. So we do
have Azir going first on the second one
which makes sense with Arena's greatest.
We are going to play out again the Dor
and shield play out a token and we're
going to pass it back. profile one. Yep.
>> I love these alt art runes though on
Thunder Tree's side. They look
absolutely great. And it seems like this
is a person of your own flavor choosing
to have a different types of runes.
>> There's so many good art pieces, right?
You got to, you know, show show the
variety of them. Uh, you know, agree to
disagree on it, but yeah, when they keep
adding new ones, you got to collect them
all, right?
>> True, true, true. I That does make
sense. Maybe I'll slowly move towards
it. But it does look like it's going to
be a really urgent early uh Sprite
Fountain here going that sprite up into
Arena's greatest. That would bring him
up to two points since both players did
get that arena's greatest trigger,
putting us at one point at the start.
>> Yeah, and I really do like this sprite
fountain. Also works really well with
our uh Victor champion, Victor Legend,
Victor Leader, sorry. Uh, so being able
to use that so the sprite token uh, you
know, gets killed and then you get to
make a recruit off of it ends up being
nice. But again, we've got uh, you know,
a sword and shield with our uh, uh, sand
soldier there. So going four to three
and ends up taking the arena's greatest.
>> I won't let them.
>> Yeah, and we're just slowly building up
these sand soldiers. You can see we're
kind of trying to avoid this forbidden
uh, forbidding waste of that north
battlefield. If a unit there is
defending alone, it gets minus two
might, which does not feel good.
>> Yeah. And I honestly, it's it's kind of
one of my my battlefields I just keep in
rotation often. Uh the fact that it is a
uh you know, if you're playing against
these whole decks, they really get
disincentivized from holding that one,
right? Uh it makes it difficult for them
to hold alone. Getting that extra minus
two might is strong. And I don't believe
it it's to a minimum of uh one either.
So there can be that extra interaction.
But we do have the pickpocket here being
able to get rid of the Dor and shield
and offer a gold gear token. We're going
three to three.
>> Yeah, I mean we've talked we saw just
last match how strong some of these uh
gear killing units are and pickpocket
already doing that. Also generating a
gold token for Wisely, which just seems
like we're getting more and more
resources.
>> Yep. And deciding to just pass on the
opportunity to get that extra point
here. I think that's fair. I think
Victor kind of has to be on more of the
control and value side for this deck. Uh
Thunder Trees here though going into the
arena's greatest once again going to
three points to two and then playing out
the BF sword.
>> Oo, at least we are getting BF sword
down even though we did L that lose that
Doran shield which could have given
different units tank. Uh however, I mean
BF sword so strong plus three. Fingers
crossed they don't have another pick
pocket.
>> Yeah. And uh so we do have the BF sword.
Uh and then we are hiding one at the
arena's greatest. So not equipping the
BF sword to me kind of means that we
might have uh the guards there to be
able to play a soul a sand soldier token
and equip the BF sword. So uh you know a
little bit telegraphed, but it's still
like a good combo there.
>> Yeah, for sure.
>> All right, thinking on our I believe
this is a six might or six rune turn.
paying V3.
>> I love Zenhao in this list. Uh just in
or in Victor lists in general, I should
say. Uh Zenhou has tank and also if you
have two other units in your base, it
comes in ready. And honestly, when it
comes to Victor, often times you're
going to have those two units, meaning
it kind of just reads reads, I come in
ready.
>> Yeah. And uh we're at 7 to seven here
with the guards. Once again, get to play
a sand soldier unit token. And since the
Azir gives weapon master, you do get to
use the weapon master to immediately
equip that BF sword. So, uh there needs
to be an interaction to try to get one
more difference. I do think that there
might be a supify in hand. Uh might just
not be uh you know, you might have
wanted that third rune for something,
but going to use the supify on the sand
soldier. So, now it's going to be seven
to six. get the draw there and we will
be able to win this arena's greatest.
>> Oo, I mean that is going to be nice just
slowly building up these points. Again,
we are kind of avoiding that top
battlefield here and both players just
Oh, not never not anymore.
>> No, no, we need that that extra point.
Again, it is important to be on these
even numbers so like a double conquer
can offer a a win. And we are going to
put one more unit in our base and pass
it back to Thunder Trees.
>> Yeah, now Thunder Trees has two
battlefields. So, they kind of have to
contest here. They only have one sand
soldier that is ready right now. And
obviously, we'd need to find another
equipment if we want to create another
sand soldier.
>> Floating one.
>> Yeah. And looks like we are going to uh
recycle one to put the BF sword on our
sand soldier. So, we're currently at six
might. And we do have one floating.
And yeah, we do have uh you know, a big
six to their three. We're just you know,
conquering only the arena's greatest.
You're just saying we're the best. We
got to we got to keep proving it, right?
>> We are the greatest.
I I mean, I think it's a good game plan.
>> Yeah, it's it's a you know, it's a
mental thing, right? He's just making
sure like, hey, just keep saying it. I
conquer the greatest, right? That has to
keep happening here. And uh we do also
get another Sand Soldier token out with
the Doran Shield. We've got four runes
left active. Uh but, you know, we're
still kind of going back and forth with
these kind of token econ uh economics.
>> Is there a basis?
>> Yeah, 100%. in. And it does look like
our Azir Sovereign is going to find its
way from the champion, the chosen
champion spot to our base. And I mean,
it seems really nice eventually getting
to move around hopefully. As well as
that door and shield, it does give that
sand soldier tank, which means if we
decide to move with Azir Sovereign into
one of these battlefields, you'll have
to attack the sand soldier before you
put damage into what you really want to,
which is that Azir.
>> Yeah. And we're looking at the numbers
here and it's going to be a six, but
that is the exact numbers for this VI to
come down and take this arena greatest.
Uh, you know, if you guys haven't been
convinced that this VI is a good card
yet, there's been so many situations
already on stream this weekend to show.
Yeah, it is a meanie. And another picked
pocket. Man, that is two shields for two
gold. What a good trade.
>> Yeah, I think this kind of shows just
like how strong these Doran shields are
as well. both these pick pockets really
just targeting them making sure they
can't stay on the board making sure that
Wisely can choose where they want to put
that damage.
>> Yeah, and you know I've played a good
amount of Azir and there is definitely
like this all right game one you know I
have kind of the advantage most the time
but you know there's so many ways
especially in this meta to interact with
gear and equipment that games two and
three ends up being a little bit more
uphill due to that sideboard. So, we do
have the shadows call for a draw two,
making our sand soldier a temporary
unit. And uh we're going to see there's
six might on the arena's greatest right
now. And it might be a little bit tough
to interact with, but we can move the
Azir and the sand soldier token and
contest it.
>> Yeah, I'm excited to see really like how
the shadows call does in this list just
because like it can generate so much
more draw and if it'll give us the
resources we need here.
All right, thinking about it, we've got
five runes left open. I mean, there are
some like you can equip a uh a gear and
you can make it a, you know, a seven or
higher, but then, you know, you're, you
know, you're going to lose your zir. Uh,
unfortunately, if we had the door and
shield, that would be the best uh usage,
right? Being able to give tank to our
token that we know is going to lose
anyways is pretty strong.
>> Yeah, it would be so nice especially I
mean the VI is just such a big baddy
right now. Uh obviously if we can also
play another equipment we could make
another sand soldier that we'd be able
to bring along with Azir as well because
even though it wouldn't be ready and it
moved by itself that Azir sovereign is
able to move tokens with it to a
battlefield.
>> All right. So still thinking here I
think I did see like an ash in hand. So
getting that knowledge I think there's
only three cards in Wisley's hand. So
reducing that to two would be strong. Um
yeah, and it was just saying, okay, do
we Yeah, what do we what do we do here?
There's just too many options to really
have it be automatic
>> 100%.
And I feel like forbidding waste is like
doing a really good job here in the fact
that because that Azir is was minus two
by itself because now it is not
defending alone and therefore it does
not have minus two. Uh cards like charm
can't really be used to bring the token
over, but now I guess it doesn't really
matter.
>> Yeah. So, uh choosing one of the three
here. Uh the thing is that if they hold,
they do uh you know lose out on uh they
get the card right back, right? So, uh
we are kind of uh pressed to now take
this
>> this battlefield.
>> Yeah. And I think
>> I think those is a great choice to try
to banish here. Uh I think especially if
you try to move into these battlefields,
if you're trying to be at different
spots, it could be kind of dangerous,
especially with these sand soldiers that
are only two might.
>> Yeah. So, uh we decide to double equip
with the Azir here. So, that's going to
be seven might to six. Uh so, that means
they don't get to hold. Uh the other
thing about having Ash at the northern
battlefield means that we don't get the
negative effect of that forbidding
waste. So, all that is strong, but we
don't have any runes up. And oh, getting
rid of that token here could spell
disaster.
>> Yeah, that's going to be bad because
even though Oh, yep. And there's going
to be
>> Yeah, there it is. Wisely, you know,
putting it together like, man, I really
can't interact with this. You have so
much tempo on your side. And Wisely
going to enter the next round 10 and one
with what, two more rounds left of Swiss
to go.
>> Yeah, I think only two more. So, I mean,
Wisley is in a fantastic position right
now, and they did such a great job
against Azir.
>> Yeah. So, a bit of a tough round for
Azir fans on stream here, but we did see
uh both the Victor take the win there as
well as the Master Yi uh for uh you
know, the secret sauce there.
>> Yeah, I would definitely say as an Azir
stand, my heart hurts, but really
exciting to see such a cool Yi be doing
well. So cool to see as well that Victor
who's continue is continuing on X and
one.
>> Yeah. And you know, we've seen Victor
obviously be played a lot. Honestly,
probably one of the most played legends
in this game in particular. And I think
we've got an interview with them. So,
we'll see why they're continuing to play
with Victor in the set three meta
>> point here with Wesley, the Victor Xen
one deck that just took down an
incredible match there. Now, I've got to
say you had the battle of tokens with
against an Azir deck. And funny enough,
we had another Azir deck on our other
feature match. And so, you know, I won't
tell you the spoilers of that one, of
course, in case you want to go back and
watch it. But, I got to ask you, how
does it feel in general having to go
against another deck that's very similar
to that kind of play style that Victor
brings, but you know, your tokens are a
little smaller, but the you're still
both playing like quite a bit of
removal.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Uh, I think it in this
matchup it's whoever gets six points
first is usually the person that's way
ahead. Um, they have a rise to finish
the game. I have either removals,
Imperial decree to finish the game. Um,
so it's just can who can push tempo
faster throughout the game. And I was
able to find some Z sha and some
removals to uh get point pace. And it's
good to see cards like Zenzho because
like I think a lot of people were
interested in that card as soon as it
got revealed and people were trying it
out in a couple of decks. I think we've
even seen it in one other deck across
the weekend. But in general, you know,
the fact that you get to play such this
heavy removal and funny enough, we just
had another mind order domain deck in
Lux and last round. So I and I heard you
actually went against that specific deck
earlier.
>> And that's got to be really interesting
because I want you to kind of tell me
like why did you end up bringing Victor
this weekend? Because I think it's
always been a deck that people are
talking about, but it never actually is
getting the results we need ever since
Bolognia where it got a top finish.
Yeah, I think Victor is one of the most
aggro decks uh in this meta. So, in one
a room full of Auroras and like maybe
even Diana, it's okay against um just go
fast and uh push temp point tempo. Uh
get remove dudes and never miss a two
drop is very helpful.
>> Oh, absolutely. And and the fact you
know that your your legend helps you
even generate even more units to get
that aggro tempo. I'm actually glad you
said that because the last time I talked
to an Azir player and what their game
plan to go against these Aurora decks is
just be the faster deck. And you
literally just said
>> against that other Azir deck, the way
that you win is by being a little faster
than them. So all of that makes sense.
It's unlocking a lot of the information
on why a deck like Victor can be
successful. And Wesley, you're currently
X and one with only two more rounds to
go.
>> Very close. I'm not going to say you've
locked in a best of cuz I don't know
that information right now. But I've got
to say you've got to be pretty close
because I don't know any other Victor
decks right now. But I've also got to
say if you keep winning, you could
potentially also represent Victor in top
eight as well. How does that feel?
>> Amazing. Um this has been my one trick
deck since day one. So it to see it be
able to go to this heights would be and
me piloting up it to there would be
amazing. Yeah.
>> And I also just wanted to shout out
Wesley. I hear you're also from
Vancouver, so the hometown, you know,
buff is really coming into full fruition
here. And you've also been playing
Victor since the beginning in Origins,
correct?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Well, it's really working out for you.
It's really proving that if you put in a
lot of extra work, anyone can win and do
well in Riftbound. Even if you're the
only victor deck amongst a field of
other legends. Wesley, congratulations
on your win. I wish you luck in the rest
of the tournament, but we're going to
send it back.
>> All right. Thank you for that interview,
Barrett, and congratulations to Wesley
once again. Good luck on their next two
rounds. And yeah, we're really just
getting down to it.
>> Yeah, it is so cool to see someone who
has been playing a deck since day one
succeeding here in Vancouver, especially
as a Vancouver local as well. So cool.
>> Definitely. So, we are going to take a
quick break, but we're going to be back
with round 12 of 13 of Swiss here in
Vancouver. We'll see you guys then.
Welcome and let's take a look at Yi from
houses are big on the secret sauce
against challenger TCG's player
Alexander the greatest on Azir. So,
we're going to take a look at our first
scenario here where we have two Oxrons
who were actually found into the main
board here of the Master Yi, which we
don't see very often, but because of all
the gear we see in the meta, it's been a
key card. And poor Azir is getting hit
in the crossfire here as we see
Alexander the Greatest not so happy
about this board state. And there's a
big question we must ask. The big
question is if we kill one of these
auctionons and the gear does move over
to the Azir once again, can we use our
legend ability, Emperor of the Sands?
And the answer is no, we cannot. So,
even if we kill this Auction, we are not
able to make a sand soldier. Let's go
ahead and take a look into our next
scenario where we have the hidden cards
question. And with that question is, do
we have to reveal these hidden cards
right here at the end of the game? And
because of the rules, you must reveal
the hidden cards if your opponent
concedes or if the game is at the end to
confirm that these are indeed legitimate
hidden cards that you can play. And
after that, we will see those hidden
guards revealed into our next video. I
want to highlight an amazing play that
we had by our houses are big. And what
we have here is the Yi is being play is
at the battlefield ready to go. And we
are playing a first mate which doesn't
actually have to ready this Yi. And what
will happen is we'll have a star spring
bounce from this Yi which is a fantastic
play. He is still at four might but at
Trifiran War camp he goes up to five
might instead. And what will happen next
is we really want to kill this Azir. And
one of our few ways of backline access
in this deck is using challenge. So Yei
is now at five might versus this Azir is
only at four might and we get to save
our one rune with our two recycle runes
from punch first. A lot of players might
have just played punch first onto Yei
and then gone for the Azir, but instead
we get to save it by this great play
from houses are big. That's all I have
for you today and I hope to see you for
the next one.
I'm here with two members of Challenger
TCG, uh, Rossam and Coco Lopez. Would
you guys like to tell me what deck are
playing and how y'all's rounds are
going?
>> Uh, yeah. I'm on a rail today. It's, uh,
it's been going pretty good. I just
picked up my first loss in round five
uh, to Aurora. Feel like I played well,
but, you know, high roll deck, sometimes
you see it and and you can't really do
nothing about it, but it it was still
good match. And overall, I'm happy we've
been playing today.
I'm playing Pike, the Blood Harbor
Butcher, the mid-range deck that I wrote
about. Um, I'm very excited. Um, the
deck's great. I'm 4 in one right now, so
I can't really complain. I beat Match
Eye once today. I lost Matchy once
today. The match was a little bit
difficult, but it's, you know, not the
end of the world, so I'm, you know, I'm
just glad to be here. It's fun. I love
tournaments, so doing it for so long.
>> How did you guys join Challenger TCG?
>> Uh, I joined Challenger TCG after the
win in Houston at the CCS 25K. uh they
reached out to me and Min and picked us
both up and like uh basically we got
some insight to like how they do things
and it's like to me personally it's like
a big family so I was like super down to
get into it and and I loved it ever
since. So
>> yeah, so one of my friends um Alex
Blandon was on the team kind of knew me
from Magic. I come from Magic. Uh I'm 27
now but I've been playing CCG since I
was like 12 and I was competing like
when I was 18 or whatever knew me as a
young guy but uh I kind of swapped over
the riffbound. I met with Blandon and
talked to all the boys and it's just
yeah, it's it's just been good. Uh, you
know, it's great team dynamic. We're
always hanging. We're always having a
good time. Team dinners are great.
>> That sounds like a lot of fun.
Obviously, it sucks that you guys did
lose this round. Uh, but does it how
does it feel like in a team in
situations like that?
>> Uh, usually if you take a loss and your
team, you know, your teammates going to
be supportive. So, you always have the
system that's like supportive and if
honestly it's like if they see some
mistakes, they'll let you know so to
also help you. You know what I'm saying?
So, it's pretty it's pretty good.
Everybody usually supports each other.
>> Yeah, I would I would say that uh post
round just like trying to talk about
things, especially things where like if
you messed up or like you something
could have gone a little bit
differently, just asking for advice. It
really helps especially in situations
like that when you start like really
reflecting that's just you get better as
a player. So, it's it's just a great
dynamic.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I think dynamic is good that
way that you sometime stuff they you
know they're watching your games.
They're going to give you insight what
they think you maybe should have done
that you could have done differently to
give you a different perspective. So,
it's pretty it's pretty good.
>> That's awesome. And we love to hear it
and hopefully you guys will have a good
team dinner no matter what.
>> 71. Let's go. 71.
>> 71. 71. I believe it.
>> I'm joined here with TSS Houses are big
after an incredible match that you got
to perform here. And not only an
incredible match, but an incredible
rivalry that I'm starting to see get
built here. The secret sauce versus
challenger TCG. And a very tough best of
three. Obviously, game three, I think,
was pretty handily your way. Obviously,
hands not really going the best way, but
I want to I want to specifically talk
about game two. Game two, when you
remove the Azir Sovereign off the board,
I genuinely thought the game was over at
that moment because once you get that
sort of tempo advantage against the Azir
deck, it feels like the deck slows down
significantly and you were already in
game two when you had things like
disarming rake to help you get rid of
the gear removal. I think it was perfect
play. So, can you kind of speak to your
approach to that match in general?
Because game one,
>> you ended up not losing, right? And then
you had to come back and get that kind
of reverse sweep. So, how did you how'd
your mind go when you had to do that?
>> Yeah. So, first of all, like I I feel
like when you lose like game one, like
you lose a year off your life like
easily. Um I I'm probably getting a gray
hair just from losing that game. But, um
I had to really lock in and figure it
out. Uh, I was happy to have disarming
rake pretty early in um, you know, in
both of those games. Azir's a very tough
matchup. You know, like the statistics
say, you know, it's supposed to be good
for E, but there's a lot of weird things
that happen. Sometimes they just have
brutalizer at the right time or Vi is a
really nasty card. Uh, there's a they
have a lot of really nasty things that
you need to play around. But um yeah,
after the I was trying to figure out
like how I could get my Yi over there to
get him to five so I could challenge and
keep him. So I in a weird way I was kind
of like lucky that they use war camp.
Yeah.
>> Um I know some of his ears don't and
that was that was like that's that's the
crazy thing about this game. the
battlefield selection makes such a big
difference and it made a difference uh
for for me as the opponent where I was
able to use his camp to get the plus one
so my E lives which was insane insane in
that spot and I'm glad you brought that
up because you're right because they
that Trifarian War camp was their choice
for for Alex to pick as they're going
second. you know, they won game one
already and that gave you an even extra
big advantage for you to basically lock
in that game two like you said and then
game three you know it kind of goes to
whoever. So I also want to shout out of
course you already have a best of win
right now under your belt from Atlanta
but so congrats of course on that but
you are now X and one with two rounds
left to go for today on Master Y pretty
decidedly near the top so you might be
going home with another one but I know
you and your team I won't jinx it. I
won't. I'm sorry. But I got to say, you
and your team are doing fantastic on
stream. Currently 3 and 0 every uh for
the three times that we've had the
secret sauce on. So your team has done a
very good job at doing practice and
prepping for this event and you guys
have all been playing even before the
game came out. So
>> that's right. So
>> a very long time.
>> I think you guys are on your way to
really making a name for yourself and
you guys are really putting a showing
this weekend. But thank you so much.
Congratulations. Good luck on your next
two rounds, but we're going to send it
back.
>> Thank you. Round 12 is just getting
started here in Vancouver. It has been a
tremendous ride thus far and it is going
to continue. We have two feature matches
getting ready to get set up here and I
am beyond excited to see what is being
made available to us cuz uh Silverfuse,
as always, the people are going to get a
chance to vote.
>> Of course, where would we be if we
didn't have everyone here watching us
helping us out and seeing all these
interesting decks that we have, we have
some good stuff in store for you all.
Now, before we get into the vote though,
let's take a look at the standings and
see how everything is shaping up. We do
have Dewali and Allen both on Diana,
both undefeated currently.
>> And yeah, last uh last match they
actually decided to ID with each other
instead of saying like, hey, this might
be a win and they both respect each
other so much as players and they want
to keep each other both in the running.
So, they have a big next round.
>> Now, you do have two Diana at the top,
then you have two civers and swag yolo
420. A is once again still near the
absolute top. Really looking forward to
seeing them on the main stage eventually
there. I have to talk about Azir here
making its presence known of course. And
then we have TSS Houses are big taking
that win on Ye earlier. And of course we
have to point out Sam Sherban here on
Rengar, our champion earlier in Vegas on
Draven. So seeing him do really well in
this uh event once again. A lot of deck
variety and legend variety here. As we
move on to the second page, we'll take a
look as to who is still in this top 20.
We do have Leblanc the deceiver here at
10 and one. Does anything stand out to
you here? Cuz for me, I'm looking at
that Pike.
>> Of course, Pike was one that we were
hoping to see like make a splash here
overall. And we're really happy to see
him in the running for going into the
top eight still. We do have to see
Prismaticism there on Annie at 9 and
two. going to be tough to get there as
well as TSS. No veggies on that Poppy
Aurora still making a splash there and
likely locking in for that best of.
>> All the Fury haters are in shambles as
you see a wide variety of Fury legends
here in the top 20. Let's go to the
vote.
All right, on your screen you have your
options. Spam A if you'd like to see.
It's Pike versus Annie, Battle of the
Furies. And then we have match B, which
is going to be Fiora versus Diana. Spam
that chat, set your vote. I'm excited
for both of these games.
>> Exactly. And it's fun to see the same
color combinations, but two completely
different decks. On top of that, we do
have Fiora Aurora as our Fiora matchup
as well. So, two really great games
going on of players who are really
looking to cement their spot.
>> Now, for me, I was actually asked
earlier, okay, who do you think in Fury
is going to make a splash? And I was all
in on Pike. I think that Pike has had
decent results, but I feel like it's an
opportunity for it to really cement
itself in the Fury archetype. Pike is
one of those legends I think has
multiple variations of its play style.
And with Roy, I think we might be
looking at more of a disruption style
build.
>> Oh, the disruption is a lot of fun with
Bewitching Spirit, being able to bounce
that back and make your opponent discard
their cards. It's one of my favorite
things that we've had in this new set.
>> Silverfuse, I got great news.
>> Are we seeing it?
>> We are going to be seeing match A. It is
Pike versus Annie as we get prepared to
go to the main tables here. Let's get
ready for our next round.
I have to tell you, Pike is one of the
most anticipated game uh legends that I
am looking forward to seeing here on the
main stage. And here is Royy's deck. Roy
has come to this year with a
particularly unique list. There is a lot
that stands out to me as particularly
interesting. Silver, what do you see?
Well, a big thing is the number of
one-offs in this list. We have a lot of
one-offs. We haven't seen players really
cut down on Kai'Sa, for instance. Most
players have said, "This is one of the
best cards in Fury. I need to run three
of these." But that's not what we're
seeing here. Instead, we have things
such as the Ezreal just allowing us to
filter through our deck a little bit
extra. Seeing him outside of Ezreal
himself is really cool.
>> We are seeing seeing three stacked decks
there. They are particularly valuable.
And in this current meta, we're also
seeing a three of falling star. There
are a ton of one-offs in this deck, but
Falling Star is being played as a three
of likely because you have so many high
impact three might legends that are
making their way into the field of play.
>> And I also want to highlight the
treasure treasure trove and the pack of
wonders. Overall, this combination just
allows Pike to draw so much more. Really
smart choice by Roy here. Roy is also
main decking to Vex Apathetic, which
could potentially be problematic for our
Annie player, who we'll see on our next
deck here. Annie wants to be as
aggressive as possible. And what we see
here is a deck that is designed to do
exactly that while also utilizing that
those extra runes that are uh readied at
the end of each turn alongside things
like flash. Flash is incredibly
defensive. It's going to help Annie to
protect its units and ensure that
nothing gets picked off so they can
continue poking away at the score.
>> Yep. And both players have a lot of reps
on these as they have been playing them
in our pre-regional qualifier as well.
So, the pre-regional challenge.
>> We are ready for the match. Let's dive
in here. I'm actually super excited. We
have a Fury versus Fury showdown. It is
sure to be one for the books here in
Vancouver. a lot at stake as both
players get ready to stake their claim.
We have Rippers Bay and the Seed of
Power,
>> right?
>> Of course, seeing that Seed of Power has
been such a great choice for Annie. It's
really become the go-to for a lot of
players because the way that you're able
to be so aggressive and draw additional
cards along with, you know, Son Warren
is also very commonly played. But I love
this choice from Annie from Ko.
>> We're getting started here.
We're in the mulligan stage. We'll have
to see what their selections are.
>> One mulligan from Roy
Mulligan, too.
>> Two being mulligan from KGO.
>> A mull one. Okay.
>> All right. Are we good to go?
>> And also
too, we do have the reverse bay. If when
a unit is returned to a player's hand,
that player may pay one energy and
channel one rune exhausted. It works
really well with Pike's legend power of
being able to use Pike to bounce units
back into hand for very cheap amount.
>> KGO getting started with the Inferno uh
Inferna being played
card
>> and we're getting the immediate discard
here.
>> Bewishing Spirit is one of my favorite
cards of the new set. It allows it
doesn't show hands, so it doesn't get
all that much value from the knowledge
it gains. However, it does force your
opponent to discard a card of which we
just saw that switcheroo go to the
trash. And because of Pike's legend
ability, we are able to play the
Bewitching Spirit, attack in, and then
get a conquer. And then we can even use
Pike to put it back into our hand and
continue forcing our opponent to discard
their cards. And why that's so good in
this matchup is because Annie doesn't
usually run very high on cards overall.
The seed of power may negate this
Bewitching Spirit a little bit, but
we'll have to see what happens here.
>> What I expect here is I wonder if
they're going to bring in that
Bewitching Spirit. There it is. There's
the Conquer going to get the point. I
would expect them to bring it perhaps
back to him. But it looks like we're
going to get uh that trigger there to do
a stacked deck.
>> Yep, a showdown has begun. Um not
expecting too many answers here on one
rune. However, we do just get to be very
efficient with our runes here because we
can use that energy power very well.
>> Roy establishing what their next play is
going to be here.
>> Got it last time, too.
>> Let's take a look. A lot of options. I
did see a falling star there. We got
Mindsplitter as well. It looks like a
Tai Turner.
>> Lots of options here for this turn.
>> Yep, Ezreal's there as well. One big
thing is this bewitching spirit is a
pretty low tempmpo play. Overall, it is
a three energy for two might and as much
as we want to bounce it back over and
over again, it is quite expensive. We
will go ahead and do that. We'll see if
we get another one played. This Kai'Sa
will be looking to potentially draw a
card off the conquer. So, we'll have to
see from there.
>> There's one for this and then you pay
one for
>> Yeah, I'm thinking I haven't done
>> Oh, you're thinking. Okay, gotcha. Okay.
Yeah, they're sorry. My bad.
>> Clarifications between the two players
there.
Yep.
>> The stakes are so high they have to take
their opportunities to think out their
plays here.
>> It looks like we might see the
bewitching spirit come back down.
>> Wouldn't be surprised.
>> And it is coming right back down.
Starcross being discarded there. And uh
Ko was ready for that. Ko's like, "You
know what? Yeah, I don't have to think
about this. It's Starcross is going down
because uh realistically, what you want
to bounce the uh the spirit back the
hand so it can be played again?" I don't
think so. So a big thing here is we do
have a double conquer opportunity where
we can draw an additional two cards with
Kai'Sa as well as the seed of power. So
we're likely going to see that the
Bewitching Spirit getting a lot less B
value here because Seed of Power is
going to be giving us a lot of cards
along with Kai'Sa because Pike has to
play this pretty low tempo game overall.
The Annie might be able to take
advantage of this.
>> Seed of Power has been consistently one
of the best battlefields that we've seen
this weekend. and it's been used to
excellent effectiveness and a great
example is what you just saw there as
you mentioned with the Kai'Sa getting
the double draw.
>> I wouldn't be surprised if we were to
see the Pike be played this next turn
because we can make it ready and
potentially contest this Kai'Sa and also
the Inferna as well can be contested. So
the next turn for Pike isn't that bad.
This development from KGO is really
going to matter. Oh no, we won't be able
to see that Pike. Apathetic coming on
down and Pike is not going to be
particularly useful in this case. It
looks like Ko was thinking exactly what
you were thinking.
>> Really strong play from Ko here.
>> Oh, and the Noxis hopeful. This is a
card that's come up all weekend long
when you get to play with that Legion
effect. That two for four might is
absolutely insane. You get that
incredible value there. You have a
strong board presence here. That
bewitching spirit is not going to be
able to effectively contest either of
these locations. And when you can't
contest the the battlefields there,
you're not going to be able to get
bounced back either. So, we'll have to
see what Roy does.
>> And also, this board from KGO is very
falling star resistant. A big tool for
Pike overall. We have four might units.
We have deflect. These four might units
are causing so much trouble for Roy
right now.
>> He's planning his next turn here. He's
going to go with a big play here. Let's
see what it is.
Thinking it through. Oh, changes his
mind.
No information was gained here, so we'll
be able to see what he decides to do and
is going back to that once again.
>> A gold token being and it's going to be
a mine spplitter. Let's take a look at
the hand here. Another card being
discarded here. We have starcross and it
looks like two Rengars. Mind spplitter
has been a key card that we've seen
throughout the weekend and it looks like
the starcross will be removed. Both
Rengars remaining in hand.
>> Yes. Big thing here is the star cross
pretty much has to be the removed one
because mines spplitter was just played.
Getting that bounce back isn't the best
thing that you want to see. It is just a
little bit too low tempo to play it
twice. However, though the surprise
factor of the Rengars, you know, since
we've been into the set a bit now,
everyone kind of knows about them.
However, knowing that there's two in
hand, a lot of players will play around
one Rengar, but now seeing that we know
there are two in hand, a big difference.
And I want to note too, we do see that
void seeker from the from Roy. It is in
hand. It is very costly if we were to
hit that Vex, but it might give us a
window of opportunity if we are able to
use it on Vex and then acceler
accelerate this Pike.
>> We did see a tie turner in that hand as
well. Um, very interesting board state
that we have here. And what's been
happening is you see this constant
little just chipping away at the hand of
Ko, but this board presence is
incredibly strong. And you're right,
that earlier turn when Kai'Sa was able
to secure two additional draws was
absolutely massive to mitigate the
impact of the discards happening prior.
>> Absolutely. And still having to make
tough choices here.
>> Both players carefully considering each
turn.
>> Looking at perhaps the Annie here. Can't
get back a star crossed.
And
>> I believe in Royy's hand, we did see a
Fizz as well.
>> Annie.
>> So Annie's going to come in from the
champion zone.
>> Star cross.
>> Starrass. Star cross. Sorry. He's going
to return from the trash.
>> Star cross targeting inferna and mind
spplitter.
>> Inferna. Mind spplitter.
>> Return inferna. Use this. Pay one. Get
>> it is very cheap.
>> They're going to use the rippers bay to
channel an exhausted rune. Um,
>> and then we're going to return Kai'Sa to
base
>> and passing that down.
>> And we have so many ambush cards in hand
now. We have Inferna and we have the
Rengars there as well. So, lots of
ability to put Mop on the board very
quickly.
I love this pullback from Kai'Sa as well
because then we're able to potentially
conquer with Kais again. Draw another
card. Seed of Power also ready to be
there as well. And because that fax is
still on board, uh it is the only valid
void seeker target as well and it does
have to flect. So a lot of tough choices
here for Roy.
>> Yeah, void seeker would do the job to
take out the Vex apathetic, but
unfortunately you will be paying two
power cost which will uh dramp you quite
a bit. Going through the rest of the
hand there.
>> Yeah, do see that Fizz there
potentially.
>> Looks like they're thinking about this
Void Seeker. That's two paid. It's going
to be the void seeker onto the Vex
apathetic
>> and no longer the target for Pike on the
battlefield either.
>> Yeah, do them two. Yeah, for
>> see if there's a response here.
>> Remember, Void Seeker is at a
battlefield. So, a flash would be pretty
devastating here. Lucky for Roy, there
was no flash or if there were to be one,
KO decided it was worth letting go of
the VEX.
giving us a nice peek at the hand there.
Just the options are tough because
there's so much might on the board for
Ko here. Anything that's played isn't
going to be accelerated. It's not going
to be readied. So, it's really tough
here. Of course, we could try to do
something with a double conquer with the
pike. However, that's just kind of
delaying the inevitable at this point
because the might that we have from Ko
is just too much.
>> Azreal does take the board here.
>> We still have the Bewitching Spirit
available. Bewitching Spirit can also
come into the field to play, but you're
first going to do the discard and draw
two.
>> Let's see if we got any options here to
help us out. Once again, to highlight,
there are four might. So, Falling Star
really doesn't do all that much. Needs
to have something here. Has the Tide
Turner. Just has to establish a board.
Hoping to retake after KO goes into
these battlefields.
>> It becomes a question if you want to put
the uh the Being Spirit into the
battlefield. They choose not to. They
pass the turn over to KO.
>> Now, Ko does have a really strong board
state here. You'd expect perhaps the
double draw on Kaiso once again. Take
the Reppers Bay perhap
uh the channel one run exhausted. be
very interesting to see whether or not
they choose to take that line. But
you're definitely going to see the
double draw on Kai'Sa, especially when
you're working against someone who is
consistently discarding cards in your
hand. You know that they have the mind
splitter as well. You're going to want
to keep a pretty solid hand.
>> Yeah. And as we know, we have all access
to all those ambush as well. Isn't the
best thing always for protecting, but
for attacking, it's very well. And if we
go up to six points here, as well as
drawing two cards, being able to
potentially retake here will be really I
mean should be quite easy in some ways.
We'll have to see what happens if Pike
does have the resources.
>> We have here a situation where Ko has
gone to that vital six points. While Roy
does still sit at one, they'll have to
start staging their comeback now if they
wish to get back in the game because KGO
will be able to threaten victory on
every given turn going forward.
Yeah, has to really figure this out
exactly what they want to do because you
really don't want to give Pike an
opportunity to come back to this game.
Roy has had a very calculated game
overall and of course it's been lower
tempo, but if they're able to find some
of these higher tempo options, then it
could be a tough game for KO if we don't
finish it out because Annie is running
out of cards here.
>> Ultimately, we do have two holding
threatening to be able to win the game
here. You have the Noxis Hopeful, Kaisa,
Inferna, and of course the Traveling
Merchant in base.
>> That's what happens.
>> Three runes up for KGO.
>> Lots of options for Annie as Roy takes
over here and tries to make some magic
happen.
>> Yeah, we did see a couple options there
for KO. Did have the 4Runner in hand,
has the Rengars, and then we already
played the Inferno. So, just one
question mark there. Roy has a lot of
information to operate off of here.
>> He's got a lot of information. lot of
runes as well to show it to me. I saw it
before, but I don't anymore.
>> Oh, yeah. Cuz you just know it in my
hand. Yeah, that's fine.
>> So, we are reading the Rengar which was
shown earlier. So, that's why we were
able to read it there because we knew it
was already in the hand. It was open
information.
>> Yeah. Yeah, it was like Yeah, it was set
two and ambush set three.
>> Okay, we do see that mind spitter those
bounce back as well. Fizz not the best
option. Um,
yeah, this is going to be tough overall.
Pack of wonders is there and it won't do
anything. It's just one of those things
where Pike really Annie is the aggressor
here and uh Roy has to play very
reactively and Pike can kind of do
either one. It can be aggressive or it
can be reactive. And we had the more
reactive game plan with this bewitching
spirit and this well of course drawing
Kai'Sa and then the seed of power has
just given so much value through the
draws. So the bewitching spirit plan
didn't really go to
>> didn't really happen because we just had
ways to draw more cards. However, in
this typical matchup, the Bewitching
Spirit can be absolutely lethal. I've
actually played this match up myself
several times where if the bewitching
spirit gets online and does discard your
hand, you just have no resources. But
because of the way this deck was built
and starting with the seed of power, we
we were able to get around that.
>> Yeah, once you start discarding your
hand, if uh unfortunately you get lower
and lower, each additional discard just
does that much more additional damage.
Fizz is being used to bring back the
void seeker, which will target the
Kai'Sa. Is there a flash available here
to perhaps save the Kai'Sa? We do have
like a ton of power in base here. Still
capable of certainly securing the win on
the next turn, but it looks like it's
going to go through.
>> On top of that, no hesitation there to
play that Fizz at the Ripper Bay
battlefield. And the reason being is
that we cannot allow a double conquer to
happen. So, that was the best choice
that we had. It'll be interesting to see
if we see the Spirit be there as well.
The issue is that we can't let Annie
hold either, which is also really tough.
And we're going to be adding Vex
ourselves
over to the Ripper's Bay trying to
definitely secure that battlefield and
hopefully hold on for another turn. And
as you suggested, it is going to be the
uh the Spirit going into the uh going
into that battlefield. So a full hold
position here on Rippers Bay from Roy.
>> Be interesting if KO can do anything to
take the game here or if we look to win
through that seat of power as well. If I
saw my opponent start stacking, I would
assume that they have something going on
there. And I'm going to have to go for
the hold or the hold game plan myself
instead. And I would be very suspicious
of seeing uh the hidden card as well. So
there are a couple options there such as
uh Pike himself and the Yep. A tie
turner as well would be an option. Yeah,
tide turner is a big one, but there's no
it would be a bluff at that point
because there's nothing to actually
switch locations with. So, I think that
bluff if it is the case is really good.
>> Could also be the windser actually now
that I think about it. I believe the
Windser was in the main deck. Now, that
would be an excellent choice because
what would happen? would reveal and it
would return one of the units with three
or more three or less might to the
owner's hand and that could perhaps
>> put them in a situation where they're
able to aggressively hold. We have the
traveling merchant coming in here and do
the discard draw one. See if they can
get an answer for this position.
Potentially a gamewinning play upcoming
from KGO.
>> And because Roy knew about all these
Rengars in hand, that's why we stacked
this so much is because Rengar when it
does attack, it does get two assault.
So, it's actually deceptively strong.
Uh, just having Tinmite that can come
from your hand out of nowhere and then
on top of that still have runes
available. It's a very efficient card
and has really pushed Annie to the next
level as a champion.
>> The question now does become, do you try
to pile into this or as you suggested,
do you just try to hold seat of power?
Because I mean, we do have like we don't
have that many options here. So, I'm
just curious like there's
it's KGO's game to win here and it's all
about perhaps the strategy as to how
they achieve that. There's nothing crazy
about holding seat of power as all these
units are at the battlefield. They are
going to send inferno and the Nox is
hopeful.
>> This is a uh a decent amount of power
here. Going up to seven
>> damage.
>> Just looking for some trades here. Uh
Rengar is a reaction so could be played
before these trades. However, we are
going to keep that hidden card a secret
for now on. and Kaiso looking to
potentially make the trades here. I
>> was going to say Vex being taken out
allows for the Rengar to be pounced in
with the uh the opportunity to perhaps
take this battlefield. Here we do have
the hidden card. It is going to be as I
suggested the Windser. So the wind
singer is going to bounce.
>> Nothing cuz nothing is under the three
might threshold because they were having
the assault. So KO does take game number
one in 8 to2 fashion. Uh Royy's probably
going to want to look at perhaps how
they could uh kind of gain the tempo
back there because they were kind of on
the back foot the entire game which I
think was potentially problematic for
them.
>> Yes, when Andy gets established and
especially drawing all those cards. Like
I said, the tempo wasn't there for Roy.
This deck can play either way. It can
play tempo or it can play a little bit
more on the control side, but because
Annie is so quick overall, Roy didn't
really have the options they were
looking for. A different start without
the bewitching spirit. Maybe we see it
sideboarded out, maybe we don't. It's
hard to say because there's no access to
seed of power. I'm expecting it to stay
and potentially be a bigger player in
future games.
>> That's a great call there. Because of
the seat of power, um KGO was able to
mitigate the effect of all the discards,
whether it was the Mindsplitter or the
Bewitching Spirit, it did not have as
much of a factor. Now naturally with
Kaiser Survivor that acts as a bit of a
mitigation against the discard as a
whole but seed of power definitely
helped shore out that mid game so that
Ko was not too far behind. In this case
here we do have Voidgate and Z Warren.
Um really do like the Z warren here.
It's going to allow KO to find the
answers that they need, cycle through
their deck and hopefully be able to
respond effectively to whatever um Roy
throws their way.
>> And personally I really like the void
gate here. and he plays so many formite
units and we saw what a struggle that
was before. So now void gate whenever
the unit is on the battlefield we can
now use falling star for four instead of
only three specifically when it's on the
battlefield but that's so crucial here
>> you do get some additional opport
optionality of course you have falling
star and void seeker which you'll be
able to kind of reach a little further
hit those Noxis hopefuls hit those
Kai'Sa survivors which were clearly a
factor in this prior game it looks like
we're in the sideboarding phase here um
>> yes and ideally here Roy would love to
have a little bit more of a reactive
game if they're able to just deal with
the onslaught of Annie. There's no
longer the seed of power card draws. I
feel like Roy is going to have a much
better matchup now.
>> I would expect the same. And if I
remember correctly, I think it was uh Ko
that went first. Now we're going to have
the uh Roy start us off here.
>> That's the treasure hunter coming on in.
>> The treasure hunter start is so good,
too, because we do have a lot of power
hungry cards in this deck. So, because
the treasure hunter will make a gold
when it moves, we'll be able to
uh mitigate that a little bit further.
>> Roy with three uh four runes, sorry.
Thinking through their play.
>> Is that a double Rengar we see in hand
for Roy or for KGO again?
>> We have Starcross and Noxus Hopeful in
hand. It looks like a potentially void
seeker as well for Roy. That's good. Go
to one. One.
>> First point is scored on Zan Warren.
>> Yep.
>> We're going to get the trigger here.
>> This is interesting because uh Roy, I
actually like this quite a bit because
the Inferno is going to be coming in to
conquer this. And what happens is Ko's
fine with the Zon Warren overall.
However, because Roy forces the inferna
over to the zon, a bigger creature will
likely have to come in to conquer the
void gate instead. So, he'll be able to
generate more value from his cards, such
as this void seeker.
>> It is notable as well that that switch
was discarded on the Zongworn's conquer.
It's notable because that was not in the
main deck. So, that would be a
sideboarded card of the switcheroo. is
going to go ahead and essentially save
that treasure seeker since inferno would
always get the proper trade with it. Uh
Ko now has the option to take these Zon
Warren if they do want to filter through
their deck a little bit more. Uh void
gate would also make a lot of sense for
the reason that I stated earlier is that
you have a one might unit. The voidgate
isn't getting the value that it wants to
get.
>> Yeah, he's taking the uh the cycle here
going into the zonal wars. Discard one,
draw one. It's going to be a cleave.
And that makes a lot of sense as a
discard because we aren't really playing
the might game as much with the pike
deck overall. Overall, we are looking to
remove things as pike. So, playing the
cleave and saying I don't need to get
over a giant hold like we do against
things such as Vex makes a lot of sense.
>> There's a chance that this is a stacked
deck into a stacked deck. We'll have to
see here. I'm not precisely sure what
was drawn. I think I saw a a stack deck
in there and a void seeker. We'll have
to see what KGO decides to hold on to.
>> Stack deck being a key card, especially
in Annie where you don't usually have
that same amount of card draw some of
the other chaos domain decks.
>> One of the things that Annie is so good
at is getting that very early board
presence there. Going to already an
additional rune at the end there, but
ultimately decides to not play any
additional cards.
>> And depending on how this next turn goes
for Roy, this might just be the dream
that they are looking for. for the
reason that Andy has five runes up. Does
have access to multiple ambush
creatures. And I think one of those
units though looks like I still think
that is two Rengars there. And it looks
like we do have a 4Runner in hand as
well. Getting a little peek into that
hand. The treasure is going to be making
so much gold here.
>> A lot of treasure there. That hunter is
hunting. There's no doubt about that. Um
so priority does does still stay on Roy.
Are they looking for the trade or they
going to make a move here?
Do you see that falling star and void
secret hand star cross as well?
>> Long sword.
>> Okay, long sword being played.
>> Inferna getting the additional two might
>> that happens.
>> Looks like there will be a response and
it will be a void seeker onto the
inferna.
>> That is a very costly play for the
inferno or killing this inferno overall.
Ko a little bit surprised by this. Uh
but still Pike has the can play the long
game. It has access to so much draw, so
many resources. So people will say,
"Yeah, I you know what? I can void this.
If you're on void gate, my falling star
actually does more." So we do see the
Rengar come into play.
>> So it looks like that they do not want
to give up on this fight yet. Rengar
pounces as you would expect to see. It's
going to get that additional assault
too.
>> Can be a play to any battlefield that
you're attacking at reaction speed.
>> It's basically normal playing rules.
>> Yes. The important thing is that it is a
reaction. So, this is a valid play here.
>> Oh, because uh
>> because I control it.
>> Yeah. Yeah. But then that means what?
What's the point of this text?
>> Uh well, if I'm attacking, I don't
control it.
>> Oh, you don't. Ah,
>> yeah. So, that was like the ambush
before ambush thing.
>> Okay. Yeah, that happens.
>> So, yeah, that resolves. Yeah.
>> Awesome. Doing the casting for us.
>> Getting the players are sorting it out
together as a team, which is always
great to see. And we do see that resolve
with the Rengar there.
KO still has some things to think about
here.
>> It's a three, right?
>> Correct. So, right now, what you're
going to see is uh the opportunity for
the Rengar. It is overpowering this uh
this treasure hunter.
Void seeker or have been used.
Thankfully, that was mitigated the cost
slightly by a gold token,
>> but it looks like the treasure hunter is
going to die there. It did its job.
Generated three gold tokens. We do have
Fizz coming on down. Let's take a look
at the trash. Not many options there.
You're going to take the void here. It's
going to be used to hit the Rengar
>> uh gold for the purple.
>> And you can tell just how comfortable
Roy is with this deck. The way that he
just made that decision as quick as he
did, discarded everything and recycled
everything. It knew exactly what to do,
what he wanted to do. So, I love to see
the proficiency that Roy has on this
deck. It's kind of also fascinating to
see you have these two aggressive style
decks and you just saw almost like a
control style play here from Roy trying
to make sure that the additional points
not being scored by Ko trying to keep
control of the battlefield. So now we
have a situation where Ko has nothing on
the field of play. You have the Fizz.
Now Fizz is not often used as a
particular powerful body on the field of
play. But in this case here, it's going
to be enough to start scoring some
points and perhaps give Kgo uh sorry,
Roy an opportunity to get on the board
and get ahead of KGO.
>> And I have to mention Royy's hand size
here looks pretty good. We've seen a
number of players that whenever their
hand size is this big, usually there's a
lot of options and overall just strong
plays to be made.
>> Second point is going to be scored here.
We're going to go into the Zong Warren.
We're going to get the discard draw
trigger.
>> Is this a plus trigger?
>> Yes. And I I'm almost positive we saw
the Noxis hopefully in Roy's hand. So I
think that he might be able to really
build a pretty decent board here. We
also see Ezreal Starcross. Couple couple
options here.
>> Well, I mean Starcross is not going to
be an option in this case, but it is in
hand. It is Ezreal that gets discarded.
>> The Ezreal is really more for draw. And
because we have access to so many cards
already, discarding the Ezreal makes
sense. We don't need to play a power and
then discard and draw two more cards.
Instead, we can just do it with the Zon
Warren. So, this actually being very
useful for Roy. And we do see Bewitching
Spirit, one of our favorite cards that
we have seen. It does not reveal the
hand, but when it is played, a player
gets to discard a card. They must do it.
And it makes a tough decision for Ko
here.
>> I like your phrasing. They get to
discard the card. It's like, yes, I'm so
excited to blow up my hand. But this is
actually huge cuz I think we only have
about three cards in Ko's hand. And uh
so this is actually pretty damaging.
This is where you start to get to the
point where especially with the uh the
lack of Kai'Sa on the field of play. It
just there's no way to really mitigate
this damage. Especially if you top deck
a Kai'Sa and then like you're unable to
play then Bing Spear comes out again.
It's like you don't get a choice. That
Kaisa is gone and you're never really
going to catch up
and it's Rengar being discarded.
>> Yeah, that is tough overall because
we're just going to bring the Bewitching
Spirit right back and we're going to
make a gold as well. and
>> falling star. Yeah, now we're down to a
single card and this is exactly what
Pike wants to do.
>> Yes, we're seeing that game plan that we
really wanted to see in game one from
Roy, but of course the seed of power as
well as the Kais mitigated that and
we'll have to see what KO can do this
time because if this bewitching spirit
is left on the board, it's just going to
come down once again and there might be
an empty hand for Ko. So, Kgo either
needs to deal with this bewitching
spirit or potentially just play all the
cards that they have already.
>> As a card game player, I can say
something. The reason why you play card
games is because you want to play cards.
And when you don't have cards in your
hand, it feels really hard to play the
game. And so, we're in a position here
where you have to try to contest. You
have to try to punish that bewitching
spirit. But what's to say that another
bewitching spirit doesn't just come down
later, right? It is a three of in the
deck. This one has done a tremendous
amount of damage. The Overzels fan does
go in to the battlefield, scores a vital
point here, but the control game from
Roy is starting to really showcase um
you know what it's capable of
>> falling start back to hand thanks to
Annie Stubborn
pass
>> and easily taking out that bewitching
spirit as well as a fizz. We'll have to
see if another bewitching spirit is
found or not because that would make
this game really tough. A really smart
play though from Kgo here being able to
recognize that you know you made me
discard the falling star. Well, I can
just get it right back. So that was a
really smart discard from KGO.
>> Falling star does come down hits both
the overzealous fan and Annie both go to
the trash.
>> Yep. Yep.
>> Gold tokens being used to mitigate the
downside.
>> Yep.
>> Noxis hopeful. And I think I might have
seen a second Nox. And it is a second
Noxis hopeful. This is eight might
represented from four runes. Absolutely
insane.
No more disruption, but uh Oh, we got
the pack of wonders.
>> Yep, we may be seeing potentially
treasure trove in the future just to
draw a little bit more. Pack of wonders
is a really great combo with that
because it does return a friendly gear
or unit into a a an owner's hand.
>> And when use that treasure trove, it's
just basically like a giant cycle of
hey,
>> I get to drop and I get to channel a
rune exhaust. That's a lot of fun there.
Love that combo. It is absolutely a
great combo overall and we do see three
cards in the hand for KGO. So at least
we'll have some options here. The
bewitching spirit not coming down. Very
grateful for that. I assume
>> it is a three of in Roy's deck and it is
going to be the ferious 4runner.
>> It's a very sticky card and hard to deal
with overall. But if Roy is able to deal
with this 4Runner cleanly, it could be
really tough for Annie here as they have
to make up so much ground with the
points overall and overall tempo of the
game. And look at the rune difference
here. Roy has all the runes in the
world. Can do whatever they want. We do
see that treasure trove there already
and has access to drawing even more
cards after this.
>> I'm expecting to see star cross come
down, get that 4Runner back in the hand.
You're going to punish a little bit of
the uh the power cost, reduce the temp.
What's going We got the combo. We did
it. There we are. Channel exhaust to
draw a card. More options for Roy. And
is Starcross going to send that 4Runner
running home? Awesome. We do see that
stack deck as well. Uh as good card
players do, drawing before making the
play. So that's always a bit of a note
there, especially when you know you have
the resources, the runes to be able to
do it. We see a downwell that is going
to be going back into the deck. So
that's an interesting choice there for
sure. Might have been the beast below
drawn into the hand there.
We'll have to see. And it is the beast
below.
>> Y going to return back to hand. Beast
below is a card that you don't see all
that often when you play me. Return
another friendly unit and an enemy unit
to their owner's hands. So so often we
talk about Riptide Rex being a uh um a
singularity with a body. We got
ourselves a beast that is also a
starcross. One time I played this card
in free-for-all in a draft and it was
the best feeling ever. However, it does
have so much might too and Annie doesn't
really do a great job of dealing with
high might units overall.
>> I also just want to recognize that I
talked about Starcross in a Ferris
4Runner. We utilize the beast below from
the stack deck and uh you were right,
the beast below does present a much more
significant threat here as it's holding
a battlefield. So, as you said, open up
your options before committing to the
play. Words of wisdom from Silver.
Got it.
>> Okay, we got Vex and we have Inferna
trying to establish a bit of a board
here. Double hold points here going to
six for Roy. Six is a magic number in
Riftbound.
>> And I really love that Roy decided to go
for a hold here. And the reason being is
you can ready these units and you can
pull them back. you force KGO to go into
the battlefields potentially unless
you're concerned about this Vex
Apathetic getting to a battlefield. So,
we might go for a hold again. I'm really
interested to see what Roy decides to do
here because I could see players going
through either option.
>> That Vex does represent some challenges
for Roy,
but what KO is experiencing right now is
a challenge from a score perspective.
Treasure Trove does come down.
Pack of wonders likely to be used here.
We're going to hide a card.
>> We're going to hide a pike.
>> That's most certainly a pike.
>> So, we will be going for that hold then.
>> Yep.
>> Royy's looking to close out this game
here.
Knox is hopeful.
We have eight represented. Might
>> to see them together.
>> And we do have the Knoxville into the
Yeah, we're going for the hold here.
Not the one
>> and another card hidden as well.
>> Turn uh changed over to Kgo.
>> This is a make it or break it moment.
>> So something important to note is Roy
has starcross in hand because we have so
many runes open. We can easily take off
one of these Noxis hopefuls and then be
able to either take away the Vex.
Really, it's going to be so hard for KO
to retake here. This is a beautiful
setup from Roy.
>> Ko's going to have to carefully consider
how they do this turn. They don't have
to clear both, but they're going to have
to clear
>> at least one. Vex apathetic in hand
here. It looks like they're going to be
making a choice as to where they want to
go. You got two hidden cards,
>> two stack battlefields,
and not all that much yourself on the
battlefield. Now, we have not seen Ko's
hand. We do know that there are a lot of
ambush opportunities in his deck. So
perhaps he's able to ramp up some of the
might. So we're going to go into the
battlefield here.
>> We're going to showcase that Pike as you
called.
>> Yes, Pike is ready to go and also can
pay that extra to gain that might if
needed.
>> Actually, uh I do have a question. I
think that might have screwed up.
>> Uh
>> it is stunn is stunned.
>> Yeah, it is stunned but it's still there
for might. So if I don't kill
everything, I bounce back.
>> Yeah. So still
>> card is revealed in the battlefield as
Vex is already present.
>> So an important information that these
players just discussed is that because
Vex is on the battlefield, the pike is
revealed, it is stunned, although it
does still represent the might on the
board. So if there is not enough might
from Ko, then it has to retreat. And
that is exactly what we're seeing there
as
>> looks like a scoop here.
>> Yes, Roy will be taking that second
match. A much better match for Roy
overall. Yeah, much stronger. And I
think what you saw there was the start
too. Ko dropped to what, two cards,
single card almost. That early pressure
that was applied was absolutely
fantastic by Roy. We saw these two
backto-back games. The first game Ko
definitely had control. Roy wasn't able
to do enough damage. Those Kaisers got
out early and actually that's the key
thing here. Like how much of an impact
do you think that not getting those
early Kaiis had on Ko? I mean the early
Kaises definitely matter, but more so is
just overall the draw matters so much
here and the Bewitching Spirit being
played on curve is also really important
here. We'll have to see if this
Bewitching Spirit game plan works again
or not.
>> Now, this is going to be a really
interesting next game cuz if my memory
serves me correctly, I believe this is
going to be an Arena's greatest game.
Um, I don't remember which deck had it,
but I'm almost 99% positive we have an
Arena's greatest game. So, it's going to
be a race to the finish here.
If I had to assume I assume on Annie as
it is going first and Arena's greatest
is so good on her because Annie wants to
go quick overall very aggressive. Pike
can play the long game as a as a whole.
Roy is very comfortable doing that as we
saw in that last game. Ko wants to get
on the board score points quickly and
then win the game quickly as well.
>> Now with Ko, he's probably concerned
with the ability for Roy to just
completely punish his hand early. Um
because if if you give Roy turn two when
he sorry the the the draw there, he's
going to have that three uh three runes,
he's going to be able to play the
bewitching spirit on turn one. Is that
something you want to avoid or if you're
Annie, you just want to go first and
make sure that you start putting points
on the board.
>> Oh, you definitely want to just go first
and put points on the board. You have so
much efficiency overall in your two
drops. They're so strong overall. So you
want to just take advantage of that as a
whole.
>> Yeah, we do have forbidding waste and
the arena's greatest. So both players if
they remember will start at one
additional point.
>> This is going to be an intense one. And
uh I mean both players have really
showcased what their decks can do early.
>> Game one dominated by KGO. Game two Roy
really showcase what it can do.
>> Attacks here does win. This is the one
that was the one that draws a card if he
has no cards.
>> Top deck Kaisa kills me.
>> Oh gross.
>> Oh my god.
>> And I love hearing this conversation
between I had um like
>> Yeah, let's listen.
>> Four or five creatures on the
battlefield. He has one card in hand.
>> Yeah.
>> But um I was playing too slowly because
I was still like learning the physical
game
>> and then
>> I don't know if I was one minute faster
I win that.
>> That's tough.
>> Yeah. A lot of matchups it's Yeah, it's
tough to get the games in. You got to
>> Yeah. All right.
>> Fair enough.
>> I love to see the uh
>> the the uh the kind of the bonding
occurring between competitors. You see
that in Riftbound.
I absolutely love it.
>> That's one of the great things we get
about being here face to face at an
actual event. Of course, you can do so
much online. So, being able to play at
your local game stores and meet people
in the community, as well as being here
in Vancouver.
>> I know. And actually, I've remember I
pulled a uh a card from one of my packs.
I thought to myself, "Oh, this is an
altar that I know a friend from an LGS
wants." And so, I packed it away,
brought it next week. It's one of those
things you build communities, you build
relationships, and that is one of the
absolute special things about these
physical TCGs. They allow you to build
communities all around the world. And
that's something that Riftbound has
done, especially showcased by the
success of their regional championships.
>> And mulligans are always tough decisions
overall because they are so crucial in
your games. It looks like we are getting
into that pretty pretty quickly here.
And we have the arena's greatest trigger
being called out by KGO. Well done.
We do have one point by KGO.
>> Roy's beginning phase. Grab the point.
>> We'll see if he does.
>> As of now, it's We have not.
>> Thank you.
>> Stack deck.
>> Still has time. So hopefully we do grab
that point.
>> I am officially terrified for Roy.
>> Come on, Roy.
>> We believe in you.
>> We do.
Do we keep that beast slayer?
>> Uh, no. Hopeful does come down. Oh no,
the turn's been passed.
>> Wait, this is like half the reason this
card sees play.
>> Yeah, exactly.
>> My heart is broken. Officially broken
here.
>> We've seen this before and it has come
back. I mean, it was it was Allen, I
think, in the first Houston event which
did something similar and it uh it had a
it had a role to play in the ultimate
results.
The good news is is that although a miss
trigger does suck, there's still ways to
get back into this game overall and
really Pike can still be just fine. I
believe that Roy, you know, of course
there's a lot going on here. It's been a
long weekend as a whole. A lot of these
players have traveled as well. We're
still going to see a great game
regardless.
>> Absolutely. There's no question about
that. Traveling merchant does go into
the arena's greatest.
>> You're going to have to discard one to
draw one. What do you want to discard?
And it looks like it's going to be the
inferna being discarded. Go
>> to two. Two.
just a lower value card overall. We do
have that Nox's hopeful ready, so I'm
assuming we are going to see a play with
that. I mean, it's the only reason to
really discard the Inferna is that you
already have another two drop here
potentially or a stack deck that can
work with the Noxus Hopeful.
>> Forbidding Waste is somewhat of a
challenge. That Noxis Hopeful is likely
going to want to contest into the
arena's greatest. dropping too might
when defending is significant especially
when like realistically Annie doesn't
have that many large units I think in
terms of overall power you're going to
see more power from Roy here but we do
see the Noxus hopeful coming alongside a
traveling merchant that's a lot of
movement you're going to be discarding
and drawing quite a bit here and you do
have a relatively solid body you
definitely do not want to put that Noxus
hopeful into the forbidden waste because
if you do it's going to get picked apart
and going into the arena's greatest is
the Noxus hopeful and I Yep and the the
uh price will be paid by the traveling
merchant.
>> I want to note that in that previous
stack deck, we decided to take the beast
below specifically from it.
>> You didn't Let's listen to players real
quick.
>> I just wrote it down. Sorry. Sorry.
Sorry.
>> I did not know that. You have to
announce something.
>> Yeah. That's why it's like at the
beginning I said it. Yeah.
>> Oh, okay.
>> It looks like that point will be
assigned.
>> No, that is the conquer point there. Uh
Roy did not realize that it had to
announce the trigger there at the start.
So unfortunately will be missing that
arena's greatest.
So I want to talk once again about this
beast below that during that stack deck
that was the choice from it and it
wasn't really with much hesitation
either and that was just how much value
that the beast below got in the last
game and it is a oneup in the list. So
the fact that there's so much value for
Roy going for that card. Yeah,
>> we do have three cards in hand for KGO.
We might be having some communication
here.
>> And I saw on the stream that he wrote
down during his turn.
>> I I didn't say say it though. I just
assume you don't have to say it. You
just write it down. That's
>> I I'm not used to this. Sorry.
>> I I I've
watched back there. I'm going to say it
was an acknowledgement of the point
being written down. you feel free to
appeal if you like to appeal.
>> Yeah, I Yeah,
>> yeah,
>> it looks like we're going to have a bit
of a judge discussion whether or not the
point from the arena's greatest will be
applied.
>> I'm more used to the
>> Now, you were discussing utilizing the
uh Actually, you know what? Let's listen
in for a second.
>> I don't know which one's which.
>> No, fair enough. There's a lot of
>> mixed signals on like what you do when
in this game.
>> Yeah,
>> like this one like as long as you catch
it anytime during your turn, like you
get it. Um
So, what we heard from there earlier is
that Roy did mark it on the notepad but
did not announce it verbally.
>> Did not declare the point. I'm sorry.
>> I'm I'm the control deck.
>> Yeah, exactly. That's why I figure
>> I'm the control deck.
>> So, we'll have to see what the judge
call is on that.
Both players being good uh just good at
communicating with each other, being
patient. So really nice to see that as
well, especially in a crucial third
match here.
>> And this is one of those situations as
well. If you're KGO, I know you want to
be kind. You want to be supportive, but
the rules exist for a reason. You want
to allow the judges to make the correct
choice based on what the states uh the
rules state you want to be fair. We're
at the highest levels of competition
here. Allow the judges to so hard to
find cards.
>> Oh, I didn't play. I played at the very
end of set two. Yeah.
>> And then um this is Felix on our field
search.
We'll listen in.
>> Hello. I understand that there was an
issue with uh Arena's greatest and just
a question on when that was declared and
if if that it's appropriate to give it.
>> Um so we reviewed the the footage and
hacks from the judges that took um the
rule and we will be granting it.
>> We'll be what?
>> Well, we we will be giving the point.
>> Oh, okay.
>> Yes.
>> So that's just based like if if he marks
it down, doesn't say anything, it's
still good is the understanding.
acknowledging the trigger um in a very
tangible way.
>> I see. So like if this was not a stream
game uh and someone said I marked it
down that like you would have granted
the same way.
>> Um so without being able to speculate
because every single situation is a
little bit different. We just want to
see people acknowledging the you know
the trigger which it appears like
>> that's done. Okay.
>> Yeah. I Yeah. Okay. I understand that.
Um, I guess my my only concern like I
don't think it mattered in this case,
but where the point where he writes it
down, he doesn't say anything and then I
make a decision based on the fact that I
haven't written it down cuz it was never
acknowledged, right? Nothing was ever
said.
>> Okay. No, and communication can always
be a little bit better. So, for the rest
of
>> Yeah. Sorry, I didn't know you have to
announce this. That's never happened
before. Clearly about um this type of
information. Okay.
>> Gotcha. All right. Please. Yep. Yeah. No
worries. Enjoy your game.
>> Yep. Thanks. So, I'll mark it down a
one. year two.
>> Sorry. Uh I play also differently. I
thought uh we were like very friendly.
So I was like I'll play a little bit
more casually. I will start announcing
everything from now on. You see how like
I was also announcing all your triggers.
Uh it's because that's how I play. No,
you're good. Um I'm not meaning I don't
even need the point. I just want you to
realize um I'm not trying to do anything
crazy.
>> Yeah. Like I said, I don't think it was
malicious. I was just I think the ruling
is inconsistent
based on that. But we're all good.
>> Okay. Looks like we're going to get back
into the action here. Uh, acknowledging
it by marking it on paper does
illustrate that the knowledge was
presented. Uh, I think is what the the
judges were trying to illustrate there.
And I'm sure this will be a point of uh
contention. But regardless, I'm just
interested in seeing this game play out.
This game three, which has had this
whole match has been remarkable. We have
Vex Apathetic coming into play here onto
the battlefield alongside a Noxis
Hopeful.
A lot of might being represented here.
Uh we'll have to see if there is a way
to remove the specs because it can
present a lot of issues for KO because
all the number of ambush units that we
have access to.
>> It does shut down the Rengars and
everything else that wants to be
aggressive, which is exactly what KGO
wants to do. Now, at the same time here,
>> KGO does have a few options. I mean, of
course, you have the uh the falling
star. The Falling Star won't actually do
it. Never mind. We we got rid of the uh
the void gate here. So no, you're just
short. You don't have void seekers.
>> Um
hopefully here.
>> Yeah, this could be really tough. Has to
really look for the trade right here
right now. And getting that Vex off the
board. It could be potentially game
saving here.
>> Now we do have the traveling merchant
coming in as the attacker. You will have
priority. He's going to discard a draw
>> and it's going to be Rengar coming in
and again getting rid of that Vex
apathetic allows for this play to happen
>> and going to take that conquer point
there as well because we were able to
get that Vex off the board. The Rengar
was back on the table. There's also
Kha'Zix in this board for Ko. So a lot
of things really relied on that Vex
apathetic being off the board there.
>> Okay. Overzealous fan an absolutely
excellent card for holding and defending
battlefields.
Yeah,
>> Roy is now up.
>> A really strong hold here overall. We'll
have to see what Roy can do here. Looks
like stack deck, as we said, good
players calculating their runes and then
making sure they draw to have all their
options available to them before making
their decisions.
>> Every decision carries so much weight at
this point in the tournament. 10-1
Annie, 911 Pike. A lot on the line here.
They want to get it right.
And always a tough choice from these
stack decks because whatever gets
shuffled at the bottom, especially in a
deck like Pike, you're probably not
seeing it again.
>> Looks like the decisions being made.
>> Slowly but surely.
>> Not thinking so well.
>> They're all garbage.
>> They're all garbage is what Roy said.
>> We do see a bewitching spirit and I
think we saw a uh star cross as well in
hand. Oh, no, no, no.
>> Was kind of going through them rather
rapidly.
>> Which one?
>> Just put them all back at this point.
>> Looks the prettiest.
>> Exactly.
>> Ah, Beast Below.
>> Yes, Beast Below is there. I think Ty
Turner was the other card there as well.
just what do you do when you know
sometimes stack deck you get it and
everything's too good and you don't want
to put anything to your uh recycle
anything but instead in this case all of
them were garbage and wasn't even sure
which one wants to put to hand instead
>> just for a banter
some judge interaction here
>> but not the stack deck pile
>> okay never mind it's it's it's kind of
funny but I'll show Tell me after. I'll
tell you after. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Wants to show opponent later about how
bad the stack deck actually was. We do
see the bewitching spirit come out. Will
force a discard from KGO here.
>> Yeah, I'm not 100% sure, but I thought I
saw two treasure troves in the stack
deck and that he kind of just flipped
him against. So, I think it might have
been a really really awful choice. I'm
not 100% sure though cuz, you know, we
don't have the the greatest view at
times. But, uh, you know, I think that's
particularly funny. We do have the
Bewitching Spear coming out starting to
damage the hand. There's the pack of
wonders
>> holds to four.
>> Yeah, is going to really be playing this
bewitching spirit game. Once again, we
don't have many cards in the hand for KO
and we know that that can make all the
difference in the world in this Annie
matchup. Once again, these battlefields
don't allow you to draw more cards, so
we're not able to negate these
bewitching spirits.
>> Once the Bewitching Spirit gets into
that battlefield, it's going to come
back and forth. It's going to start
chipping away at the hand and then Ko's
going to be in the exact same position
they were last time. It's going to be a
terrible position to be in. So, he's
definitely thinking, "Okay, hold on. I
don't want to give free real estate to
this bewitching spirit. Is there
something I can do to start shoring up
these battlefields?"
>> So, something that Roy mentioned when
talking about the arena's greatest and
the point, he actually said, "I don't
even need the point." And I don't think
it's like you might think, oh, they're
being really, you know, too confident on
this, but that's really not the case
here. It's just the way that this
matchup plays up. They knew plays out.
They knew they had the bewitching
spirit. So, they knew that discarding
cards was going to be a big part of this
game and that it's not going to be this
close neck andneck game. It's really
going to see if Roy can run away with
the game with Bewitching Spirit and just
try to make Ko's life hard.
>> I I do wonder if you start to consider
Fizz into the stack deck if there's
something specific that Roy is looking
for. But once again, we're seeing Ko not
drawing into Kaisa Survivor. Uh that's
been a consistent theme with the type of
tempo being generated by the player. No
Kai'Sa, significantly less tempo. And so
Roy is thinking out their turn here.
Tons of runes, tons of options.
Bewitching Spirit on the field right
now. Could score an easy point. Let's
see what his decision is.
>> Yeah, good look here. The thing is if we
want to take a point potentially with
this Bewitching Spirit or do we
potentially put it into a spot where it
might die? However, if we could just use
the pack of wonders or return it to
hand.
>> Was looking at potentially playing that
Fizz there, but going to go ahead and uh
just hand play.
>> I'm just thinking on the trigger.
>> Keo considering on the trigger there.
>> Yes, it can be reacted to. It is able to
be reacted to. However, if not, the
discard star cross will be played
instead. Could have used this
potentially. Decides not to.
So, Roy seeing what else they can do
here. Potentially thinking about this
Fizz as we are eyeing that purple rune.
>> Looks like it's going to be Fizz
stack deck. Yeah.
No, I'm look I'm the one looking into
the future.
>> That one was good.
>> Those looked like a a very quick pick.
So, obviously the option that Roy wanted
to find find was found very quickly
there.
>> A little better than last time, it
sounds like. And it's going to be fun.
That's a That's what you're looking for.
Falling star.
>> Roy is now in control of the board.
>> Absolutely massive. We've talked so many
times about how that deal three is so
devastating in this current meta.
>> Absolutely. and we didn't have all those
four units for Ko. We will see though a
stack deck and maybe we're able to find
something that puts us back into this
game.
>> Even just an accelerated Kai'Sa.
>> Looks like it's a flash. Nox is hopeful
is what it looks like we took here. So,
we will be able to develop just a little
bit further because we really don't want
to keep anything in our hand because
Bewitching Spirit has the potential of
being bounced back back by Pike and then
being played once again.
>> Cards in hand.
>> Three. Three cards in hand for Roy. Ko
considering their options
>> has to figure out if they want to put
this Vex on a battlefield or not. Try to
get that extra point.
This these matches started so fast and
now as the pressure is on in game three,
round 12,
everything is slowing down as the
players carefully consider each action.
Each move could be the difference
between making it into the later stages
of the day and going home early.
>> Especially on two Fury decks, which
means these players have absolutely done
a great job not only building these
decks, but also piloting them to the
stage.
>> I honestly didn't think I'd find myself
in a position where I'm cheering on Fury
after months and months of Fury
dominance, but here we are. And in
particular, Pike is a is a legend that
I've been uh really hoping to see some
solid performances for. And of course,
Annie is synonymous with championship
winning performances. So either way,
we're in for a treat as the last 9
minutes of this game elapses.
This is a really tough decision here
because Vex is such a key part of the
deck and it does there is Pike that is
actually still ready and accessible
here. So it can be readied if Vex is not
on a battlefield.
Vex is going to come into the
battlefield, score the fifth point.
The question is, do you try to go after
the sixth point? Now, five-2, the score
is moving against Roy, but the the
battlefield and the hand on Ko is
starting to dwindle.
>> And this is the Noxis hopeful.
>> I did end up paying four for that there.
Uh they I do believe they played the
stack deck before this.
>> Yes.
>> So might have just a little bit of a
miscue. It's been a long game overall.
Uh but there's no there's no cards in
hand, so it doesn't even matter anyway,
but uh we'll have to keep an eye on on
that.
>> Sitting there with your arms crossed.
>> It's not a good feeling in a card game.
>> Is it possible he placed the cards on
the I don't No, I don't see any cards on
the on the deck there. So unfortunately,
it looks like he is out of cards in top
deck mode.
And Bewitching Spirit has just done its
job in every game but the first game.
>> Every game but that first one.
>> When it comes right down, it's this
third one that's going to count as Roy
considers their options here. Now, if
unfortunately for Kel, if he gets into
top deck mode, he still has to get to
eight points. This lead is going to
dissipate rather quickly as Roy starts
to just slowly pick apart here. Um, do
you have the beast below in hand,
starcross as well, lots of options.
>> The funny play would be to play
starcross on bewitching and vex and then
play bewitching again. It would be very
pricey acting as a removal there and
having to pay a deflect cost, but it
does make me laugh.
>> Okay, it's going to be a tie turner.
>> Not quite as exciting as what you have
described, but
>> it's another body on the field.
saving it most likely for 4Runner
overall which would make a lot of sense.
It adds a lot more consistency that way
and it just there isn't much other ways
to deal with 4Runner outside of
Starcross. Oh, we are going to see it.
>> It's going to be the Noxis Hopeful going
back to hand here
and two in
card in hand is Knoxville.
>> Yep. Go to damage.
>> Can't do anything on that. We're going
to go damage. And so KGO is going to
decide. Does he hate Fizz or does he
hate Spirit Birds?
>> Well, they've both been quite annoying
overall. Wolf Fizz is more annoying. I
think
>> you think Fizz is more annoying.
>> I would take Fizz out.
>> Fizz just has like that grin on their
face. Let's see what he decides. Ah,
went for the spirit. Okay, I understand.
I understand. It has been more annoying
over the course of this game.
>> Oh, yes. So, it's been gamechanging
overall.
>> Roy doing his due diligence, checking
the trash.
>> Any information you can gain in a card
game, the better. Still has that beast
below in hand. We have the Noxus Hopeful
coming out here as well.
>> It's going to stack the arena's greatest
>> turn past.
>> So, the reason too why we're thinking
about that Fizz versus Bewitching so
much is because we do have Pack of
Wonders on the board. Just a reminder
that it is there. So, it can bounce a
unit back to hand without even being on
a battlefield and being able to get
value from it. Uh, Roy has so many
options to just continue generating
value that Kgo does not have. Uh, looks
like we do see a stack deck and I think
I see a stack deck and flash. Yeah,
>> some other options. Will we see another
stack deck here?
>> Another one. Another stack deck. All the
stacking out of the way.
>> Okay. Long sword. Uh, maybe a Rengar.
really needs to find potentially units
here, I would say. Uh the only way
you're going to score points is by
finding more units. We have to remind
ourselves that we do have access to
Annie down there at the bottom as well.
So, we could potentially find more
things, but we don't want to have it in
hand if possible because we are still
worried about another bewitching spirit
potentially.
>> The bewitching spirit is a three of and
at some point you're going to be able to
play the mind spplitter as well.
Absolutely.
>> Really has to take a look at this
discard pile overall because we do run
Fizz in Ko's deck, I believe. So, if we
are able to actually, no, we do not. Um,
>> no. Yeah, no Fizz, but uh the Annie
Stubborn might be able to pull something
from the trash and that's exactly what
we're seeing here. Yeah,
>> KO is slowly ringing options, but as you
suggested, that champion zone, it's
there for a reason. you got to use it.
And on that note, you still have Pike
there, too, which could obviously
represent uh a serious issue when it
comes into play.
>> Yes, as they can be ready to take that
next battlefield as well.
>> And we are starting to wind down here a
bit on our time, so we'll have to see
what these players can do from here on
out.
>> Thinking about the star cross
potentially.
>> It's going to be hard to get it back on
board here.
Stack deck is another option.
>> Yeah, looks like he's choosing star
cross here.
>> Bounce Annie and probably the
>> Noxis. I don't know if you want you
don't want FS win.
>> Yeah, I mean regardless something or
it's just not played. It was just two
hand here. The star crossed.
>> So he chose not to play 45.
>> Okay.
>> The way he positioned on the table, it
looked like perhaps he was considering
playing it there. Yes, he does have to
reveal what he does take out of the
trash to his opponent. So, just making
it nice and clear for Roy to see what it
was.
>> You did mention prior that uh
you don't have much of a board state
here for Ko. Bouncing things back to
your hand just to make it susceptible to
the removal of the discards is probably
not the greatest idea either. It looks
like KGO's running out of good options
though. Time is ticking down though.
This might become a factor. Roy is going
to want to try to get ahead here before
we go to turns.
two cards.
>> Yeah, over time I would definitely say
this is Roy favored. However, this time
will definitely be a factor for sure. Uh
cleave was our next draw which really
isn't all that useful. So KGO might be
able to keep continue sneaking in a few
more points here. We do have access to
tide turner for one, but Beast Below
also is a possibility, but you aren't
really hitting that great of targets.
Beast below probably likely being a save
once again for 4Runner.
>> Yeah, like you're not going to beast
below the Annie. You don't want it
bringing something back. Noxis hopeful
is just really not that impactful. I
mean, it does slow it down. It'll have
to be replayed. So then it'll have to
come in into the base. That does slow
down the general game plan of KGO.
Considering perhaps bringing back Fizz
playing Fizz
>> and a lot of options from our trash
here. Stack deck going to be the call.
Three cards. Switcheroo. Knox is
hopeful, I think. And
>> I think that was Ezreal that we saw
there.
>> Ezreal is not a bad choice if you want
to start searching through that deck for
some answers here.
>> Tough choice here, unlike the uh last
stack deck where we very quickly took
what we wanted.
I mean, I don't mind that Nox is hopeful
here just to continue putting more units
on the board, especially as we are
winding down on time and points are
going to be so crucial here.
Riot needs to develop like some sort of
resource for casters where like, hey
guys, here's a picture of every card at
an angle in poor lighting so you can get
used to trying to figure out uh Oh, and
also we're going to show you just the
like the top left corner of it. It's a
developed skill, can I say?
>> And it looks like we took the edge roll
there. Um, sorry. That one's in.
>> So, we'll be able to draw a little bit
farther as well.
>> That does get that does get recycled.
Good call out from Ko.
>> So, will we play this Ezreal now here?
Potentially just to give ourselves a few
more options. U looks like we are going
to be doing that. I really like this
play here.
>> Critically important. We're at 30
seconds before we go to turns.
>> Yep.
Now, in your opinion here, does does Roy
want to get this turn done?
Like, I don't think it favors him to to
let the clock expire here.
>> No, I wouldn't say so. I would say even
the this current turn getting done a
little bit quicker on it would have
helped him out. He'll play this treasure
hunter out to the base, so has an option
in the future. We do have cleave inhand,
which could could be a very sneaky way
to get a good trade in. He did pass just
as it hit zero.
>> Literally as it hit zero, the hand
motion was sent over. So be very
interesting,
>> I believe.
>> Turn zero has been declared here for
Kgo. So it seems as though the judge
call there was right in time for Roy.
>> So each player will be able to take a
couple more turns here. And we'll
probably see these players think these
out quite a bit because we are no longer
on time. We are only concerned about the
turns themselves. So these players will
be taking their time to make these
critical choices as it is win by two
after these turns.
>> KGO's probably trying to consider here.
Listen, we're on turns.
I can get easily up to six here and at
best next turn he matches me.
It's a very different game here.
>> Yeah. So overall, I mean, this
battlefield is stacked and ready to go.
>> The other issue here is it it is
forbidding waste. You don't want to just
send a Noxis Hopeful to stand there by
its own on its own here.
>> Yes, this uh treasure hunter is actually
such a smart play here overall. But KO
we've seen navigate this game very well.
Has to be thinking this treasure hunter
not being part of the stack. There must
be a reason for it. But we will see that
Nox's hope will go into that forbidding
waste and we might see a big play here
for Roy very soon. We'll have to see
what happens.
>> The Knox is hopeful sitting by itself in
the forbidding waste.
>> We'll have to see if Annie ends up
joining him or not because then the
forbidding waste won't be triggered
because the unit will not be defending
alone.
>> Annie's kind of just in no man's land
right now. It's definitely not going to
do anything left. There's also a hidden
card left. Let's not forget it's kind of
>> I don't want to say difficult to see,
but there's a hidden It's hidden. Would
you believe it? It's actually
legitimately kind of hidden there.
So, we'll have to see what KGO does.
Each turn incredibly important.
>> Taking a look at that discard once
again.
Has to decide what they want to do here.
And we see the star cross potentially
coming down to get more value from this
Annie is what we're looking at. Does Roy
have a way to respond to it? Looks like
not very quickly taking that card up.
>> Yeah, choosing to go on the Noxus
hopeful and Annie will join in the
forbidding waste.
>> You don't want to star cross neither
Fizz or Ezreal in this given situation.
It'll just give too much optionality to
Roy.
>> But we do have to remind ourselves that
we are on turns here. So you have to
decide if like for me Ezreal yes
potentially draws two more cards but we
are only going to be on eight runes next
turn that is pretty expensive overall to
pay that energy and power for Ezreal.
I'm not saying that that's the right
play by any means here but I'm less
concerned about the Ezreal and more
concerned about like a Fizz getting
bounced back if that's the case and we
do have pack of wonder so we can
actually make that decision ourselves.
We go to the fifth point here. Vital.
The question is going to be, can Roy
knock off the Forbidden Waste. Even some
removal. Just remove one of them and
then it makes the the other so much
weaker while defending.
>> And that's a down well that we see in
hand here for Roy. It's not really going
to do all that much here because we
don't really want to reset this board.
We are behind on points. However, if we
were ahead on points, this downwell
would be insane,
>> especially given that you're on turns.
It would just slow the game completely
down.
>> So, I want to note here that Beast Below
could come into play here potentially.
Um, that could also, you know, remove
one of these cards on the forfeiting
mice and set up this treasure hunter
potentially.
>> Yeah, at the very least to maybe trade
the Annie,
>> get rid of the Noxis. hopeful and he
then represents one might send in the
the treasure hunter.
>> Although the inferno would just take the
conquer point regardless after that. But
I feel like there's something there and
that's maybe what Roy is looking at
potentially.
>> You still have pike as well.
>> Pike from the champ zone
>> is
okay. Oh.
>> Oh yes.
>> That is heartbreaking there.
waiting to see if it resolves
>> as we do. We have starcross in hand for
KGO still.
>> I believe we do. Yes, we do cuz we put
it in hand that last round from Annie.
>> Could consider using it for Annie.
>> Once again, we are at turns here. This
is turn one. So, Ko gets one more turn
after this. Really wants to try to keep
that point advantage here.
The point's incredibly important.
>> Oh, sorry. Okay, let's I believe. Okay,
these are all gone.
>> Oh, we know the exact board state. This
is perfectly fine. We're at turns. This
isn't even delaying the time. No issues
here at all.
>> We have photographic evidence if we got
to go to it, guys. Don't worry. We know
you're nervous.
>> Okay,
>> I'm nervous for them.
>> Let's not do that again.
>> But getting the cards back just fine
here. I was going to say, man, he's
playing a lot of cards all at once here.
>> Hey, sometimes Annie does do stuff like
that.
>> Not quite like that, but
>> Rengar, Rengar, Rengar.
>> Yeah, it's true. We did see Prismaticism
close out their game with Rengar,
Rengar, which was actually really
awesome. So, I guess Ko's considering
here, do you try to save Annie?
>> And really considering it here. Oh,
>> double checking the power cost on the
Fizz here. Most likely, uh, those were
recycled properly. So, assume that is
good
>> response
>> because some cards have a power limit on
it. It is good to check that, but Fizz
does not have a power limit. It does
just have an energy limit inside.
>> That resolves. This resolves.
>> So, Inferno does die. So, that one gets
put to the bottom.
>> Yeah.
>> And he goes back to hand. Starcross was
used.
Doc's hopeful is there still.
>> Oo, this is going to be so good because
we have access to that cleave into the
forbidding waste. Now, this is actually
a huge potential here.
>> Suddenly cleave, which looked like a
dead draw. Um, is uh
>> Oh, actually, no. We discarded the
>> Where's the cle pile? No,
>> the trash. No, I just realized.
>> You got me so excited for a second. Then
I'm like, wait a minute. He's flipping
through the cards. I don't see an axe.
We We do still have options though. Even
Ezreal can kind of search through a bit
>> which I think
>> that's going to be the pike and going to
come and accelerate. Yeah, that's
>> that's going to be difficult. There's
only a single card in hand, I think.
Maybe two. No, that looks like a single
card. No, that's two cards.
>> Two cards.
Has to make the decision here. I mean,
if we have an ambush unit, maybe we're
able to do something.
>> That forbidden waste though definitely
is impacting
the Knox is hopeful.
>> This is a vital point.
>> Yes, Roy definitely wants to try to find
this point for sure
>> because All right. Yep.
>> going through.
>> 66.
>> Hey, we got to see both champions be
played.
>> Knoxville secures that.
Well, Roy is sitting in a really nice
spot here overall.
>> I think that might be a Rengar in Ko's
hand. I'm not sure. It's hard to tell.
>> Definitely could be.
>> I love this play of saying, "Okay, I
need to hold these battlefields now. I
need you to not double conquer here.
It's the only thing that loses me the
game. If not, we will be very close to
each other in points. And also, we are
going for the holds here to get our
>> eighth point."
>> Yes. Exactly. This is actually kind of
crazy.
>> And even like Kai'Sa, you go Kai'Sa
accelerated into what? Like you you
really only have a few options here.
Checks.
Checks again. Of course, he has Annie
available to him. So Annie is able to
bring something from the trash there.
>> We are going to see Annie
>> stack deck
>> bringing back stack deck.
>> And what can stack deck find? Even
Kai'Sa just isn't good enough here.
>> Okay, quickly chosen. Yeah, even that's
what I was saying. Yeah, Kai'Sa even
just not quite enough. You need more.
Just a little slow here.
>> Very bad choices.
>> We'll have to take a look and see. Is
there a way out?
>> Roy only down to three runes. all
exhausted and it is Kai'Sa
>> accelerated Kai'Sa
and it is going to be a tie turn. It's
going to bring the Noxis whole over
excellent play m and that's it.
>> That is going to be Roy achieving
victory in round 12. Pike on full
display here. Absolutely excellent
control.
>> I absolutely love watching Roy navigate
this deck. In fact, I'm kind of cheering
on for him now because just his
demeanor, his happiness and joy when
he's playing the game, it made me feel a
little extra special watching this
Riftbound game.
>> I was so excited to see Pike in this.
It's one of those things where it's
like, you know what, Pike has been
relatively quiet ever since coming into
the scene and unleashed. And finally,
we're seeing a pretty decent result
here.
>> Oh, yeah. Just seeing Pike being
navigated so well too and seeing the
power of Bewitching Spirit, especially
against, like I said, battlefields that
don't allow you to draw. Uh, that was
the biggest thing there. And even if you
don't draw the Bewitching Spirit, you
still have other options in the Pike
deck. That's why it's so cool is because
it can be tempo based. It could be a
little bit more of the control side. It
has so much flexibility. And when you
have such a wide array of decks you have
to play into, having the Pike options
available to you is so nice.
>> Guys, I got great news. Do you want to
see more Riftbound? because we can go
into game three here. We got the deck
lists up the game that you guys are
excited to see. We have Fiora coming in
here and uh what do you see from this
deck here? We're going to be catching on
from game number three.
>> Well, of course, we have Aurora Fiora
and we haven't really seen too much of
that yet. Of course, I like seeing the
diving shells as being a way to filter
through the deck. That's one of the
deck's biggest weaknesses. So, seeing
Frozen take advantage of the diving
shells overall to be able to just find
that Aurora is really important. And
because you can't always find Aurora so
quickly, Frozen was very smart to
include a lot more units than what you
usually see. And that is for the reason
of that even if you miss out on the
Aurora, you still have ways to win the
game with the units that you have.
>> And I absolutely love the three of of
Repost. Uh Repost is one of those
signature abilities that seems like it
can consistently get value. Having the
opportunity to counter a spell and then
of course giving that equal might can
have an absolutely tremendous effect on
any given uh interaction.
>> And of course we have three main board
auctionons in this list as players
expected a lot of Aurora and gear in
general. Oshan can just steal that for
himself and that is a huge part of this
deck overall.
>> Let's move on to the next deck which if
my memory serves me correctly is going
to be a Dianaist. This Diana list is a
little unique here. I do see acceptable
losses being put into the main deck
here. Not something that I often see in
Diana. What are your thoughts on that?
>> I think it's a great tech right now.
Especially Diana is not a very gear
focused. Uh we don't have frigid jewel
in this for instance. We've seen Allen
CQ also add acceptable losses. So
multiple players coming to the same
conclusion usually means it's a good
conclusion.
>> Yeah, I really like what Gorka is doing
here. trying to find unique ways to
splash some flavor into the deck. And
guys, I've got some great news. We're
ready for this game. Game number three.
Let's go to it. We have Frozen on Fiora
and Gorka on Diana. We are in game
three. It's round 12. There's a lot at
stake here. 9 and2 Frozen, 9 into Gorka.
>> Let's see what happens.
>> All right. Good luck, man.
>> Good luck to you, too. So, we do have
the abandoned hall, which uh is one of
Diana's fave riot battlefields because
she is able to play a lot of spells and
gain a good amount of might as well from
it. And we are playing in that third
game, which is such a strong battlefield
for her. Stupify, for instance, is such
an insane combo with it, just being able
to get so much might on top of
>> reducing your opponent's might as well.
>> And am amateur recital is a pretty
unique battlefield. When you hold here,
you may move a unit at a battlefield to
its base. It provides a lot of
optionality for the controlling player
to reposition their units.
>> So, a big thing of why this is so good
in these Aurora style decks is when
you're playing these big units, you're
often trying to stabilize at the end of
the game. And because you essentially
have a pseudo ganking from this
battlefield, you're able to control both
battlefields easier. It's like having
kind of like Misfortune's power without
actually playing Misfortune. And so it's
a really good option for Fiora overall.
>> Fiora does come out here. I have to say
this is not relevant to the absolute
gameplay here, but those runes,
>> my gosh, what an amazing addition to
unleash. Those runes are absolutely
ridiculous. I can't stop looking at
them. Absolutely beautiful. Fiora does
hit the field of play here. And it looks
like uh we're going to be following up
here with the Diana into
>> not yet. Thinking it through here.
Gorkas considering the next play.
>> Sure.
And it is into the abandoned home
>> trigger
>> and will be taking that Diana trigger
very quickly and finds that Moonfall.
>> That is an absolute blessed play there.
You're going to take that all day long.
>> Two pay deflects
>> and it is going to be Moonfall being
played immediately.
>> So currently I'll get plus one from the
hall.
>> Yeah.
>> So four to four.
>> So big thing here is that Fiora does
lose here
>> and a stupify.
go to two. You're at minus one draw.
>> And because the Fiora lost the mighty
there, the stupify, there's no longer
deflect that you have to pay. So the
stupify being second makes a lot of
sense here as well. And because
specifically Moonfall does target the
battlefield, too.
>> It is notable we're in game three here,
but we only do have 5 minutes and 52
seconds here. So we have to make sure
that uh you know, we get these turns
done quicker. We have some communication
between the players. It looks like
everything got sorted out
>> and it's going to be Rengar.
>> Rengar coming in to the battlefield to
contest with Diana.
>> That's the trophy hunter.
>> Uh
>> and they are able to take that Diana
trigger once again too because she is in
a showdown.
>> Let's see what happens here. Okay, we
are getting the uh divining shells
>> getting vision there. for being able to
look at the top card of our deck. Very
useful.
>> Frozen's uh rune game is on point.
>> Very good indeed.
>> Actually, the the ones with the
mushrooms are my favorite ones of
Unleashed. I love them.
>> They're all so good. They're all so
good.
>> It's actually one thing about riffound I
really like. I know this is kind of
silly, but you get to have all these
beautiful runes. You get to use all the
different sleeves. You have all
different colors. I got sleeves for my
tokens. I got sleeves for my runes. I
got sleeves for my deck. Sleeves
everywhere. You get to go right right
into your inventory of everything you've
been collecting through the years.
>> Well, Rift Herald coming out as we
talked about a little bit earlier is
even though if you don't have the Aurora
in this deck, it doesn't just fall flat
on its face because it has other options
like this. It has the Rengar. It has the
Rift Herald, for instance. So, being
able to see this that this deck can also
operate as pretty much a mid-range deck
and not just a full control deck. It's
just a really tall mid-range deck is a
way to think about it.
>> Yeah, that death now being being able to
play a unit from your hand to the base
ignoring its cost is actually relatively
significant.
Excellent play there. And by seeing that
Rift Herald come out, you have to start
playing around Elder Dragon now, which
is a really funny thing to think about
as a whole, I'm sure it's done a lot of
work over the weekend.
>> Um, Raven Bloom student out here. And we
do have the Eager Apprentice as well.
That's a card that you don't see all
that often. While I'm at a battlefield,
the energy uh costs for spells that you
play are reduced by one to a minimum of
one.
It's exactly what Gorka is going to want
to do as he tries to contest all these
battlefields.
>> And we have a double score.
>> Yeah, going to want to take advantage of
getting as much points as possible when
we are low on time and you are playing
against a pretty tall deck as a whole.
So, you want to be the proactive player
in this game overall.
Top
>> two cycle. Yep.
>> I see.
>> Moonfall
here.
>> Okay. So, it's three to four.
>> So, this Raven Blue student is going to
be getting large very quickly. Of
course, we have the abandoned hall and
then also the Moonfall itself. So, it is
up to four and Rhaegar is also at four.
>> Did you ramp?
>> Yeah.
>> Raven Bloom Students one of those cards
that can definitely get bigger.
relatively fast stack deck that's going
to improve Raven Bloom students
opportunities to survive here
>> once again going up by another two here
and this is the power of abandoned hall
in Diana is why pretty much every Diana
deck that you see is running this
>> Gorka considering their play here
>> um
might have to go a little bit faster.
>> Yeah,
>> still having to decide on that stack
deck here.
>> Such critical decisions overall. Uh
Diana is a very punishing deck as a
whole. If you make the wrong decision,
>> then you can fall fli
something as strong as Fiora with lots
of lots of high might units that you
have to navigate well. And we've already
played two Moonfalls as well. So, we do
have good options if we can continue to
take control of these battlefields. And
we have to be very careful here with the
placement of this Fizz because if this
Rift Herald dies and it does summon an
Elder Dragon, that would be a full
clear. So, we have to really be thinking
about where we are placing these units.
Let's see what happens here. There's a,
for instance, a sacrifice onto this Rift
Herald. We could have a very different
game going on here if we had Elder
Dragon in hand.
>> Back in
>> Cora instead chooses to go with the Vex
Apathetic here. Not at the battlefield
though perhaps
>> thinking about exactly what you just
cited there.
>> Uh
>> and it's the Rift Herald that's going to
come in. It's going to take the point
there. Scored a three.
>> Yeah. Doesn't have too many options
because they're forked a bit because of
how large this Rift Herald actually is.
Uh really frozen doesn't even have to
play the Elder Dragon here either if uh
they were to have all sacrifice into
Rift Herald, but instead we have the
harness dragon coming out. Another
dragon that can do a lot of damage as
well as we do get to kill a unit.
Killing Raven Bloom student being a
great choice because we don't have to
play a deflect cost. It was also on a
battlefield so we don't have to worry
about the hold either. And that is a
huge thing. And these players know that
the time is winding down. So we might be
going into the hold game very quickly.
However, because we are on the amateur
recital battlefield, we will be able to
pull units back. So that's why double
stacking this makes a ton of sense. And
then we do have the challenge there
taking out that Vex as well. We're
looking like we have a really strong
spot for Frozen right now. for body. Um,
challenge represents a fantastic way to
deal with Vex because you often can't
really like you can't use the Rengar
trophy hunter to ambush into it. So,
you're going to have to find more
creative ways and challenge is one of
the unique ways that you can work around
uh Vex apathetic by still forcing the
might damage to be applied to it.
>> Yeah, we're really getting to see this
Fiora deck shine even without Aurora.
Uh, like I said, I love these decks that
can do well even when they don't have
Aurora. And it doesn't even look like
this is an Aurora deck. It just looks
like it's a Fiora deck. At this point,
>> we are now officially on turns. This is
turn zero.
>> In our round of 12.
Have to see what we can do here. As the
points are close, but the board state is
not so close.
>> No, it's not. The points are a little
deceiving here.
>> It's
>> However, depending on the hand for
Agora, if we do have Wayey, if we do
have Ride the Wind,
>> maybe there's options here. But we
haven't seen that way yet. So maybe not
going to be an option anytime soon.
>> Also highly notable, we do have amateur
recital. So when you hold, he's going to
be able to move one of those to the
base. That's very significant here as it
allow to uh allow Frozen to reposition
for perhaps maximum damage on these
final turns.
>> And for Gorka, this hand is pretty
awkward. It looks like we do have double
Vex, double Fizz, and those just aren't
what you want to see right now. So maybe
we're looking for a stack deck right
here. Nope. Uh, okay. We are playing
stack deck here.
>> So stack deck here makes a lot of sense
because we really need to find a bit
more higher value and we need a way to
ideally score on this battlefield just
to start keeping the points close.
Talking about the abandoned hole here.
So a ride the win for instance would be
excellent
>> on turns every single point is critical.
You do have to win by two.
>> Exactly. So, finding a way to score here
would be huge. Of course, we do see the
star cross is in hand, but it doesn't do
all that much here because one of these
units will still be left on the immature
recital.
>> It's worth noting as we did catch this
game on the third, this is a Fiora
Aurora deck. So, we still run the risk
for Gora of Frozen eventually being able
to play the Aurora. He has an amazing uh
presence on the field of play already.
And it's without the Aurora. And there
we saw the amateur recital on the whole
trigger repositioning and therefore
grabbing and we got an Elder Dragon. The
board gets scarier.
>> Going straight to hand here. Uh can't
quite hard cast it yet, but if we do
have a way to kill Rift Herald, we could
cast it for instance, but we're going to
just play our equipment out instead.
>> Hey, more mighty units is fantastic.
>> Exactly what Fur wants.
>> Um
>> so with knowing that Elder Dragon is now
in hand, we're fine with the Rough
Herald dying because we can play Elder
Dragon. So instead, we are going to just
stack up this harness dragon instead.
>> It's a hard punish for trying to take
that battlefield there
>> cuz you know what's coming down. Turn
past
>> Gora has a hill to climb here.
>> Down by two and an extremely
intimidating board state to try to go
through.
>> Yeah, just very well navigated from
Frozen overall. Very smart game play,
especially once we do find that elder.
I believe I heard a judge say this is
the last turn.
So to draw out Gorka will have to clear
both battlefields or at least the point.
Just look at how this goes here. What
like what is your plan if you're Gora
here? What are you trying to do? Like
what's your what's your strategy?
>> I'm trying to get a tie here
>> is what I want. So this star cross is
what I'm really looking at doing
potentially and looking at maybe having
on the Fizz. We have to know that
challenge could potentially be a
response to this. Uh, you do have to be
able to bounce a unit to bounce your
opponent's unit. So, we'll have to see
if there is a response here. This could
make a big difference in this game.
>> Fizz and
>> Okay, Rift Herald being bounced. And
there's the reaction sacrifice.
>> Sacrifice the cost.
>> Uh,
>> pay the additional cost.
>> Holding on the trigger.
>> So, I have to do the death now first.
>> So,
>> well, I'm taking on reacting to this. Uh
you I do this first.
>> Oh, you do this first. Okay. Yeah, sure.
Sure. Sure.
>> Yep. We'll listen to the players on that
one.
>> As they say, we do the death nail first
here
>> before we look at the card. So, if you
actually
>> Wait, did he uh choose targets for
starcross first?
>> Yeah, I chose Fizz and uh
>> let's listen in here.
>> So, Fizz recycles the starcross, right?
>> When it when it No, no, no. I'm I play
this from hands.
>> Oh, okay. Okay. I see. See, I see see.
Uh
I'll kill the fizz then.
>> Okay. Thinking on the trigger.
>> Okay, let's go ahead and get back into
it as we do have the elder dragon
sandwich was assigned to Fizz here.
>> Gora considering their action on top of
the sacrifice. Frozen did pay the
additional cost. Um,
>> tough decision here overall. We do have
the abandon in hand.
>> However, that was not going to do all
that much. It's hard to see what else is
there. What other options? We have
another Fizz in hand and that looks like
maybe away.
>> Sorry, I'm pretty sure I'm pretty sure I
lose my I'm just going to think.
>> Yeah, no problem. Take take all your
time. Gorka doing the correct thing
here, saying, you know what, I'm in
trouble, but this is a big game. I want
to think it through. I want to make sure
I go through every option here. Don't
want to watch the replay back and regret
not taking the time needed.
>> Exactly. The number of times that I've
seen players uh concede and then realize
they could have done something else is
really high, especially in these games
that there's just so much to think
about. So, making sure to take the time
to really make sure that you know that
whether the game is over or not, or what
you need to do to get back into the
game, potentially get a tie. I really
like how we're taking our time here.
>> There aren't really any options, though.
The card I couldn't see there was a
flash, and the flash is not helpful here
in any way, shape, form.
>> That's not
another Fizz would probably have to be
the play here, but has to decide if they
can do anything with it.
Um,
>> still waiting on the trigger from the
Elder Dragon that targeted the Fizz.
>> Frozen would win here on the hold.
>> Abandon.
>> Going to cast abandon.
Okay. So, this will return to hand.
>> Once this resolves return to hand.
>> Yeah. Does my damage go to
>> It's where it it'll So, once it goes
back to hand, it'll go back to the
damage and then I can react again.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah. Good.
>> Yeah.
>> All right. Predict.
>> Yep.
>> Bottom.
>> Okay.
>> To hand.
>> Go ahead and explain what is going on
there to help you viewers at home.
>> Little more of a complex interaction
there. Cross down again. on Fizz and
this
>> the dragon. Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> Uh actually Fizz and the
>> It doesn't matter. This will die
anyways.
>> Um
>> it'll prevent the whole still win by
two.
>> The Elder. Sure.
>> Uh okay. And then this goes back and
then this resolves.
>> No. Well, okay. So, this resolves this
resolves first. Yeah. And then
>> now I channel and draw.
>> Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes.
>> Channel draw two.
>> Yeah.
>> All right. There we go. We finally have
the sacrifice is resolved now. So, we
get the channel and the draw from it.
>> And then Vex does move into the
abandoned hall to get that next point.
>> Channel uh move back.
>> Yeah, you got
>> Yep. Yeah,
>> good game's called Frozen on Fiora.
Successful in completing the victory
here in game three. That came right down
to the wire there. Going on turns and
ultimately getting the win.
>> Absolutely a great game from Frozen. We
saw that you don't need Aurora in Fiora.
You can just play strong units and of
course sacrifice. What a great card from
Unleashed.
Yeah, having the option to play the Fior
uh the Dazzling Aurora of course is a
benefit in this given circumstance here.
Didn't need it. Get those big chunky
units, get them on the field of play,
let them carry the play.
>> Exactly. And we see that we can still
cheat out Elder Dragon in other ways. We
don't always have to have Aurora.
Referral can do the work all itself.
>> At the end of the day, one of the things
that I've learned watching these games
is we had multiple series go to turns.
Every individual point is so incredibly
important. You absolutely have to score
them when you can and then when you get
the opportunity to close out the games,
you have to try to take advantage of
those chances.
>> Exactly. We saw also too, I like to see
how that recital did such a great job as
well. So I being able to use it to pull
back units to take both battlefields
working as that ganking exactly like we
talked about earlier as well.
>> And for me, I'm excited to see Fiora out
here. We're seeing a very good
performance here. I think that one of my
absolute favorite things about Riftbound
is the meta diversity. Were you
expecting to see a run like this from
Fiora?
>> Well, with the Aurora, anything feels a
little bit possible, but there's been so
much gear hate in the meta. I wasn't
expecting it to do this good. And as we
saw, we don't even need the Aurora. So,
Fiora going deep wasn't exactly what I
was expecting, but it doesn't surprise
me either.
>> We've got more Riftbound action coming
in round 13 after this break.
Welcome everybody. I'm Barrett Bryant
and I'm absolutely humbled to be joined
by two very prolific players. We have
Ali Andrazi as well as Allen's EQ
joining me on the desk. We're doing
another deep dive and specifically we
want to talk about tournament and player
journeys. Of course, we're going to play
a little bit of footage in the
background. Spoilers for everybody at
home. They got paired against each other
in round 12. But I want to talk about
how we also got there. Allan, you've
been piloting this Diana list not just
for this event, but also prior before
into Sydney for that first ever
Unleashed event. I want you to kind of
talk about some of the matches that
you've gone across and then of course
we're going to go to you as well, Ali,
afterwards. So, after this is going to
roll. Incredible match. I got to witness
some of the B-roll getting filmed and
just two professional players playing
against each other at such high skill
levels making the most intense decisions
possible. I want to talk to you as we've
got to about round five. I believe you
played against the Lilia. How was that
sort of matchup and how do you think
your deck was tailored to go against
that sort of match? Because I know you
came into this tournament prepared to go
against quite a few calm decks. That's a
very unfortunate matchup for the Lilia
because the deck is heavily tech to deal
with those type of the decks with just
triple gas the purple vex and Lilia just
doesn't get to play the game against the
Diana. The only out they have is pretty
much unchecked power and hope I don't
have hard bargain or the flesh. So it's
rather one of the easier matchups for
the Diana.
>> Yeah, absolutely. So for everybody at
home, we got this graphic right here. So
that was actually round four. So, my
mistake, but as you can see, for your
first eight rounds, that embodies your
entire journey for day one and including
the beginning of today having to go
against Dulon on Leblanc. And he was
doing very successfully. Obviously,
another X and0 going into the day. What
about the Leblanc matchups particularly?
>> It's very like Lilia. When I see my per
I'm like, oh, looks like a buy. It's
just like so bad for the Leblanc that uh
it's a great deck, but it has the main
equiana and Ani for the Leblanc. and the
deck is just not suited to deal with it.
So, it has to sacrifice all the cards
that are good into the Diana to make
sure they beat all the other matchups
constantly enough. And then uh we only
had room for the 10 here, but of course
in round 11, I also heard that you got
paired against Dewali himself. Also
piloting Diana with a lot of insight and
discussion from you. How did that round
go? I believe you guys ended up drawing.
Yeah, we intentionally drew because we
end up thinking one of us won't make it,
might not make it if we have a loss and
instead we have two shots at just
winning one of the two matches since we
prep together. Uh Sean is playing the
different version of the list that
pretty much we worked on for like two
weeks a week or something between C and
now and the other list I was just uh
kind of uh taking idea from the China
and adjust adjusting it for my own play
style uh which I liked more into the top
uh top the tournament when you get get
to XO parts while Joel version is very
good into the jungle meta. So I think
the my version is favorite to go into
the top eight. However, the dual one is
better if you want to have a consistent
results up to top 64
>> and we have seen that seeing as how you
two met at that round right now. I'm
going to hold off on the round 12
obviously. Ali, I want to turn to you.
We got to witness your match at the end
of round eight on day one and it was one
of the best matches I've actually seen
in a very long time just for the amount
of intricacies and level of play that it
takes to play this Aurora list. I want
to talk about your journey. So, we have
your graphic that we want to bring up,
but
>> in general, your run, I know you had one
loss going into your matchup against
Allen and it was against
>> Swallie. Yeah.
>> So, the same sort of Diana, is that a
struggle for the deck, would you say,
right now?
>> Um, I it's a struggle. I think they're
probably favored, but it's not by much.
Uh,
our all our games were really close. All
they all went to game three, and it was
all decided like micro decisions, so
it's very, very close.
Yeah, absolutely. I can also take a
quick look on here. You actually had to
play against a lot of calm this run.
Azir, Lilia, Azir, Ireelia. How's that
feel as well? I mean,
>> well, in the beginning, I had like I
don't say buys, but Master G, which was
very good for Aurora, obviously two,
three, four, Master G.
>> Um, against Azir, the yellow the yellow
decks, I'm I'm more I'm more more afraid
of yellow than I am calm. But, uh, Annie
is great against all the yellow decks as
we saw also in round eight yesterday
against Leblanc. um allow me to like
loop and lock people out with challenge
or uh fading memories or
>> fl your blades or whatever. So,
>> and then real quickly, your round 11, do
you do you remember that match up? Can
you kind of break that one down as we
don't have room for it?
>> Is that Dwali?
>> No, right after the Dewali, the one that
you played before Allen.
>> That's okay. It's all right. So,
>> I'm sorry. They all blend together at
this point
>> for that's that's part of
>> Oh, I I think I think it was actually I
think also Mastery again, but it's
Mastery Aurora.
>> I understand. Oh yeah, that's at at
round 11 at that high up. That's pretty
crazy.
>> Yeah, he had a he had a cool tech where
he was like boarding out Auroras. He had
one Aurora and he was like boarding
actuons and D. So basically his goal was
to steal my Auroras. It was very close
as well. That was that was the closest E
match up. Um
>> Wow.
>> for the this event for me.
>> Yeah, that's good to hear that as well.
But I want to then now get to round 12
because part of this conversation is
about the amount of like mental
fortitude that it takes to play
competitive card games from two very
professional players. the result of
that. I'm sure everyone's kind of dying
to know if they haven't looked at it
already, but what was the end result of
that match for you two? Just recently,
>> I managed to pull in the game three by
just the Liy. That was such a close
series. The game one I got stomped. Game
two, Ali got stomped and game three was
a very very very close series on the
when the Ali was going first on the
aspirant climb. But uh and I ended up
taking it barely just by removing two
auroras from the plate. So, so also Ali
missing out on his our uh the bad unit.
>> No, but but game one you said you end up
winning game one.
>> Game one. Yeah. And then game two. Game
one was I just like you said I bodied
him. Game two he bodied me. Game three
was a game three was a heartbreaker for
me overall. Um I actually punted the
match. I'm pretty I'm 9 9% positive. Uh
I couldn't remember if I had bottomed
all dragon or mine splitter first and I
basically I could
I just forgot and I went to go draw cuz
I wanted to draw the mind sweater so I
hit the dragon with my aurora but I
bought him a dragon first. I drew it
first and that was that was basically
it. Um,
>> and we know how important that is
because again, the match that we saw
yesterday in round eight, when you go to
recycle the two cards at the bottom and
it's a flurry of blades and the Elder
Dragon, the order, the randomization of
those cards getting recycled makes or
breaks whether or not you draw that Fury
Flurry of Blades or you don't and you
have to recycle your entire deck.
>> Yeah, with Last Rights. Yes, this was
just like
>> Yeah.
>> But yes, it was it was a great game
though. It was love playing against
Allen. Uh, like I'm happy he made it.
It's like bittersweet. I'm glad he made
it. uh sad to make it, but overall it's,
you know, it's it's good.
>> I mean, and once again, another powerful
performance here on Civer. I mean, you
already have a best of, of course. Um,
you know, I won't say you're out of it
yet. I don't know the stories for the
rest of the Civers, of course, right
now, but there's one more round to play,
of course. I'm sure you're probably
going to finish it out as most want to.
Um Allan, congratulations. You've
basically all but been guaranteed your
top cut. Obviously, I don't know the
bracket math, but I guess you could get
paired against somebody that has to play
in a down pair, maybe. Yeah, but the
tiebreers are pretty high, so like even
if I lose the next one, it should be
still top eight. Wow.
>> Exactly. So, I mean,
>> honestly, I first of all, I have to
thank you both so much for joining me on
this segment. It's just something I want
to really bring to light because these
tournaments are very difficult and you
two really prove that putting in the
work gets you so far in a game like
Riftbound. And this, I can't imagine, is
the last time you two will be paired
against each other. And I hope not the
last time that I have either of you both
here on the desk. So, thank you so much
to both of you. Great job this weekend
overall. Still more Riftbound to be
played, but we're going to send it back.
>> All right, thank you very much, Barrett.
That was a great interview. Uh,
obviously some titans of this game right
now. Love to see they're both doing
well, especially going into this 13th
and final round of Swiss for the
regional qualifier here in Vancouver.
>> Yeah, it is so cool to see them get to
fight each other. Too bad we didn't get
it on stream, but I am excited that we
got to have an interview. Really fun
also to get to see them interact. I
always love seeing players and how they
interact with each other.
>> Definitely. And we're going to look at
some standings real quick as we go into
this 13th and final round of Swiss.
We've got Dewali and Alen ZQ on those
Diana. Uh so very likely going to top
eight, I think, at this point, right?
>> Yeah, I think you guys are pretty happy,
but I think there's some interesting
ones here as well. You know, there is no
Leblanc in this first picture, but I do
see a really cool Rengar, obviously,
Master Yi that we looked at earlier,
Civers, Pikes, really cool ones. And
there's so many names that we see
Dewali, see the Allen ZQ, which both
have won tournaments in the past,
including Sam D. Sherman. And then names
like houses are big like we saw earlier
today.
>> Yeah, I think Zali and Allen ZQ have two
of the spots, but that's means six more
spots are available for our players.
We've got another page of standings to
look at, too. But yeah, everyone's
trying to fight for it. That top eight
finish would be, you know, a highlight
for sure.
>> Yeah, 100%. And so many great names
still in this top 20 here. Seeing
Prismaticism,
No Veggies, all names that we've been
seeing. KG O that we just watched on
stream as well. But Ireelas, Kais,
Annies, so many cool decks.
>> Yeah. And and the Poppy, right? Uh
another kind of dark horse here.
Honestly, you know, Chrisism has like so
much of experience with being best of
Annie and now there's quite a rush for
that top placing now.
>> Yeah, it seems like we're going to be
really competing for that best of Annie
this weekend.
>> Yeah. So, uh we're going to go to a
community vote for our last round of
Swiss here. Both of these matches are
winningins essentially for getting this
top eight. We've got uh the secret sauce
are big on Mastery and Ryan Ferris for
the civer. And then match B, we've got
Arito and Roy. If you put A in the chat
for match A and B in the chat for match
B.
>> Yeah, I mean, I'm so excited for either
of these. In match A, TSS Houses are big
we saw earlier today. And Ryan Ferris, I
do believe has gotten like top 16, top
32s in some of these other regional
qualifiers. Arto also did really well in
Lil I believe it was. Uh, and Roy
obviously we saw earlier as well. What a
cool pike.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And to be able to get that
into top eight would be phenomenal,
right? A a legend that hasn't really
been able to do so so far. So, I think
both matches are fantastic.
>> Yeah. Make sure that in chat you do put
A if you want to see match A and B if
you want to see match B.
>> All right. And it looks like we actually
have the vote. It's going to be match B.
Uh I think almost every match we've done
has been match B when we do these, but
Aarito on Aurelia and Roy on Pike. Let's
look at their deck list real quick as we
get on into it. So, we've got Arito here
with their Aurelia. Uh, probably, you
know, one of the more popular uh,
legends for this, but, you know, not
really as popular in the top eight this
time around, I think.
>> Yeah, I think I heard that there was
only a couple that were in contention,
but I think there's some really cool
things in Arto's list here. I'm looking
at that edge of night, which honestly
was such a cool gear back in set 2. It's
a hidden, so you don't really know when
it's going to come into play. And
obviously you can hide it for just that
one power instead of having to pay that
three energy.
>> Yeah. And we have seen I think uh you
know renewal of not maybe renewal but
the addition of scuttle crab. I know a
lot of people have been deciding you
know is this the card to add for the
deck or not. I think uh hands down it's
been a positive ad uh not only for the
draw but being able to get the
information of your opponent's hand.
Very you know incremental ad.
>> Yeah. And also a really interesting card
is going to be that Pike. Especially
because we're going against Pike. I did
want to call it out there.
interesting card to see when we are
fighting that deck.
>> Yeah. So, I think guaranteed pike in top
eight just kind of have to decide if
it's going to be the legend and champion
or just the champion. Uh but let's go
over and look at that pike list as well.
>> Yeah, we got to see Royy's list a little
bit just last round. How interesting it
was obviously between that bewitching
spirit that tried to discard cards from
their opponent's hand as well as this
beast below. We saw it in Ry's list back
in Bolognia uh during set two and it did
really well then. Really excited to see
it in Royy's list.
>> Yeah, I'm a big fan of the pack of
wonders and treasure trove uh kind of
combo there. That treasure trove does
offer some additional draw and uh some
ways to interact. Obviously, we have a
lot of cards we want to keep adding back
to our hands. So, pack of wonders can
help that as well. Uh we do need to get
a little bit more runes, so being able
to channel it, especially on the usage
of gold gear, can be great here. But I
also like look at how many one-ups this
deck runs too.
>> Yeah. I mean, one of the one of I think
is so cool to see is actually going to
be that signature spell from Pike. Uh
the signature spell kind of is like an
ode to I believe it's the alt from
League of Legends where if you're
killing a unit that is three miter
below, you get to continually use it
back from your trash pile. Uh and
because of that, very close to the old
from the game.
>> Yeah. So really cool to see a build like
this. And I think we're ready to go. So,
we're going to go into our 13th and
final round of our Swiss uh tournament
here in Vancouver.
>> Oo. Rippers Bay versus Abandoned Hall.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And we've got game one.
Pretty quick here. Sounds good. Good
luck, man.
>> And looks like they're ready to go.
We've got Arito again on the left with
Aurelia choosing the abandoned hall and
we got Roy on the right with the rippers
bay.
>> Yeah, this is going to be interesting to
I mean obviously they are just doing
their mulligans here but I think
abandoned hall spells so nice with
Ireelia. Obviously Ielia does like its
spell swifting ones that choose and are
able to work with the Ireelia text
>> for sure and yeah I think abandon hall
has been one of the best battlefields
from unleash. So that has been uh very
important there.
>> Yeah 100%. We'll have to see this game
is going to go on and get started now.
It does look like um Arto is going to be
going first here with some beautiful
runes.
>> Yeah, and also Rippers Bay probably a
less known battlefield, but uh when a
unit here is returned to a player's
hand, that player may pay one to channel
one rune exhausted. So, uh by a being
able to do that, you are able to get
that interaction with the uh the pike.
But having the bewitching spirit here,
uh this is a really obnoxious card if
you're able to see it on curve. Yeah,
this is so nice to be that first card
from Roy starting to discard some of
Arutoto's cards and especially with the
fact that these Ireelia list oftent
times these early turns are trying to
build up how to protect some of those uh
protect the princess, protect the queen,
protect the president cards like Ireelia
that guardian angels so strong, but
we're stripping away their options they
have by making them discard. I did not.
>> So, we're going to move the spirit to
the rippers bay and then that will give
us an opportunity to use our pike legend
ability for Roy here.
>> And again, if Roy decides to, they can
pay one to bring the spirit back. They
can also channel a rune off of that
effect, but deciding instead to just use
the pack of wonders to do it for
essentially cheaper here. Uh, and then
we do just play out the bewitching
spirit.
>> Yeah, it's going to make them discard
again, I believe. And I mean just a
really nice kind of synergy between what
is almost a draw engine as well with
Pack of Warers, but synergizing well
with this Pike picking cards up getting
to play them again.
>> Yeah. So currently sitting at uh 1.2
playing out Aurelia with the two gear.
We could be a little aggressive here if
we want to, but Aruto's thinking about
>> correct.
>> Let's see.
And here we already do see that Ireelia
in play, which is going to be really
nice. Uh, and obviously guardian angel
also there able to protect Ireelia if
needed after it's attached.
>> Guardian Angel sounds good.
>> All right, so we are going to attach the
guardian angel here and we have I think
three cards in hand here for Arito. So
we do have to be careful. Uh, you know,
two more Bewitching Spirits can pretty
much decimate your hand. But we are
going to attach the guardian angel
there. We are going to uh be able to uh,
you know, ready it with our legend
ability. and we'll see on uh yeah where
we're moving it.
>> Um we will go
>> all right decision on the first one. We
are going to go to the Ripper's Bay
here.
>> Going to go one to one.
Yeah, it does seem like we are not going
to be using uh the the battlefield text
just yet for that yet, but we do see
that charm come down bringing that
bewitched bewitching spirit up and going
on and killing it before it can discard
anymore.
>> Yeah, so being able to get some removal
for one there super strong. Uh there
could have been a choice where we, you
know, readied our legend and then we
could have equipped the boots and then
move over to get the two points. But I
think the the sooner we get rid of the
witching spirit, the better.
>> Yeah, 100%. And I think it's a great
idea, especially just trying to get
ahead of what Roy is trying to do to
win.
>> Good.
>> Yeah. So, it looks like we are at seven
runes right now. Currently, the Aurelia,
it has deflect, it has seven might, it
has a guardian angel. So, very difficult
to remove successfully and interact
with. And we'll see what Roiy's uh
decision is here. Yeah, it's definitely
going to be difficult, but both of the
runes have been tapped on Ardo's side,
which does mean this could be a great
moment to do it or at least try to get
rid of that guardian angel.
Yeah, and you know, if we want to
continue uh, you know, making Arito's
hand smaller if we do have like a uh
mind spplitter that could be used right
here. Uh, look at the hand, get rid of a
card. Uh, but if that's not the case,
curious on the play. Looks like we're
going to play three to play out the
pike. And we are able to uh essentially
accelerate it. Uh you know, if you pay
an additional fury uh and recycle it,
you can play me and then if you pay the
cost, you get to ready me, get the plus
two might. We're going to add it back
into our hand.
>> Bounce and then pay channel. Oh, sorry.
>> Yeah, you're not you're not the wrong
one. Oh,
>> yeah. Yeah. Yeah. It looks like there's
going to be a quick judge call. Yeah, I
made a mistake. Was that the wrong uh
battlefield? cuz it was one
>> channel one and that's the knowledge on
the top of your deck. So, we're going to
have a judge confirm on the best way to
go through that.
>> Unche?
>> Yes.
>> Yeah. I mean, these players have been
playing so many games this weekend. So,
>> just on channel the rune.
>> It gets exhausting at some point. That
being said, really exciting to see how
this game proceeds.
>> Let's shuffle.
>> And I think they might be okay and
shuffle
the one that you recycled to play the
pipe. because that is the
>> Yeah,
>> it's fine.
>> The random Well, it would be the
procedure.
>> Okay, I'll do it. No worries. Doesn't
matter to me.
>> Yeah,
>> this this deck doesn't need that many uh
colors.
>> Okay. Okay. Anyway, so just making sure
on the procedure, right? Uh and we're
going to pass from there. Uh we might
have needed to have one more open. I
don't recall cuz I think we had to pay
one for the rippers bay. But regardless,
we're we're here now. Uh and we've got
uh you know, two points for Roy. Uh and
we know that there is a pike in hand
currently. So, moving back to Ari as our
Aurelia player, we do have ganking off
our boots of swiftness there. So, we are
going to move over to the other spot and
and then pass from there.
>> Yeah, boots of swiftness is so nice on
Aurelia just letting her dance back and
forth in between these different
battlefields scoring those points. We
are up to three now.
>> All right. And looks like we are going
to play seven and recycle one and the
gold gear. This could be the uh Oh, it's
going to be the beast below here.
>> Yep. Yeah, I mean getting to bounce this
Ireelia back into Arto's hand does feel
really nice. And because it is going to
be a unit's ability, you can't defy it
or do things like that that could stop
it if we were playing something like
Starcross instead.
>> Yeah. And once again, Beast Below, when
you play me, return another friendly
unit uh and an enemy to the owner's hand
uh to ready. So, uh, you know, we could
have potentially, you know, also moved
up for Rippers Bay and got like another
channel, but that does open some
interaction and we'd rather them just
have to play out the Aurelia again and
spend some recycles to re-equip the uh,
boots and the guardian angel.
>> Yeah, and honestly, Arto is at so low
resources. We saw him just only a turn
or two ago at two runes while Roy was at
so many more. So, Arto is really
battling to keep up these resources. All
right. So, we are going to equip the
guardian angel here, but we're not going
to be bold enough to move it up to the
battlefield and it's going to be back to
Roy three runes, right?
>> Uh, no.
>> Miselo has a lot of might on it. So, it
is going to be a little daunting as it
decides which battlefield to move up to
potentially taking a point. Obviously,
if there is one deck that can deal with
it though, I do think it's going to be
she can just grow grow fast
>> and then went to me and then back to him
and now back to me. So that was your
third.
>> All right, just confirming we know where
we're at, too. I mean, you know, this
has been a long weekend on games.
There's a lot of interaction back and
forth, too. So,
>> all right, taking our draw here.
>> I was I was I wasn't paying attention.
>> It's always good to make sure they're
doing it correctly because it's not
always malicious. I might just be
stupid.
>> Yeah, I'm not It's not malicious. I
think
>> so. So, we got eight runes here. And,
you know, even even when you're on top
eight point, even when this is your
winning, you can tell these players are
happy to be here. uh they want to play
Riftbound. They love playing this game.
Uh you know, the competitiveness, the
back and forth, like I really do love
the amount of interaction this game,
right?
>> Yeah, I completely agree. And it's so
beautiful getting to watch these players
just kind of laugh and joke. Even though
obviously these this game is probably
very stressful for these players,
they're still able to make light of the
entire situation and have some fun.
>> Yeah. I mean, this is this there's a lot
on the line. there's a good chance that
this is like the the largest, you know,
prize-wise at least game of their life.
And so, even with that, they are able to
joke back and forth and, you know,
smiles all around.
>> Mhm. Both to play a game that they both
really love together and doing it at the
highest level.
>> Yeah. I mean, 10 wins over this weekend
already.
>> I can't I can't like I don't think I've
gone 1011 in any situation uh you know
in a row like this. So, it's a great
accomplishment here. And uh yeah, we
really saw it play.
>> Yeah, I completely agree.
>> We got there.
>> So, we'll have to see what they decide
to do here. It does look like we are
going to be using that moving that beast
below up to one of those battlefields
potentially, but we also just have so
many cards in hand that we could try to
use here.
>> Yeah, and you know, being able to use it
again to return Aelia back next turn
could be strong. Mhm.
>> Uh, you know, obviously, uh, getting a
seven, sorry, an eight might unit back
to your hand is, uh, expensive when you
have to pay seven for it. But
>> these chairs are so much better
>> and the two power is not a price
>> discussion.
So, we'll see if I mean, we get some
gold to help play it later, but
>> it looks like we are thinking about uh
some additional plays here.
>> We are looking at them organizing kind
of in a three and five. So, I have to
wonder what we're planning.
And looking at the hand, I do see like
Ezreal. I see, you know, again, we were
playing so many different one-ups.
There's so much possibilities here. Uh
looks like we're just going to play out
Kai'Sa uh for four, not accelerated, and
then for two, we're going to play out
the noxious hopeful, and then we're
going to use the ability to return the
beast below uh and make it the uh the
beast in hand. I guess
>> that's a good one. And yeah, having it
back in hand is going to let us, as you
mentioned earlier, kind of bounce that
Ireelia back as we kind of please and
have the runes to be able to do so. But
h we still have such a nice base here
with that Kai'Sa and Nox is hopeful.
Kind of threatening it might.
>> Yeah. And uh being kind, just letting
them reread the card. Yeah, just how it
works, right? When you play, return
another friendly unit and an enemy unit
to the uh owner's hand. So uh you know,
we do have the Aelia. The other good
thing is that uh for Roy is that Arito,
our Aurelia player, is only at three
points. So even if we get the double
conquer here, which we're allowed to
with like the boots of swiftness and uh
being able to use our legend ability, uh
we're still like two turns away from
being able to win.
>> Yeah, being on odd numbers is a little
bit uh awkward here because of just that
situation,
but I mean does feel good for Roy. We
obviously
player, right? All those runes are
tapped on Royy's side, which means we
can kind of dance in as we need.
>> Mhm. The other thing is that like, well,
I have
>> uh they don't have any units and any
battlefields. They have no runes up, so
like I guess I can just do my Aelia
thing, right? I can just like conquer my
battlefields, right? Get my points. Uh
like there's no there's no interaction.
I guess I can just do it.
>> It does feel like that for this moment.
Aelia seems pretty safe.
We'll pass here.
>> Oh, and we're actually going to pass
here. Uh we could have been more
aggressive uh by getting another point.
We also could have been a little bit
safer by putting the Aurelia back into
base by again using a equip and then
moving it back with the legend ability,
but uh feeling confident with it here.
Currently at five might and does have
the guardian angel. So a little bit
tough to interact with, but if we've got
another uh if we decide to use Beast
Below, I'm not sure what the interaction
from Arto would be. Yeah, we do have
five runes up on Arto's side, so we
could potentially have some type of
response that we would want to reply
with. Meanwhile, though, Royce,
I mean, has a good number of units. I
have to wonder if this Ireelia being up
into Ripper Bay is kind of trying to
keep him off of that battlefield where
this also puts us back to even points,
which with boost of swiftness, we can do
pretty nicely dance in between. That's
exhausting.
>> Uh and keep up even numbers in here.
>> Yeah. And uh we could have a not so fast
here. Uh and we can use this to
potentially protect our
>> we'll see if that's the uh
>> pay for. That's correct.
>> In the uh in play here, but yeah, not
not going to happen. If we do have it,
we get the treasure hunter back. And
yeah, this beast below has been really
successful at keeping uh you know that
Aurelia off the board. up to four. It'll
>> Yeah. I mean, Guardian Angel is really
strong to help you when your unit is
dying. But when you're just sending it
back to hand, there's not much you can
do.
>> Yeah. And now we can uh if we want to
decide to put the Kai'Sa back, uh this
could offer us another way to channel
some runes and get uh into uh a larger
amount. I don't think I I want to see
Baron on stream. That's that's my my,
you know, side quest I haven't achieved
yet, right? Uh I don't think we've seen
the third battlefield hit the uh hit the
stream yet. So I I I hope it happens
this game.
>> Yeah, I would love to see the Baron
Nasher. It does look like we're getting
a lot of runes. We are just a little bit
shy of 12 about two more turns, but
would be really really cool to see.
>> Yeah. Uh and it might have happened
during Royy's last game. I wasn't able
to catch the whole thing of it. So I do
apolog
I I want to see it live. So
>> we'll see if I get my wish. Let's see
here.
>> I mean, wow. Roy has such a full hand as
well. So many runes, so many cards
potential to play. It does feel like
even though we are at similar points, we
still have a pretty commanding presence
right now.
>> Yeah. And you know, the beast below
being at eight might is a little bit
tough to interact with. Now, I think we
could get to a point where charm is
enough to interact with it. Arto is
going to do
>> the Aurelia things uh to be able to get
the equipment and the attachment. We're
going to go to five points. Just going
to ride the wind over to the abandoned
hall and that's going to get us to uh
six points.
>> Y
>> move it back.
>> We did a we did a lap around the base of
Battlefields here at six points. So kind
of a threatening game next turn
>> and uh we'll see what Roy is going to do
from there.
>> That's a lot of runes.
Yeah, I have to wonder if Roy has some
way to bounce I really again or if we're
going to be trying to hold one of these
battlefields to stop from being able
just to win in a similar fashion next
turn.
>> Yeah. Uh we're going to equip one more
guardian angel just in case.
>> Just in case.
>> Just in case. And we're going to go to
the full 12 runes and we'll see what
we've got in store.
>> Let's see here. It would be really cool
uh to I mean to see Pike do well here.
Looks like we have I mean we do have a
lot of runes to play with as well this
turn. We may want to leave some up if
we're not able to completely wipe
Aurelia off the board or even if we are
able to just to make sure that we have
some response if they do something that
we don't expect.
>> Yeah.
Now, uh there could be a possibility
where a lot of might on one battlefield,
right? Uh that could be strong. I think
we do have uh you know, uh we have some
of our own spells that we could be using
during their um
>> uh my hand,
>> you know, reaction steps, too. Uh it's
four cards in hand, too. I think Roy has
like what, eight, eight cards in hand.
>> Ridiculous like that.
>> I wouldn't be surprised if it was more.
>> Yeah. Now, we do know some of them,
right? We do know that Kai'Sa is in
there. We know Treasure Hunter is in
there. We do know that the Noxious
Hopeful is in there. Uh, but there's a
good amount of unknowns that are in that
hand right now as well.
>> Yeah, completely true. Um, a lot of good
options though for sure. It does seem
daunting to do anything with damage type
removal on Aelia right now with those
two gas. It would potentially remove
some of the might on her, but we we know
she can just grow so large with those
hand spells. Yeah, I think we tried to
play a stack deck and we act for a
reaction. We may would have been a
little bit quick on it, but we are going
to uh draw off the top there.
>> Mhm.
I saw that signature spy I really liked,
but I don't think we chose it.
>> Yeah, I think it's not necessarily
strong enough here. Uh could have been a
maybe a Vex, I think I saw off the top.
Yeah, I do think it was the Vex that
gets stunned, which would be kind of
nice, especially if we can take a
battlefield uh and maybe send that
Ireelia back to hand so that it doesn't
have the potential where it can do
damage to win a battlefield next turn.
>> I just don't know if we have enough
runes to do so, unfortunately. Right. Uh
we'd have to play seven for Beast Below.
We could pay two for uh like a treasure
hunter and then four for the Vex. Yeah,
it's just I think a little bit too
expensive, unfortunately. Yeah,
definitely too expensive. Uh does look
like we are going to be sending Beast
Blow up into Rippers Bay.
>> Oh, you have four.
>> I have myself at five. Oh, okay.
>> Yeah, just confirming.
>> Huh?
>> Oh, I'm wrong.
>> Yeah, that they are. Yeah, they are
going to six.
>> I must have missed one.
>> Uhoh.
>> Conquers last turn.
>> Yeah. And Judge Judge agrees. Yeah. Uh
our UI agrees, too. So,
>> shoot.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> I thought you were My bad. Yeah. So, six
points a piece here. Uh, obviously not
something to that would have lost the
game on the spot, right? If they started
the turn at six and thought they thought
it was five,
>> maybe a little bit more urgency, but
>> still in the game here. Uh, looking, you
know, I'm not sure if they're going to
activate Rivers Bay or the Pack of
Wonders here, but I think an eight might
on a battlefield is quite strong. And
now maybe deciding, yeah, what other
cards could we put here? Good notes.
>> Yeah, I mean, we have so many cards to
choose from. Obviously that Vex does
look so strong. It looks like we are
going to be sending uh the
>> you get no runes though.
>> The treasure trove back to hand. It does
let us draw one and rune, but
>> we I think have all of our runes
already.
>> Yeah, we are going to play out the Vex.
We're going to play the Noxus hopeful
for two. So currently we've got 16 might
on the Ripper Bay.
>> That does seem like a lot here.
potentially trying to hold Dipper's bay
so that Ariota cannot win just this next
turn. Also an Ezreal now as well adding
another three.
>> Yeah, he's probably trying to find a
hidden card to interact with as well
>> on me.
>> Uh not yet.
>> Looks like we have potentially used all
of our runes now though. So Oh,
>> one more. Yeah, there we go.
>> And uh
>> there's the pass. So 19 might. Uh,
honestly, that's kind of a record for me
on Unleash for for holding. So, we also
have a hidden card. Could be a good
amount of choices here. And we'll see if
Arito can beat through.
>> Okay, so that's
>> Yeah, we'll have to see. It's a lot of
might threatening. We also have to
wonder what is that hidden card. I mean,
Arto is going to have to figure it out.
Hopefully find a way into River's Bay
and be able to take both points for a
win. Maybe.
>> Plus one. Not one. It is a plus. Yeah,
you're you wish it was a minus one, but
it is that plus one here. So, right off
the gate here, we do have the Aurelia
that is at this uh what seven points, I
think. Uh 5 + 2, 7. Uh we can also
attach the boots of swiftness for an
additional uh the other thing too is
that even though we're not at the
abandoned hall, what we could do is we
can move the Aurelia to the abandoned
hall and then we can start using some
spells and then equip the boots of
swiftness and then move on over to try
to capture the uh rippers bay.
>> Yeah, I mean that could definitely be an
interesting way to do it. We know Roy
has no runes up, so they don't really
have any options other than that hidden
card. But only has seven runes to work
with here.
>> Yeah, man. I wish I was as confident as
Roy with just saying, "I don't need
these runes open. We can, you know, I've
done everything I can do. Do whatever
you want. I I'm not really I don't
really mind that much.
>> Here's what I have. Find a way into the
battlefield.
>> Yep. Just uh, you know, get to 20. I'm
sure Aelia would do that though, man.
Aelia gets so much might though off of
all of these different spells.
Obviously, we've seen defiant dance be
super strong. Uh especially if you
define dance on top of the abandoned
hall. Uh yeah, just making sure Arto I
mean these numbers make a big
difference. If you win this match, you
are in top eight with Aurelia in great
contention for best of. So definitely
need to doublech check your numbers.
>> Yeah, for sure. And yeah, if one person
or if one of these champions can make it
to 20 might, I think it may be Ireelia.
So, let's see what she can do here.
>> Be very, very good. Uh,
>> I mean, obviously, I do think there's a
couple cards that we could see.
Obviously, on guards,
>> sorry,
>> you know, a lot of these different might
changing ones. You said the defiant
dance, so many options to help grow
this. And because this game is just so
important, you know, it's going to take
a moment to make sure that we don't make
any misplays that could cost us the
game.
>> I need to, right? And again, we've got
1, two, three, four, five, six, seven
runes there. And I believe we've got uh
about five cards. So again, defined
dance is the kind of most bang for our
buck, I think, for for that.
>> We're going to move the Aurelia
>> just straight into the battlefield. Wow.
>> Oh, wow.
>> Uh pass focus to you for
>> Okay, Vex and Ezreal.
>> All right.
>> Oh, this is going to be interesting. So,
it looks like we're sending Aurelia in
specifically just to take might off the
board and Then it pops a G. Ireelia is
still alive because she has another GA
as well. And now we can still grow
Ireelia Mora as needed.
>> Yeah, I think that's a really cool
interaction with these gas here. Uh you
know, we will have to try to uh you
know, make it uh active again, but we do
have ways off of our uh legend ability,
but you know, already chipping that down
to 12 is a little bit more manageable.
>> Yeah. Um from 202 feels a lot better.
>> 12
This is at six. I will go to nine. Okay.
Um, so I cycle two
>> to ready her
>> and equip. So she gets
>> So she's ready and I get uh another plus
two plus one.
>> Okay.
>> Uh, so she's currently at um 4, six,
seven, nine.
>> Yeah. So nine there as mentioned. I do
want to just hear the hear the math for
it
>> again. Um, this time
this time with an ong guard. Uh, I can't
do this, right? Sorry. So, I need to
have two.
>> So, this will go to one and she's going
to 12 to match her 12.
>> Yeah. And 12. So, we are currently even
12 to 12. We have that hidden card out
come out though. And it's Pike.
>> What do you mean? This is the the
champion unit, right? Hidden. you can
pay an additional fury as an additional
cost play when you do get the additional
uh plus two might and it's active on
that support for being able to uh you
know add an additional four might to
this
>> field I'll do this
>> um to ride the winelia here
>> yeah I mean that's just enough not to
fight going to ride the wind away for
choosing
and plus two for abandoned hall so she
will go another plus
All right. So, uh, they're going through
it, but they do get a good amount of
additional might from not only ride the
wind, but all the additional triggers.
And we do get to
>> go back in.
>> Yeah. Move back and gank back again. And
then defined dance. Yeah, that's enough.
There it is. Okay. All right. I couldn't
tell you the exact M numbers, but I know
I know that Defiant Dance seals the
deal.
>> Yeah. I mean, I think even just the
stuff on Abandoned Hall, I think, was
>> pretty good.
>> I mean, it was definitely pushing it.
Defiant Dance,
>> the icing on the cake.
>> Yeah. And that's why like this can be so
strong. I mean again 19 might. We just
had our single champion unit. I think I
think that's the only unit we've played
all game. Is that right?
>> I do believe in this case it was the
only unit that I played. It felt really
I mean it felt back like in set two with
our protect the princess list. I in set
three obviously you kind of have more
units nowadays but not that time. This
time we are going into game two though.
It is going to be that sunken temple
versus voidgate. Uh, Voidgate, I'm not
sure we've seen too much this tournament
uh just because we don't have as many
fury uh decks and Voidgate gives an
extra plus one damage when doing
damaging spells.
>> Yeah. And we were looking at Royy's hand
uh you know as they're going. There were
a lot of like falling stars, a lot of
spells that were doing damage and they
just never felt worth it, especially
with those two copies of the guardian
angels, right?
>> Yeah, 100%.
>> So, we'll see if Voidgate makes a
difference here. uh make it a little bit
easier to get rid of Aurelia. But yeah,
uh it's you know when that wants to get
two points, it's so strong at doing so.
>> Yeah, I mean it and it can just grow
grow and grow and she knows how to move
between those battlefields, too.
>> All right, Royy's going to start us off
with two runes, no cards to play. Uh a
little unfortunate but kind of
understood for it. We've got our scuttle
crab hitting the board there, getting
that draw one and putting Roy four
runes.
>> Yeah, scuttle crab. I mean, so nice.
Obviously, it gives you that draw, but
we've seen so many times this weekend
just how important that information on
your opponent's hand really is.
>> All right. And so, uh, we're going to go
to five runes for Arriito here.
>> And we're going to, uh, we'll see if
we're going to scuttle, uh, to either
the void gate or the sunken temple.
>> Just scuttle on over.
>> Yeah. I mean, it's it's tempting, right?
I mean, what what's that void gate
doing? It's not going to be that crazy,
right? It's just, you know, a gate to
the void. I
>> I mean, but if you're already zero
might, does it really matter if it gives
a plus one damage?
>> I mean, and you get to get the
information of your opponent's hand,
right? Uh we'll we'll see what the
decision is, but we're going to play out
the Aurelia champion, and we're just
going to pass back scuttle crab going to
be safe in the base.
>> It feels kind of risky just playing
Aelia here, though, if I'm being
completely honest. We have no runes up,
nothing to protect her from being
killed. And right now we're at six runes
for Roy, which definitely does open up
some options to take out that Aurelia.
>> Yeah, and especially when I mean it's
going to be very expensive, but falling
star if we have it, we'd have to recycle
four runes to do so. But I think
recycling four to get rid of Aelia is uh
is kind of worth it.
>> Yes,
>> especially when she was so integral last
game, you could see that just from
Ireelia alone, that could take out your
entire game plan.
>> Yeah. And uh I think we're thinking
about I think I do see a falling star.
>> I think I do too. And it does look like
we're potentially looking at those
>> four rooms to recycle.
>> Okay. No, you're not doing this right.
Okay. All right. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Uh okay. That's why I was so confused.
Are you floating too?
>> I'm floating two.
>> You're floating too. Sorry. Can I just
see the runes you just cycled? I want to
know.
>> Confirming on the runes. Yeah. Has to be
two red.
Two furious two chaos there. So,
>> um Yes.
>> There goes the Aurelia there. I guess
that's
>> got two floating. You've eaten her face.
>> Two floating.
>> Oh my goodness.
>> It's very interesting to see like very
fast how like players who really know
their deck can play at some of these
faster paces. Uh and it is I mean really
cool to watch sometimes as well. Even
like some of the slower decks we've seen
this weekend getting three games in in
that in just the 1 hour period. Really
really nice.
>> Yeah. And looks like we're going to end
the turn by playing the uh tie turner
there again. Such a strong card. keeps
the uh Kai'Sa safe here. We got six
might on the sunken temple and you know
Kai'Sa can move and draw again if gets
another conquer next turn.
>> Yeah, I mean Kaisa's already done her
job. She's drawn one. She's gotten us a
point. She's going to be really nice to
draw more again. Nox is hopeful and that
tie turner posing six might at that top
battlefield.
>> All right, Arito thinking about this
next turn. I think they're at seven
runes here.
>> Play four. Yeah,
>> looks like four could be a Stellaorn
coming down.
>> Let me tell you, the game would be over.
>> Oh, Adaptron. Okay. All right.
>> Yeah, Roy's like,
>> "What What does this do against me?" I'm
not I I think I think this could be for
a different deck. But we are actually
going to use the adaptron, man.
Definitely wish this was a stellar corn,
but uh we are going to press it into the
sunken tempo, I believe.
>> Um
>> yeah, it will make this adapt to that.
Good.
>> Yeah.
>> I think it was tapped to adapt a five
might unit.
>> Making it looks like four might
potentially at that top battlefield.
>> I've never seen Aurelia. I've never seen
Aurelia hit that high. Yeah.
>> And there it is. So, we got the double
removal there with the adaptron. Not
eating gears this time around. Eating
units. And uh we do have uh the sunken
temple. We are going to use the charm.
Oh man, what a good interaction there.
Scuttle crab finally feeling safe enough
to go to the void gate and it's going to
be two to one. Uh and a pretty free hold
next turn I think too for Ari.
>> Yeah, that felt like a huge tempo swing
for Ari there. Obviously it kind of felt
like for a moment even though we had to
spin so much to take out the Ireelia. We
took out Ireelia. But I mean look at
this now. Roy has no units on board and
Arto does have control of both
battlefields.
>> All right. Uh, I think that there is a
another falling star in hand if we want
to. I think there's also a void seeker
if we want to be less aggressive with
losing uh our runes cuz again we're only
at four. We've been m you know that
falling star I think was a fine play but
was very rune greedy here.
>> Uh five cards
>> and we'll see what
>> I got value already.
>> Good.
H I mean, do you want to use the runes
to kill both or have more runes to deal
with it later? And I think that's going
to be a huge struggle for what Roy is
dealing with here. Obviously, it does
look like instead we're actually just
going to bring in that pike. We did
>> recycle one rune, so that did mean Pike
was accelerated.
>> Yeah. And yeah, it looked like it had
like an ambush ability. No, the ability
instead is once again, we will be able
to pay the extra one fury and then we're
able to have it active. It was a four to
three and we were able to get another
point and get rid of the adapter.
>> Start with this.
>> Yeah, at least we did get it off the
board and it does keep our hands still a
secret for not going for that scuttle
crab. A second scuttle crab is going to
be coming down though for Ariel which is
going to be a draw as well as I mean
just another unit on board for four.
>> Yeah. And with the tie turner we are
able to get another double uh point
turn. One from holding, one from
conquering.
We're uh the scuttle crab's a little bit
short of being mighty, so not getting a
draw off that sunken temple. But we we
will still take the point.
>> He may be the farthest thing from mighty
you can be in this game.
>> Yeah, I I think that's fair.
>> But at this point, he is very important
taking I think almost three points at
this point.
>> It's you know once the scuttle starts
right it's it starts moving and again uh
the death kneel effect I think will be
important.
>> Six runes. Yeah, five. Yeah, five runes
to I think five or sorry, five runes to
six runes here.
>> Yeah,
>> but not looking super great.
>> Does look like we were getting back a
little bit even in resources again,
which is going to feel a lot nicer. I
mean, Arito did show last game that even
though Roy sometimes had 10 to 12 runes,
he was still able to take the win. So 5
to five, I'm sure he's feeling far more
confident.
>> Yeah. Uh, and the tempo for this game is
a lot different, right? Like we were
able to get to max runes and now we're
just so uh a little bit poor on runes
here and a little bit tough to interact
with. So, I think Royy's thinking we did
get the sprite uh we could get like a
discard one and the falling star, but
another
>> uh you know the scuttle crab in the back
can offer you know another uh point
there. And
>> very nice.
>> Yeah, looks like we are going to get
another falling star
>> targets. Ooh,
>> two crabs.
>> Hitting both the crabs. Actually, very
interesting.
>> It's something.
>> I kind of like the idea of hitting both
crabs. Even though it doesn't free up
the void gate, it does mean all the
information that we have to give happens
at one time instead of again having to
show that hidden information of what is
in my hand at a later point.
>> Yeah. And this if they're going to five
uh next turn, it's not as outrageous. I
definitely would have thought about
hitting the void gate though just
>> just in case it made a difference cuz I
think we are going to play out the
>> sprite down
from there but yeah we'll see what uh
>> what is doing after this
>> that is good.
>> Yeah I mean obviously sprite could be
nice. We know a couple different cards
as well. Uh but it looks like instead
Pike is going to be the answer here and
we are going to play it where it can can
come in ready. Yeah, that that uh that
gold token was in my blind spot. I'm
like, "Oh, yeah. Unfortunately, we don't
have another fury for this spike, but we
can recycle the gold there and that will
offer." So, 100% makes more sense for
that that play there. So, we get the
removal. We get to get to two points and
we do get to clear the battlefield.
Unfortunately, Aelia is just so good at
moving units and man, the mind
spplitter. Now, we're getting some
reverse uh discards here. And yeah, what
is the card to fear here? Yeah, I mean
there's a couple really strong cards
obviously in Roy's hand. Starcross, we
saw that ability be so strong on Beast
Below in the game before, but it looks
like we are going to take out even
though it is doubled in hand.
>> Yeah, and I mean we're going to, you
know, it's a high recycle turn. We're
recycling four runes this turn, but
definitely worth it. We get the mind
spplitter on the void gate with the
guardian angel. Such a strong card. And
we're just still stuck at this five
runes.
>> Stop trying to kill my creatures. Yeah.
Now we're going have to figure out what
to do with the mind spplitter. Seven
might on this guy is going to be a lot
to deal with. It does look like we're
going to bring out the treasure hunter
though.
>> Yeah. And it was a really good top deck
right there.
>> Uh
>> and thinking about, you know, uh if we
want to play around the defy or not,
>> if we want to try to play the sprite. I
mean, they're going to go to six points
next turn, which is scary, but not in
contention for winning next turn.
>> Yeah, I mean, six definitely scary if we
can hold here, but obviously max you can
get to is seven. Even if we were able to
get into the other
>> other battlefield is why it's just so
important sometimes staying on those
even numbers or trying to force your
opponent off of the even numbers.
All right. So, we're going to get the
discard one off the bewitching spirit.
And I think there's only like two
additional cards. So, yeah, we get the
charm out of hand.
>> And uh we're going to hold to six as
Arito as we draw.
>> Seven runes, right? Correct.
>> Not eight. Correct.
>> Draw one.
>> Yeah.
>> All right. We've got the six runes here.
We're holding to six points. We do have
a boots of swiftness which will be very
nice to move over to the sunken.
>> Uh they again shortcutting a little bit
but we do get the ganking and then we do
get the point and then we are uh mighty.
So we get the draw for one and then
we're passing back.
>> Yeah, nice to kind of replenish our hand
especially after having to discard uh
with that bewitching
>> spirit again. God damn.
>> Kind of make sure our resources stay
healthy here as we potentially close
into that eight points. Yeah. Uh, and we
got to be careful from a couple
interactions. We're going to move the
treasure hunter here.
>> Get some gold. Go to four.
>> Go to four points
>> and then yeah, I think like the choices
we have to starcross, you have defy and
that's going to be it. Arito ends the
day of Swiss with an 111 and1 record and
should be in that top eight contention.
Yeah, what a strong move holding that
defy just be able to stop site
starcross. We knew he had starcross just
because of that the scuttle crab just
earlier last the turn before.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And you know we we have we
were behind on runes for a lot of the
game because we did get that force
interaction for the Aurelia but you know
also after game one when Aelia was the
MVP, the only unit that hit the board,
uh getting that off the board was a
priority, right? Yeah, it was such a
priority. It did seem to kind of set us
back in resources, which was a bit of a
problem. But it was kind of interesting
to see between the two games completely
different ways to win, but we still got
there.
>> Yeah. Well, uh, so we know one of our
likely top eight contentions, but we
still have our table A, so we're going
to look at those decks real quick before
we jump into that match. We do have, uh,
the Secret Sauce. Houses are big. We saw
them earlier uh, on their rank uh, climb
here. And we've got the Master Y.
>> Yeah, what an interesting list from uh
TSS. Houses are big. I mean, we saw so
much fun with this deck. Obviously,
those ring guards were so important that
sabotage was used at one point.
Obviously, punch first did a lot and
just I'm excited to see how they deal
with this next match.
>> Yeah. And uh another kind of uh key card
is the battlefield Emperor's Das. uh not
usually seen in the mastery list that
I'm used to, but was able to reactivate
some on plays uh and get some really
good results here. So, a really
interesting battlefield that I think has
caught a lot of people off guard today.
>> Yeah, I think so for sure. And we saw
that earlier just how much it could and
how much damage it could do lifting
those units up and getting to play them
again.
>> All right, so that is our uh mastery
deck and let's see our opponent for uh
houses are big. It's going to be Ryan
Ferris here with their build of Civer.
>> Yeah, I mean Civer has been crazy this
weekend. She definitely seems to be
getting played a lot, especially with
that Dazzling Aurora.
>> Yeah, and there has been kind of a race
to the top on what is the best Dazzling
Aurora deck, right? Is synergies with
Elder Dragon have been talked about time
and time again. And you know, with the
consistency when it comes to not only
the chaos side with some card draw, but
also having alternative ways to ramp
with stuff like the pack of wonders and
the treasure trove as well as how it
interacts with the legend ability. Uh,
you know, there's a lot of reasons to
play Civer as an Aurora deck.
>> Yeah, I mean, she's so nice as well just
with that legend ability where when you
recycle a rune, you get to generate a
gold. And we've seen some really nice
resource plays throughout this weekend
uh on how we can use that.
>> Yeah. And I think we're ready. We're
going to go to uh you know, houses are
big versus Ryan Fairies here, Ferris
here. And it's going to be game one.
Looks like seed of power for uh on the
left side. And we also do have Sigil of
the Storm. Yeah, Sigil of the Storm on
the right.
>> Yeah, I think Sigil of the Storm is a
battlefield that Civer has really
enjoyed even in that second set.
>> Uh meanwhile, Seed of Power. We've seen
it a lot today. Honestly,
>> we have. And I will say that this is a
bit of a tough match up for Ye at times.
Uh which you know a little ironic
because sometimes he has been an Aurora
deck in the history of this game too. Uh
but just the fact that you know the
amount of damage from outer dragon uh is
tough for for mastery to play around.
And if we do see an Aurora on curve he's
going to be on the back foot
immediately.
>> Yeah 100%. Though I will say when we
watched houses are big earlier, he did
such a great job against the Azir and
really controlling the gears and the
equipment that Azir had. So I'm hopeful
he'll be able to do something similar
here even if Aurora can come into play.
>> Yep. And just a quick pit rookie uh
hitting the base here. We've got the
treasure trove for two and we are just
going to
>> get a gold. Yeah. Immediately use the
effects to uh Yeah. ramp one and get a
gold here and then pass.
>> Can we leave the in the base
>> the gold?
>> Oh, yes.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> So, one of the one of the cool ways it
just kind of uh allows for like a draw
one, but also uh lets you uh now kind of
recycle one in the future, too. So, uh
which means if you need to play out your
champion, you know, you're not actually
unramping yourself.
>> Yeah, that makes a lot of sense. And it
I really do like these more like
consistency resource building versions
of Civer. Really nice to see. We'll have
to see how it works. It does look like
Pokei tried to move up into the seat of
power, but that Gus is going to come
down and send her back the hand, which
honestly
>> doesn't seem the worst since we'll get
to use her ability of buffing another
unit.
>> Yeah. And then like this these kind of
turns just kind of show uh the new power
I think of Master Yi uh where we're able
to play out that champion for four uh
and just helps makes our play you know a
little bit more uh affordable and
playable.
>> Yeah does look like we also hit that
catalyst of AON's adjust on curve really
getting us ramped up as quickly as
possible on these runes.
>> All right looking at six for the uh TSS
houses are big here. Uh we could offer a
uh you know a point uh from conquering.
Uh we do know that what there is a pit
rookie in the hand as well
>> which could be nice and making this ye a
little bit bigger. It does look like
we're going to play that pit rookie and
buff ye.
>> It's good.
>> We're good at five might now.
>> And uh we are going to move it to the uh
seat of power which again is kind of
awkward. seed of power you want to
conquer second but the uh you know
having to recycle a rune from the sigual
power is so tough that you know I
understand yeah what the decision is so
we're going to put mastery seed to power
no conquering effect but we do get to
one point here we also get two XP so
just four XP away from level six and
going to Ryan Ferris here
>> we'll tap out
>> yeah and it looks like we are going to
hit that Aurora just on curve
which is going to be I mean nice for
Ryan Ferris but not so nice for our
houses are big who's going to need an
answer for it next turn but first we
will get to go on and use that Aurora
more than likely we are going to be
hitting I believe that elder dragon yep
there it is just these decks are built
so that you can very consistently hit
them by running only three elder dragons
and I think it was one mind spplitter
>> yeah that's kind of the ratios I'm used
to seeing and yeah just makes it super
consistent like when you see the piece,
when you see the ramp, and then when you
see the Aurora, uh, you get these plays.
And, you know, with Houses of Big not
being that aggressive early, it means
that it's only one point to zero. It's
just a one point difference right now.
>> You're good.
>> And so, I mean, you really wanted to get
more points before that Aurora comes
down. That's the one I feel like one of
the main game plans is just trying to
get
>> maybe to six before that Aurora appears
and then like trying to eek out those
last two points.
All right, we're at houses are big here.
We've got, I believe, eight runes to
play with and we are going to start off
a little tentatively, but we are going
to yeah play four for the Aon. We are
going to be stealing the Dazzling
Aurora. We did see Oxan Wreck have it in
the Azir match up, but now we have our
own copy of Dazzling Aurora. I I don't
think it's equipped. Uh I think it's
just Yeah,
>> that would be impressive, right? if
you're playing, you know, if you're
stealing a weapon, right? That's how it
works. But you do get to get control of
the dazzling auror. And as long as the
ashan stays around, you do get that. So
we get the scuttle crab off the aurora.
Here we get to draw one. Uh
>> just a lot of goofy interactions on that
one.
>> Yeah, I love it though. I mean, it's not
equipped, but it is kind of tied to Oxan
in some way. As you said, when Oxan
dies, that that gear will return back to
Ryan Ferris, who I'm sure he wants his
Aurora. He paid a lot for it.
>> You did, right? Yeah, it is. Uh, you
know, you've you've come along. We It's
makes you a 1011, right? You're now
emotionally attached to the card, too,
right? So, you do want it back. But
looking at here, we've got the sabotage
to start off the turn using our uh gold
gear to pay for the power cost here. And
we are going to defy saying, "Nah, my
hand uh I want every card inside it."
>> My hand is mine.
>> Yes.
>> But when you kill my scuttle crab,
you'll have to show me yours.
>> Yes, exactly.
So, let's see here. I mean,
>> obviously, Ryan does have another more
runes to play. He also is just going to
move that Elder Dragon up into that seat
of power. Also kind of avoiding using
that sigil uh storm. Sigil of the storm.
>> All right, looks like we are going to
play out the last rights here for three.
>> Uh, and yeah, we don't have Aurora
anymore, so back to houses are big.
Yeah, we will get to use the energy in
hand first or to play the cards in hand
first, but it's going to be really nice
getting this free unit off of well, our
borrowed Aurora.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Uh, you know, it's it's
going to be, you know, weird that we,
you know, it's so linked to AON. We do
have to make sure it stays around, but
with it being formite and if it stays in
base, I don't think there are some quick
interactions with it. Um, now it's just
uh let's can scuttle crab take care of
the elder dragon.
>> Yeah, the only thing is obviously is
that we are one turn away from Ryan
Ferris having 10 runes which does mean
if he has an Elder Dragon in hand, he
could play it for the full price and
potentially kill the Aon and return his
Aurora to him.
>> Sure. Yeah. No, and that would be again
like another huge swing back. So, we'll
see the play here,
but this is kind of a little bit of the
issue why the match up's a little bit
tough. Obviously, uh it's not always
easy for us to interact with Aurora, but
the other thing is that, you know, our
answers to Elder Dragon are still
usually combat, and that's still going
at least one card for one.
>> It's so difficult dealing with Elder
Dragon. I feel like that's something
that we've seen a like this weekend as a
repeat whenever we see Aurora really
killing these Elder Dragons is a
struggle. Mhm.
>> All right, we are going to move the
>> scuttle crab
>> to the sigil. And for one, looks like we
are going to play the flurry of blades.
>> Yeah, I mean obviously
it could potentially stop the crab from
taking the point, but it does mean that
we're going to have we're going to get
to see Ryan Ferris's hand. Uh, is there
another Aurora? Is there that Elder
Dragon? I'm kind of excited to find out.
And it looks like neither.
>> We do have the Fading Memories, which
using Fading Memories on our copy of
Aurora that they're borrowing would be a
fun interaction for sure. Uh, but I also
think there is a copy of Sabotage houses
our big hand. Uh, so, you know, having
the scout first is important.
>> Mhm. I also think we might be at 3 XP
because I think we did conquer with uh
with Master Y. Uh I don't think the XP
really matters this point moving
forward, but we did get at least one
from the death meal of the crab there.
>> 12. Yes, thank you.
>> Yeah, it is going to it does look like
it's going to be that sabotage or not.
Uh but sabotage could be nice to make
sure Fading Memories doesn't
the Aurora, but I mean
>> fing bottom.
>> I mean, you're just borrowing it. Yeah,
you're just borrowing it. It's not
Aurora, it's our Aurora, right? I think
Feel free to grab it whenever.
>> Yeah,
checking what you
>> Obviously, we did choose to send the
fading memories to the bottom of Ryan's
deck. But I kind of wonder as well like
would you ra like cuz if the Oxon dies,
the Aurora goes back. kind of forcing
him to kill there where it might have
been nice just to be able to make sure
that it can't be, you know,
>> retaken and used again.
>> All right. Uh we're going to see Aurora.
We're going to see another scuttle.
Another scuttle crab. Oh my goodness.
>> They're just so eager to get onto the
base there. We do get an extra draw and
uh yeah, pass it back to Ryan.
>> And Ryan is just keeping control of that
seat of power. He's slowly getting
points from this Elder Dragon who
doesn't seem to be going anywhere.
>> No, I mean again it is uh you know a bit
of a boss here is going to be tough to
interact with. Um but at the same point
Ryan's really out of resources uh which
is the good thing. I think we can
catalyst of Aons if we want to and that
would let us just get a draw one for
four runes which is a bit expensive. Uh,
we also do have our civer champion unit
and yeah, we are going to pay for
>> we'll draw a card
>> to draw one.
>> At least we get a card from it. So,
that's going to be nice. Hopefully some
uh something extra that we can use. It's
something that houses are big doesn't
know what it is. At least
>> we'll have to see. It looks like we are
spending.
>> Yes.
>> Five
>> to accelerate
>> and oh to bring out civer for that.
>> Yeah. Making sure getting the gold
>> from the civer.
>> I will move in here. I have you at
three. I'll burn that.
>> Yeah, I think there's a very important
that sigil of the storm. It's
specifically you have to pay a rune, but
obviously you can still get that civer
ability activated from it. You get that
gold, but you couldn't use a gold to pay
for the sigil of the storm.
>> Yeah. And I I like doing this play. Kind
of the issue with it though is that I
think we're down to I think nine runes.
So, we can't play Elder Dragon next turn
if we end up drawing it, which is a
little unfortunate. We are at I believe
seven runes here for houses are big.
>> Yeah, I mean, and Houses of Big is going
to have to do something. He's definitely
the one who's on the back foot here.
He's the one who has to take action and
force his way into these battlefields
cuz he's slowly going to lose out on
points.
>> Yep. Uh, and then Ryan has two cards in
hand, but they're new cards now.
>> Uh, float one.
>> Yep.
>> Uh, there could be a decision to maybe
attack with Scuttle Crab first, just so
you again get that perfect knowledge.
>> Sure.
>> Rengar is now though at a plus five. So,
it's at 11. Uh, which can pressure this
>> uh, elder dragon. Uh
>> Ryan does have three runes up though, so
there are some potential options to try
to deal with this Rengar. We'll have to
see what they have. Looks like Fury of
Blades. O
>> though. Yeah, and that does mean that
this combat happens.
>> And yeah, there is the trade which you
are very happy to see that Elder Dragon
leave the board. Yeah, I will note we do
have a last right so it's already been
put onto the board as well for Ryan
which does mean we could potentially see
uh it again later.
>> Yeah, and
looks like we are going to pay play the
pit rookie uh for one of the floating
and another one. So we do get the buff.
So we are at a five to this four.
>> Mhm. You got
>> Yeah. And that is the removal there. So,
we are now at two points. We do have to
recycle off the sigil. Looks like we're
going to float a uh calm rune there.
>> I would definitely have it nervous. I
feel like to some extent moving our up
into that civer. I mean, if it dies, you
lose access that dazzling Aurora. You
just spent so much to get that other
Elder Dragon off the board. But at least
from how we were able to deal with Elder
Dragon, we kind of had an idea what was
in hand of those two cards.
>> Yeah, but it is a little scary. But I'm
looking at hand right now and I think we
could have a first mate. We could play
it on the auction since we have one
floating. Move it back to safety. Yeah,
I think I like this. Oh no, the scuttle
crab. Okay. Uh instead saying I want to
try to conquer the seat of power again
next turn and we've got the Rengar.
>> Play it anywhere.
>> Put this here.
>> Yeah, for sure. that you could
>> uh let look at my hand.
>> Yeah. And thinking about it. Yeah, it
could be either put it in the I think
putting in the auction is fine
>> or uh we have one.
>> I'm going to go here. You can go ahead.
>> All right. Passing it back to Ryan here
again. Uh you know, we've been,
>> you know, really having a hard time. We
were able to get the ramp into the
dazzling Aurora, but not only did it get
removed, but it got, you know, used now
by House of Big. I mean, we played two
scuttle crabs, right? Has gotten so much
value and uh that's going to be really
tough as uh you know, houses are big is
kind of climbing up this matchup here.
>> Yeah, it feels like I mean we definitely
gotten so much value off that dazzling
Aurora. It did feel like though when we
were getting scuttle crabs that we
weren't really a dazzling Aurora deck
yet, but now that we got a Rengar, much
more dazzling Aurora.
>> We'll discard that result.
>> Uh yeah, and we have to get rid of this
Elder Dragon. unfortunate here.
>> Eight runes.
>> Yes.
>> And now at eight runes. Yeah, getting
that extra cycle I think is hurting more
than helping cuz again if we had the
other dragon we could have gotten that
extra draw. Another copy of the boon
there.
>> Yeah, we're just trying to draw into
something here to play with. I mean it's
getting a bit difficult though because
we've drawn so much and still not found
what we're looking for. Looks like we
are going to try stack deck next. So, we
will be able to look at three cards and
pick one of those three to put into
hand. We still have four runes up, but
obviously we haven't found whatever it
is yet.
>> Yeah, and this is Yeah, it's going to be
really tough to stabilize, I think, for
Civer here. Not impossible. Again, like
Elder Dragon can offer a lot of value,
but again, we need to maybe set up
another Aurora and hope this one sticks
around uh on our side of the board a
little bit longer. I will take
>> this.
>> So it does look like we chose uh our
card for ourselves.
>> So we are going to play that catalyst of
aons here does mean we are going to get
a couple more runes and I think because
we didn't get all the runes off the aons
it does mean we'll be able to draw a
card.
>> As long as you don't channel two runes
this way you do get to draw one.
>> All right pass it back. We will be
holding to four. We will be getting two
runes.
>> We can get another card draw off the
scuttle crab as well by moving or really
anything moving into the seat of power.
>> Mhm. Which is nice that we are finally
going to get to use seed of power for
that actual card draw. It does look
going to be that scuttle crab like you
mentioned, but it's kind of uh kind of
funny seeing that houses are big even
though he's got such a well-built board
here. He only has five runes up versus
all those runes on Ryan's side.
>> And scuttle crab continues to scuttle as
the first mate activates it once again.
>> We are going to play the lonely porro up
into the sigil of the storm. Move our
auction a little bit back into safety.
>> No worries, man.
>> Maybe the Rengar stand keeping the Porro
a little less lonely.
>> Pull this back.
>> Looks like Rengar is going to move back
though as well. I'm sorry, Mr. Lonely
Borro. You're going to have to be lonely
at the sigil of this.
>> End of the turn.
>> All right. And let's see what we get off
of our Aurora.
>> I say ours very liberally, but uh we do
get the first mate here.
>> No, you're good.
>> Yeah, there's the three.
>> Uh we can activate any of our things. It
looks like it's going to be sure the
poor. All right. Hey, look at him go.
>> Got to play around.
>> I'm sure it feels like his Aurora right
now after we've gotten so many cards.
>> 12 drops.
>> Yeah. I mean, but we've gotten was it
Rengar, Scuttle Crab, Scuttle Crab, and
First Mate. I think uh like costwise, I
think we're still even on uh you know,
the 12 cost for the Elder Dragon versus
>> I think it's pretty close. I think it's
like exactly 12 cost off both just
spread across four cards.
>> Yeah, that is very true. They're not as
uh
>> energy efficient, but we only paid four
for our Aurora where they had to pay
nine
>> that. Okay. You know what? That's true.
When we we think about the full cost for
it. Yeah. Houses are big is just a
little bit ahead there.
>> Aurora times.
>> Yeah. Aurora time.
>> Let's see here.
>> Uh we'll do two.
>> All right. We're going to do the Aurora.
Uh, and we are going to recycle two
knowing that um that the you know since
we're going to get those two back
anyways. And there it is.
>> Yeah.
>> We'll have to wonder who what we get
here because I do think it's a 50/50 for
that mine splitter potentially. Uh
>> yeah, as far as as far as I've seen, and
this is also another interaction that I
wouldn't know 100%, but I would assume
that if the Elder Dragon into uh getting
rid of the Axon, uh the Aurora only
activates at the start of the Oh, and
it's the it's the splitter there.
Unfortunate for uh Ryan here cuz it
definitely was hoping for that. We do
get to see the hand. We do get to see
that hey we don't have a copy of another
auction which would be a bit
debilitating but there will be a couple
more draws afforded to houses our big
here
>> and uh yeah we are going to take the
charm just cuz it can offer uh a little
bit more scariness
at least he would get to discard the
auction if it was hand
yeah you're right yeah I think we would
have liked to get rid of the auction
right
>> 100% uh I guess now though We do
>> have an idea that as long as we can keep
this Dazzling Aurora, the next card is
Elder Dragon, which I mean could mean
we'd have two our two Aurora back
and kind of as I was saying, I I would
assume it works that this way. We'll see
if it happens. If we do play out the
Elder Dragon and we do kill the Aan, I
think the Aurora that we get back
>> uh does not see the beginning of the
step. So, because of that, I don't think
we get a second one. I could be wrong on
that, but that would be my assumption.
But we've got judges there to confirm
how that works.
>> Yeah, we have some fantastic judges
watching over our games this weekend.
>> Definitely, kid.
>> Let's see. We have 1 2 3 4 5 six seven
units here in our base up against only
one mine spplitter and uh we are
currently I think held to six points. So
I mean we can get to seven here
>> and it would offer us a draw which would
be great. It would offer us a draw, but
I think
>> I part of me feels like you have to hold
with a good number of units somewhere
and that could potentially get us eight
points.
>> I think I I I understand, but I also
think that it's not going to be too
outrageous to get a double conquer next
turn, too. So, especially with how wide
our board is. So,
>> uh we'll see what interaction we get.
We've got uh two unknown cards in hand.
Uh, you know, since we did see the mind
spplitter previously,
>> you need to do that, but you can't do
that. You can do that, but you can't.
Sure.
>> How many runes are you going to next
turn?
>> I'll be at full 12.
>> Let's see. Full 12 for Ryan on the other
side,
>> which you can do a lot with 12 runes.
>> You You really can.
>> Thinking about moving the lonely Porro
back, asking if we need the card draw.
Sorry, I need to think about that.
>> Yeah, I mean, we're trying to figure out
what the best way to win here is. We're
at seven points. We have a pretty good
idea that unless Ryan top decks that
next Elder Dragon that it could come in
off that Dazzora. That being said, there
are I think they said the full 12 is
what we heard, which means even if he
does top deck it, he could play it from
hand, which I mean that could be a huge
problem trying to, you know, hold or
double conquer into that eight points.
>> Yeah. What also something I could see is
that we could have two units in both
spots. That means if Elder Dragon comes
down, you still don't get a clear
battlefield for free and there'd have to
be some other interaction. But we are
going to charm.
Oh, this this is an interesting
interaction. Yeah. So, we're going to
actually charm it to the sigil of
distortment since they conquered. They
will need to recycle a rune here.
>> So, that does stop them from having the
full 12.
>> But it makes me wonder like it's like
what else are we thinking of?
>> Oh, this is so interesting. So, we
brought in Ruin Runner who
>> Go ahead.
>> Can't be affected either.
>> Yeah. can't be selected by it's like
abilities and spells or is it just
spells?
>> I believe it's abilities and spells.
>> Yes, I was thinking. So, no, the bear uh
the elder dragon could not deflect it,
which means it has to stay alive to some
extent, but doesn't look like we're
going to be putting it into that seat of
power like I might have expected here.
>> Yeah, but a really interesting play. Uh,
you know, there could have been some
times in the previous game uh where you
could have charmed one away uh to help
you just get the double conquer. Again,
we've got scuttle crab in the seat of
power. Uh if it's able to hold it there,
you do get the win. So, we look at Ryan
11 runes thanks to conquering with
charm. Uh again, what a unique I' I've
never seen a play like that.
>> Yeah, I kind of love it though.
I've definitely never I've seen we've
seen obviously charm being used to keep
people from getting two points from
holding. We've seen in the past
obviously people stopping you from
trying to get like a hold effect off of
a battlefield, but never to to reduce
the number of runes you have.
>> Agreed.
>> Looking top three off the stack deck
here.
I'll do this one.
>> All right. And paying another two.
>> I'll pay two
to do a trove.
>> All right. Treasure trove. We're going
to recycle one. Get a gold.
>> Get one. Get a gold. Mhm. And uh an
additional draw. Yep.
>> And draw a card. Yes.
Okay.
>> And we've got I think
>> about eight or nine left.
>> We're going to equip
>> I will use a gold
>> the uh last rights here. So we will be
able to put two cards back into our
deck.
Yeah, I will say I guess one interesting
interaction by charming up the
mindsplitter as well is you don't get
the conquer effects is when I conquer or
hold you can play a unit from your
trash. So here mindsplitter is not
conquering and therefore that last
rights effect does not get triggered.
>> Yeah. And there could be like the civer
uh champion unit that we could
accelerate if we play off of it. So that
could offer uh like a double conquer and
get rid of that top battlefield. But now
like it's going to be kind of tricky uh
to you know get the conquer on the other
side. Looks like we're going to just go
searching for again likely an elder
dragon.
>> I think there's only elder dragon at
this point. And it does look like I
thought I saw the elder dragon in hand
earlier. I wasn't fully sure. I
definitely thought that there was a
ability from the rune but from how far
we got in the deck that other Elder
Dragon is in hand.
>> Yeah. And uh we finally got our Aurora
back.
>> Uh I was I was looking.
>> Okay, I'll shuffle and you can go.
>> Yeah. And then uh we should be able to
get the death kneel from the uh scuttle
crab to look at hand.
>> Uh this
>> uh that buff was
Yeah. Yes. Yes. Very good.
>> Yeah. And that was the buff off the
auction from a bit ago.
>> I'm going to do channel.
>> Yeah. And uh House of Rig might have
forgotten that they can look at their
hand off the scuttle crab.
>> Yeah. Uh but we'll have to see what else
they can do here. I mean, we have just a
couple cards left in hand. Obviously,
both of I mean, the Elder Dragon and the
Mindsplitter are on
the uh Sigil of the Storm.
>> Seed of Power is open. Um, but we can't
get eight points just by conquering. We
do have to get it basically by holding.
>> Uh, you have me at seven. Is that right?
>> Yes, I'm at five. You're at seven.
>> All right, we're going to send the porro
to the seat of power.
>> Judges might have caught the uh the
scuttle crab. Unsure, but uh might be a
bit pause here.
Who's a problem?
>> We'll see.
>> Yeah. And again, like you know, when
when Aurora happens, all this stuff
happens at the end of the turn. A lot of
things are happening, especially since
multiple uh units are killed at the same
time. So, uh we're going to confirm on
this again. I think it's it's likely.
Yeah, my guess is it's probably due to
the scuttle crab.
>> Yeah, that's my guess as well. And I
mean there, as you said, so many
different interactions happening at the
same time. obviously as well. We are
just getting to the end of those Swiss
rounds. Trying to make sure everything
is just perfect because this is a really
important game.
>> All right, looks like we are jumping
ahead a little bit here.
>> Verbalized trigger. So, we've remembered
it. We've done part of it and we the
only
>> and we are getting final confirmation.
>> Entire trigger.
>> Sure. So, uh, instead of saying that
you've missed your trigger, which you
haven't because you've done all this
stuff, uh, this is just instead going to
be a, uh, a general error instead of a
missed trigger.
>> What we're going to do is you'll receive
a warning.
>> I'm really excited to see what houses
are big can do here. I think he
obviously has a lot of options for
Aurora. We've obvious seen the one
auction. Uh, I don't remember if he had
a second in his list or not, but he's
got answers for gear.
>> Obviously, he knows how to deal with
Aurora. If he's gotten this far into the
game, and he has so many units in his
base, he has to have an answer here this
close to the goal line.
>> All right, easy. Uh, one more question.
Has any cards entered?
>> And since
>> Yeah, I think they're just confirming.
Yeah. Um I I think there might be a
warning associated with it, but there
there was a judge call for it.
>> No new cards I think have entered hand
either for uh Ryan since the scuttle
crab. So
>> getting a confirmation on that.
>> So like my hand is what it should be
when the skull crab died.
>> I understand. Thank you.
>> Um so basically we can we can do a very
short rewind of putting the skull crab
back in the hand. Uh untapping runes.
>> We have such great judges this weekend.
Really awesome. uh you know just making
sure that everything is just how it
needs to work out uh and making sure
everything is in order here.
I think there is uh you know decision of
you know we have drawn another card off
the scuttle crab here
>> in my hand
>> and then we can just have one card I
don't know
>> yeah since since we are rewinding we are
random
>> skuttle crab or one card also per turn
>> because of the scuttle crab basically
we're rewinding to the point of
>> um we are still in
>> there so it should be two cards on sktle
crab and drawing per turn
>> but I know the scuttle crab's in my hand
or
>> uh we'll just put uh we'll just put two
back. Yes, I understand.
>> No, but the problem is if the scuttle
crab we know was in my hand before I
drew this card.
>> So, we'll put this not scuttle crab.
>> Yeah. So, we've drawn two cards since
the mist trigger. So, judge is just
confirming the cards to put back and it
would be randomly. So,
>> they are doing it. We're just going to
put those two cards back.
>> Yeah.
>> One for turn and one forcuffle.
Yeah. One victory turn one for the skull
crab as well. We'll see how this goes.
>> So, this is drawing for turn.
>> Oh, yeah. I see. Yeah. Yeah. I'll get
>> Yeah, they put one back, but then
they're just going to say they're going
to draw for the skull crab.
>> I Well, I'm not sure if I do, but maybe
I do.
>> I don't.
>> Uh, this one.
>> All right, there it is. All right, we're
back. We're back to it. All right, this
is going to be the end of Ryan's turn.
We did have the elder dragon, and now we
do have the death nail from the scuttle
crab here. We do see a gust, an elder
dragon, and the uh frigid fading fading.
Sorry, fading memories.
>> Shout outs to the AC in this room right
now. But uh all right, so uh obviously
that's some good news or information for
houses are big because now we are
knowing that the only card we're really
playing around is the gust, right? Uh so
if we've got some numbers that can get
around it, we're going to be in a good
spot. And I definitely think we have
enough units to kind of get around it in
general. Uh we do have just so many
units already set up in base. We are
going to go and continue into house is
our big turn here. I do believe. So we
have our
>> draw for turn. And then we're going to
have that scuttle crab crab draw as
well.
>> Yeah.
>> All right. So uh we do have scuttle crab
again. Scuttling over. Uh we do know
that on the southern battlefield there
is 17 might.
29. Do you want me to take out my
>> which is a lot to contend with?
>> Yeah.
>> Uh but obviously we have a lot to worry
about as well. Obviously, we do know
that Aurora could bring out a Elder
Dragon. Uh and but we do at least have
just so many different units.
>> Yeah. So, it looks like we're trying to
mount an offense onto the southern
battlefield here. Looks like we've
decided to go
a two
>> nine.
>> Yeah, I think it's going to be 8 + 5.
So, I think 13 right now.
>> Mhm.
>> And again, there's 17 on the other side.
So,
uh No. Okay. So, we're just we're just
>> uh organizing in the base.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Uh how many?
>> Yeah. Just organizing before we get
everything played out here. I think one
big concern other than I mean obviously
we are looks like we may be going into a
showdown here in a second. I was just
thinking of ways that you do obviously
you still could kill like the ruin
runner because obviously you cannot
select her with the elder dragon but we
have seen cards like that flurry of
blades that doesn't really select uh
that could still cause some of those
Elder Dragon triggers I believe.
>> Yeah. And we're going to let that Porro
return to hand. We're going to put the
other Porro here. Yeah. get get the draw
and then I think we need to get
>> oh boy
>> 18 on this I think we could have maybe
on guard to get out of the gust here as
well
but now that we've got kind of this
perfect knowledge here if we're able to
go 10 first and then eight on the second
one
>> that could be enough
>> math is hard man um it's a long day
>> facts
>> this is 19
>> yes you have Two cards in your hand.
>> Crap.
>> That doesn't work. I almost died.
>> Yeah. Yeah, cuz
>> and the the back and forth of like what
the numbers need to be. Yeah, you need
to make sure to put 10 first.
>> Oh, yeah. And there is the extra two. I
I forgot it was hidden uh the last
rights here. So, uh we've got the primal
for four.
>> Primal fury is such a sorry. Primal
strength is such a strong card that I
love that houses of our big has put into
his deck. That plus seven is the I mean
the original might of the by itself.
>> All right. You know, a lot on the line
here. How are big finds the math that
gets there obviously Ryan saying, you
know what,
>> you got to make sure you do it right.
And uh game one's over. We're gonna
scoot over to game two. So, we've got
Emperor's Das uh on the side of houses
are big and then Ryan uh Ferris does
have the uh the Aspirin's climb.
>> Yeah, I mean Aspirin's climb just making
us go to nine points to win this game.
Aurora obviously wants to make this game
as long as possible, which this
aspirin's climb is fantastic at doing.
Obviously, Emperor's Das does give you
the option to uh
>> potentially make a sand soldier if you
can bounce that unit back to hand. So,
you know, both of these battlefields
really interesting. But Emperor's Das I
think is pretty unique in this list. We
saw it earlier and did really well for
uh for houses are big.
>> Yeah. And uh I think another point too,
we got 26 minutes left. That first game
took about 34 with uh some compensation
from judge calls, right? Uh but you
know, houses are big is in a really good
spot. I think at this point it can you
can mildly say that you're going to tie
or win, right? As long as you keep going
forward.
>> You do have to keep going forward with
it though. Uh but you know a tie here
having an 11-1 and one record is in
contention I think for a top eight
finish too which is really exciting.
>> Yeah, that is so exciting. This is going
to be really I mean makes it a really
important game for sure. And we are just
getting started. Obviously, we did see
some sack decks. We see that Scriers's
Bloom to help us get a little deeper
into the deck as well. Uh, and
>> I mean, off to the races we go. Can we
find the Aurora?
>> That put bottom.
>> Yeah, you got it.
>> And, uh, yeah, with the vision two, uh,
you can choose which ones you're putting
where. And then you essentially can
choose, okay, do I want to draw one of
these two or a third random one? We are
going to use the treasure trove again
for two.
>> Yeah. get the effect, get the gold, you
know, kind of the the bread and butter
we've been seeing from Civer for the
last couple games.
>> Yeah, that I mean, Treasures Trove, I
feel like, is such a staple in these
Civer lists. I mean, it offers
consistency. It offers, you know, it's
part of a package that allows you to
bounce things back to your hand. So many
really cool interactions.
>> Yeah, I mean, the the shortcut is draw,
you know, pay two to draw one, make a
gold, right? uh which is a good
interaction uh and again lets us uh you
know be less worried about recycling a
little bit later as we try to get to
nine
>> gust.
>> All right, we've got gust added again on
the pit rookie
>> and we are actually going to use the
discipline here to make it a four might
draw off the discipline here. So we will
be able to get this point.
>> Yeah, some of these low cost cards like
Gus that only cost one energy do have
these uh might ceiling. So, it's a three
might or lower. Was two might on that P
uh that pit rookie, but discipline
bringing it out of range.
>> This is
>> all right.
>> Well, here it is.
>> Also, we are uh we might be trying to go
a little bit faster through this, too.
Uh so, we'll see what that means. We are
uh you know, trying to get from the
round 13 to top eight. So, we'll see how
this goes. But we do have the uh thought
of the scuttle crab. We are going to use
the pit rookie again since we did use
the emperor's dis to make the sand
soldier token and now it's at three
might hanging out on the northern
battlefield.
>> Yeah, I mean just getting these early
points is going to be so important. We
saw I mean obviously we the Aurora could
just not arrive on curve but in case it
does we want to get as many points as
possible before it arrives. try to find
some cards that could potentially help
with Aurora. Um, and I do think
obviously Houseer Big now that we're
into game two has some extra options.
You see that Aan though in hand from the
sabotage which is very threatening.
However, sabotage only hits nonunit
cards, meaning Oxan is safe in hand
right now.
>> Yeah. And now you're like, do I even
want to play Aurora? So again, this was
uh recorded as we were watching our
first match of the round, right? So we
were watching our second match. So, we
are able to fast forward through a
little bit of kind of the setup turns
here. Uh, but through it, we do see
houses are big. Uh, again on two points
with the buffed sand soldier token. Uh,
we are going to move the pit rookie to
the bottom one going three to zero as
the timer ticks.
>> Yeah, I mean looks like we are just
going to be moving that sand soldier
safely back to base. We got that hold
point and I mean pit rookie also taking
a point off that aspirin's climb.
>> Yep. And then we're gonna put uh the
scuttle crab, one of our I would imagine
favorite cards at this point. Uh and
then yeah, Ryan is going to be like,
man, I could play Aurora and I get one
off of it, but then they can just
auction on it. They get to take it their
way. They can start using it and they
are going to have to find a way. But
yeah, we're going to say, you know,
that's fine. We're going to play our
Aurora and uh let's see the card we hit.
If we do hit Mindsplitter, though, that
could be strong to get rid of the Axon
first and then the Elder Dragon could
come down on a second one. So, we're
going to go through our deck. Let's see
what we hit here. Looks like it is going
to be an Elder Dragon and uh it's going
to be the pit rookie and the Master Yi.
>> Yeah, I mean it's still going to be bad
to lose those two units. Obviously,
Elder Dragon is just such a monster. But
we do know that Houseler Big has that
Oxon in hand. Can very well take that
Dazzling Aurora and make it his own. And
if last game was anything, he can use it
to its full extent.
>> Oh yeah. So, we'll move uh through this
here. Uh there is also some cool
interactions like we can move the
scuttle crab to the emperor's dice. We
can return it to hand to make a sand
soldier. We can play scuttle crab again
to get a draw one. And then we could
play the oxon.
>> Yeah, so many good options here. It It
does look we have one rune up on Ryan's
side. So, just making just in case
there's anything else. And we're going
to grab this information here from
sabotage el at least one elder dragon in
hand. Meaning even if a future Aurora
comes down, there is only one Elder
Dragon and one Mindsplitter left in that
deck.
>> Yeah, and I do think uh Blades of Flurry
could be strong. Uh looks like we are
also thinking about, you know, there's
so much draw cards. Uh stack deck is
still very helpful for finding, you
know, another piece of the puzzle a
little bit later, but it looks like it
is going to be the stack deck going to
get recycled there. We're going to keep
the uh flurry of blades there and we are
just going to play it immediately and we
are going to actually defy. We said this
crab is too important to us. We got to
keep it around.
>> He said I already saw your hand. I don't
want to see it right now.
>> Yeah.
>> All right. So, we do have uh the choice
on the Empress Das. Looks like uh we are
going to do it and play a sand soldier
token.
>> Mhm.
>> Very nice.
>> Yeah, it's pretty nice to just get these
sand soldier tokens almost like every
turn at this point. And so I mean
building out the the board without even
really having to put our own units down
yet.
>> Yep. And uh then we still can for four
play out the Oshawn. Yep. Back to uh you
know again our Aurora here and uh we
will be able to activate at the end of
the turn. And then lastly, we got
Scuttle Crab in hand and we're going to
leave it in hand. We're going to look at
the top. We're going to play out the uh
first mate H and we're going to I guess
activate our AON.
>> Mhm. This time we did not equip the
Aurora though. So, uh that is that is
definitely worth
>> that that is uh you know the intended
functionality. So that that is helpful.
Uh we are going to play likely the uh
yeah the lunar boon that we knew was in
hand getting rid of immobilize a new
card that we drew. But we get another
new two cards in hand here. We still
have the elder dragon which we will be
putting on the aspirin climb. We will be
getting rid of that buffed sand soldier.
Get our first point of the game here.
And then we are going to play the
challenge on the oxan and that is going
to be a little bit scary here especially
since you know we did use the defy on
the uh you know the flurry and then we
are going to uh respond with the
unyielding spirit here. So no damage
this turn and we do keep our sand
soldier healthy. We do hold to six
points here and then we've got six runes
to start the turn.
>> Yeah, I feel like the yielding spirit is
such a uh overlooked card. It seems so
strong was especially strong during set
one, especially strong when you have a
lot of damaging spells in the meta, but
it hasn't been seen a lot lately because
there haven't been a lot of those
spells. That being said, it does we're
going to be playing another Elder Dragon
from hand.
>> Yeah. And so we had not only uh this
disarming rake to get rid of the Aurora,
and you're like, fine, you can get rid
of it. I already have my three dragons
on the board. This is going to be really
tough for houses our big to interact
with this terrifying three dragons.
>> Yeah, 100%. This is so much to deal
with. We really didn't get the same
amount of uh payoff from the Aurora that
we had taken over, but now we're just
going to try to find our way back here.
We are at six points. So, we got you
made a nice journey forward, but it's
not over yet.
>> Yeah. And you know I I said like you
know houses are big was you know a
little bit advantageous going into this
but now we're like man we are you know a
lot of points on Ryan's side. They are
going to climb uh to nine pretty quickly
and yeah we're going to play out of
Rengar but we are kind of terrified
what's on that other side of the board.
>> Right. Sabotage uh the charm on the left
the charm on the right. Looks like the
charm on the left is the call there.
Yeah, which which charm. But uh it is
potentially going to I mean let's see
what they have. We are slowly building
out our base again. Obviously that rain
guard is coming down. We have that
disarming rake uh and these scuttle
crabs. But obviously scuttle crabs are
not doing much to that might.
>> Yeah. And uh you know we could be using
uh the punch first here and this could
be enough to attack into this. We do
have the extra copy of Flurry and it
looks like we might have a Defy here.
Oh, it's going to be a discipline first
to see if we do get a Defy off that, but
we do not. So, unfortunately, we do lose
our Rengar here.
>> Yeah, I do love seeing things like that
though, playing some of these draw cards
that we have to try to find the pieces
we need. Looks like instead though that
we are going to be charming these
dragons over to Aspirin's climb which
could potentially help to protect versus
them getting those two point draws
again.
>> Yeah. And we are going to put the
scuttle back in hand uh to play a sand
soldier token. We're going to play out
the scuttle once again to get another
draw one. And it's going to be seven
points to five and a lonely porro. Pass
it back to Ryan who's only going to be
holding to six points instead of holding
to seven here.
Let's see.
>> Yeah. All right. There goes that. We're
not going to use the Emperor's Das here.
>> Yeah. I mean, it does obviously I don't
think we really want to return that
dragon to hand. It's a lot to pay for,
but we do see that civer come out as
well. And it kind of seems like we're
just going to be trying to hold into
those nine points.
>> All right, we've got the boon. We're
just going to be like, you know what? I
can read the writing on the wall. We've
got 10 minutes uh to try to end it out.
I'm not sure what we're going to go
through. Yeah. Okay. Just going straight
to game three. All right. Lot on the
line here. Uh and again, this is kind of
the a bit of the win and in. And uh
we'll have to see who ends up taking it.
>> Yeah, this is going to be the game that
decides it all. I mean, it is only seven
minutes left. So, I have to think that
houses are big has a big advantage here,
right? He doesn't have to find the
Aurora. Obviously, we kind of have
access to that civer, but we don't have
access her to to her till at least turn
two. Uh, and houses are big can already
start scoring points by then.
>> All right, so we got the treasure trove
for two here. Uh, once again, using the
effect, get the gold. So, again, short
hand, draw one, make a gold. Uh, and we
are going to play out the Scrier's Boon
here or sorry, Bloom here. Uh, which
means that we aren't afraid of Gus.
We're going to play out the lonely
porro. We're going to play the first
mate for three to move the uh lonely
pore back and activate it. So, we do get
the double conquer here. Real strong
from houses are big.
>> Yeah, that feels so nice to get those
two points so early just in our second
turn. And I mean, Ryan Ferris doesn't
even have a single unit on board yet.
Still trying to get enough runes to
potentially play that Aurora.
>> Yeah, I mean, but here we are. We're
just speeding to seven. I mean, it's
already seems pretty fast, but at one
times or 1.5 speed, right? It's a little
extra but uh we are holding to four
points here uh which is quite good for
houses are big uh will offer some uh
support there. Now unfortunately we are
stuck on the vile mos layer due to the
battlefield effect. So that lonely poor
is going to likely stay lonely for a
while but now thinking on this six uh
and we're just passing straight up for
uh for houses are big. Yeah, I mean I
have to wonder does Houses are big have
something that he's holding for Aurora?
Is his hand only spells? But it looks
like we are going to instead see that
Mindsplitter instead of Aurora come down
and we are going to have to see how
their big's hand and potentially dis and
discard one of their cards.
>> Yeah, so mind spplitter activates uh
and yeah, just I think making sure on
Yeah, the runes uh and deciding to
likely react with the Rengar here. Yeah.
So, she will also move the first mate
back, which I love this interaction with
the Starring. Looking at hand, we've got
two copies of punch first, scuttle crab,
and discipline.
>> All right, getting rid of Oh, I'm going
to call that punch second.
And uh we're going to pass it back, but
we're holding to six points with without
any other interaction here. Yeah, but I
think that was such a smart play by
Huster Big reacting to that Mind
Splitter ability by ambushing into
Starring does save that Rengar so that
Mindsplitter can't discard it because
unlike Sabotage, Mind Splitter can hit
units.
>> Yeah. And so we do have again uh six
points here. Uh we're just a double
conqueror away from qualifying to our
top eight with Master Yi. Uh think about
this Rengar. We're going to start with
looks like a scuttle crab. Maybe with
with the spring we can move it back for
free, but going to get the draw there.
>> Man, if we have a sabotage, I think that
could be really insightful for trying to
interact with their hand.
>> Yeah, I think so for sure. Especially
turns like this, you really kind of want
to sabotage. Try to take that Aurora out
of hand so you can still finish off
those eight points.
>> Yep. All right, we're going to buff our
Porro and pass it back, though.
believe we have 10 runes. Again, that
we're going kind of fast, so I'm not
immediately sure, but uh we have at
least nine, it seems. So, we are going
to play out our Dazzling Aurora and then
use the effect. And when there's only
Elder Dragons left into it, pretty clear
that is the play. And what are we going
to get rid of? So, uh we're going to
play it into the Starring. We do have an
opportunity to use uh the Battlefield
effect to move it back.
>> Yeah, we could move that mine spplitter
back for sure, but
At least we have a couple units still
alive on houses are big's side.
>> Yep. And only one rune, so we can have
like a flurry of blades uh activate
here.
>> Mhm.
>> But yeah, making sure we know our
numbers.
>> We have nine runes now and has their big
side. 33 seconds left on the clock,
which does mean we should be going to
turns shortly.
>> Yeah. And if if we end up being uh I
mean, at this point, it's pretty clear
that Ryan's only going to have two more
turns left. Whether they're going to be
turn zero or turn one uh doesn't
particularly matter. But the biggest
thing is that the most amount of points
I think they can get is four. Uh which
means that you're still not even like
going to win. Maybe get a tie here. But
uh we are going to discipline
there be at five might. We could go five
and two to pressure a seven minds
spplitter here.
>> All right. And I think we're caught up.
He took the breath for me cuz we were we
uh we might have been zooming through
that one a little bit. But this should
be turn zero for houses are big. The top
eight point on the line here. Getting a
win here I think would secure a top
eight finish. Uh and you know a big
finish for the you know the secret
sauce.
>> Yeah that would be absolutely huge
getting a player into top eight. But
honestly, either player
>> two
>> would feel really nice securing the top
eight.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> Okay.
>> All right. And we are playing out the
discipline looks like on the pit rookie
as well.
So, it will get us to a total of five
and four.
>> Mhm.
>> That's nine.
>> Yep.
>> And the punch first. So, an additional
plus five. So, I think we've got 10.
Yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> 10 into the Elder Dragon.
>> Looks like we do have the 10 and the
Elder Dragon does die. Giving us a lot
of information I feel like about that.
What if we may have that flurry?
>> Yeah.
>> Flurry of blades in hand because
>> if it was it would have been played.
Yeah. Right.
>> Yeah. Exactly. So that one rune isn't
for the flurry of blades.
>> All right. Well, we're at four. We've
got I think our third copy of the punch
first. So we're at nine. Sorry, I'm a
little
>> punch third. Yes.
>> All right. I mean, it's it's uh yeah, a
nine to seven.
>> Uh this can get the eighth point. This
can wrap up the round here.
>> It very well could. We'll have
>> I mean, it looks like we are going to
play another pit rookie as well,
bringing it up to 10 might, I believe,
with that buff.
>> Just getting one more point of might
here.
Nine
10 at seven 10.
>> Yeah. 10 10 into the mine splitter.
>> 10
>> to the seven.
>> 10 all together.
>> That's right.
>> That's nice.
>> Good game.
>> Good games. All right. There it is.
Okay.
Sometimes you just got to make sure. And
uh the secret sauce is in the top eight.
Houses are big with a huge 12-1 finish.
And what a finish that is.
>> Yeah, what a fantastic job by Houses are
big really bringing it home, right? Even
though we went to turns, we spent so
much time obviously with finishing out
this entire round and it we still did
it. We got the math even if it took a
bit.
>> All right. Well, I think we might be
going directly into the top eight, but
we're going to take a little second of
there. Yeah, obviously we did watch a
match that was happening since we were
able to get both of our studio games for
uh the top, you know, the 13th round
there. So, uh honestly, really exciting
and and hopefully we get to see the
standings of what top eight are pretty
soon. But, uh just a lot of gameplay to
finalize that 13th round.
>> Yeah, for sure. And I am so excited to
see who made it into the top eight.
>> Yeah, and and honestly, from what it
looks like, uh you know, there could be
a lot of different legends, right? I
think we've saw Master Yi and uh I think
I think we're going into our 13th game.
So, I'm not sure if we're taking a break
or going directly into it, but that's on
the next.
>> Yeah, there's gonna be so many great
games coming up here.
>> All right, so we are going to take a
tiny break. We will be back with the top
eight from there. So, don't go anywhere
and let's get into this top eight right
after this break.
Heat. Heat. Heat.
Here
we go.